and just to remind you that just after
10 o'clock this morning we're going to
bring you those pictures of the Queen's
funeral Cortez as it begins its final
Journey so do stay with us for that and
also do join Trevor Phillips tonight for
a special program it's at nine o'clock
every evening on the death of the queen
well let's turn our attention to some
other news now and at least 16 people
have been killed in a large earthquake
in northeastern Papua New Guinea the
head of the local Red Cross had the 7.6
magnitude earthquake was one of the
largest that ever hit the country
tsunami warning was initially issued but
has since been withdrawn
the war in Ukraine has seen a major
development with Ukrainian forces making
gains in the east of the country
President Vladimir zelenski has welcomed
Russia's withdrawal from Key areas after
a Ukrainian counter-offensive
the movement of our soldiers in
different directions of the front
continues the date as part of active
action since the beginning of September
about 2 000 kilometers of our territory
have already been liberated
the Russian army in these days is
demonstrating the best that it can do
showing its back and of course it's a
good decision for them to run there is
no place for the occupiers in Ukraine
and there never will be one
or Russia is said to have been taken by
surprise by Ukraine's advances Ukraine
launched its counter-offensive in the
East earlier this week and in a daily
update UK defense officials said
Ukraine's forces have made advances in
around 31 miles into previously
russian-held territory
the attack is said to have left
thousands of Russian troops increasingly
isolated near the key city of isium the
offensive is now seeking to sever the
Russian supply lines near kupians and
trap thousands of troops in Israel
overnight president zielinski said
Ukraine had retaken 30 settlements in
the khakif region our security and
defense center Deborah Haynes has this
report from Eastern Ukraine
this is the gateway to a key City that
Russian forces captured in the first
weeks of the war but these are Ukrainian
troops
they're part of a lightning advance
retaking swathes of territory across the
kharkiv region punching through Russia's
defenses driving its troops back
in order to achieve the stated goals of
the special military operation to
liberate Don bass a decision was made to
regroup the Russian troops stationed in
balaclia and Islam regions to build up
our efforts in the direction of the Nets
regrouping sounds more like retreating
to reinforce Russia's positions in The
crucial donbass region
a sudden Russian order came as Ukrainian
troops celebrated the recapturing of the
small city of balaclia the national flag
flying high once more
questions
today we are completing the liberation
of balaclia the first major city in our
offensive I'm sure that it will not be
our last
Russia's worst nightmare appears to be
unfolding in eastern Ukraine it could be
their gravest setback since the failure
to capture Keith back in March these
pictures were taken from the city of
kupiansk recapturing this place would
deal a significant blow to Russia as
it's been an important Supply route to
support Russian forces in donbath
Russia's decision to pull back some
forces from Eastern positions is
extraordinary but Ukraine is also wading
counter-attacks from the south the
simultaneous operations backed by
Western weapons marked the biggest
Ukrainian offensive of the war and could
be a key turning point if the games are
sustained
[Music]
for those who've spent months under
Russian occupation the relief is all too
clear to see
they've waited a long time for this
debraham Sky News in eastern Ukraine
or the walkabouts in Windsor dominating
the morning's front pages I'm joined Now
by Royal historian Tessa Dunlop and
political editor at the Sunday Bearer
Nigel Nelson for for a look at the
papers and we we dealt with those front
pages in some depth in the last hour a
lot of them had at the the two brothers
that the grandsons of the queen of
course doing they walk about in Windsor
yesterday with their wives but we're
delving inside the papers now aren't we
and Nigel you want to kick us off with
an article that you've seen in the
Observer focusing on the new era of King
Charles yes and and the difference
between Prince Charles and King Charles
um he gave a sort of a slight impression
yesterday he's going to uphold the
constitution of course that means he's
going to be a completely different
person if you go back to his Prince of
Wales days he got involved in North
Florida politics he was very keen on
climate change dealing with pollution uh
getting up good opportunities for young
people and also having a good
architecture he didn't like all that
change
that's right indeed indeed
um and so used for seven Prime Ministers
uh what would call the the
um black spider memos in his black
spidery handwriting complaining about
this complaining about that Tony Blair
used to get really fed up with that
um but the whole thing is all that
changes and the one thing that was
interesting about his accession speech
yesterday is him saying yes that will
change that now um I am the king I don't
get involved in that I'm above politics
and we were very lucky to have a
non-political head of state not beholden
to any political party
um and just there for them to it to give
advice to Prime Ministers which of
course always remains private but the
difference says of course we know for
example she's obsessed with the climate
he was known as the sort of potty prince
who talked to pot plants so while he may
no longer in tone on that you know what
the government then chooses to do about
Renewables or so forth we we actually
have this inside track on what's going
on in our king's head I rather like that
which we never did with the queen of
course we've never had a hinge did we
really
um and let's move on to uh to focus on
um Prince William and the Walkabout
yesterday this is a story inside the
mail yeah he released a statement so the
headline on the mail is you know a take
from the new Prince of Wales uh
statement which was very moving and
thought through uh she was by my side at
my happiest moments and she was by my
side during the saddest days of my life
I was listening yesterday actually when
he was at school and Wednesday he used
to pop across at Eaton rather used to
pop across to see his grandmother at
Windsor and pick up tips and we know he
very much models his style of sort of um
I don't know not Royal posturing but the
the way William is is modeled very much
on his grandmother and I was
particularly taken with one line in that
statement where he wrote I thank her for
her kindness and I thank her on behalf
of my generation for providing an
example of service and dignity in public
life that was from a different age but
always relevant to us all and I work a
lot with war generation those the same
age as the queen in fact I talked to
Betty yesterday at 99 he said I do wish
they'd stop calling her everyone's
grandmother she was younger than me you
know and there's quite a few of those
women who suddenly feel gosh are key
contemporary the only pin-up
non-agenarian has suddenly gone and they
feel a different sort of bereavement but
they do certainly have this beautiful
stance the best foot forward starts in
fact Betty still wears those little
Court heels the Queen West determined
even if it makes her a bit unstable and
I noticed on the second last day of the
Queen's life when she met Liz trust she
was still wearing little stacked shoes
but it is really interesting how people
relate the royal family isn't it I mean
we have these amazing big formal
occasions but but it is that sense of
people thinking my grannies like that or
my sons like that or we had a bus stop
in our family like that and I think
that's how the Royal Family do make
those personal connections and so like a
gigantic mirror but what's interesting
about the queen is she's been alive so
long that you know for those in the 50s
shoes like the pin-up sugar pink
princess then you move into the 60s she
was everyone's mother and now of course
uh grandmother and uh and great
grandmother just incidentally they also
pick up on him calling her granny but
with an ie apparently a more modern form
of spelling granny is it really I didn't
know
I didn't know that let's move into the
Sunday Telegraph shall we at Nigel
because of course the state funeral we
now have the date of it it is uh
tomorrow week Monday the 19th of
September isn't it and we're getting a
few more details that's right
um yes and a number of things have
obviously had been canceled because of
what's been because of the Queen's death
um and the TUC for instance would have
begun their conference today but they
can't do that they've had to cancel the
conference the liberal Democrats are
canceling theirs they will lose an awful
lot of money on the basis of that and
people won't be able to get their hotel
bookings back and so on but we're going
to start talking about the cost of this
well
well we
need to find out if they're talking
about something like this Arrangement is
like doing the Olympics but in 12 in 10
days there is going to be a cost
gigantic financial crisis that's right
but the good news is we get the Bangkok
we get a bank holiday uh on the day of
the queen State funeral we didn't get
that when Georgia Six was there and
there's holding out the possibility we
might get another bank holiday when when
King Charles is is
um uh where the coronation happens
so we've got two bank holidays to look
forward to I mean certainly kids would
love that but uh and all you need to do
is make sure your employer will give you
the day off schools have closed banks
will close shocks will close but not all
of us will be able to actually take time
off
iceration interestingly in 1952
the reasons given by Churches to get the
bailiffs out of the house because of
course we were still rationing and it
was to save up money to have this
coronation so whether we'll
um exercise the same restraint and have
one in a year or so time of course we
have a much older King so that might be
a reason to sort of crack on with it and
of course the paper was dominated by
coverage of the Queen's death and in
fact I had a guest yesterday who said
that in France they devoted pages and
pages of of coverage to the Queen's
death and yet there and here we've got a
cost of living crisis haven't we
um Liz truss features in the article
that you've picked out here
um
Liz trust to join the King on tour of
the four corners of the UK to lead a
nation in mourning now she doesn't have
to do that protocol doesn't stipulate
that a prime minister goes with harmonic
to visit those four corners of Britain
the United Kingdom I slightly feel a
cynic in me is wondering if this trust
isn't piggybacking a little bit off King
Charles's moment I wonder what your
thoughts well I also wonder what King
Charles thinks about if I mean it's
meant to be his tour he's meant to be
seeing all the devolved Nations uh how
Keen he will he will be with having this
trust as a backseat driver I'm not quite
so sure in terms of the prime minister's
involvement she will join the king as he
leads in it you know it's all rather
sort of you know tiptoeing around this
idea that Liz very very new couldn't be
more new in her Premiership and we know
that actually these great Royal moments
they are big National moments
um Tony Blair the death of Diana you
know really made a name for himself just
four months into his own Premiership
with the people's princess and slightly
leading and helping guiding the royal
family and likewise Churchill with the
death of George VI very famously made a
valedictory speech that hit all the
headlines okay and we've only got about
a minute so we can talk about the
Queen's friendships or we can talk about
corgis I know other stories which would
you like to do would you like to do
corgis or friendships uh
a queen would say they won in the same
there is there's no more loyal a friend
very quickly yeah very quickly it's a
Jackie Stewart who's been a great friend
of the queen uh met her through the
Princess Royal who uh he became a friend
of as well went on shooting parties with
her and he spoke on the telephone tour
only two weeks ago and so she was in
fine form he'd seen her a few weeks
before that what is interesting is like
everybody else he won't say what they
talked about so he talks about how
wonderful she was and how nice she was
but won't reveal their private
conversations that's that's very good of
him but obviously for us we would be
absolutely fascinated wouldn't we anyway
we will no doubt cover the subject of
Corgi so dear to the Queen's heart in
the later hours but uh for the moment
thanks both very much indeed Tessa and
Nigel we will see you later
do you stay with us we've got live
coverage from Buckingham Palace and from
Balmoral later on this morning as the
Queen's coffin will begin its journey to
its final resting place it's been
described as King Charles as his
mother's last great journey will have
plenty of coverage on that throughout
the day and plenty of reaction to the
crowds arriving here at Buckingham
Palace to do stay with us
one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George become our only lawful and
rightful leads Lord Charles III
preachers for his majesty the king
hip hip
[Music]
foreign
thank you so much thank you everyone
[Applause]
hello good morning from Buckingham
Palace
the Queen's funeral Cortez will leave
Balmoral making its way to Edinburgh in
what King Charles described as his
mother's last great journey
foreign
referendum in my first term in an
international exclusive Australia's
prime minister Tel Sky News there'll be
no break with the monarchy in the near
future it will need to continue to move
with the times but the bigger questions
about our Constitution are not ones for
this current period
for the Prime Minister of Antigua and
Barbuda says he will call for a
referendum on a republic as the king
prepares to meet the Commonwealth
Secretary General this morning
reunited in their grief the new Prince
and Princess of Wales joined the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex during a walkabout
at Windsor
from portraits to pop celebrating the
queen as a cultural icon
and we'll take a look at how this
morning's papers are marking this moment
in history
hello and a very good morning from
Buckingham Palace the Queen's coffin
will this morning begin the journey to
its final resting place in what King
Charles has described as his mother's
last great journey thousands are
expected to line the route as the
Queen's funeral Cortez moves along the
first part of its route to Edinburgh
or the Queen's coffin which is currently
in the ballroom at Balmoral will be
carried by six gamekeepers from the
estate and lifted into the hearse at 10
o'clock this morning
the funeral Cortez will make its way to
Aberdeen passing through balita aboyne
bankery and Peter Cooter arriving in
Aberdeen at around 11 20 this morning
and will move through the city's suburbs
the King George VI Bridge which was
opened By Her Majesty's mother in 1941
is also on route
next the Cortez will head through the
Angus Countryside past Breakin arriving
in Dundee at around 2PM where it'll
drive around the city on the king's way
it will then head towards Perth across
the frighten bridge and cross over the
queensfree crossing heading towards
Edinburgh
the Cortez will pass by Edinburgh Castle
and head down the Royal mile to the
Palace of Hollywood house arriving at
around 4pm
the coffin will rest in the throne room
to allow staff at the palace to pay
their respects
well meanwhile new details have been
released about the Queen's lion state in
London and her funeral at Westminster
Abbey which will take place on Monday
the 19th of September that as the new
Prince and Princess of Wales and the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex were reunited
in Windsor for a walkabout our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock reports now
on what would unfold in the coming days
[Music]
from traditional ceremony heralding and
proclaiming a new sovereign
to a windsor Walkabout bringing Brothers
together and differences set aside
[Music]
[Applause]
historic moments which Crowds Are
Gathering to witness
at the moment so despite whatever
is going on outside of that so it's nice
nice to see I like to see them bend in
the bridges and that sort of thing but
who knows it's been very hurtful for the
queen for the family so yeah they can
put that to rest and start afresh that
would probably
your majesty the new King has duties and
meetings he also has to plan his
mother's funeral
this morning the Queen's coffin will
leave Balmoral for the Palace of
holyrood house in Edinburgh on Monday
afternoon the coffin will be taken to
Saint Giles cathedral in Edinburgh the
king and queen consort and other members
of the family will follow in procession
for 24 hours the coffin will rest in the
cathedral so the public can pay their
respects
later that evening the king and other
Royals will hold a vigil
on Tuesday the king and queen consort
will visit Northern Ireland and that
evening the Queen's coffin arrives in
London and rests at Buckingham Palace
the following day on Wednesday the
coffin will be taken to the Palace of
Westminster in silent procession
the Queen's coffin will arrive here at
Westminster hall for the lying in state
five days during which members of the
public can pay their respects in person
and on Monday the 19th of September now
a bank holiday at 11 o'clock the state
funeral at Westminster Abbey
with a committal service afterwards at
Windsor as the late Queen is finally
laid to rest
it will be beautifully put together
bringing together all the agencies of
the state and the Armed Forces with the
finest drill the best pageantry and the
noblest of ceremonial in Westminster
Abbey it will be
a great salute to a wonderful Queen
[Music]
the crowds have been growing with
days
bringing tributes to the queen and a
welcome to the new king Laura bundock
Sky News Westminster
so as we've been telling you the Queen's
coffin will leave Balmoral at 10 o'clock
this morning Sky's Greg mylam is there
for us today so Greg a difficult
appointment moment for the royal family
this what are the plans
yeah I think it is a real moment for the
royal family and the members of the
royal family who are still here of
course but also for the community and
and for those members of the royal staff
on the on the Balmoral uh estate the the
coffin has been at rest in the ballroom
um inside Balmoral for a number of days
now uh draped in the Royal Standard of
Scotland with the wreath of flowers as
well as so that those estate workers
many of whom have been in in the service
of the royal family for many years have
been able to pay their respects there of
course to the Queen's relationship with
them um built over many years here uh
and then at 10 A.M that that final
Journey Begins with six game Keepers
from the from the estate here taking the
the coffin from that Ballroom through a
small dining room to the to the entrance
Portico and then the hearse will begin
um The Journey here I think symbolic
that those members of staff are are
taking part in that in that process
because of those years of of that that
relationship and then the journey will
continue from here the first uh Port of
call if you like is a place called
ballot are about six or seven miles from
here a place that the queen was a
regular visitor to where they considered
her to be one of their neighbors one of
the community and where pretty much
everyone has a story about their their
meetings and their chats with the queen
over the years there will be a salute
there by the Lord Lieutenant of
aberdeenshire and it then continues that
that journey through a number of small
communities where people will have the
chance to to line the streets and and
pay their respects before it reaches
Aberdeen and makes its way past duthie
Park they're down to Dundee and finally
to to Edinburgh in the Palace of
Hollywood house so that Journey which
will last they tell us about six hours a
chance for the people of Scotland to to
mark this this last journey of the the
queen through Scotland
great great thanks very much indeed and
so from just after 10 o'clock this
morning we will bring you those pictures
of the Queen's funeral Cortez as it
begins its final Journey
well let's bring in now our
International Affairs editor Dominique
Whitehorn as well as the Queen's former
Royal Protection Officer Dick Griffin
good to see you both
um and Dominic first of all let's just
take a look at the scene shall we here
at Buckingham Palace the gates more
people arriving there in front of the
gates perhaps a little bit quieter than
at the same time yesterday
um but people still do seem to want to
come to pay tribute yeah I think the
numbers are steadily building I think
people are probably a bit pit off put
off by what they saw yesterday and the
number of people I've been speaking to
over there outside the gate saying they
got up early just because they wanted to
beat the crowds um also in the same
thing which which they felt they feel
they had they felt they had to come here
and that they couldn't stay at home they
felt that you know just watching on TV
wasn't enough they've come to lay
flowers to be with others and to and to
pay their respects
um and
um and sort of just just be part of the
moment I think because one woman said
you know 70 years of service doing a fan
fantastic job for it's not too much to
get up at three in the morning and drive
him from leicestershire
to to pay her respects and some people
can't a lot of people want to come to
the funeral but say they can't because
they've got holidays and things
the weather not cooperating again this
time it's sort of fog rather gloomy and
um unlike the rain we've had the
previous days but the same kind of
atmosphere of a mixture I think of
sadness uh people wanting to be part of
the moment to pay their respects and
also saying they're quite quite
apprehensive about the future but
they've been pretty reassured they say
by what they've heard from King Charles
and what they've seen of the succession
process so far
anti-griffin you were a royal Protection
Officer to the queen for 14 years so you
knew her well I mean do you think that
she would have been surprised if she
could have seen the scenes of this
outpouring of love for her Across the
Nation on the news of her death I don't
think she'd have been surprised but she
would be very very touched
um I mean she was loved by everybody and
and it's just a great Testament uh her
service and everything you did for this
country the way everyone's turning up I
mean I was around on Friday and when the
announcement was here and I could not
get the Victoria Station I mean there
were just so many thousands of people
around arriving and and there were
people arriving with flowers who I
wouldn't really experience skinheads
with earrings bringing big bunches of
flowers and it was just wonderful to see
really has reached so many people
absolutely and tell us a little bit
about your time working with her you I
mean you actually told a story to us on
Sky News in the Platinum Jubilee which
is now gone viral again on on Twitter
because you had such a rapport with her
that she had a real sense of humor
didn't she well she well she did and In
fairness I mean all the police officers
who work with the Majesty
um became very close to her because of
all the time you spent to her but yes
you're right um she didn't have a wicked
sense of humor and and you could pull a
leg and then of course the story about
the the tourists I didn't realize
because I was driving back from a
funeral an Exeter yesterday how viral it
gone but my son said to me last night if
I hear that damn story about the Taurus
again I'm throwing you out the window
should we should we increase his Agony
and just you might have to give us a
little potted up some summary of it
because some people might not know oh
really no I think very briefly if you
can so people know what we're talking
about well we're up at Balmoral and the
queen would go out for picnics and on
this occasion it was just myself and her
majesty and we'd gone for a walk up in
the hills and there's nobody normally
nobody around and there were two hikers
approaching us and it turned out there
was two American tourists on a walk-in
holiday
so the queen would obviously stop and
say hello and from the moment we spoke
it was obviously hadn't recognized the
queen and they were telling the queen
where they'd come from where they were
going to next and then the American
gentleman said to the queen and where do
you live what should I live in London
I've got a holiday home just the other
side of the hills how often you come up
here I've been coming out with over 80
years ever since I was a little girl
and he says oh we've been coming over
for eight years you must have met the
queen which is well I haven't but did
you meet so regularly and then the next
thing he comes I will put his armor
under my shoulder gives his camera to
the queen and asked him to take a
picture of the two of us that's
fantastic for realizing who she was I
just love that story and Buckingham
Palace obviously an important place of
work for you at times and you had your
retirement party there didn't you tell
us about that well I was very fortunate
because Christopher Guyton was then the
Queen's private secretary asked me what
I was going to do for a retirement party
and I really thought of it he said well
there's no need a Majesty wants you to
have your retirement party in the state
departments at Buckingham Palace you can
invite 200 people and she'll pay and of
course I don't know 200 people but I
soon did but what was really lovely is
when I actually arrived with my family
for the party
um one of my fellow colleagues that was
taking me to the office he said to me
there's a little old lady coming to your
party tonight I said what little old
lady he said the queen I said don't be
silly she doesn't go to anything thing
like this because once she does it for
one person she's got to do for everyone
she said well she's coming to yours
because I was with her this afternoon
and she said his dicks fell well party
tonight I'd love to have gone but he
hasn't invited me so Colin said to her
of course you can go mum is your party
you're the hostess well do you think
it's okay if I go unannounced and of
course it was a great thrill because
both her
um Prince Philip and the other Wessex
all turned up my retirement party and
met all my family so I was probably the
highlighting my career the fact that she
did that for me yeah that's very special
isn't it well dick Griffin I'm pleased
to say that you're with us for a few
hours this morning so we will
I'm sorry about that but it's lovely for
us anyway we will come back to you very
shortly and uh to you as well of course
Dominic thank you
now the Australian prime minister
Anthony albanesi has told Sky News that
he will not hold a referendum on whether
the country should become a republic in
his first term in an international
exclusive interview he said this was a
moment to show gratitude for the Queen's
service to Australia the Commonwealth
and the world the Queen's death has
reignited a debate about Australia's
relationship with the monarchy well
let's speak then to our correspondent
Cordelia Lynch who's in the Australian
Capital Canberra and Cordelia it was you
that did this interview of course with
the Australian prime minister so get us
up to date with exactly what he said
about the Australia's relationship with
the monarchy
[Music]
well Anthony Albanese has long been
known as a republican back in 2018 he
said that Australia needed an Australian
head of state but I think what he
recognizes now in this moment is that
this is a critical time for the country
to pour to show its respect and its
gratitude to the queen I think whatever
debate we have seen in the past rage
around Australia's relationship with the
monarchy is separate to its relationship
with the queen I have witnessed a really
deep love for the Monarch here she
visited the country 16 times she always
spoke for her fondness for it and
Anthony Albanese said that she was able
to console to comfort at the times when
the country most needed it that's during
floods for instance during natural
disasters she was there for them and he
doesn't think that this is a time to
discuss politics and he confirmed that
he would not be holding another
referendum on weather indeed Australia
should become a republic but I did press
him on whether he felt that Australian
people wanted to see the institution of
the monarchy evolved here's what he had
to say
well of course and and it has evolved
and it will continue to evolve it will
need to continue to move with the times
but the bigger questions about our
Constitution are not ones for this
current period This is a period in which
we are showing the grief that so many
Australians are feeling at the moment
showing our deep respect and admiration
for the contribution of the queen to
Australia and today of course the the
transition formally here to recognize
that with the Queen's passing King
Charles automatically became the head of
state of Australia
one of the perceived successes of Queen
Elizabeth's Reign here is that many
people felt she stayed outside of
politics and Anthony Albanese he said he
felt that King Charles would be very
conscious of the need to do that too he
will be going to the United Kingdom for
the Queen's funeral and he will also be
meeting the king
Cordelia Lynch in Canberra thanks very
much indeed for that so let's just bring
you these pictures from overnight now
foreign
not sure if we can bring you those
pictures but let me tell you what uh was
happening there in Australia Today
marked the formal proclamation of the
accession of Charles as king of
Australia in a ceremony in the country's
capital Canberra from where Cordelia was
just reporting from the Proclamation was
marked by a 21 gun that salute
foreign
New Zealand there have been two 21 gun
salutes to acknowledge the proclamation
of King Charles III
well the salutes took place in
Wellington and in Auckland and prime
minister Jacinda Arden spoke of the loss
felt by the death of Queen Elizabeth but
also the welcoming of a new era
for 70 years Queen Elizabeth served the
people of aotearoa New Zealand with
unwavering Duty
for the vast majority of new zealanders
she is the only monarch we have known
and so upon who death we enter a time of
change
one filled with sadness for her passing
but also gratitude for the life she
lived in the example she said King
Charles has long-haired an affection for
Altera New Zealand and has consistently
demonstrated his deep care for our
nation
this relationship is deeply valued by
our people
let's take a look now how the front
pages of the Sunday papers are covering
the story of the Queen's death and its
aftermath and reunited for granny reads
the front of the mirror as The Prince
and Princess of Wales and the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex are pictured together
for the first time in mourning and
there's the inside page coverage of it
peace for Grant reads the front of the
Sunday people as they also lead with
that same story
the Sunday Times also leads with the
Royal Walkabout their headline warring
Windsors awkward truce
to honor the queen
The Daily Star on Sunday looks at the
two Royal couples reunion as well with
the four pictured together in mourning
reunited in sorrow reads the front of
the Sunday Telegraph
Sunday Express goes with the headline
together with Granny William hands Olive
Branch to Harry
and the same story is on the front of
the sun this morning the sun on Sunday
their headline all four one
the front of the Observer this morning
in contrast pictures our new King
Charles III as he ascends the throne
so join me now is the former policy
advisor to the queen and Royal household
at Mary McLeod there is the observance
front page you can see it there now Mary
McLeod we will talk about that Windsor
Walkabout in a moment but first let's
turn our attention to what's happening
today and the funeral Cortez Begins for
what's been described by King Charles as
the Queen's final journey and I noticed
that there are game Keepers who are
going to be first moving her coffin and
it has been lying in the Ballroom in in
Balmoral for the Royal household to
visit and pay their respect
just wanted from your inside point of
view what this will be like for the
Royal household at the moment well I
feel every day just now we're living a
whole lifetime each day as we see so
much and develop and today is will be
another real I think really sad day as
we as we get a glimpse to
um of the Cortez for the first time but
it's starting off in a very personal way
and I think it was a lovely touch to let
the gamekeepers actually
um move that body because I think it's
they're ones who she would know
um the queen at Balmoral and I've just
come back from there I mean the queen
was always it was her it was a home it
was something where a family were there
they had freedom to to relax and enjoy
and have fun and and she was very close
to the land and the people on the land
so it's again a really personal
Community touch which is just some
bodies what the queen was like and
therefore and then of course we will see
that
um
travel through Scotland from
aberdeenshire down towards Edinburgh and
again people will be able to you know
see that Express their sorrow and and so
I think it'll be really sad moving day
and then of course get to Hollywood
house where
um you know I remember my time with the
queen there and it was again about it's
a it's a lovely small Palace and very
personal and and she will be in the the
throne room so I think this will be a
really sad Moving Day for for everyone
involved and but it feels right that the
queen is you know a traveling the the
length of Scotland
um before of course she travels
um to London but it's it'll be again
people will just have a chance to
express that sorrow and sadness at
seeing
um the the passing of the the late Queen
and um and and a little bit of great
that the sort of community can be
involved in it and we did see members of
the royal family up at Balmoral were you
there when that happened do you see
you've just come down I was there before
the queen died and but again just seeing
the members of their old family
yesterday both in Scotland and Windsor
but in Scotland it was you saw the
emotion and this is a family grieving
and it was therefore you know just
getting a glimpse of that I mean we knew
that would be the case but just coming
out to read some of the messages of
course that brought up
um additional grief but just I think
it's also that's comforting too to see
the amazing things that people are doing
reaching out writing their their
thoughts and memories about the queen
and what the queen meant to them and
therefore it was it was lovely that they
did that well yes and and you mentioned
that there were two moments one more
than two in fact but there was one at
Balmoral but let's talk about the
Windsor Walkabout as well where we saw
William and Harry together seen together
for the first time for a while with
their Partners how important do you
think that was that kind of symbol of
unity I think incredibly important and
really good for the new king and he he
expressed already in his address how
important each member of his family is
um and therefore just seeing them
together there's real strength in that
and there always was
um strength in the four of them a
working together and and they're sharing
in this grief and it reminded me also
about their mother's death where they
were there together supporting each
other and and in times of grief and a
really difficult moments sometimes grief
can bring you together and unite and I
thought that was a lovely way to do it
yesterday well yes and and obviously I
mean some of the papers are suggesting
that the atmosphere was a little awkward
and a lot of people will be watching
closely to see how they interacted but
from having worked with the queen one
can only assume that this was something
that she would want to see oh completely
it's I think it's really really
important and you sort of feel that the
queen will be looking down and just
smiling and very warmly at seeing the
the four of them together other it's
definitely something that she would have
and she kept close of course to it to
Prince Harry and whilst he has been
abroad but it's I think just for for
right now it was really important to do
that and more so I think for the new
king to where you know he is starting
off his new Arena Sovereign and he
showed very clearly his family right
behind him well yes and what do you make
of how he is is handling this this new
weight of responsibility
I mean and he's grieving too so you know
and it's not long since he buried his
father so it really is a momentous time
for for him but I thought the accession
council yesterday was done really well
and professionally and what are you know
a special thing for us all to get a
glimpse of that and see some advice for
the first time yeah so you know and the
privy Council doing the tasks they had
to do
um for that so you know we're getting to
to see the glimpse of what the process
is like and and I think that just
includes all of us in it so it makes us
feel more bonded and and part off the
the process but everything he has said
um over the last few days has just I
think touched the hearts of people right
across the country and around the world
as he pledges
um to be there and have that loyalty
Duty
um to the to the country and to the
people of this country and of course to
the Commonwealth of Beyond and and just
a quick thought on on the week ahead we
now have date for the funeral estate
funeral Monday week tomorrow week a bank
holiday for people how do you expect the
week to pan out
well I think I mean there will be things
going on each day and I think people it
gives people time to come and express
their sorrow and a be involved in some
way I think everybody wants to do
something because they want to show that
they are this is a new era and and you
want to both show that you miss and
mourn and grieve for the late Queen but
at the same time you're there to support
the the new king and um and I think
people will want to feel part of that
too so it feels like that we will be
well Mary McLeod former policy advisor
to the queen and Royal household thanks
very much indeed for joining us this
morning we appreciate it
well Queen Elizabeth became Monarch five
years after India's independence she
made three state visits to the country
during her Reign so let's find out how
her death has been received there
Neville Lazarus is in Delhi for us this
morning so Neville what has a reaction
been
it's been a bit builted out here the
government has announced a day off
mourning where the national flag will
fly half mast and there will be no
government function of entertainment
today at all now the queen has visited
India three times in the past in 1961
1983 and 1997 25 years ago and each one
with a life partner Prince Philip they
have they have gone driven been driven
down this very large but which you see
the building behind me is the
president's house where and the other
buildings which are the seat of power
and government and where she would have
been given a ceremonial welcome now the
queen has has often said that she she is
very grateful for the hospitality of
India and the diversity of the country
is an inspiration for all she has been
the chief guest of the Republic Day
Parade in India which is the highest I
mean the most important government
calendar date in the country she's also
given speeches to thousands of people at
the ramlin which is a few miles away
from here but most importantly she's
traveled quite a lot in the country in
different parts in in the South and the
and the West and East as well
and uh and and people are in awe and
admiration for the unwavering Duty and
dedication she has towards the
institution and this is now a new India
it is a confident Point aspiring and
assertive India where the younger
population is 25 is almost half half of
this country's population and they are
quite disconnected with the Royal with
the royal family monarchy and now it's
left up to the King Charles III and his
family to make that strong bonding
enduring relation with the largest
Commonwealth country in the world
Neville thanks very much indeed
now Australian prime minister Anthony
Albanese has told Sky News that he will
not hold a referendum on whether the
country should become a republic in his
first term he said this was a moment to
show gratitude for the Queen's service
to Australia the Commonwealth and to the
world so here's that International
exclusive interview with our
correspondent Cordelia Lynch the
Australian's relationship with the queen
appears enduring
what do you think
the Australian's relationship with the
queen appears enduring
what do you think it was about her Reign
that achieved that special connection
I think the the queen was with
Australians during times of Celebration
but was also with Australia at our times
of difficulties and Queen Elizabeth
always reached out to give that Comfort
to Australians at our time of of need
and she was such a a respected figure
regardless of where people stand on the
political spectrum that 70 years of
public service that that Devotion to
duty is something that holds her in in
such high regard it's reignited a debate
about a republic do you think in this
moment that that is appropriate so
perhaps even opportunistic
well I I am the person of you and I've
made it uh clear that now is the time
for us to pay tribute
to the life of Queen Elizabeth II to
give thanks for her service to Australia
to the Commonwealth and to the world and
that is the focus that I have when it
comes to the monarchy do you think
though Australians want to see the
institution evolve
uh will of course and and it has evolved
and it will continue uh to evolve uh it
will need to continue to move with the
times but the bigger questions about our
Constitution are not ones for uh this
current period uh this is a period in
which uh we are showing the grief that
so many Australians are feeling at the
moment uh showing our deep respect and
admiration for the contribution of the
queen to Australia and today of course
the the transition formally here to
recognize that with the Queen's passing
King Charles automatically became the
head of state of Australia you will be
attending the Queen's funeral you'll be
meeting with the King how do you want to
see your relationship with him I look
forward very much uh to meeting King
Charles I have met him before in his uh
his previous capacity and I had the
honor of meeting Queen Elizabeth at
Buckingham Palace and Prince Charles was
there on that occasion at the first
meeting of of the G20 and I thought it
was a beautiful statement that King
Charles made in his first statement as
as our new sovereign
either and as we've been telling you the
Prime Minister of Antigua and Barbuda
has said that he will call a referendum
on the country being a republic within
three years well the latest country to
become a republic was Barbados which
parted ways with the monarchy last
November and I'm joined Now by Guy
Hewitt the former High Commissioner of
Barbados to the United Kingdom guy here
very good to see you here and so
Barbados cut ties with the queen last
year we now have the Prime Minister of
Antigua and Barbuda saying that he
intends to hold a referendum on the
subject Anthony Albanese in Australia
saying he's ruling that out for one term
but do you think there will be more
sovereign states who are reconsidering
their relationship with the monarchy now
that the queen has died
I think in light of the transition there
is going to be consideration more
consideration given to this but I think
there's an important point to make about
barbados's journey to become a republic
was not an
anti-monarchic stance but really a
progression in terms of the journey
towards self-determination we broke
previously with the privy Council and
the Caribbean has a court of justice as
our final Court we we saw becoming a
republican having a citizen as our head
of state as just the expression of a
national aspiration of
self-determination so I think when
countries look at this it's more along
the lines of how do we see ourselves in
the future
um representing and speaking of
ourselves for ourselves rather than
necessarily a break with monarchy
although that is a necessary result I
think what the motivators may be may be
one towards that self-expression and how
will the people of Barbados then respond
do you think to the queen dying I mean
there was a complicated relationship
some some might see the Barbados is
having cut imperialist ties for example
and a difficult part so how well I would
say I mean speaking personally there
there is that sense of personal loss Her
Majesty was an icon of the the 20th
century and into the 21st her her life
of service is one to be celebrated and
let me use this opportunity to convey
condolences to all those around the
Commonwealth particularly the members of
our family who are suffering this loss
at this time but
Barbados will feel that loss because up
to last year she was our Queen she was
the queen of Barbados and and this is an
individual that was held in very very
high regard in Barbados
um and I dare say around the
Commonwealth which is an important point
because even as Barbados and other
countries may decide to establish create
its own head of state there will always
be linked back to the UK back to the
monarchy in terms of being members of
the Commonwealth and I think one of the
lasting legacies of her majesty around
the Commonwealth was her role in keeping
this family of Nations together as Sir
John Major said she was the invisible
glue that kept the Commonwealth together
and we are very very thankful for that
and you met her on many occasions the
privilege of and and we shared two
passions the Commonwealth and horse
racing not necessarily in that order sir
Michael Stout is from Barbados and and
we have celebrated him as a champion
train in the UK and Her Majesty's
passion for for horse racing everyone
knew how one great that was
oh was she to deal with how did you find
her
there was a resilience a dignity but
also I would say a quiet faith
that had will have a lasting impact I
say on me and all those who had the
privilege of me too
and what about King Charles you've also
come into contact with him haven't you
in your work we have and and we worked
the princess Trust International did a
project in Barbados and I was pleased
that we were able to collaborate on that
but also Barbados took an active role in
ensuring the stability of the
Commonwealth by supporting his
succession as the head of the
Commonwealth and I think given the time
he has had to prepare for this role
given his experience in the Commonwealth
he is going to make an outstanding head
he has spoken to much of the issues that
Commonwealth is concerned about
sustainable development the environment
of small states so we think he's coming
into the role understanding its members
understanding its needs and is going to
help it go from strength to strength and
tell us a little bit about why you think
that the Commonwealth is so important
it's clearly a big priority for King
Charles and was for the queen why does
it matter I think it reflects a
significant Legacy
um
that
it's unusual within a European Colonial
setting if you look across Europe many
of the former Colonial Powers have
strained relationships with their former
colleagues the Commonwealth is
considered a family of Nations and that
family I think has been kept together
because of her majesty or through her
majesty who was able to move away from
old redundant Notions of Imperial
loyalty or european signal um
superiority and engage with the emerging
heads of state from around the
Commonwealth as her equals and ideas if
they responded very favorably and have
stayed in the Commonwealth simply
because she was able to make that
adjustment and put aside all Antiquated
Notions and I think King Charles is
going to be going to do the same and
continue the Legacy that his mother
created well guy Hewitt former High
Commissioner of Barbados in the UK
pleasure to have you here this morning
thank you so much yes thank you
well over the course of her Reign the
queen became perhaps the most
photographed person ever to have lived
and Her Image has been used in
everything from pop art to punk Katie
Spencer has been looking at the life of
a cultural icon
she was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous Her
Image at the core of British culture
[Applause]
coronation was groundbreaking the first
ever to be televised watched by 27
million it was the premier of sorts for
the lifelong pivotal role she'd play in
maintaining the Allure of brand Britain
I remember when I was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
Prince Philip who was about the best
looking man in the world I mean
everybody at school had a crush on him
and I kept scrapbooks of the queen
everything that was in the papers or the
magazines I cut out and it was um
princess Elizabeth's wedding and she was
a fairy tale princess she really was she
was gorgeous he had a hand span waist
big wonderful eyes we all just loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her Platinum Jubilee
[Music]
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
I always keep one for emergencies
so do I
I keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown one of the countless screen
portrayals fueled by the Relentless
public infatuation with this woman
imagine I'm going to drop everything and
come down to London before I attend to
my grandchildren who've just lost their
mother
celebrated by our greatest artists from
Lucy and Freud to Andy Warhol her
portraits now a huge part of her Legacy
I remember when I was first commissioned
it was a daunting Prospect you know the
Queen the most portrayed woman in
history I asked if man would like to
rest in between shots that'd be fine
just I was conscious of all the light
onto her so she closed her eyes and that
was the moment it was you know
I didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at sitting for artists was part
of her cultural duty but she also
inspired some significant unofficial art
an anti-establishment Target epitomized
on the cover of the 1977 sex pistol
single a defaced lightness and easy Act
of rebellion if you enter most West
Indians home at the time they would
probably have a picture of the queen on
a wall as well as a picture of Jesus
while Rock photographer Dennis Morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the Queen's
Silver Jubilee He was following the
pistol's provocative Boat Trip on the
Thames at that time the monarchy was
very very strong we were not
particularly like for being
anti-monarchy in that sense As I Grew
Older and knew more and more about it I
have a very very deep respect for the
queen and my respect for the queen is
this that basically it takes a lot to
hold something like that together in the
way she had over the years so you know
for me big respect for that in that
sense
while many British artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honors for services to the
entertainment sector
for 70 years she was champion of the
Arts for those who embraced her
magisterial Authority or rebelled
against it she inspired her influence
over British culture irrefutable and
unique
thank you
call everything
that's very kind Katie Spencer Sky News
well here moving once again is our
International Affairs editor Dominic
Blackhorn as well as the Queen's former
Royal Protection Officer Dick Griffin so
welcome back to YouTube and Dominic the
crowds are beginning to build aren't
they a bit of a slower start this
morning than yesterday but people do
still want to come and pay their
respects here at Buckingham Palace yeah
maybe it's Sunday morning or maybe
they're put off by what they've seen
over the last few days and um a lot of
people I've spoken to wanted to get here
early and got up very early three or
four in the morning to beat the crowds
and maybe people think that they didn't
want to sort of come out and such great
numbers today we'll see the weather's
certainly not cooperating again but we
have seen thousands of people and we
over the last few days coming I think
numbers that have surprised a lot of
people and I think the question a lot of
people a lot of us had even before when
we knew the queen was was Ill was when
she dies eventually will it be like
Diana's death and what happened after
that because that's the only real event
that we can sort of connect it to or
have a reference to and I think it's
it's gonna it feels different but it's
still all similar numbers and a lot of
people saying that they just they feel
they want to come here and pay their
respects so people I've been talking to
today and it's just simply not good
enough being at home that doesn't
sort of work emotionally for them they
feel they need to make the effort make
the journey and come here and pay their
respects and obviously we'll see that in
coming days and today as the as the
coffin emerges from uh Balmoral in the
hearse people will be lining the route
there as one woman said to me that that
will be that's when she thinks it will
really hit home a heart-wrenching moment
she said it will be to see the coffin
come out and as we sort of see physical
proof of what we know has happened but
see it's it's there and and the Earth is
making its way finally down towards here
for the funeral next week and
essentially I think people do want to
come here and have some connection with
others and kind of have that sense of
shared grief for someone that I think
lots of people feel that they knew in
some ways it obviously seen her on
television screens over the years but
dick you actually did know her and you
knew what she was really like and
there's many sides of her no doubt that
the public never saw and that you did
one example of that I know is that you
you I know have a little story about
being in one of Prince Edward's plays
all right yes do you tell us okay um
well when we were at Cambridge
um 83 86 Edward was into amateur
Dramatics and they were doing this one
student play and for some reason one of
the students never ever used to come to
rehearsals and then the night before
Edward handed me this piece of paper and
so you need to learn this I said why do
I need to learn it well you're the
you're the mission actor we didn't want
to tell you because you made 101 excuses
not to do it
so anyway the next night I had to go and
do this little sketch and seemed to have
gone okay and I thought no more of it
next morning commissioner staff officer
Rings up
Mr Griffin the commissioner is furious
with you what on Earth are you doing in
Cambridge last night
so I said I did this little student play
he said when the commissioner came on
and said I was watching news at 10 last
night and your face was everywhere don't
act anymore I said well there's a slight
problem there the Princess of Wales is
coming up to watch the show tonight I've
got an understudy well you can do
tonight but no more I said I'm afraid
not sir I said on Saturday we're going
down to Windsor Castle to do it for a
Majesty the queen and the entire Royal
Family oh my God anyway we go down to
Windsor Castle and they build it then
yes we had to he built a beautiful stage
in the Waterloo chamber all the Royal
House of the guests come and a Magister
Queen had a dinner party before and then
she came in and sat down and when she
sat down she was directly below a
skylight and there was a awful night and
the rain was coming in and the rain was
dripping down onto her head
so all the members of the household
started offering our seats and no no
that's okay she literally gets up goes
and sits on the floor puts a program
over her head and she sits there for an
hour and a half watching the show I mean
that just shows how wonderful the queen
is and how down to earth that's right
and another instance of her of her being
very Down to Earth was actually when she
had an accident she broke her wrist
didn't she she did yes we were
Sandringham and she fell off a horse and
broke her wrist and we obviously had to
take her to the local casualty Hospital
and members of the public think you have
problems getting seen to in a casualty
Hospital you try walking in with the
Majesty the queen
um the young nurse that met us first of
all she was absolutely fine
but then the first doctor came oh no no
no I can't touch the you're the queen
um we'll have to get my boss so we get
the senior consultant to come in oh no
no no no I can't touch you you're the
queen so anyway they did the X-ray to
prove the break was there and then we
had to take a Majesty back to
Sandringham while we waited for the big
white Chief to come in from his homes it
was a Saturday and they eventually rang
us up and said yeah he's arrived now you
can bring the queen back so I think it
took four hours to get the Queen's arm
put in plaster so she had to wait like
everybody else longer than everyone else
probably that's right oh and she dealt
with it because humans oh she did they
put on in a sling we took it away and
brought it back for the plaster of Paris
to be put on okay well
fabulous to hear your your stories of
someone who really knew her at dick
Griffin thanks very much indeed and
Dominic thanks very much to you too
so here is the scene at Balmoral this
morning as you can see a huge number of
flowers have been brought by people
locally to pay tribute to the queen
Balmoral of course where she spent her
last days and from where her coffin will
begin begin its final Journey today from
10 o'clock this morning it will leave
Balmoral it'll be carried by some of her
game Keepers out of Balmoral to begin
that Journey so involving some of the
royal household in that beginning of its
final Journey that will end up of course
at the state funeral
Westminster Abbey which we now know will
be a week on Monday so that's the scene
there at Balmoral this morning a rather
somber mood there
in Scotland ahead of that funeral Cortez
beginning its Journey
flowers here too at Buckingham Palace
being broad but many of them being
removed by
officials taken to a memorial flower
garden in the nearby Green Park
but a few are still attached to the
front Gates of Buckingham Palace and
there are a few Candles there as well
that have been burning overnight
so we'll return to Balmoral a little bit
later when they start to move the
Queen's coffee and that's from about 10
o'clock this morning but in the meantime
let's uh take you through how some of
the newspapers are covering at this
story I'm joined Now by Royal historian
at Tessa Dunlop and also little
political editor at the Sunday Mirror at
Nigel Nelson for a look at some of the
inside Pages you'll have to tell me
who's kicking off because I haven't been
organized enough to look ahead Nigel we
can take it away so that um
I was researching her 15 Prime Ministers
that she's gone through 16 if you count
Harold Wilson who popped up twice
um so that's the total she appointed she
also went through seven popes and
goodness that knows how many presidents
what was interesting about it was just
how much detail the queen had and her
prime ministers didn't so Winston
Churchill dismissed her as being a mere
child and he was certainly pulled up on
his first audience that he'd not read
all the telegrams remember ambassadors
around the world she had and picked him
up on one from Baghdad and said isn't it
interesting what's going on there
Churchill knew nothing about it Harold
Wilson came a Cropper when she suddenly
sprung on him that there's a very
interesting new town about to be built
in
um near Bletchley Harold Wilson didn't
know anything about him he hadn't read
his papers that was Milton Keynes but
she seemed to have the the grasp of
detail that even her prime ministers
didn't over the years they came to Value
what she knew the knowledge she built up
the fact that basically she had much
more experience than they did about the
whole world of politics and they went to
her for advice and they went here for
advice notice in your article and you
think she she wasn't too partial to
Boris Johnson no and I think that
because with lack of attention to detail
and obviously it didn't help terribly
with Boris Johnson that he had to
apologize to her formerly Twice first
pieroging Parliament when the Supreme
Court said
um that that he couldn't done that and
the second time and probably more
seriously was when
um he helped that number 10 held a
lockdown party on the eve of Prince
Philip's funeral oh yes timing was never
his strong point was it Boris Johnson's
um to the times yeah and looking at
politicians overseas I've been
fascinated by macro over the last few
days the headline in the times is
Republican France Mourns Monarch
referring of course to their heads
chopped off of their models way back in
1793 but macron they're flying or
raising the Union Jack in front of the
Elise Palace and talking to us in
English for three minutes saying you
know she might well be your queen but to
us she's the queen questions of course
of whether he will come to the funeral
certainly in 1952 the French president
came to George VI funeral and the
edinburghs as they were before princess
Elizabeth became Queen their first
overseas tour was to Paris in 1948 and
she wowed them and it was all the time
of the Dior new look really tight waist
and big skirts and the queen was
pregnant with Charles nobody knew but
she couldn't wear this new fashion she
was in a rather stodgy heart little
dress
she spoke brilliant French better than
Prince Phillips oh that's interesting to
know and in fact I think it's the Sunday
telegrapher I write not the times in
case anyone's trying to find it it
wasn't the correction it was just
information for the for the audience
um and let's move on shall we to your
next choice and this is focusing on kiss
armor isn't it yes and this was the fact
that Kirsten affirmed the oath rather
than
um schwart God uh yesterday in
Parliament uh kirstrama is a um an
atheist although he respects people of
Faith what was interesting I think that
um I only sort of mentioned that because
of the way that Charles dealt with it at
the accession council where he described
himself as defender of faith and it was
faith in the singular there'd been some
speculation he wanted to be a defender
of Faith to actually represent
um our Multicultural multi-religious
Britain and in fact he's obviously
decided no that what he what he actually
is is the Supreme governor of the Church
of England and that is the faith that he
is the defender of he goes back to Henry
VII and so he's decided that that is the
way he should be as the Monarch it
wouldn't stop him embracing other faiths
but I think that he was quite good he's
he stuck rigidly again to the
Constitution he might have looked a
little bit presumptuous if he'd
suggested he was the defender of all
faiths what do you think because he's
officially got the role as the head of
the church exactly and now to the to the
mail on Sunday and back to those boys uh
William and Harry two two points to be
made on this page
um the first is of course the male have
got a body language expert to have a
look at what they're referring to as
Prince Harry's barrier gesture this is
when apparently Prince Harry does this a
lot he sort of puts his hand across his
jacket like that this is a protective
defensive slightly insecure move
apparently they reckon that the new
Prince of Wales is much more secure and
of course we do know that William
apparently instigated this Walkabout
yesterday which is dominated all the
front pages in today's papers but after
all he is in the more secure position he
is now officially heir to the throne
he's fully embedded in this giant
institution of monarchy and I really
feel it's got to be front footed that
reproshmoor by William and by Charles
because they've got the big seats
whatever people may say about Harry and
Megan and the millions that they're
ironing you know they are just a couple
on their own and I think it has to come
from from the royal family really those
efforts to build Bridges well yeah and
interesting how important that is to the
public or not I mean what do you think
Nigel I mean people love to see these
scenes to see these four together
meeting the crowds to people want to see
them because it is so popular or do they
want to see them because they feel a
connection with the royal family and
they really care they want Unity they
think that's what the queen would have
wanted I think it goes above the idea of
the dressing celebrities I think that it
it really is something that they knew
the queen really did want they wanted
William and Harry to get back together
and the joy that you saw at Windsor
Castle yesterday went unexpectedly they
both came out for the Walkabout you
could see that people were really happy
that they were back together it might
have been a little bit awkward there may
be a lot of ground to cover still but
people were really delighted that they
would actually come out together it's a
bit of both isn't it it is a soap opera
and it's a family that we thought was
really invested and it's a real family
yeah and also at the bottom of this page
a tag on to the relationship and the
institution of monarchy versus this new
sort of American royal family Archie
apparently is still not a prince this is
an announcement or a post made by
Buckingham Palace yesterday Archie
lillibet in line to succession obviously
they've moved up to sixth and seventh
place now under what was stipulated by
George V in 1917 the grandchildren of
the Monarch are automatically Prince and
princesses but by all accounts those
titles haven't been taken up they remain
master and Miss mank back in Windsor
which is interesting now does that mean
Harry and Megan have chosen because they
wanted their children to be ordinary
people not to give them those titles or
does it come from Charles himself who
knows very interesting and we've got
we've got 15 seconds can we talk dogs
very quickly yeah well Susie who was
with the queen she took Susie yes
she took her with her a honeymoon she's
given it for an 18th birthday there were
three in that marriage from the very
beginning apparently Philip used to
frequently trip over them corgi's
descendants right through to 1918 the
last one died Willow but she then had
doggies which is a hybrid by the way of
a dashund and a corgi because you know
one cookie got busy with Princess
Margaret's dash hound interesting I
don't know we will leave it anyway um
Tessa and Nigel thanks both very much
indeed good to have your take on the
papers
do stay with us that we're going to have
live coverage from Buckingham Palace and
Balmoral throughout the morning this
morning as the Queen's funeral Cortez
begins at 10 o'clock do stay with us
one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George become our only lawful and
rightful leads Lord Charles III
three cheers for his majesty the king
hip hip
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone thank you so much thank you
everyone
[Applause]
hello good morning from Buckingham
Palace the Queen's funeral Cortez will
leave our moral making its way to
Edinburgh in what King Charles described
as his mother's last great journey
[Music]
thank you
a final farewell to Scotland the Queen's
neighbors here in the village of balator
will have the opportunity to say goodbye
as the Cortez passes through the village
[Music]
no Republic referendum in my first term
in an exclusive International exclusive
Australia's prime minister Tel Sky News
there'll be no break with the monarchy
in the near future
will need to continue to move with the
times but the bigger questions about our
Constitution are not ones for this
current period
the Prime Minister of Antigua and
Barbuda says he will call for a
referendum on a republic as the queen
prepares to meet the Commonwealth
Secretary General this morning
reunited in their grief the new Prince
and Princess of Wales joined the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex during a walkabout
at Windsor
from portraits to pop celebrating the
queen as a cultural icon
and we'll take a look at how this
morning's newspapers are marking this
moment in history
[Music]
hello good morning from Buckingham
Palace the Queen's coffin will this
morning begin the journey to its final
resting place in what King Charles has
described as his mother's last great
journey
thousands are expected to line The Roots
as the Queen's funeral Cortez moves
along the first part of its route to
Edinburgh
well the Queen's coffin which is
currently in the ballroom at Balmoral
will be carried by six gamekeepers from
the estate and lifted into the hearse at
10 A.M
the funeral Cortez will make its way to
Aberdeen passing through balloter a
Boyne bankery and Peter Cooter arriving
in Aberdeen at around 11 20 this morning
and will move through the city's suburbs
the King George VI Bridge which was
opened By Her Majesty's mother in 1941
is also on route
next the Cortez will head through the
Angus Countryside past brecon arriving
in Dundee at around 2PM where it'll
drive around the city on the King's Way
it'll then head towards Perth across the
frighten bridge and cross over the
Queensbury Crossing heading towards
Edinburgh the Cortez will pass by
Edinburgh Castle and will head down the
Royal mile to the Palace of Hollywood
house arriving at around 4pm
the coffin will rest in the throne room
to allow staff at the palace to pay
their respects
well meanwhile new details have been
released about the Queens lying in state
in London as well as her funeral at
Westminster Abbey which will take place
on Monday the 19th of September that as
the new Prince and Princess of Wales and
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex were
reunited in Windsor for a walkabout our
Royal correspondent Laura bundog reports
and what will unfold in the coming days
from traditional ceremony heralding and
proclaiming a new sovereign
to a windsor Walkabout bringing Brothers
together and differences set aside
[Music]
[Applause]
a historic moments which Crowds Are
Gathering to witness
at the moment so despite whatever
is going on outside of that so it's nice
nice to see I like to see them ending
the bridges and that sort of thing but
who knows it's been very hurtful for the
queen for the family so yeah if they can
put that to rest and start a fresh that
would probably Professor will do
the new King has duties and meetings he
also has to plan his mother's funeral
this morning the Queen's coffin will
leave Balmoral for the Palace of
holyrood house in Edinburgh
on Monday afternoon the coffin will be
taken to Saint Giles cathedral in
Edinburgh the king and queen consort and
other members of the family will follow
in procession
for 24 hours the coffin will rest in the
cathedral so the public can pay their
respects
later that evening the king and other
Royals will hold a vigil
on Tuesday the king and queen consort
will visit Northern Ireland and that
evening the Queen's coffin arrives in
London and rests at Buckingham Palace
the following day on Wednesday the
coffin will be taken to the Palace of
Westminster in silent procession
the Queen's coffin will arrive here at
Westminster hall for the lying in state
five days during which members of the
public can pay their respects in person
and on Monday the 19th of September now
a bank holiday at 11 o'clock the state
funeral at Westminster Abbey
with a committal service afterwards at
Windsor as the lake Queen is finally
laid to rest
it will be beautifully put together
bringing together all the agencies of
the state and the Armed Forces with the
finest drill the best pageantry and the
noblest of ceremonial in Westminster
Abbey it will be
a great salute to a wonderful Queen
[Music]
the crowds have been growing with
thousands and thousands expected in the
coming days bringing tributes to the
queen and a welcome to the new king
Laura bundock Sky News Westminster
so as we've been telling you the Queen's
coffin will leave Balmoral at 10 o'clock
this morning Skies Greg Milam is there
for us this morning and James Matthews
is also on the route of the coffin Greg
to you first of all this is quite a
moment for the royal family isn't it as
the coffin leaves Balmoral
yeah I think very poignant for the
members of the royal family who are
still here at Balmoral we saw some of
them yesterday of course but also for
the community and the people who work on
the estate the people live in the
surrounding area a very significant
moment the Queen's coffin has been at
rest in the ballroom uh inside baumroll
for a number of days now draped in the
the Royal Standard of Scotland with a
wreath of flowers uh on top of it it's
been a chance for those workers on the
estate many of whom have been in the
service of the royal family for many
years to pay their respects before the
the coffin begins its journey and that
Journey will begin at 10 A.M when six of
the gamekeepers from the estate will
will lift that coffin and carry it from
the ballroom through a small dining room
and then to the entrance Portico and
into the hearse for that journey to
begin and I think the symbolism there of
of the members of Staff the people who
the queen knew and worked with for so
long uh being part of that procession is
is really key I think for those
arranging what's uh what's happening
here and then that that Journey will
begin they describe the scene here and
inside Balmoral as one of quiet dignity
and that I think fitting for what will
be the the beginning of the Queen's last
journey through Scotland
and James Matthews are
which is on the roads are people
Gathering there do they want to be able
to witness this moment
they are it's early it's still a couple
of hours to go and already you can see
behind me several dozen people booking
their places in the village that is a
15-minute drive from the bar model
estate they knew the queen here they
know the royal family here because their
Village is was the Queen's Village she
used to come here on a regular basis uh
shopping walking around the village
nodding hello to the local people here
she was regarded with pride as a member
of the community let me show you uh a
tribute knitted for the queen on top of
the the post box in the Central Square
here that's her majesty and that was put
up overnight and you can see a knitted
Angel and Fleur at her feet with the
message thank you your majesty made with
love by Facebook torphin's knitted post
box that's a nice touch by the villagers
here this morning let's speak to a
prominent villager here in ballater the
Reverend David Barr of Glenn Mick Church
David hello
um talk to me about this occasion what
this means here to people here
well her majesty has been coming here
all our life as a child and uh if you
could imagine when she was in the big
cities and she had to be maybe Stan
trimming proper with a resistor and not
be able to play but when she got to Bill
Morrow she would be able to do
cartwheels with her sisters she would
just be able to be a child and I think
that stuck with her so that's why Bob
Maro became really special and then when
she
became Queen
she held on to that and knew that and so
she would I think when she came in
through the gates
she hung her crown up on the door
and then he went and and she was a
loving wife
our mom I get on and then later on I get
it Grant and an aunt and been able to do
normal things
and because she really served her
country
over life majority of the people who are
loving all their life she's been her
Queen this Village wants to historically
I've only been here eight years but
historically wants to give something
back and I think giving that back was
trying to give that little bit of
normality so yes in their younger years
their Majesty would come in and Shop
here are the royal family still do to
today and this is a time to
to see that with pride and honor
but in five weeks time
if you were to come up here today and
say did you see a royal I would say no
even if I saw one two minutes ago I
wouldn't I definitely just would lie
through my teeth so I know that so that
does that part of here the Privacy was
guarded privacy is guarded and cherished
and cherished because
Libra this is her Village
now for the royal family that I thought
about this to trying to put it into
perspective
of King Charles
maybe said his younger brother Edward
Manchester United is playing Dortmund
let's go down the pub and watch it never
happened never will but we take that as
a normality so to try and give back
that because they are so precious to us
yeah and tell me about the sense of loss
oh I get it loss uh
when it was announced
I came down to a ring the church bells
70 bills one for each year of rain
I'm a six foot three guy a x Navy X
realm evil Commando
Glasgow
I went up that church
and I cried
everybody here you see them all crying
and I think the TV has been on TV it's
on world TV and it should be its
earthqueen it's the Commonwealth the
world's Queen the Commonwealth Queen
and it's been subliminally in where life
says well she's been on her our money on
a postie stamps we all had Christmas
dinner we all go around three o'clock
our Christmas dinners are all set around
three o'clock so
we can hear the Queen's speech
she's been not rock that stability from
through the world wars through the cold
Wars through covid she was her constant
so sublimly she's been near and in this
Village we've been cherished but
there'll be a lot of people who are
talking from people who've traveled from
the south of England to be up here today
when her mother's Majesty's cortage
comes through as a physical tangible
thing and I think it will be an awful
lot of our whelm of emotion then so yeah
Reverend David bar from Glenn Mick
church here in Balter many thanks for
your time today is the Public's chance
to pay their respects there was that
window yesterday of course in traffic
Kirk when members of the royal family
were able to to pay their respect during
a short service they were joined by some
members of the the Royal household and
intimate Gathering and I can tell you
that during that service in the pews for
the royal family normally sit just to
the side of the altar there was a space
left for where the queen normally sits
in that front Pew right in the middle
respect a space left for her majesty and
the tune that played them out and that
short service was a haunting very
beautiful tune played in the violin the
death of King George VI the Queen's
father of course attuned much loved by
the queen
Chase Matthews there in balata thanks
very much indeed
and just to let you know that from just
after 10 o'clock this morning we will
bring you those pictures of the Queen's
funeral Cortez as it begins its final
Journey
at Buckingham Palace I'm joined by our
International Affairs editor Dominique
Wacko and as well as the Queen's former
Royal Protection Officer Dick Griffin
and Dominic people Gathering once again
say here at Buckingham Palace wanting to
pay their respects yes and we've seen
them in their thousands coming slightly
fewer in number I think so far this
morning possibly put off by the weather
quite overbearing security as well it's
quite hard to move around here some
people saying they just can't it's taken
a while to get here but the people I
have spoken to have got up pretty early
to try and beat the crowds and they've
been determined to come here because
they have said it's just it's just not
been good enough sitting at home
watching on telly they've wanted to come
and connect with it and be part of it
which is a reminder of what people were
saying 25 years ago when Princess Diana
died I remember people then saying that
just being at home just just didn't cut
it they felt they had to come and pay
the respects and be part of what was
going on here so we I think we have been
wondering whether we would see similar
scenes to what happened 25 years ago
obviously very different in character
and tone and circumstances but I think
in terms of numbers we are seeing a lot
of people coming out and wanting to pay
their respects wanting to be part of
history and wanting to be involved and
obviously we're going to see more of
that I think and more emotion as the
Queen's coffin is placed on a hearse in
Balmoral and then begins her last
journey out of Balmoral through ballot
through Scotland and then on the way
here in London and as Greg Milam a
correspondent there in Balmoral was
saying it's a very poignant moment how
difficult do you think this will be for
the royal family to see the coffin begin
this journey it's going to be an
insanely
sad day
um Balmoral Castle meant so much to her
majesty the queen and the royal family
it was no doubt the Queen's favorite
residence she would always go up there
late July and she'd stay there with the
family well the family would come and go
but she would always stay right there
till the beginning of October and even
she'd always have the odd private
weekend as well there was a little house
on his State cook were going she'd go up
there in May early June and spend four
or five days up there and it was
noticeable when we used to bring her
back from Balmoral to come back to
Buckingham Palace it was one of the few
times you'd see a grouchy you know
because she was leaving the Beloved
Scotland to come back to London and
resume obviously all the work she had to
do although she carried on working in
Balmoral anyway and of course the family
will have so many happy memories from up
there and as you say a a place that she
would associate with being happy with
having fun and and I know that you will
have witnessed a fair few of those fun
times Well Balmoral was very very
special because the queen would go
picnic in the evening barbecuing with
Prince Philip which you actually loved
doing but she also was a great make sure
the staff are all happy they used to
have at least two big fancy dress
parties and the queen would always come
along and personally judge it
um there would always be two Gillies
balls which all the staff were invited
to and used to do a Paul Jones so you
had a good chance of ending up dancing
with the queen or and so everyone was
included it was just just such a happy
place to be and he had a story about a
hat that you were one of my colleagues
tells me the story I want to thank me
for telling him this story but it's Ian
was on Juve the Majesty the queen and he
was taken to the crafty Church on a
Sunday and from gregon house which is
about a miles drive and
when when the queen came back to London
I was I said how did you get on
with the new Protection Officer over the
weekend and she's always exceptionally
nice I like him a lot you can stay but
you must must get him to relax a bit
more he's very very nervous and so we're
all nervous when we first started
working with you yeah she said but he's
just basically nervous I was getting in
the car to go to church and I was only
halfway in the car and he slammed the
door on me and it banged my shoulder
knocked me back against the door and as
the door shut my big hat stuck in the
top of the door
so she said rather than upset him
um I went to church with my head stuck
in the top of the and I remember seeing
the news film that day of the queen
going to church and I see the queen in
such a funny angle and I thought what a
lovely lady rather than upset a
policeman who was on you in the job
um she decided to just and obviously Ian
getzer opens the car door when he gets
to church and she's released she's
managed to sit up right
oh that's a really lovely story what a
what a lovely touch
well it's good to see you dick Griffin
and Dominic we will catch up with you
again later thank you for now
so now the Australian prime minister
Anthony Albanese has told Sky News that
he will not hold a referendum on whether
the country should become a republic in
his first term in an exclusive interview
he said he this was a moment to show
gratitude for the Queen's service to
Australia the Commonwealth and the world
the Queen's death has reignited a debate
about Australia's relationship with the
monarchy so let's speak to our
correspondents Cordelia Lynch he's in
the Australian Capital Canberra and he's
carried out that interview so Cordelia
tell us a little bit more about what
Anthony Albanese told you
well Anthony albanese's Republican views
have long been known back in 2018 he
spoke for Australia's need to have an
Australian head of state but he
recognizes the gravity of this moment of
the need for the nation to mourn and of
their deep affection and connection with
the Monarch she was the first reigning
monarch to step foot on Australian soil
she visited the country 16 times he
spoke very fondly of her ability to
support the nation in its time of need
whether that was in floods droughts or
natural disasters in the wake of her
death there has been a discussion once
again about a referendum on a republic
in Australia there was already a
referendum that's taken place back in
1996 but he has made clear that he will
not be holding one in his first term of
office and he very much wants to
dedicate this time in really respecting
the honor of the service that the queen
gave this country and the Deep affection
everyone had for her here I did ask him
though of about whether he felt
Foundation evolve
of course and and it has evolved and it
will continue to evolve it will need to
continue to move with the times but the
bigger questions about our Constitution
are not ones for this current period
This is a period in which we are showing
the grief that so many Australians are
feeling at the moment showing our deep
respect and admiration
for the contribution of the queen to
Australia and today of course the the
transition formally here to recognize
that with the Queen's passing King
Charles automatically became the head of
state of Australia
foreign
Australians love the queen for many
different reasons and for her ability to
understand those that work the land here
they also respected her for her ability
to stay out of politics and I asked
Anthony Albanese if he believed that
King Charles would also be able to do
that and he said he felt he would be
deeply conscious of it Anthony Albanese
will be traveling to the UK for the
Queen's funeral and he will also be
meeting with King Charles
Cordelia thanks very much indeed
so let's bring you now these pictures
that are coming overnight
well today Mark the formal proclamation
of the accession of Charles as king of
Australia in a ceremony in the country's
capital Canberra the Proclamation was
marked by a 21 gun salute
meanwhile in New Zealand there have been
two 21 gun salutes to acknowledge the
proclamation of King Charles III
foreign
took place in Wellington and in Auckland
prime minister Jacinda Arden spoke of
the loss felt by the death of Queen
Elizabeth but also the welcoming of a
new era
for 70 years Queen Elizabeth served the
people of aotearoa New Zealand with
unwavering Duty
for the vast majority of new zealanders
she is the only monarch we have known
and so upon who death we enter a time of
change
one filled with sadness for her passing
but also gratitude for the life she
lived and the example she said King
Charles has long-haired an affection for
Altera New Zealand and has consistently
demonstrated his deep care for our
nation
this relationship is deeply valued by
our people
let's take a quick look at the front
pages of the Sunday morning papers now
and reunited for granny reads the front
of the Sunday Mirror as The Prince and
Princess of Wales and the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex are pictured together
for the first time in mourning
peace for Grant reads the front of the
Sunday people as they also lead with
that same story
the Sunday Times also leads with the
Royal Walkabout their headline warring
Windsors awkward truths to honor the
queen
the daily start on Sunday looks at the
two Royal couples reunion as well with
the four picture together in morning
reunited in sorrow reads the front of
the Sunday Telegraph
the Sunday Express goes with the
headline together for granny at William
Hans Olive Branch to Harry
and this same story is on the front of
the sun on Sunday as well this morning
their headline all four one
in front of the Observer this morning in
contrast pictures are new King Charles
III as he ascends the throne
let's speak now to Royal sculptor
Francis siegelman who has sculpted the
queen among a number of other members of
the royal family so real pleasure to
have you here Francis siegelman thanks
so much for talking to us so you made a
sculpture of the queen how was that talk
us through that process
um well it was just such an amazing
privilege obviously to be sculpting
Queen I had three sittings
um in the room you know in the palace
which was set aside for artists and um
it was it was just awe-inspiring you
know I went beforehand and I was able to
choose the Tiara and the jewelry really
that the queen was going to wear and at
the first sitting she was so amazing
because for me I was going up and
measuring her all the time with calipers
she had to measure her hair I had to
measure her head so it's quite scary it
was amazing I mean you know my hands
were definitely shaking and I was
supposed to go back and write these
measurements down but I just couldn't so
I thought for the first sitting I'm just
going to listen to her and be with her
which was excuse me amazing excuse me
um is that because you want to get a
sense of Personality as well when you're
creating a sculpture or a movement of
the face or yeah well when I'm sculpting
somebody comes through
um and um it I knew that it was
important to just listen and she was so
concerned about the people walking
around here because at that time it was
a road and she was very concerned that
people would get run over and she just
came across as such a wonderful person
she was amazing and she did chat to you
didn't she she did all the time yeah did
she so I mean you don't have to divulge
anything that was at private but what
kind of discussions were you having well
she was telling me all about her journey
she was going to make up north on the
train I think it was very imminent to
the first city and then she was talking
about visitors that were coming to stay
at the palette and um various things
really which were very interesting and
um I only had an hour so it was you know
but did that put you at ease was she
good at we've had a lot of people saying
that they were quite intimidated meeting
her but she was very quick to put people
she was such a dream really amazing
makes me quite sad because after the
third sitting I got very very very
emotionally involved you know
um and um I could tell you some unusual
things about the third sitting if you
like these two yes okay well on the
third sitting I decided I had to find a
way to see if she liked the bust before
it went to The Foundry so I said to her
majesty you know are you happy with the
hair this length and she said well
perhaps a little bit shorter
so I worked on it while she was there
until she said yes that's fine and then
I said to her
um are you happy for this to go to The
Foundry now and she said yes but don't
fiddle with it so I knew with a finger
out like that I knew that she liked it
which was such a good feeling you know
and also that she wanted some control
and he wouldn't go away and change it
yeah and I was also intrigued when you
said that you got to choose the Tiara
yeah I mean had did you have a selection
of of possibles or did you have free
reign
um do you know I that I I remember
meeting Angela Kelly and we were I had
to go there before I did the sculpture
and there were numerous amounts of
things on display and it felt as though
I was choosing the Tiara
um so yes I think it was did that
surprise you because
obviously she she could presumably
dictate what she wore for you because it
surprising that you were given that
level of freedom I know absolutely and
it's surprising how she would get up and
just go to the table and push on you
know it was sort of it was so unusual
the experience was out of this world
unusual because she to me seems so
ordinary in some ways you know so much
like just like everybody but so so
special and she had such a magic about
her and her face and her skin and the
way she walked you know and I felt
terribly emotional at the end and did
you get to see her after the the piece
was finished yes she came she unveiled
it Baden Powell house with Scouts
um and um I met her on numerous
occasions but you know just things that
we went to at the palace might Jack my
husband and I so yeah and we've got a
picture there on our screen now it
really is very beautiful yeah and so how
long did the whole process take I think
um because of her in between there were
big gaps because she was away probably a
year from start to finish
yeah that's that's a pretty good result
from a Year's work I would say it looks
absolutely gorgeous and and I think
you've worked with other members of the
royal family as well and done other
sculptures yes I have I've sculpted
um Prince Charles oh King Charles King
Charles amazing they're all getting used
to that oh my God yeah King Charles
Prince and Son
Countess of Sussex and
um Sophie's Captain sausage yeah Wessex
yes and um the Duke of Kent and um yes
it's been a privilege just an amazing I
am working on an exhibition at the
moment
um for a memorial of the of the queen
which will be at Qantas Gallery so that
would be really really good because I
need to keep that feeling going for me
yes because
um
it was such an amazing time in my life
oh well thank you so much for coming in
and sharing some of the details of it
it's really interesting thank you and uh
beautiful piece of work at the end of it
Francis Eagleman thank you thank you
bye-bye
well over the course of her Reign the
queen became perhaps the most
photographed person ever to have lived
and Her Image has been used in
everything from pop art to punk Katie
Spencer has been looking at the life of
a cultural icon
she was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous Her
Image at the core of British culture
the Queen's coronation was
groundbreaking the first ever to be
televised watched by 27 million it was
the premier of sorts for the lifelong
pivotal role she'd play in maintaining
the Allure of brand Britain
I remember when I was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
Prince Philip who was about the best
looking man in the world I mean
everybody at school had a crush on him
and I kept scrapbooks of the queen
everything that was in the papers of the
magazines I cut out and it was Princess
Elizabeth's wedding and she was a fairy
tale princess she really was she was
gorgeous he had a hand span waist big
wonderful eyes we all just loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her Platinum Jubilee
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
I always keep one for emergencies
so do I
I keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown one of the countless screen
portrayals fueled by the Relentless
public infatuation with this woman
imagine I'm going to drop everything and
come down to London before I attend to
my grandchildren who've just lost their
mother
celebrated by our greatest artists from
Lucy and Freud to Andy Warhol her
portrait is now a huge part of her
Legacy I remember when I was first
commissioned it was a daunting Prospect
you know the Queen the most portrayed
woman in history I asked if man would
like to rest in between shots that'd be
fine just I was conscious of all the
light onto her so she closed her eyes
and that was the moment it was you know
I didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at sitting for artists was part
of her cultural duty but she also
inspired some significant unofficial art
an anti-establishment Target epitomized
on the cover of the 1977 sex pistol
single her defaced lightness and easy
Act of rebellion if you went to most
West Indians home at the time they would
probably have a picture of the queen on
a wall as well as a picture of Jesus
while Rock photographer Dennis Morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the Queen's
Silver Jubilee He was following the
pistol's provocative Boat Trip on the
Thames at that time the monarchy was
very very strong we were not
particularly like for being
anti-monarchy in that sense As I Grew
Older and knew more and more about it I
have a very very deep respect for the
queen and my respect for the queen is
this that basically it takes a lot to
hold something like that together in the
way she has over the years so you know
for me big respect for that in that
sense
while many British artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honors for services to the
entertainment sector
70 years she was champion of the Arts
for those who embraced her magisterial
Authority or rebelled against it she
inspired her influence over British
culture irrefutable and unique
thank you
for everything
that's very kind Katie Spencer Sky News
just to show you the scene live this
morning in Balmoral which is where we
will see the Queen's coffin being moved
and the beginning of the funeral Cortez
from there ultimately of course it will
complete its Journey at the state
funeral the date for which we now have
as you can see a number of police
officers are now arrived at the gates of
Balmoral ahead of the beginning of that
funeral Cortez's journey across Scotland
this morning and we're going to have
plenty of coverage
of that Journey which begins at 10
o'clock this morning
now the Australian prime minister
Anthony albanesi has told Sky News that
he will not hold a referendum on whether
the country should become a republic in
his first term he said this was a moment
to show gratitude for the Queen's
service to Australia the Commonwealth
and the world so here is that
International exclusive interview with
our correspondent Cordelia Lynch
the Australian's relationship with the
queen appears enduring
what do you think it was about her Reign
that achieved that special connection
this is a land of cyclones of floods of
natural disasters and Queen Elizabeth
always reached out to give that Comfort
to Australians at our time of of need
and she was such a a respected figure
regardless of where people stand on the
political spectrum that 70 years of
public service that that Devotion to
duty is something that holds her in in
such high regard part of the success of
Queen Elizabeth reign here seems to be
that people perceived her as being
politically neutral do you think her son
will be able to achieve that too I'm
sure he's very conscious
of the need to be above politics and he
certainly has always been that in terms
of of Australia but he's someone who has
a a deep relationship with Australia I
hope that he is able to visit here on on
an occasion as as soon as as possible
but he's been a regular visitor here and
we're very familiar this of course is
it's a substantial change the the only
monarch that we have known in my
lifetime and in the lifetime of most
Australians has been Queen Elizabeth so
this is a change it's reignited a debate
about a republic do you think in this
moment that that is appropriate so
perhaps even opportunistic
well I I am of the person of you and
I've made it uh clear that now is the
time for us to pay tribute
to the life of Queen Elizabeth II to
give thanks uh for her service to
Australia to the Commonwealth and to the
world and that is the focus that I have
when it comes to the monarchy do you
think though Australians want to see the
institution evolve
uh will of course and and it has evolved
and it will continue uh to evolve uh it
will need to continue to move with the
times but the bigger questions about our
Constitution are not ones for uh this
current period uh this is a period in
which uh we are showing the grief that
so many Australians are feeling at the
moment showing our deep respect and
admiration for the contribution of the
queen to Australia do you think this
moment this pause for reflection
internationally might actually
consolidate people's belief in the power
of the monarchy oh look that that we
will see
um what occurs I think the important
thing is I think to commemorate uh the
moment that we're in now and it is a
moment of reflection about an
extraordinary life
certainly had a powerful connection and
we've witnessed that firsthand here in
Australia and just to confirm though no
no referendum in in your first term no
Anthony albanesi there speaking to
Cordelia Lynch well Queen Elizabeth
became Monarch five years after India's
independence she made three states
visits to the country during her Reign
so let's find out how her death has been
received there Neville Lazarus is in
Delhi for us this morning so Neville
what has the reaction been like there
well it has been quite muted out here
the government has called for a day of
mourning today there's the national flag
is to fly half mast and uh no government
official programs will take place today
now the queen has visited India three
times in 1961 1983 and 1997 with her
lifelong partner Prince Philip and it's
been probably on the same this same very
root she would have taken to go to the
building behind me which is the
president's house where she would have
been given a ceremonial welcome and and
over these three three periods of visits
that she has made she has known all the
leaders in India starting from Mahatma
Gandhi to the the present prime minister
Narendra Modi and she has
also been talking about how the
diversity in this the the sort of broad
diversity in the country is an
inspiration to all now India has changed
over the last 75 years since its
independence from Britain in 1947. it is
now a new buoyant confident uh India
where the young population is
disconnected with the bygone eras of
kings and queens and now it's left up to
the new monarch and the young family of
Prince William to make that connection
and endure the relations with the
largest Commonwealth country in the
world with the population of 1.3 billion
people
nevertheless there in Delhi thanks very
much indeed
well let's take a look at the Sunday
papers now and here with me to go
through the front pages I'm joined by
the Royal historian Dr Tessa Dunlop and
political editor at the Sunday Mirror
Nigel Nelson and Tessa I know that
you've spotted a story about Australia
we were talking of course about
Australia a month ago with that
interview with the prime minister so
this is in the Sunday Telegraph isn't it
yeah fascinating sort of global
reshuffle reflecting not just on our
family Elizabeth and Knight Charles but
so too on Britain's place in the world
and what it means Anthony Albanese
saying understandably now is not the
time to discuss our future head of state
of course they are Australia one of the
other 14 Realms that has our Sovereign
as their um titular head interestingly
though the headline in the telegraph is
King's green activism wins favor among
young Australians this is because
obviously they're massively impacted by
climate change those terrible bushfires
a feeling there's been a bit of lethargy
within their own political Elite dealing
with this subject and of course Charles
famously being in this long-term green
activist back in the day when will
thought he was a bit of an eccentric
what was he going on about and by all
accounts the younger generation gen Zed
is it those under 24 are more Pro the
British Monarchy particularly Charles
because of his green credentials then
those say of my generation up to the age
of 49 who of course remember the Fallout
of Diana they particularly were
passionate you'll remember about Diana
and they feel a bit less generous
towards Charles but when we're talking
about this polling I'm afraid none of it
is tilting in the right direction for
Charles in the long term 46 of those Jed
Zen's Pro retaining Charles just 36 in
favor between the ages of 30 and 49.
that's in Australia yeah interesting
okay and let's move inside
um the mail on Sunday Nigel shall we
because this focuses on Prince William
Prince of Wales yes indeed and the um
the important thing was to remember
especially is behind us now crowds are
beginning to gather outside Buckingham
Palace this is an intern honestly public
event but also there was an awful lot of
um the private in it and this is what
what Prince William showed and I thought
that his statement got it absolutely
right a public statement about his
private feelings and so he was saying
the queen had been been with him during
his happiest times also his saddest
times
and so he's obviously talking about the
death of his mother so it just I think
it was right for him to actually say
that and say it to the public that hey
folks look I have lost my beloved granny
please understand what I'm feeling as
well as actually doing his public duties
to try and deal with what with what
everybody else is feeling yeah and
reflecting what his father has done as
well hasn't he he's been very open about
his grief as well as his duties yeah
interesting and inside the Sunday
Express Tessa a story about Camilla yeah
that other big player interestingly um
quite a favorable article console who
has earned her new role referring to the
way in which she was sort of slowly
um ingratiated or upgraded within that
role pecking order uh being introduced
to the privy Council a number of years
ago and then of course the queen saying
early on in this Platinum Jubilee year
that she would like her to be Queen
consort which she now is I think it's
interesting there is clearly a
difference between the way British
people feel towards Camilla we've got
used to her we respect her she's taken
on some different difficult issues stick
abuse and sexual violence and we see how
much more she's in our press a lot
whereas overseas of course that big
memory that big huge last funeral 2.5
billion people watching Diana's funeral
they're sort of bitter aftertaste of the
Fallout of Charles's divorce means that
Camilla is a slightly harder act to sell
in the overseas territories in the
Commonwealth and and foreign realms
yeah interesting that and and inside the
Sunday Express as well a focus on
Bishops is that right it's just it's a
funny story because they've been doing
tributes in both the House of Lords and
the House of Commons it's the Archbishop
of York who who tells a story about uh
so this is the Reverend uh Stephen the
Cottrell
um tells a story about the Queen's car
breaking down and so he went up to it
and put a cross right over the the car
um it was a bit of a joke really but the
car started
and later when you met the queen when
you thought he might have gone too far
she comes up to him and says oh
Archbishop you've healed my car that's
fantastic I love that and Nigel I think
you're going to take us on as well um to
a story from a former press secretary
about tells us a little bit about King
Charles and and his his everyday
routines yes that's right this is Julian
Payne who's press secretary to uh to the
King when he was Prince Charles and what
what he says is that he's not impressed
by people who try AI to show off their
intellect with him or their titles or
their standing the Prince Charles and
now King Charles wanted to meet Ordinary
People and again he tells an anecdote of
going to the latest James Bond film to
go and meet the cast now Julian pay was
really excited about meeting Daniel
Craig but they didn't get there till
quite late because Prince Charles wanted
to talk to all the crew the lighting
people Everyone behind the scenes he
seems to be fascinated by Ordinary
People and obviously that stands him in
great stead to be the Future King
absolutely and something that I think
people will think was true of the queen
too through the queen too Nigel Nelson
and Dr Tessa Dominos always good to see
you thanks for for keeping me company
this morning going through the papers
it's been good to see you
so let's just show you the scene at
Balmoral this morning as you can see a
huge number of flowers outside the gates
there we saw a number of police officers
as well arriving at the gates of
Balmoral just a short time ago and this
of course the scene of the beginning of
the movement of the Queen's coffin from
Balmoral the journey will ultimately end
here in London and at the state funeral
which will take place in Westminster
Abbey a week on Monday that movement of
the coffin the funeral Cortez will start
at 10 o'clock this morning and just to
remind you that we will have full
coverage following the route as it
crosses Scotland
this morning
meanwhile here at Buckingham Palace here
with me is Dominic wagorn our
International Affairs editor as well as
the Queen's former Royal Protection
Officer Dick Griffin so welcome back to
both of you so a somber day a poignant
day for the royal family of course at
Dominic people still Gathering here to
pay their respects but there will be
people of course lining the route of
that quotation Scotland too yeah I think
it's a reminder that the what's what's
happening now in the run-up to the
funeral is is a twin trap process on the
one hand you have the morning process
um ending the the reign of the the now
dead at Monarch and on the other hand we
have the accession and and succession
process that is uh bringing the new king
to the throne which happened
automatically once the queen died King
Charles became Prince Charles became
King Charles but then yesterday we saw
the accession council and then the
proclamation of his accession yesterday
was all about that but I think today the
the morning process which obviously
began and a couple of days ago now
really
picks up pace and continues in Earnest
as the Cortez leaves Balmoral Castle and
makes its way towards here and what
we're seeing outside Buckingham Palace
is people doing what they've been doing
for the last few days which is coming
here to pay respects to be part of it
and the people I've been speaking to say
they just felt they they had to get up
they had to leave home they had to stop
watching it on television and come and
do something and lay flowers and also
wanted to just be with others as they're
still working out what their emotions
are and they were saying that they some
of them they're nervous about what is to
come but reassured by what they've seen
so far in terms of that succession
process but yeah the focus now today
will be on on the morning process
beginning well yes and and of course
dick there will be many people in
Scotland who want to see that Cortez
make his way across Scotland and gather
there but we should remember that this
is a very personal and poignant time for
the royal family how do you think you've
worked very closely with them and with
the queen how do you think the royal
family will be feeling about today
I'm absolutely devastated all of them
and you know the entire such a shock for
everybody I mean the queen was obviously
in health for the last year and probably
people were expecting it but when it
actually happens and it's just
devastating I I remember sitting here
um with you guys on on Thursday evening
and we're all chatting away when the
news came and you could just see the
reaction of the crowds here and it was
just Devastation for everybody of course
and and felt all the more keenly by by
her family to Dick Griffin Dominic
thanks both very much indeed
and we can take you to Balmoral as we
were telling you the Queen's coffin will
travel from there to Edinburgh today and
the queen will lie at rest in the Palace
of Hollywood house overnight so let's
take you over to Anna botting now who's
in Edinburgh Anna
Scottish Capital later on today uh well
let me introduce a man who's been
absolutely key in organizing what we're
going to see today tomorrow and indeed
the next day I'm joined by councilor
Robert Aldrich who is the right
honorable Lord Provost and Lord
Lieutenant of the City of Edinburgh the
sun is shining and and really the focus
will be on the Scottish Capital later on
today just talk us through the events
that will will happen well um yes at
lunchtime today about midday uh there
will be a proclamation of the new king
from the market cross which is in the
middle of the royal mile under further
Proclamation up at Edinburgh Castle
about half an hour later with a
procession between the two places uh and
around about four o'clock this afternoon
uh the Queen's funeral quartet
comparison sorry
um the tomorrow I have the privilege of
greeting this Majesty the King when he
arrives in the city and taking part in
the ceremony of the keys it's an ancient
ceremony where
um we offer the keys of the city to The
Sovereign and up until this time at
least every time the sovereigners handed
them back for our safe keepings I I hope
that the new king will be pleased enough
to give us the keys back then and then
we then later on uh the The Queen's
coffin will move up to some Giles uh
Cathedral virtual lie and rest and
there'll be a church service
and
many more things so it is a a very busy
few days here in Edinburgh I know the
people in Edinburgh are determined to
give the queen a show of Just how much
respect we had for her it is emotional
isn't it You are not alone and you were
the person who welcomed the queen here
in late June when she took her her time
to the Palace
um how was she there and and how did she
seem to you she was we'd Heard lots of
reports about her being unwell but she
was remarkably sprightly she was very
chatty she was a little frustrated that
she was unable to inspect the troops at
the ceremony of the keys but she was
really she made my life easy as a a
brand new Lord promised of course I made
a slight mess of my lines uh that I had
to say to her she gave that oh broad
smile the twinkle in her eye and
responded of course weren't perfect as
the true professional she was but she
made it easy for me and I noticed your
chain
what's happened well this This
Magnificent chain has got an even more
magnificent medal on the bottom of it
with diamonds and so on it and it is
traditional at times of national
mourning that we would cover this with a
dark pouch for the entire morning period
out of respect
it'll be around 10 o'clock that we see
Her Majesty's coffin for the first time
um it is always a very difficult time
there yes and certainly people will be
lining the route she's going through
some of the amazing cities in Scotland
as well how important is this for
Scotland do you think this is absolutely
important for something but I think it's
more more important for all those
individuals who have a personal
connection with her majesty I think I
heard somebody say that something like
30 million people in in the United
Kingdom had had some contact or other
with the queen and I think that when
the Cortez goes past suddenly it will
become very real to a lot of people and
different people will manage their
thoughts and their grief in different
ways right across the city across the
city and the country and then
yes I hope we can all
be respectful I hope we can all be proud
of what she gave to us and give back in
some way or another
there is so much organization that goes
into these events I know at 5am this
morning there were rehearsals for the
procession which will take place
tomorrow from the the Palace of
Hollywood house behind us up to Saint
General's Cathedral for those important
events there including a vigil with the
royal family you know how have you
prepared for this well obviously there
had been a lot of preparations actually
many years in advance in fact the queen
was involved in many of the the the the
the plans herself so it's something that
she would have wanted herself but I have
to pay tribute to the service Personnel
the council staff whole range of people
who have been involved in putting in
huge numbers of hours over the last two
or three days to get the city looking
magnificent and to prepare to try to
make this the best possible show that we
can put on of our respect for our
Majesty the queen
I'm sure you will succeed thank you very
much and leave for joining us councilor
Robert there Lord Lieutenant of the City
of Edinburgh thank you very much indeed
and uh very emotional for everybody
involved in this and as we heard there
the queen very closely involved with all
of the plans that we will see unfold
today Anna
and a bossing there in Edinburgh thanks
very much indeed and we will be
rejoining you for continuing coverage uh
in the next few minutes but in the
meantime let's just show you the scene
here at Buckingham Palace where we are
this morning there's the scene outside
the palace number of people now
Gathering there security feels a little
bit tighter this morning there are more
barriers up and uh it's harder to get to
the Palace Gates but people are still
coming we are expecting more and more
people to come and bring flowers make
their own tributes have their own
moments in front of the gates to reflect
on the Queen's death
and meanwhile of course at the events of
the day focusing largely on Scotland
today
we heard there from Anna botting just a
few moments ago in Edinburgh and talking
about the Journey of the Queen's coffin
which will start here in Balmoral where
you can see now focusing on the floral
tributes that are brought from people
locally there
the Queen's coffin will be moved today
it'll be the first time that the public
have seen her coffin of course so it's a
poignant moment for her family of course
primarily but also for members of the
public and the coffin is then going to
make a 175 mile Journey arriving at the
palace of holyroot house in Edinburgh at
around four o'clock this afternoon it's
a six hour trip and uh police have been
arriving we've seen them throughout the
morning arriving to help with that
process and a day of unwhelming
overwhelming emotion is how one local
Minister along that route described it
will be with it every step of the way
that Journey Begins at 10 o'clock this
morning but we'll have coverage
throughout the day please do stay with
us
one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George become our only lawful and
rightful leads Lord Charles III
three chairs for his majesty the king
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you so much thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Sky News live from Hollywood
house in Edinburgh
a last great journey the Queen's coffin
will begin its journey to its final
resting place
six gamekeepers will lift it into a
hearse at the Balmoral estate in about
an hour's time as it travels to the
Palace of Hollywood house the Queen's
official Scottish residence here in
Edinburgh
[Music]
no Republic referendum in my first term
in an international exclusive
Australia's prime minister Telco news
there'll be no break with the monarchy
in the near future
it will need to continue to move with
the times but the bigger questions about
our Constitution are not ones for this
current period
for the Prime Minister of Antigua and
Barbuda says he will call for a
referendum on a republic as the king
prepares to meet the Commonwealth
Secretary General this morning
[Music]
reunited in their grief the new Prince
and Princess of Wales joined the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex during a walkabout
at Windsor
and from portraits to pop celebrating
the queen as a cultural icon
[Music]
hello good morning I am live at the
Queen's official Scottish residence in
Edinburgh where this afternoon the
Queen's coffin will arrive as the
Monarch Begins the journey to her final
resting place
in about an hour's time we'll see the
Queen's coffin leave Balmoral having
been lifted into a hearse by six of the
estate's gamekeepers
thousands are expected to turn out on
the streets as the Cortez begins a
six-hour journey to Edinburgh
the Queen's coffin which is currently in
the ballroom at Balmoral will be carried
as I said by six gamekeepers from the
estate and lifted into the hearse at 10
o'clock this morning
the funeral Cottage will make its way to
Aberdeen passing through balita aboyne
bankery and Peter Cooter arriving in
Aberdeen at around 11 20 this morning
and will move through the city's suburbs
the King George VI Bridge which was
opened By Her Majesty's mother in 1941
is also on the route
next the Cortez will head through the
Angus Countryside past Breakin arriving
in Dundee at around 2PM where it will
drive around the city on the King's Way
it will then head towards Perth across
the freeton bridge and cross over the
Queensbury Crossing heading towards
Edinburgh
the Cortez will pass by Edinburgh Castle
and head down the Royal mile to the
Palace of Hollywood house arriving here
at around 4 pm
the coffin will rest in the throne room
to allow staff at the palace to pay
their respects
so as we said the Queen's coffin will
leave Balmoral at 10 o'clock this
morning Skies Greg Milam is there for us
today and certainly already Greg
thousands of people have paid their
respects there and expected now to line
the route
yeah well I mean yesterday alone uh
there were thousands who made that that
Journey uh quiet reflective uh patient
very thoughtful
um lines of people making that Journey
here today that they're not here at the
moment because in the next hour we are
expecting that that final Journey from
Balmoral to begin for the uh for the
queen and a poignant moment for the
family members who are still here inside
uh Balmoral and we saw them yesterday
looking at some of the tributes uh the
coffin standing in the uh the ballroom
at Balmoral currently uh draped in the
Royal Standard of Scotland Aretha
flowers on that on top of that uh on top
of that standard so that the estate
workers of Balmoral can pay their
tributes to uh the queen people who've
been in Royal service for for many many
years able to have those few moments
with her and then at 10 o'clock we will
see as you say those six gamekeepers
from the estate lift that coffin and
carry it through a small dining room to
the entrance Portico and into the hearse
we understand the Sovereign Piper will
play Balmoral and Glenn gelder as that
uh is as that happens and then the
hearse will will come down the driveway
and we will see
it exit the uh the the estate so a
symbolic gesture I think for those staff
members here the people who've worked on
the estate for many years to be part of
what is uh taking place today a quiet
dignity is how they've described what's
going on inside Balmoral as that Journey
Begins that final Journey for the queen
through Scotland
foreign
thank you very much indeed well let's
bring in our Royal commentator Aleister
Bruce and Aleister obviously the passing
of her majesty in Scotland has brought
in all these extra events into the
program effectively
yes and it gives Scotland a chance to
see the Queen of Scots leave and to do
so in great Simplicity along roads that
everyone uses and knows well and through
places that the queen knew and visited
often
of course when her father the king died
at Sandringham in 1952 he was conveyed
to London on board the Royal Train
and all the way along the Route the
train passed very very slowly and people
gathered in fields and at Railway
Junctions and by their heads to the king
as he passed
those Railways have reduced in number
and it's perfect that the roads that go
so much more through the communities
that the queen served will provide
people who wish to a chance to come and
pay their respects as she passes by
and Balmoral so much loved um this is
obviously uh her saying goodbye to this
place that was her Sanctuary you know
her peace her quiet her Tranquility it
was so important to her as a child and
through her life
the queen was born in April 1926 and
later that year while she was still an
infant she was brought to Balmoral
during the Royal Family's holidays
and so for the entire of her life this
has been her Haven and it was from this
Haven that she has gone to heaven and I
think that it is therefore appropriate
that she leaves this place surrounded by
her family as she is and is conveyed
through the people that she did her best
Endeavor to serve on her way to the
capital city of Scotland and as Queen of
Scots
she has I think always carried in her
that great sense of the landscape that
she will pass through particularly
because she will pass by where her
mother's family the Bose Lions lived at
glam's Castle quite close by and it's a
reminder that she did always have this
extra Scottish element in her passion
and that it's appropriate that she
passes through the land of Scotland on
her way to her final rest
and this as we saw yesterday when the
family came to look at those flowers and
those tributes outside the gates of
Balmoral it's a very upsetting time for
the royal family as well Alistair
well they all absolutely adored her they
had a profound respect for the stability
that she provided not just for their
family but they saw it for the nation
and for the Realms and for the
Commonwealth
and for the queen
this was her greatest joy her family
and yes life in the public eye for many
of them was a challenge but I think the
queen recognized what a challenge that
was for them all and tried to give them
a great deal of continuity and stability
which was really the center of her faith
and being and in the loss of her I'm
sure each of them are feeling it very
deeply and strange things trigger
emotion and grief and reading the
heartfelt messages have passes by who
perhaps didn't know their mother and
grandmother that can add to the impact
of the feelings that they have
well the queen as we know currently lies
in the ballroom of Balmoral Castle in an
oak coffin covered with the Royal
Standard for Scotland and with a wreath
of flowers on top it has been described
by Buckingham Palace as a scene of quiet
dignity and they've made the point to
Alistair that the Queen's coffin is at
rest like this in Balmoral to allow
Balmoral estate staff to pay their
respects many of whom they said have
spent a good deal of their life in Royal
Service there
and also I think it's at home and the
queen served her family
the private staff of her estate and her
royal household but today she will be
released to the nation that she served
and she will as it were pass in the
start of her journey away in some
respect from the family and the people
who serve directly to her in a very
private capacity so I think that the
procession we see leave that gate at
Balmoral today
is profoundly poignant and while she was
at Balmoral there was a chance for the
nation to prepare what we are told by
the Earl Marshall who's organizing this
event will be the greatest salute the
nation could possibly give
to a monarch who has served for more
than 70 years
here to Edinburgh a series of events we
know that the king will be arriving
tomorrow as well this is a city you know
so well Alistair how important is it for
the for the City of Edinburgh to say
it's farewell too
well Edinburgh as a city has been such a
key part of her life because after all
since she married the Duke of Edinburgh
she's been The Duchess of Edinburgh and
her annual visits there I had the
privilege of welcoming her this year
when she arrived as governor of
Edinburgh Castle
and I said to her as I gave a salute
welcome home your majesty
and there was a great grin she was
obviously delighted to be back it had
been through the period of covid quite
difficult and it was Splendid that she
was able to come back again this year
and she was able to take part in so many
of the events that had been prepared
very quietly for her not least an act of
loyalty from the Armed Forces to her in
the garden at Hollywood so the links
between the queen and Scotland have
always been deeply profound she will
pass by the great castle of Edinburgh
and she will then make her way down
through the Royal mile to Hollywood
where she will rest again
at peace within the Palace of holyroot
house giving her Scottish household the
chance to spend time and pay their
respects before tomorrow she is conveyed
to the high Kirk of Saint Giles for a
service for the opportunity of the king
to pay his vigil and also for the people
of Scotland for 24 hours if they wish to
come and pay their last respect
Alistair thank you well the Queen's
Neighbors in ballater will have their
chance also to say goodbye as the Cortez
passes through our Scotland
correspondent James Matthews is there
and James so many people feel like they
knew her this was her community was
ignored and have many already come to
line the route for the Cortez
yeah they have I know they knew a
different Queen here they knew a friend
and neighbor she was regularly seen
around here and as you can see many
people several hundred are have already
turned out lighting the streets to pay
their respect you you can see many media
here from around the world many local
people joined by
several dozen from out of town who've
traveled some distance to be here you
can see just in the foreground by the
the curbside just to the right the Lord
lieutenants of aberdeenshire
learning the drill for when the Cortez
passes it's due in something like 50
minutes Reverend David Barr the local
Minister coordinating operations if you
look uh this way you can see something
that uh yet another connection between a
tangible connection between this Village
and her majesty the queen a Cairn that
was put together
in 2012 to celebrate the the Diamond
Jubilee and you can see it's a focal
point for floral tributes many of them
went from far and wide let's um go and
speak to this gentleman hello sir we're
from Sky News we're live
um tell me what are your thoughts today
I thought some great sadness but also
remembering with much gratitude for
somebody who lived and served with great
Duty and great respect so thank you very
much indeed thank you your name sir
Andrew Simpson law Lieutenant of
Hampshire thanks very much indeed Andrew
um David cobbin runs a gift shop in uh
ballater David
this is balita this is your village it's
the Queen's Village and you came across
her tell me about that
yeah my wife and I have a gift shop in
ballater and we had a big flood here as
you know in 2015 and the shop was
completely destroyed
um so the queen a few months later
decided to come to the village and show
her support for everybody and make sure
we were all recovering properly
um so she came into the shop for a while
and had a chat with my wife and I and um
you know it was it was a very special
day for us and it lifted everybody's
spirits but uh that that's the
compassion that the queen showed you
know and it's a it's a sad day for us
here in Ballantyne tell me about the
last time you saw her yes we're involved
with the Highland Games in ballater so
as our tribute for the Jubilee we went
up to Balmoral about four weeks ago with
a pipe band and they played for her
which I'm so glad we went because she
loved the pike band she loved the
Highland Games so that was our chance to
pay our own tribute to her what did she
say tell me about her mood that day well
I I wasn't speaking to her that day in
particular but I know she enjoyed it
because she told some of the committee
people afterwards and uh you know and
music play music and all things Tartan
was was the queen so
um and yeah it's an emotional day now
here for us in the village it's our
chance to say goodbye thanks very much
indeed David yeah they say here another
the queen hung up her crown when she
entered uh the gates of the Balmoral
estate Let's Take a Walk uh that way
I'll follow one behind you and take take
a look at some of the people who've
turned up here David talking about her
love of the pipes and all things
Scottish of course the queen uh was
played a rendition every morning
wherever she went at 9am she had the
Queen's Piper who would pay a fifth play
a 15-minute medley of tunes Tunes issue
was so fond of uh and which he grew to
love as a youngster at Kelly's at balls
and so on which she enjoyed throughout
her lifetime
so there are some people here from
who've come from far and wide you so
you're from Singapore that's right um
tell me why come here today well it just
happened to be coming through brought my
Mom and Dad here to visit Scotland for
sentimental reasons
um and uh just you know the timing was
just a historic moment
um yes and your thoughts on our Majesty
the queen well actually we were
reflecting last night with my mom and
dad over dinner with a drama of whiskey
in her name and my mom was actually
saying to me and you know don't forget
to me so don't forget she she was our
Queen I said what do you mean we come
from Singapore she goes yeah but before
Singapore was independent we were
British colony so she was our Queen and
you know that kind of brought into
context everything and it's very
meaningful for my mom to be here thank
you very much indeed we have a couple
from from Glasgow yeah uh you've driven
up to be here yes yes tell me why just a
pure respects to the queen she gave her
a life to the country thank you
for what she's done for the country uh
I've known well no no not personally but
she's been there my whole life
so just to say thanks
tell me about the sense of loss that
you're feeling
um
very much so it's almost like a family
member
yeah so so you've seen a lovely day on
TV not personally but in TV or some sort
of somewhere in the world
I mean she was uh
the biggest female icon in the whole
world that's her obviously
Madam can we ask you what are you what
are your thoughts today
I thought this is a good location to
come to and I'll be a bit closer how is
that important to you and where have you
come from I've come from Cheshire
Jim from Trisha said it took me eight
hours and normally my staying power is
about two
so why was it important to be closer
I wanted to be closer I've been here
I've been to the Balmoral area about 40
years ago when I was a soldier
but I just wanted to be here today to
waver off
why is and why is that important tell me
about you she's been she's been the
constant figure in my whole of my life
thank you very much indeed well there
you are Cheshire Singapore Glasgow many
local people too have turned out to pay
their respects line English realistic a
final uh just look up the street here
the cottage due in a roundabout uh 50
minutes
uh it is the nearest Village to Balmoral
a village that the queen knew extremely
well she knew this route very well
indeed it's the village
her village where she did the shopping
where she spent time with other members
of the royal family she was familiar
with this place they weren't familiar
with her and this
is their chance
to say goodbye
yeah
James Matthews thank you very much
indeed and ballot are obviously one of
the first Villages that the Cortez will
pass through we have more details in
fact of the Cortez we understand that
the Princess Royal and her husband Tim
Lawrence will be following that Cortez
in a vehicle which is made up of uh of
uh let me tell you a hearse a motorcycle
from police Scotland a Metropolitan
Police Service Car the Royal car as I
said containing the uh the Princess
Royal another Royal car with the Lord
Chamberlain and the minister of Kathy
church and another police car from
police Scotland so that will be the
Cortez as it passes through uh through
Royal D side on its way to Aberdeen
first of all well let me bring in Louise
Tate now the Queen's Scottish press
secretary for almost 15 years who's with
me this morning it's such an emotional
time isn't it we heard people there
traveling from all over the world you
know hours and hours of traveling to get
to see her but it's that really
emotional moment when you see the often
and the realization of that loss and for
people like you who knew her very
difficult
I think many people didn't realize the
depth of their own feeling and affection
for this Monarch and that moment when we
do see that car leave the gates of
balmora will be
quite something and yeah I'm not looking
forward to seeing myself too
just remind us what she meant to people
like you who worked with her because
part of the program that we've seen the
events we've seen is to allow household
staff to say their goodbyes that she's
in the ballroom right now at Balmoral in
order for those staff who worked with
her for many of them for much of their
lives to say their own farewell that's a
really it's a really important moment to
allow them to do that and it's been
every provision made for staff to do
that to help them with understand that
transition and but also it's about the
continuity of monarchy they'll still be
serving the new king
continuity of monarchy we know that King
Charles will be arriving at the palace
of Hollywood house where we are tomorrow
there'll be a procession up to Saint
Charles Cathedral a vigil two of the
royal family and all of this as they
process up the Royal mile will be
watched by everybody who want to come
and see it it is about coming to see
that process isn't it well it's just
it's part of History you know it's a
we've never known a monarch on its own
for 70 years we'll possibly never see it
again and I think people have that real
sense that this is this is something
they want to do and they'll make a
determined effort to do it we always
felt that would be the case and every
provision was always made for people
always thought people people people but
also these media positions it's very
very important for people who can't
travel who are not able to stand on or
you know for a long periods of time it's
very important to get these pictures for
everyone who can't hear themselves
and how important do you think it is
that Princess Anne will be following and
accompanying her mother if you like as
she makes this journey oh I think it's
very poignant and I I think it comforts
me that she's got some family on that
Journey which that Journey was so
familiar to her majesty and all men for
the whole family and these places have
been frequently visited and it's lovely
that
they've been provisioned there's been
provision made for that journey and to
have that companionship knowing that the
Princess Royal and her husband certain
Lawrence is going to be right there with
her and having worked so long at uh at
Balmoral with her you know my office was
here yeah yeah it was and um I just feel
incredibly fortunate to have
served her to have um
it's there's no words she was just such
a joy to work for she was very very
straightforward and many many respects
and
you always find you had to be yourself
anything else and number two is far too
exhausting to be someone else and I
always find her just such a pleasure
um to work with both on public
engagements and when when she wasn't
officially on duty
it's a joy to be around a very emotional
day for so many people who worked with
her her family and all those who've
watched her over the years and have she
is our whole life isn't she
you know it it is this is the strength
of feeling that I don't think people
realize they had and Times of flux and
change there's been a lot of that
recently I think she has been the rock
that steadying hand that that symbol of
you know everything's changing but some
things are not changing and now this is
changing and change is always unsettling
and this is going to be a big change and
a lot for people to adjust to Louise
Tate for the moment thank you very much
indeed well let's speak now to the
Queen's former Royal Protection Officer
uh dick Griffin who is at Buckingham
Palace and you know we will all watch on
with our own emotions today
um you know 30 million people were
supposed to have had contact with her
majesty but you with your own
Recollections on a day like this
well I was lucky enough to work through
a majesty and strong harness Prince
Philip for almost 30 years
so you can imagine
um I can't imagine the grief the family
are having but even for myself and my
family it's some very very deeply
upsetting it's I was just listening to
Louise Tate then with the Recollections
and you know it almost brings a tear to
your eye just
you know it's so upsetting
so upsetting but so important do you
think that people get their chance to to
see the Cortez pass by
um you know her beloved Balmoral onto
all those cities that she would have
visited so often as we see the crowds
there at Buckingham Palace and
everybody's still wanting to pay their
own respects you know how important is
it for people to be allowed to do that
oh it's massively important I was
outside Buckingham Palace on Thursday
evening when
the death of the queen was was announced
and I was amazed with the hundreds and
hundreds of people who were turning up
and I walked amongst the crowd and there
were people turning up with flowers so I
wouldn't really expect I mean I saw a
couple of skinheads with the earrings
and a huge bouquets of flowers and I and
I chatted to a couple of them and they
said we just really really want a pair
of respect to
um
the lovely lovely Queen and certainly
today the Cortez driving through
balita I mean balita was probably eight
miles away from
the castle itself and for the people
there to be able to turn out to be able
to wave goodbye to the queen and say
their farewells is very very important a
Majesty was always very concerned about
balita and obviously the floods in 2015
when the town was almost written off the
Caravan site was blown away the lots of
the shops were devastated but the queen
and In fairness King Charles were very
very instrumental in helping rebuild the
place
foreign
came into contact
um with the Queen's children Beyond King
Charles how do you think they will all
be bearing up right now
I can't imagine
um
the grief they're in I mean it's not
just the children you know it's people
like Sophie was very close to a Majesty
the grandchildren and it just comes a
huge huge shock I think
we were all expecting it it was
obviously going to happen sometime in
the next couple of years but
when it does happen
It just strikes
like a dagger between your back I mean
it's
it's terrible
and what are your memories of the queen
at Balmoral we know that she liked you
know being with her dogs with her horses
riding her Land Rover Defender you know
meeting people who are walking through
the estate you know it was it was such a
joy for her to be there wasn't it
well it was and I spent many many happy
hours just privately with the Majesty
the queen either walking or going out
there when she had her picnics at
lunchtime and
Balmoral was definitely her favorite
place she would the staff would have
fancy dress parties the queen would
always come along and judge them
there'll be a couple of Gillies balls
that all the royal family would turn up
for and if you're lucky enough you you'd
end up dancing with the queen which was
just wonderful but the queen
she adored it I mean I remember once
when I was up at
Balmoral with a Zara was competing in
the Olympic Games and looked like she
was going to win a medal and and I
thought that we'd be flying down to
Greenwich to watch to watch her get on
but the queen said to me
I just can't I'm just so nervous I can't
face up to it let's go out for a picnic
so we drove up onto the one of the
mountain sides and one of the cabins and
we had a little private picnic Just the
Two of Us
and and eventually the queen said to me
I can't stand it any longer can you
radio your backups and find out how Zara
got on so I radioed them found out she'd
won the silver medal and I remember the
queen just grabbed me and we were
dancing around in circles on this hill
in Scotland and and that's a memory that
will stay with me forevermore
foreign
memories there um Mr Griffin it's
extraordinary to you know to hear those
experiences close hand and certainly you
will be among those people who will be
you know watching the Cortez depart
Balmoral in about half an hour with us
and we we much appreciate our time thank
you very much indeed this morning
pleasure thank you for talking to me
well the Australian prime minister
Anthony albanesi has told Sky News that
he will not hold a referendum on whether
Australia should become a republic in
his first term in his first
International interview since the
Queen's death Mr Albanese said this was
a moment to show gratitude for the
Queen's service well let's speak now to
our correspondent Cordelia Lynch who is
in the Australian Capital Canberra and
there will be other territories across
the world who are also having this
conversation Cordelia so what did he say
to you
yes many that are considering their
position but I think Anthony albanazi
has understood the gravity of this
moment the need of his nation and others
to mourn and to show their gratitude for
the reign of Queen Elizabeth he spoke
about her deep connection with the
Australian people her support for them
in their trying times whether it be
droughts floods or natural disasters he
himself is a republican his views are
well known uh previously he has spoken
of the need for a vote on the the future
of Australia's relationship with the
monarchy but he knows now is not the
time to be talking politics and I think
he wants to make that very clear at this
stage he ruled out the prospect of any
kind of referendum in his first term but
I did ask him about whether he thinks
the Australian people want to see the
royal family the institution itself
evolve
of course and and it has evolved and it
will continue to evolve it will need to
continue to move with the times but the
bigger questions about our Constitution
are not ones for this current period
This is a period in which we are showing
the grief that so many Australians are
feeling at the moment showing our deep
respect and admiration for the
contribution of the queen to Australia
and today of course the the transition
formally here to recognize that with the
Queen's passing King Charles
automatically became the head of state
of Australia
he has declared a public holiday to Mark
the death of the queen and we also today
witnessed a moving ceremony at
Parliament House where King Charles was
declared Sovereign of Australia um we
have seen the queen visit this country
16 times in the past she was the first
reigning monarch to step foot on
Australian soil and that has had a
lasting impact here her Legacy appears
enduring and now Anthony albanazi will
be making the trip to the UK to attend
her funeral and he will also he tells me
be meeting King Charles
Cordelia with that update from Australia
thank you very much indeed well crowds
of people are still gathering at
Buckingham Palace and the Mal to pay
their respects to the queen Skies Kamali
Melbourne is there and many people come
only just feeling it's a journey they
have to make
yeah absolutely right Anna it's really
become a point of pilgrimage for people
to come here I was just struck been here
a couple of hours now and just more and
more people keep on arriving they're
leaving flowers along the railings here
and you know at the moment they're kind
of been moved away by security to keep
them moving through but at one point
about 10 minutes ago it's about 15
people deep trying to read the tributes
come and pay their own respect in their
own way and want to be a part of history
and a group of people that we spoke to
earlier who um
came here to do exactly that to try and
pay their respects uh these guys who
came in from Sutton to come and see us
thank you so much for waiting around I
know that it's been a couple of minutes
we do appreciate your time and just tell
us uh why did you decide to come here
today do you think
Queen has always been a great part in
our life you know we need to pay our
respect to our beloved queen I'm from
India from childhood I have heard lots
and lots about our Queen
it's really a great shock to believe
that a queen has died
I'm sure she'll be living in her heart
forever and ever thank you for all the
services she has done to our country and
to the world and Sophia you say our
Queen Don't you I mean Joseph's wife you
see emergency Sr Queen even though you
come from India yeah no I I've been from
India I'm living for almost 15 years but
I See Her Like She's Our Queen and she
has been not only for UK she has been
for the old world as well so now we I
feel like part of us is gone now because
she has always been constant but now but
now it's going to be different in life
so we just want to pay respect we just
want to pay say thank you to her so we
just bought our family as well so the
kids we just want to say thank you and
respect and it's a really lovely thing
that you guys have done here and there
you you've come and you want to pay your
respect as well what did you what did
you want to say what are your feelings
about about the queen
um Queen Elizabeth she's very
inspirational to me and she's a role
model and I think she's witnessed many
major developments throughout her life
and I think her Reign has created
history and I feel proud to be here at
this moment
it's your little sister as well isn't it
hi sweetheart what did you think about
the queen what did you want to say queen
Queen and she is like a world queen
she's done lots of things for not just
UK and commonwealth countries but for
other countries too she certainly has uh
deeply thank you so much for that I know
you're a little nervous about talking
but that was excellent thank you for
playing that tribute and uh you're
friends with the family aren't you but
you're from Mauritius so now Mauritius
is fascinating because Mauritius joined
the Commonwealth in 1968. so it's made
the decision to join the group of family
of Nations yeah so yeah same like we've
all gone was our friends today uh you
know so I've known the queen like ever
since like when I was in Mauritius as a
child my dad even had a poetry of the
queen in our front room with the royal
family so uh really today being here is
like also to let our
um you know our kids know how important
she has been in our life so we are here
to Bear our respect yeah thank you very
much Alicia just just tell us I know
you've been thinking about what the
queen meant to you just tell us about
your thoughts this morning yeah so I
decided to come down here today because
I feel really proud to be living in this
country as we have a kind-hearted Queen
who is wandering around the world and I
feel like
um she'll be memorable and her Legacy
will be carried out she said well Alicia
you really appreciate that Alicia leave
the uh Deep D dear DJ and Sophia thank
you all so much for this morning thank
you very much and enjoy the rest of the
day so look that is a family of people
who've come from the Commonwealth that
come to Buckingham Palace today to pay
their respects to a monarch and a royal
family who they respect and who they
want to honor with their memories and
that is what we're really finding from
everyone we're speaking to here anna the
people have taken this moment out of
their lives on a Sunday morning to come
and just share in the sadness of the
nation and the Commonwealth
[Music]
Kamali live there in Buckingham Palace
thank you very much indeed well Queen
Elizabeth became Monarch five years
after India's independence she made
three state visits to the country during
her Reign let's find out how her death
has been received there Neville Lazarus
is in Delhi for us this morning we're
understanding there is a day of vigil
Neville
that's correct Anna though it has been
quite muted out here the government has
ordered for a day of mourning where the
national flag will fly half Marston
there will be no government official
ceremony at all uh in in the country now
the queen has made three trips to India
1983 and 1997 all accompanied with a
life partner Prince Philip she she
she literally went down this this this
road down to the president's house which
is behind me where she was she would she
would have been given the state
ceremonial uh welcome out there and as
you mentioned she was just five uh five
years after Indie gained its
independence in 1947 from Britain and
has known all the leaders right from
Mahatma Gandhi to the present-day prime
minister uh narender Modi who's met her
twice
but after 75 years of Independence this
is New India this is a very confident uh
assertive and buoyant and a very young
India more than half of India's
population is under the age of 25 and
they are disconnected with bygone eras
of uh kingship and kings and queens and
now they are confident to be at to be
dealt with at par they want Equitable
and just this week itself India overtook
Britain as the as the fifth largest
economy in the world so
it will be quite a lot for the new
monarch who has been here 10 times in
the past to forge and strengthen these
relations with not only the largest
democracy in the world but more
importantly the largest Commonwealth
country with a population of 1.3 billion
people
Neville thank you very much indeed and
we know that the Commonwealth was
desperately important to her majesty the
Queen and King Charles is now due to
meet the Commonwealth Secretary General
uh baroness Scotland later on today at
Buckingham Palace will also host High
Commissioners and their spouses from
countries where he is head of state at
the Royal residences bow room while our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wycorn is at Buckingham Palace for us
and uh well one third of the globe is is
in the Commonwealth um Dominic we know
it was really important to the queen but
certainly there will be the monarchy
will be under consideration for a number
of those Nations
yes I mean a huge importance of the
queen going right back to when she was a
princess on her 21st birthday she gave
this uh address to all the Commonwealth
or the Imperial countries as it was then
uh when she was on uh tour in South
Africa and in that speech she said she
would devote her life of Duty and
service to the Imperial family of
Nations as she put it and of course in
the early stages of her Reign that
Empire broke up into independent nations
and became the Commonwealth there are 56
independent nations now in the
Commonwealth and they form a large
proportion of the world's population two
and a half billion people are in the
Commonwealth at the core of the
Commonwealth uh there are those Nations
who still regard the Monarch as their
head of state 14 Nations uh as well as
as Britain and Prince Charles will be
meeting High Commissioners from those
Nations as well as meeting the Secretary
General baroness Scotland who will be
representing all the other nations as
well that number has been going
dwindling over the years the queen began
with 32 Nations who regarded her as the
head of state 17 left that number during
her Reign to say 14 plus Britain now but
numbers of countries are beginning to
move away from it as they have been over
recent years uh Barbados has already
become an independent republic Jamaica's
in the process of of doing so and the
Prime Minister of Antigua and Barbuda in
the wake of the Queen's death has said
there will be an independence referendum
in his estate over the next three years
the prime minister of New Zealand says
she expects her country to do something
similar become a republic in her
lifetime and the Australian prime
minister saying that for now at least
for his first term in office even though
he has expressed sympathies and support
of the Republican cause there will be no
uh repeated the referendum that in 1999
rejected the idea of Australia becoming
a republic but that is the direction of
travel for now at least but Prince
Charles does have this number of for
Nations whose High commissions he'll be
meeting and he'll I think we'll expect
him to give a similar similar level of
commitment to the Commonwealth as his
mother did it's a huge important group
of Nations it's not an Empire anymore
but it's hugely important in terms of
cultural political commercial diplomatic
ties and exchanges so successful
actually that countries are trying to
join us who weren't members of the
British Empire Gabon and Togo applying
for membership even though they're
francophone countries and originally
fell have been falling in the sort of
French sphere of influence in Africa so
it remains a vibrant important
organization that King Charles as he is
now will be hoping to commit himself to
as much as his mother the queen did
throughout her reign
Dominic thank you very much indeed and
certainly full coverage of those
meetings a little later but let's focus
on Australia now and as we've been
hearing the Australian prime minister
Anthony albanazi has told Sky News that
he will not hold a referendum on whether
the country should become a republic in
his first term he said this was a moment
to show gratitude for the Queen's
service to Australia the Commonwealth
and the world and here is that
International exclusive interview with
our correspondent Cordelia Lynch
a prime minister Albanese you have
announced a public holiday to Mark the
Queen's death why was that so important
to you I think it's important that we
commemorate the remarkable life and
indeed the service that Queen Elizabeth
gave to Australia as our head of state
for 70 years the longest serving British
monarch ever but also a great deal of
affection from Australians towards the
queen and on Thursday the 22nd of
September our protocol requires the
national Remembrance Day to be the day
after myself and the governor general
the the now Kings representative in
Australia return from the service in
London so here that will occur in
Parliament House at the Great Hall I've
declared a national day of mourning and
together with the states and territories
we agreed yesterday to have a national
one-off public holiday
the Australian's relationship with the
queen appears enduring
what do you think it was about her Reign
that achieved that special connection
I think the the queen was with
Australians during times of Celebration
the opening of this house Parliament
House in 1988 the opening of the Sydney
Opera House during our great historic
events but was also with Australia at
our times of difficulties this is a land
of cyclones the floods of natural
disasters and Queen Elizabeth always
reached out to give that Comfort to
Australians at our time of of need and
she was such a a respected figure
regardless of where people stand on the
political spectrum that 70 years of
public service that that Devotion to
duty is something that holds her in in
such high regard how do you think the
dynamic will change under the reign of
King Charles
well of course it's the end of the
second Elizabethan era and the beginning
of a new one King Charles of course is
very well known to Australia he did some
of his uh as a student here was in
Victoria he's someone who's been a
regular visitor to our Shores I think on
a range of issues as well that King
Charles has expressed opinion on over
the years not party political opinion
but opinion about Humanity's Direction
the need to take action on climate
change the relationship with the built
environment and its relation to our
natural environment King Charles of
course is very familiar to all of us and
today we have proclaimed him the king of
Australia
part of the success of Queen Elizabeth
reign here seems to be that people
perceived her as being politically
neutral do you think her son will be
able to achieve that too I'm sure he's
very conscious
of the need to be above politics and he
certainly has always been that in terms
of of Australia but he's someone who has
a a deep relationship with Australia I
hope that he is able to visit here on on
an occasion as as soon as as possible
but he's been a regular visitor here and
we're very familiar this of course is
it's a substantial change the the only
monarch that we have known in my
lifetime and in the lifetime of most
Australians has been Queen Elizabeth so
this is a change one of the the reasons
why I think Queen Elizabeth is held in
such affection is that if you think
about the last 70 years it's been an era
which has seen more change than any era
in human history the nature of 10
technology and the way that it's
transformed the way that our society
functions Queen Elizabeth was able to
change with with that times in terms of
her her interactions with the public and
King Charles will I'm sure do the same
it's reignited a debate about a republic
do you think in this moment that that is
appropriate so perhaps even
opportunistic
well I I am of the person of you and
I've made it uh clear that now is the
time for us to pay tribute
to the life of Queen Elizabeth II to
give thanks uh for her service to
Australia to the Commonwealth and to the
world and that is the focus that I have
you've talked about the need previously
to have an Australian head of state but
you said you won't commit to a
referendum in your first term is that
still the case is my priority and I said
this before the election and I've
maintained it since my election as prime
minister is the recognition of First
Nations people in our constitution our
constitution at the moment would have
you believe if you read it it's our
nation's birth certificate that history
began in 1788 and of course that was an
important part of our history but we are
home to and share this continent with
the oldest continuous culture on the
planet that goes back some 65 000 years
that should be a source of national
pride and we should recognize Aboriginal
and Torres Strait Islander people in our
Constitution that is absolutely my
priority
when it comes to the monarchy do you
think though Australians want to see the
institution evolve
will of course and and it has evolved
and it will continue uh to evolve uh it
will need to continue to move with the
times but the bigger questions about our
Constitution are not ones for this
current period This is a period in which
we are showing the grief that so many
Australians are feeling at the moment
showing our deep respect and admiration
for the contribution of the queen to
Australia and today of course the the
transition formally here to recognize
that with the Queen's passing King
Charles automatically became the head of
state of Australia but today we're
formalized that with the ceremony one of
the things about I think the Queen's
affection that she was held in as well
is that
there is that tradition
and we've gone through those processes
here in Australia in the last few days
it's a sad time but it's also a time to
celebrate what is a long life well lived
you will be attending the Queen's
funeral you'll be meeting with the King
how do you want to see your relationship
with him I look forward I look forward
very much to meeting King Charles I have
met him before in his his previous
capacity and I had the honor of meeting
Queen Elizabeth at Buckingham Palace and
Prince Charles was there on that
occasion at the first meeting of of the
G20 and I look forward to on behalf of
Australia expressing
face-to-face person to person
my condolences and the condolences of
our nation for the loss not just of
course of Queen Elizabeth as the head of
state but as his beloved mother and I
thought it was a beautiful statement
that King Charles made in his that first
statement as as our new sovereign do you
think this moment this pause for
reflection internationally might
actually consolidate people's belief in
the power of the monarchy I'll look that
that we will see
what occurs I think the important thing
is I think to commemorate
the moment that we're in now and it is a
moment of reflection about an
extraordinary life and one of the the
videos I saw this morning I remember
seeing the the joke video that the queen
did with Paddington Bear recently and
that says something about her character
as well that's one of the reasons why
Australians who were a pretty relaxed
slot can really relate I think so well
to the life of Queen Elizabeth
she certainly had a powerful connection
and we've witnessed that firsthand here
in Australia and just to confirm though
no referendum in in your first term no
that's great thank you so much prime
minister really appreciate you speaking
with us and um that's something we we
saw yesterday was just the amount of
people who talked about her enduring
Legacy no matter what people's
perspective on the institution may have
been flowed waned over the time she in
particular seemed to really Garner a lot
of respect and love here well that's Rod
um I think that Australians might have
different views about the full range of
views about the institution My Views are
there very much on the record uh but
regardless of that I don't think that
gets in the way of an admiration and
respect
for Queen Elizabeth and for her
contribution
speaking to the Australian prime
minister there who paid his own tribute
to her
well the police are preparing the route
for Her Majesty's Cortez
in a few moments time we will see her
departing
Balmoral Castle
she has been at rest in the ballroom
since her death there on Thursday
she is in an oak coffin covered with the
Royal Standard for Scotland and with a
wreath of flowers on top
those picked from The Gardens of
Balmoral some of her favorite flowers we
are told
flocks dahlias sweet peas lamonium white
Heather and pine fur
atop the coffin as it will depart
accompanied
by Princess Royal Princess Anne and her
husband
Tim Lawrence
well let's bring in our correspondent
who is there Greg mylam
and the Tranquility of Balmoral the
quietness there Greg for all to see
yes and we know that away from the
cameras at the castle that what we
expect to happen out of sight of all of
us that very private moment for those
members of the the estate those staff
who worked here members of the the
household staff for many years many of
them and those six gamekeepers who will
carry the Queen's coffin from as you say
the ballroom through the small dining
room to the entrance Portico we
understand that the Sovereign Piper who
has been a feature of many of the
Queen's visits here will play uh we'll
play Balmoral and Glenn gelder to
accompany the Queen's coffin to the
hearse and then she will begin that
Journey uh down the driveway into those
Gates that you see there which opened a
couple of minutes ago we saw the the
police outriders taking up position at
the end of the driveway across the
bridge for the beginning of this this
journey but of course the final
departure from a place that meant so
much to her majesty and her family over
so many years and as you say the
Princess Royal her husband Tim Lawrence
will accompany the the hearse on that
the entirety of that Journey six hours
they anticipate to Edinburgh the other
members of the the royal family the the
uh the new Kings other siblings their
partner's children will make their own
way to Edinburgh and what's due to
happen there uh later but a hugely
symbolic moment I think for Balmoral
certainly for the community here the
people who believe and have only believe
the queen is is one of their neighbors
one of their community
a a private moment inside the estate
there but a very significant one for the
community and for the royal family to to
make this final farewell to Balmoral
described by Queen Victoria as her dear
Paradise in the highlands it was brought
privately by Prince Albert for his wife
in 1852 and this place this 50 000 acre
estate with its sense of wildness and
Beauty in the Ken gums national park has
provided Joy too for her majesty the
queen a sanctuary a community for which
she could become a part and the journey
will take the Cortez along the the river
D like a lifeblood flowing through the
villages along its course towards
Aberdeen bursting with life and full
from the the reign of last week and and
there Alistair Bruce people will come
out and you know pay tribute to to her
to to their Queen the woman they saw out
and about in the local community
undoubtedly it is a very special place
for the queen and her family and in
this intermittent Sunshine which always
elevates the beauty of this place
the queen will be conveyed now from
the small dining room in
Balmoral Castle by
six of her gamekeepers all of whom she
will have known extremely well she'll
know their families she will have heard
the news of the birth of any of their
children
and they will convey her with the
company of
the man who was the Queen's Piper
who is the sovereign's Piper who will
play
her to the hearse
and accompanied by the minister of the
krati Kirk
the Reverend Kenneth McKenzie it will be
a profound departure from a much-loved
castle
coffin at rest like this in Balmoral has
allowed Balmoral estate staff to pay
their respects many of whom Buckingham
Palace tells us have spent a good deal
of their lives in Royal Service here the
royal family employing approximately 50
full-time and about 50 to 100 part-time
staff to maintain the estate and it's a
working estate too of all 50 000 Acres
Grouse malls forestry Farmland as well
as managed herds of deer Highland cattle
and ponies in approximately 150
buildings on the estate too so lots
going on and certainly the royal family
who are there still with her we saw them
coming outside yesterday to these Gates
heavily protected now as you can see to
see those flowers the tears of her her
grandchildren Zara and Eugenie as they
read those tributes to her majesty
and the thousands of people who have
come to pay their respects many from far
and wide they've had to put on bus
services from the nearby towns of uh
from Braemar and balita and balita one
of the first villagers through which
this Cortez will pass
they will be preparing now
Alistair it is 10 o'clock to lift Her
Majesty's body the six gamekeepers
whose role it will be to begin this
journey for her
when she emerges from the castle the
ballater royal guard formed by balaclava
company of the royal Regiment of
Scotland will
present arms and a royal salute to their
sovereign
of happy memory
the links that the queen had with the
regiment
went right back to the beginning of her
reign
and during that Reign the
many threads of Scottish military
tradition were woven into that regiment
and so she had great pride in being
their colonel in Chief
as she's brought from the castle in
private at the moment
she'll be watched by those who looked
after her in the final
hours of her life
should be watched by the
estate staff
and then the simple procession will
leave and we'll see her shortly appear
through the gates that recall and
reflect her grandparents
King George V and Queen Mary and it was
during their reign that she was born
and in the very first year of her life
as an infant she was brought through
those Gates
to share one of those great summer
holidays
with the royal family for which Balmoral
has continued to provide
the perfect Haven and
it was at the end of one of those
holidays
that the queen was called upon
to receive a new prime minister
and so shortly after that her last
Constitutional work done
the Angels Came to her Haven
and started her journey to heaven
the police have stepped aside
and shortly
that slow Journey the final Journey from
Balmoral will begin
for the late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II
Queen of Scots
from the gate they will pass across the
river d
and then turn right towards
Aberdeen
she'll pass through a number of
different villages on the way
and each of them known very well to her
because
always she made sure well here
at the castle she took part
in the Civic life of aberdeenshire
the sign for the
suggestion that all cars drive very
slowly here which Prince Philippine
system upon because of the red squirrels
that were so rare and so beautiful and
and really danced about on this drive
we wait now for
the queen to start a journey which
will take her through land that her
family
knew well she was a Bose lion through
her mother
and the Bose Lions as Earls of
Strathmore and King Horn
who themselves descended from the Stuart
Kings and King Robert The Brute
lived at glam's Castle not far from
Balmoral
while we wait
the royal family are saying goodbye in
Balmoral
to a beloved mother and grandmother
and the staff here in Scotland
are taking their leave
as they hand
the monarch and family matriarch
after her death back to her Nation
to her realms
to the Commonwealth and her
people across the world who have been
moved
by the ending of a reign of more than 70
years
and a life of more than 96.
the sun will be Illuminating the turrets
and spiers of Balmoral
as the queen leaves
her beloved home
thank you
Elizabeth II by the grace of God of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland Queen head of the
Commonwealth defender of the faith Queen
of Scots
now turning down towards Aberdeen
the oak coffin covered with the Royal
Standard of Scotland
and while she passed onto the main road
the police had their heads bowed police
who throughout her life as Sovereign
have been responsible for maintaining
her security not least here in her
holiday home
and the beauty of aberdeenshire
the hills that she knew themselves
scattered with memorials to Queen
Victoria's time here to marriages of the
royal family and of course to the
Queen's own jubilees
there were places she went for her
picnics with her family particularly
this year in her declining health
but she had right to the end the joy of
her family around her
and they have now
sent her on her final Journey
she's accompanied
in the car following the hearse by her
daughter
the Princess Royal
with her husband
Admirals sir Tim Lawrence
and also following
is
the minister of the Kirk
where the queen
worshiped regularly at krati just at the
point that
we saw her pass from our site
every week she would go
and attend Divine service
led by the minister
the Reverend Kevin McKenzie
Reverend Kenneth Mckenzie was a
a great orator and gave the most
wonderful sermons
and was often asked back for
a drink with the queen so she could talk
about it and particularly
with the Duke of Edinburgh all part of
the life of this community here
in aberdeenshire of which there are so
many
the D Valley is where Farmland
juxtaposes beside the wildness of the
Heather and rocks of the mountains of
aberdeenshire
and
quite quickly as
the Convoy moves to
the east
the hills give way to
shallow Hills and finally come to the
Sea
but the D which is a thread all the way
through
this Valley
has always been part of the life of
Balmoral
and the Farmland here where the Queen's
cattle have grazed she heads towards
abigailde Castle
which was
still used by the royal family when she
was very young
just see it there at the bottom of the
picture
and
part of the neighboring estate
of Balmoral Castle
looking Westward
towards the hills of imber called
and again
the family that used to live at
invercall were close friends
of the queen and Prince Philip
and would also worship quite regularly
at crafty Kirk
from the rooms that the queen occupied
on the first floor of Balmoral Castle
and where she daily attended to the red
boxes of State papers that were sent to
her
from the Realms and from the
Commonwealth
the queen could always glance out of the
window at her horses
there were always horses
for her majesty to enjoy she knew all
their names
she bred plenty of them particularly up
here the hill ponies
that she cared so much about and
regularly went down to check how they
were getting on
it's not a great distance to
ballater the
first town close to Balmoral
and it was at balita where until the 60s
the
Railway line used to come and it was two
ballater station that the Royal Family
came by train to start their holidays
and
so balita has always been
important to the Royal Family
and here is where the
Royal Guard who have just presented on
behalf of the Armed Forces
the first salute to the late sovereign
on this journey it's where they're based
at Victoria Barracks named after of
course the Monarch who fell in love with
these Hills
and who decided that this
was where
the Royal Highland home would be
the queen particularly loved going for
picnic lunches and picnic suppers
whilst that sounds like
rather a cold and wet thing to do there
were a number of old
cottages on the Balmoral estate that
Prince Philip and she
developed so that there were places to
go to and from which to have walks
across the countryside
of course the great thing about Scotland
is that there is no rule of trespass
and very often when the queen would
arrive at one of the Cottages there
would be members of the public who just
happened to be having a picnic too
and they would hear
a cacophony of corgis barking
and the queen would always be very
courteous because that was very much her
nature
and she would always be
very interested in how they'd find their
way there and learn their story
there's an art gallery in here here on
the road where often members of the
royal family would go in and spot
paintings of Balmoral which would be
brought to the Queen's attention and she
would
consider whether they should be
held in the private collection
which the royal family holds for the
nation
the glint of the
yellow and red
of Scotland's lion rampant coming
through the roof
caught in the Sun
as it lies across
Elizabeth II
who carried the lion rampant
as Queen
for over 70 years
and did her best to serve
the kingship of Scots
and that of the United Kingdom
the rounds
and her headship of the Commonwealth
other members of the royal family who
were at Balmoral to see
Queen Elizabeth leave will make their
way now to
Hollywood where this
procession will arrive
in about six hours
shortly they will turn towards
ballater
and make their way through
the Main Street there where very often
particularly as a child
princess Elizabeth of York
would go shopping with her nanny
and sometimes with her mother then
Duchess of your
they lived at Burke Hall which is
quite close to where the Cortez is now
and it was only when
her uncle abdicated King Edward VII to
marry Mrs Simpson
that this young girl's life changed
completely
her father unexpectedly became king
and Emperor
at a time when there was a
responsibility for the crime for
an Empire that stretched across the
world
and suddenly this young princess was the
heir presumptive to the throne
almost immediately on
the point of accession King George VI
the Queen's father became very concerned
that if anything happened to him
that his daughter should be properly
protected
and made arrangements for
Parliament to
adjust the Regency act to make sure that
this young girl
whose life had now completely changed
would be protected
but by her father's side particularly
during the second world war and of
course
the Second World War began
while the royal family were at Balmoral
and the king and queen had to leave
in order to return to London
on the advice of the Prime Minister
and it was at Balmoral when the royal
family was gathered around
the dining room table
one evening that the aquarium came in
and asked the king to leave the room
and the queen watched as her father left
then the queen was called out too
and there was some concern that
something might have happened to
Churchill but it was the Queen's Uncle
the Duke of Kent had been killed as the
queen now comes
into balater
for
the chance of the people of balita
to show their respect
to one of the locals who has died who
just happened to be
the queen
foreign
will be passing the entrance of the road
now to Victoria Barracks where the royal
guard
have stood station upon her protection
right throughout her Reign when she's
been here and also passed the station
foreign
a salute from the Lord Lieutenant of
aberdeenshire
and other members of the lieutenancy as
the queen passed by the War Memorial
she passes the fishmonger
the baker
the Bookshop
the clothing stores
of the Main Street most of them
holding above their places of trade
Royal warrants that they have earned
from the queen
and from the new king as Prince of Wales
and the queen and the prince of Wales
were deeply distressed when terrible
flooding caused
enormous damage yeah
and they took a part in
supporting the reconstruction
as the final part of the procession
passes by
and we see the Lord of tempter of
aberdeenshire
just before the bridge where so much
damage was done due to trees being
pulled down
the D they got caught at the bridge and
that led the flooding of balita
the Queen's procession will turn
and head towards
aberdeenshire
but across that bridge had
there been more memories that one can
tell of the queen heading across that
bridge in order to go to stay
at Burke Hall
as a girl
in those early days when
the very thought of queenship
was not even considered
and yet from
this place
the time she knew so well
the quietest and most Scottish of
salutes
from the accession of her father King
George VI
it was clear to him and his wife Queen
Elizabeth the queen mother as we knew
her
that the
careful upbringing of Princess Elizabeth
and her younger sister Princess Margaret
Rhodes
was going to be
of particular importance to prepare
princess Elizabeth for one day being
Queen
every parent does their best for their
children
and a bond was developed between
the queen and her father that was
as profound as any daughter can have for
a father
and whatever he did it must have been
entirely inspired
because whilst her father was dealing
with
the impediment that he had in his
speaking
which made
public moments like his own accession
Council in nineteen
36 so difficult for
the new King George VI at the same time
the king took such immense confidence
from his wife Queen Elizabeth and from
his two daughters
they were a really powerful
family the King used to call
than we fought
and of course as the eldest daughter
she had to be part of the stability for
her father
during the challenges of the second
World War
The War Began only a few years after her
father became king
that had been noises from across
in Germany as nationalism
took a grip
and during the war
the king's stability and quiet voice and
hesitancy
was it self-inspirational
there are pictures of the queen as a
young princess beside her father's he
went through the red boxes
and those pictures give a sense of the
bond between them as she studied and
learned
the way in which he was learning
to be sovereign
to be separate to be alone
I had the privilege of a conversation
with the queen about her coronation in
1953.
and she recalled how difficult it was
for her to really remember much of it
because she was
involved and making sure that she did
what she needed to do correctly
in a long ceremony
but she said she remembered her father's
much better
and had I read her recollections
and indeed there's an exercise book
written
by the young princess
very soon after
she came into
the palace after returning from this
extraordinary moment of Splendor for her
father
as he was elevated to kingship
and it's delightful description of an
ancient ceremony
Louise Tate Her Majesty's Communications
secretary here in Scotland joins us now
under deep sadness for people like you
who knew her there that the queen has
left Balmoral and this part of Roald D
side for the last time it is her beloved
or moral it's incredibly sad it's a
place that obviously she loved and she
knows this Countryside so well and these
small towns and Villages were so
important and they visited these these
areas often publicly but also privately
they're very familiar faces
so many of these people and it will be a
desperately sad time and each of them
with its own history they went over
Balmoral bridge this wrought iron girder
bridge
a single span Bridge the only structure
in Scotland designed by the notable
engineer izombard Kingdom Brunel it was
built on the instructions of Prince
Albert and when Queen Victoria saw it
she didn't like it because it was it
lacked ornamentation for her the history
of this place is is steeped as it not in
in the royal family for a for 150 years
yes I mean Prince Albert built that
castle from Granite that was human from
the estate and um it's a
Scottish in the Scottish baronial style
and it's I've said it before it's it's a
castle but it's still an intimate castle
and everything in Scotland always feels
a little bit magnified and you know
that's all struck me that uh whenever a
royal family out about especially our
Majesty they were very visible but never
troubled by anyone and the queen of
course would have arrived by train as
Alistair was saying there and in fact
the small station
at ballater is a tea room now is it not
and it hosts the queen Queen Victoria's
waiting room and is is still much loved
by by locals and visitors alike yes I
believe the the it's the rossly rooms
now actually the Tea Room um but yes I
remember when the real characters are
stored Railway Carriage was opened by
the now King many years ago and it's
it's a popular
um very popular visitors experience that
I I know endures
and you were saying that only recently
you drove the Duke of Edinburgh from
Edinburgh all the way to Balmoral what
was that Journey
well it was after the floods uh in
ballater when the D brought its banks
and there was I think we can all
remember some of the pictures and his
Royal enemies wanted to go and see for
himself the damage on the estate but he
also wanted to visit local shops and
businesses just to see how they're
recovering
um so I'm I picked him up off a sleeper
sleeper for Edinburgh super from London
picked him up in Edinburgh at seven
o'clock in the morning
and we drove to Balmoral
and he went into the village and I
completely accompany you for that that
part and then you went on to the estate
and had a tour of the estate and I
picked them up again and we drove back
and I've been back on a sleeper and he
was 95 years old
he never wasted a single minute of his
life and um it was just it was an
extraordinary experience what an old
treasure
and it was the two of them together it
wasn't here to Who Loved Balmoral before
that it was the Queen's parents as well
at the time Duke and Duchess of York
before he came King George VI so it
really is rooted in her and her happy
memories as a child but in later life
too what did she get out of being there
and in this part of the world I think
she she did love being outdoors and that
not the midges not the weather nothing
phased Her Majesty in my experience and
just that opportunity to go and do the
things she enjoys and no doubt it was a
blessed relief from some of the heavier
official things that she never had to do
each morning and they say the red boxes
they're only two days of the year where
she didn't receive them one was her
birthday one was Christmas day so amidst
all this Glory the beauty of a royalty
side and the kangoms national parks and
still had to go through her papers on a
daily basis yes I mean that's just an
understood that was her Duty she was
very determined our work ethic is
something extraordinary really was
how would she spend her days what would
they be like there
well you if members of the fabric would
often encounter the queen and other
members of our family just when she was
riding sometimes or just out on a hill
or some of the places he used to go for
barbecues these are just generally
understood kind of typical country
Pursuits and I said not the weather not
the Mitch is nothing with the term from
enjoying that Countryside because it is
absolutely beautiful and it is a shame
that traditionally the court used to end
at the end of September and October
before that part turns into Autumn that
world becomes Autumn and the trees just
turn and it's stunning it's just a
stunning very atmospheric place
as the cottage makes it weigh its way
through further Villages of
aberdeenshire like dinner where again it
had that railway station the D side
Railway serving The Village a locality
from 1866 to 1966 and this Village said
to be the gateway to both the highlands
and the kangoms national park despite
the fact that it is well within the
boundaries of present-day aberdeenshire
it's the first Village along the D to be
located inside the park and they can see
once again the people on the streets to
say goodbye and how important is it do
you think that people are being
you know afforded this opportunity to
see the quartet like this
well they want you know they have the
opportunity which is really important
they have the space provision has been
made so that members of the public can
where it's possible and safe to do so
line the route and it they desperately I
I think are being very keen from the
people I've spoken to just I'm very
determined to be there at whatever they
could to get a view and just take a
moment as that coffin goes past
and at Balmoral constant visitors her
family and others I remember being told
on Friday while I was there that a
visiting dignitary had said oh look at
those little brown Hills I think they
were American and the queen was quite
affronted that the mighty monroes had
been described thus that would have that
would have irritated her well you know
she's just she's so familiar with that
landscape and she knows all the you know
look Mick and all the these lovely
Charming names that don't took off the
tongue necessarily
um she knows it's all well and
she would always be Keen to just be
private actual problem I don't know
about that story but uh yeah perhaps it
would be a little bit just me that they
weren't perhaps impressive enough but uh
yeah no it's it's a stunning stunning
part of the world
and all of these cities that she will
pass through Aberdeen of course the the
first one there on the coast such an
important Oil City she will have visited
all of these as well would she not oh
many times I I've done countless Royal
engagements with emergency in Aberdeen
um and interestingly I met an Italian
young Italian man in a city called
macarata in central Italy and
be for chatting and he told me that he
went to see the queen in Aberdeen
when he was working in Edinburgh and he
went to Aberdeen to see the queen and he
was Italian it was it was that important
to him and I it was just a very random
encounter but I think that's the that
was the power of her you know she was a
draw she's people desperately want to
see her and I think this is no different
obviously the circumstances are so
different but
that sense of wanting to be there for
her and to have that experience of
saying they were there that part of
History I think is
very powerful
she had this amazing smile did she not
which put people at their ease and
that's what everybody says that she had
this ability to put you at your ears
including the photographer on Tuesday
who took the photograph of of the queen
with the new prime minister and the
Queen at the time commented that the
skies had got dark and the weather was
coming in talking about the weather out
the window and I know you were outside
you felt moral on that very wet day but
uh inside with the with the fire raging
and still that warmth the sunshine smile
that comes from and that smile was there
just as much behind the scenes as it was
in in public I just remember her real
kindness and care and her humor she was
personally very kind to me
um
few years ago I had a rotten Health
diagnosis and I had to take a bit of
time off work and when I came back the
following year she asked me to be a lady
in waiting
to the at the Garden Party traditionally
there were two ladies and waiting and I
was incredibly touched and then she
asked that I wear the brooch
the E diamond and platinum brooch on
pink ribbon and
you know she didn't have to do that
she didn't have to do that and but the
gesture I know was meant as welcome back
you're not the only one who talks about
the kindness and in fact the household
staff who've had the opportunity to pay
their respects with the coffin resting
in the ballroom at Balmoral and then it
will come here later on today to the
Palace of Hollywood house with the same
time will be afforded for those
household staff many like you who worked
for years decades with the queen and how
important will it be for staff who are
so deeply affected by this to be able to
pay their respects well I think it's
to say it's a punctuation Point perhaps
that's not the right choice of words but
you need that moment because we still
have a monarch and they still continue
to serve that Monarch but they have to
have that that moment where they can pay
their last respects because of the many
years of service that they've um enjoyed
and I think it is part of the
fabric of
of being part of the royal household the
Royal life that they have to have that
moment I think and I I think it's a
it's going to be quite moving
we talked about the visitors she had at
Balmoral and in fact
last weekend it is only last weekend she
was host to the right Reverend Dr Ian
greenshields the moderator of the
general assembly of the Church of
Scotland who will pay such an important
role obviously here in Edinburgh and he
said that she enjoyed eating ice cream
made with berries from the Balmoral
estate that she loved making jokes as
well and talked about the afterlife as
well and at one point he asked her what
her favorite hymn was and she said she
couldn't possibly tell him because then
that was the only thing they would play
and uh she was very she was very
contemplative and talking about some of
the remarkable people she'd met she was
just reflecting on that reflecting on
life and where this life leads to and we
just talked about that and eternal life
and Resurrection even he said and what
these things meant and then as things
these things happen in conversation you
move on to something else but
extraordinary that only last weekend
they talked about that as they shared a
beautiful meal an intimate dinner he
said consisting of a fish course
followed by ham and strawberry ice cream
that she particularly liked made with
those berries from the Balmoral estate
so enjoying the convivial company of her
family and guests only last weekend I
know she's an extraordinary one I mean
extraordinary
um I was very fortunate too to have many
lunches and dinners in the palace
Hollywood house when the queen was in
Residence
and it was always a wonderful experience
there's always some nerves when you're
trying to move a fish course perhaps
onto a Peak from a from a tree but those
kind of to have those kind of memories
is incredibly special and I have many of
my own
some people describe her as shy but
clearly she enjoyed company how did you
find her
I wouldn't say shy
um no I I find her to be very forthright
um very straightforward in many regards
and it is that that humor that always
came across that humor she got me a cup
of time but um that was what had that
you know that twinkle just you could be
in a room full of Extraordinary People
impressive people but there's only one
person in that room really well that is
exactly what the former prime minister
Theresa May said that she was the most
remarkable person she had ever met I I
would agree
I would agree
and the twinkle perhaps saved most for
her husband the Duke of Edinburgh what
what were they like together on the
estate and and here at uh at the palace
that was Private time but officially you
know I the Duke of Edinburgh I wasn't
where I was supposed to be 1D
I was in Glasgow looking at the
following engagement for the following
day and I didn't think I'd be missed
and when I joined when I joined the
party that evening before dinner
she immediately came and said you
weren't there today and that you could
then reset it here we are again
so the result she knew exactly who was
meant to be where and when and what they
were supposed to be doing and I had to
explain myself
did they make each other laugh oh yes oh
yes there was always a lot of laughter
there was always a lot of laughter I
mean like I used to because the way this
setting usually goes there's usually
um a woman wouldn't ordinarily sit next
to her majesty and so I often sat next
to the Duke of Edinburgh and there was
one conversation I was having with him
that I had to say Sir I've navigated
myself into another tricky water can we
change the subject and he said no we
can't so I I'm gonna have to see it so I
did and he was roaring with laughter and
just at that point Her Majesty started
speaking to the other person or a person
on the other side of her so he turned
still laughing and I had the Lord
Chamberlain on my right and he said I
don't care what you're about to say I
want to know what you've just said to
him and I had to go with it all again
but they were you had to be yourself
with them I said earlier
sick of fancy and all that in my
experience that was not something that
they appreciated and so I I found that
he very much put you at your ease
clearly you're always respectful and
mindful
but the sense of history as well with
both of them
I remember watching something on the
news and it was about a steam ship that
had been restored I've been part of the
small ships at Dunkirk and I mean a
couple of colleagues were talking about
it
and the queen came and joined our small
group
so I explained what we've been talking
about and she started talking about her
Recollections of that day
and and first you just enraptured
thinking someone you mentioned then you
remember she's the queen
on the Drive North he
with that time I drove him to Balmoral
occasion he talked as we were going over
the bridge about his life at the South
and the Navy and and just I think about
these roles in this journey he actually
talked to me about the where the old a93
this is the a93
um used to be and it you know the recall
was a sharp
sharp never dipped never dipped
and through the Villages of a boy in
Kincardine O'Neill they'll go uh born
Castle the lock of a boy a boy in itself
home to the oldest 18-hole golf course
on Royal d-side as well King cardi and
O'Neill since ancient times a crossing
of the D River at kingcardine O'Neill so
again you can see the people lining up
there
and it seems as the Cortez go past quiet
respectful contemplative does it not the
atmosphere
it does uh you know it has slowed too I
think just almost walking peace
um you know to allow people to have that
that quiet moment
and
you know we'll never see this Lake again
and we talked earlier about the
importance of the Princess Royal
following the cottage alongside her
husband Admiral Sir Tim Lawrence as well
and the fact that she has her family by
her side for this journey which we will
see here too when King Charles arrives
in Edinburgh tomorrow yeah so it's it's
glad it's my heart that the Princess
Royal
and said Timothy Lawrence are
accompanying this journey because
to see her alone
just feel very heartbreaking
it does feel very heartbreaking
and the Princess Royal is um
Scotland she's in Scotland a lot she is
the um
Chancellor of Edinburgh University
and she takes that
she got home from her father from The
Duke of Edinburgh and she's very
diligent in that role
so she's a very familiar I would say
she's the most regular visitor here to
the Palace of Hollywood house
she visits Scotland a lot and they of
course were married at crafty Kirk as
well were they not because it was a
remarriage and the Church of Scotland
allowed that at the time so that was so
clearly that is a very important spot to
her as well well it's very personal
um and it was interesting that her
daughter Zara and Mike Tyndall chose to
be married at Canongate cook
stop the Royal Mail there and I was
closely involved with media planning for
that and working with Mike and Zara
and it was just so clear how important
it was Edinburgh and Scotland to the
whole family
we will certainly see that over the next
couple of days when the coffin arrives
this afternoon later and then tomorrow
when the Cortez will process up the
Royal mile from the Palace of Hollywood
house to the historic Cathedral of Saint
Giles
11th century some of it still it's a
very Gothic Cathedral very Gothic
Cathedral it's been through many
incarnations has it not been destroyed
by the English and the jacobites and
Through the Ages it has changed but you
know a very important site too for the
real family that's the high quirk I said
you know when the Queensland residents
she worshiped at Canongate but Saint
Giles was also a familiar church for her
Cathedral Kirk Kirk is in Scotland
exactly Louise Tate for the moment thank
you very much indeed thank you
and Aleister we see once again uh the
Cortez slowing to a walking pace as it
makes its way through these villages on
its way to the coast and Aberdeen
yes and passed
Estates that the queen knew well
particularly
glentana which
March is very close to Balmoral where
the Great Hall there used to be a scene
of many an event that gathered people
from this area and
Prince Philip and the queen often
attended events there they passed by a
Boyne and had now
further towards Aberdeen and they'll
head through bankery
it's
this ribbon of one
major Trunk Road and the river and the
Old Railway line all Meandering through
the remaining Hills as they head further
and further to the east
I've had phone calls from friends of
mine who live in the area around there
from Acton donect and
places they were going to go to a nearby
Village some people have pulled their
cars to the side of the road to watch
and
this may continue all the way down
it is a chance for people to
stop and reflect and when the king died
in 1950 in 1952
it was by train that he was conveyed
to London but the
purse is a much more effective way of
taking
the queen on her journey through so many
more parts of Scotland
meanwhile the King has a busy day back
at Buckingham Palace and we should
remember that
from the principal Proclamation at St
James's Palace yesterday when flags were
put up to full mast in order to
celebrate the accession of a new king
the flags remain at full mast and we are
in a period of Celebration
until one o'clock today which will be an
hour after the remaining proclamations
within the United Kingdom but
particularly in Edinburgh and Cardiff
and
it is an irony that while we watch the
mournful
journey of the late Queen to Hollywood
Palace that further up the Royal mile
the
opportunities to mark
the new monarchs accession will be
taking place much as we saw them before
we see the people that are on the side
of the road
you've come down
to this artery of life into the
Highlands
of aberdeenshire
the King's Day at two o'clock he will
receive the Secretary General of the
Commonwealth
baroness Scotland in the 1844 room at
Buckingham Palace
half an hour later at 2 30.
the king will attend a reception with
the high commissioners of the realms
of which he is now King in the bow room
at Buckingham Palace which is next door
to the 1844 room
and at 3 30 this afternoon
the king will receive the dean of
Windsor
the right Reverend David Connor is Dean
of Windsor and responsible for Saint
George's Chapel at Windsor where we
witnessed the funeral under covert
restrictions
of the Duke of Edinburgh
and where ultimately
the committal service for the queen and
the private family internment
will take place
the king will receive the dean of
Windsor in the 1844 room at 3 30.
and the King will also be dealing with
appraising himself of the
vast amount of business that
Sovereign needs to attend to in order
the function of government not only in
the United Kingdom
but also
in the Realms and across the
Commonwealth such as he takes part are
delivered
that burden laid down by the queen as
she
has now taken
by a Grateful Nation to
the process of the MC quiz
the
acknowledgment
of her life in death
which will end with the funeral
on Monday week at Westminster Abbey
coming into bankery I believe
a dotted ribbon of the community and
officials
along the side of the road as she passes
through this Main Street
past the ruins of the old Kirk
leaving bankery and heading on down
towards Aberdeen
when the procession will head south
make its way
past Dundee
and close to Perth
before crossing the Queens Ferry
crossing the Great Bridge that the queen
herself opened not all that long ago
then finally crammond's bridge and into
Edinburgh itself
all the way
recognition being given to the queen in
these small towns and villages
where just like the village around
Balmoral itself
the queen has been
a neighbor
and friend
as the procession conveying the queen to
Edinburgh comes into bankery we will
have a chance to see more closely
the hearse as it conveys
her late majesty and a chance to see
more closely the Royal Standard of
Scotland
with its lion rampant repeated twice
the lines of England once and also
the harp of Ireland
and then over that the wreath that has
been
prepared from the garden at Balmoral
Castle the Gardens at this time looking
absolutely wonderful for the Queen's
visit always timed so that her favorite
flowers which are in the wreath
including flocks
dahlias
sweet peas lemonium white Heather of
course from the Hills
and pine for Queen's favorite flowers
which
sit upon the coffin and
because it's so
open it's visible to see the
strong yellow of Scotland's lion rampant
wherever this
journey goes
Banker is the first big time on the road
from Balmoral down to
Aberdeen
thriving community
again further down the D we keep seeing
the D appear
in the shot just beside this road
meanwhile in bankria they're waiting for
the arrival of the Queen's procession
a reminder that she's being followed on
this journey in the car behind by her
daughter the Princess Royal Princess
Anne with her husband
said Tim Lawrence
keeping the Queens
company on this journey
on behalf of the king
to Hollywood
after resting overnight in Hollywood
Palace tonight
the queen will be conveyed
to the high Kirk
of Saint Giles on the Royal mile at the
heart of the Old City of Edinburgh
the cathedral there is the home to
Scotland's
most ancient and Noble order of the
thistle of which the queen was Sovereign
head
16 Knights Brethren and Ladies of the
order of the thistle
who wearing green velvet robes
are deemed by demonic
to be the most August contributors to
Scottish life
and it's an order that is within the
Queen's personal gift
the queen was graciously
happy to be photographed in the Robes of
the order of the thistle
for a book
that we compiled
and she
came out into the middle
of the Balmoral estate
driving wearing the robes
and on the way out there was a family
having a walk on one of the roads
it's really a track in the middle of the
estate
and I was in the car in front
and the family is stepped off the road
and stared in at me I think with
incredulous surprise that somebody
should suddenly appear on this track
and then the queen was following behind
and when we stopped at the location the
photograph is going to be taken of her
in robes in the middle of the Balmoral
more with all its beautiful Heather and
Hills
I went to open the door and bowed to the
queen as she got out
and she indicated behind her and said
they must think I'm mad
and
I said I think people sometimes think
you dress like this for dinner
and it just showed her sense of humor
dressed as she was in robes and wearing
a tiara
in the middle of the Balmoral estate
she just loved being
in aberdeenshire and it is deeply
appropriate
that it was here that her life ended
with her family
the late Queen now comes into bankery
where we will see
the reaction of the people there
as the hearse passes
through the heart of the time
the river D making its way past bankery
as the queen now comes into this town
it's a large area and
as I was saying a thriving Community
here at bankery the queen
often came to carry out engagements in
bankery sometimes on her way in or out
of her holiday here
and again it was
moderately affected although not so
badly
as balloted by some of the flooding this
River can
from time to time
create great challenge for those who
live beside it and yet it brings such
beauty to the area
as I was mentioning as the hearse comes
by
chance to look at the Royal Standard of
Scotland
lies across
the late Queen and also
the wonderful flowers from the garden at
Balmoral
a garden that the queen would often when
she was able walk around
in a famous documentary about the queen
called Elizabeth
there were pictures of her walking with
her then prime minister Sir John Major
as they meandered through the garden and
one can imagine many a prime minister
has walked with the queen going back to
the time of
Winston Churchill
and
the greenhouse and the garden which any
visitors to Balmoral will have seen
I will recall it so they'll have a
chance to look
with respect at the queen as she passes
through bankery
[Music]
everything
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
a wonderful salute from bankery
quiet
gentle Applause and a few of them
throwing
flowers into the path of the hearse as a
salute is given to the queen
this very long quartet of cars following
along behind both
the hearse itself and the cars carrying
the Princess Royal and Sir Tim Lawrence
and also
the minister of
crafty who will accompany
the coffin all the way to Hollywood
Heights the minister who had
been there for the queen
always when she was at our moral seeing
her all the way
to Hollywood
and
bankria set in this most beautiful
countryside of aberdeenshire as we look
down from above and the journey
continues
on its way
to Aberdeen
tears and Applause then from the people
of bankery and watching these pictures
with me from the Palace of Hollywood
house in Edinburgh is the Deputy first
Minister John Swinney and what have you
made of the reaction that you've seen so
far today is an immensely poignant day
Her Majesty's last journey from her
beloved by moral is is so sad to witness
and I think the people that have come
out are determined to pay respectful
tribute to her majesty she loved this
particular part of Scotland in deeside
she was very much part of it she was
part of the community she had neighbors
who counted the queen as their neighbor
and it's lovely to see people coming out
to pay that to quiet respectful tribute
to her majesty and indeed before bankery
it was quiet wasn't it it was almost as
everybody was having their own Minute
silence as the Cortez went past but as
you say the response might be different
nearer to Balmoral where people you know
saw the queen going to the local
butchers for example people in the
immediate area around Balmoral
particularly in balata were accustomed
to seeing the queen out and about she
was very much part of the community and
people loved that and they love the
queen in in that Community as people did
right across the country so the journey
that the queen is making today is a
final journey through parts of the
country that she knew well the Cortez
will come through Aberdeen down to the
city of Dundee through perthshire the
community I have the privilege to
represent and down here into the capital
city to Hollywood Palace where the queen
spent a large proportion of our time she
obviously relaxed the Balmoral she
worked very much here at Hollywood's
house and the queen was only here a few
weeks ago for Hollywood week when she
would spend a week here meeting people
in Scotland she had a really busy
demanding program back in late June
early July people loved singer she was
in great spirits and we enjoyed having
her as a visitor to the Scottish
Parliament she came to every session of
our Parliament she was here for the
opening in 1999 a day of utter joy in
Scotland and at the heart of that Joy
was her majesty Queen being very much
part of that joyful day well we're
literally stood aren't we right by the
Scottish Parliament which faces the the
palace where we are now and that will
become part of the focus tomorrow will
it not when King Charles arrives in the
capital to be welcomed by the first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon that's right
today is a day a very solemn day where
the Queen's body will be brought to
Hollywood Palace tomorrow
um the Queen's coffin will process up to
Saint gel's Cathedral for a service of
Thanksgiving for her life and then later
in the day his majesty the king will
honor Parliament by making his first
appearance there as as as our King
the King has been to Parliament on many
occasions in the past but he was there
with the queen just in October of last
year but it will be the King's first
visit to Parliament and it will be an
opportunity for Parliament to express
our condolences directly to him on the
loss of the queen and and to hear from
the King for the first time
many people have taken Solace that it
was actually in Balmoral that the the
queen passed away somewhere that she
absolutely adored and that adored her
back do you see do you see it like that
the uh you know the sense of calmness
she got from that environment the
Queen's been a good part of the year and
and actually in recent years an
increasing part of the year at Memorial
she was extending our stay there she
loved being been there she loved being
out in the outdoors uh she would have
seen in the last few weeks
frankly the magisterial conditions of
the Memorial Estates the Heather in
Scotland this year has been Exquisite
and her majesty will have seen that over
the last few weeks at Balmoral she will
have seen Balmoral look at its finest
and she was very much at peace there she
enjoyed the countryside she enjoyed
being out and about in it and she
enjoyed being part of the community
around Balmoral and a community
respected having the queen as one of
their neighbors unrespected how much of
a contribution she made to the local
community and to the bargain
are there questions do you think about
what happens to Balmoral now and are
there questions too about the monarchy
in Scotland under you know any any of
your hopes and ambitions
as much of the King has always been a
very involved and engaged part of
Scottish Society indeed his majesty
lives a large part of the year in the
memorial State as well at Burke Hall and
and and has engaged very much in the
life of Scotland so I would expect his
mind to the king to take forward the
same approach as the queen took forward
of being involved in Scottish Society of
being a big figure in Scottish Society
or being close to us at moments of Joy
such as the opening of the parliament
and moments of tragedy when the queen
has always been at our sight she the
queen came to to Scotland in the major
aftermath of the tragedy of them Blaine
in 1996 she was right at our side when
we felt the greatest Agony we have faced
and it will be I think I expect
King Charles to take the same approach
and to be part of our society and our
country just as the queen was and indeed
we're watching pictures there as we
watch more bowed heads as the Cortez
makes its way along the river D towards
Aberdeen
more quiet contemplative
response to this
site
not the Clapping we saw in the bankery
necessarily but
again many people lining the streets but
yeah
how was this route picked then on the
way was it is it was it an ordered that
most people or many people could see her
majesty as she makes this journey it was
always the intention of the royal
household that as many people as
possible could have the opportunity to
pay the respects to her majesty and the
route that the cottage will will follow
comes through Royal decide so intimately
connected to the royal family through
the city of Aberdeen where there is a a
an opportunity for people to gather it
was the Lord Provost of Aberdeen to pay
their respects to her majesty to then
come down to the city of Dundee and
again the Lord Provost and the City of
Dundee will lead one of our great cities
in its remembrance of her majesty then
throughout this journey there will be
opportunities for people to pay the
respects as the courtesh comes into the
City of Edinburgh the one thing I would
ask people to do is to follow all of the
advice that's around there's going to be
congestion there's going to be lots of
people around I just ask people to to be
patient we want everyone to have an
opportunity to pay the respects but to
be able to do that in a safe Manner and
that's what we've worked hard to make
sure is the case and to make it possible
we want to pay the respects to how much
love monarch you say the queen was by
your side by dunblane they're all family
there too for storm Frank in 2016 you
were talking about the river D but large
parts that were flooded very badly in
the communities very badly hit and
certainly we know the Juve Edinburgh
came out by by sleeper train and came to
look for himself at the at the damage
that had been done and support the
people there there have been many
occasions where members of the royal
family in particular Her Majesty the
queen has made has come to support us in
our time they need the floods in in
balata and decide where you know
colossal in their impact but
particularly no King Charles acted with
solidarity towards the people supported
the recovery as we worked with the
community to enable the recovery of the
community to take place and I think
that's an important part of what the
king will be able to continue to do to
to be at our side in our times of need
and to work with us to make sure that
good and positive things can happen for
our communities
there is so much history involved in all
of this isn't there not least
when her majesty arrives in Edinburgh
and we see the events of tomorrow with
the royal family you've got the
extraordinary role model with all those
historic buildings on them Saint Charles
Cathedral the center of the Reformation
in Scotland as well and all the history
of
The Inheritance the accession after
Elizabeth the First and James VI of
Scotland all of it you can sort of you
have a sense of it here don't you very
much so I thought that also when I
watched the accession council in London
yesterday because right at the heart of
it was the significance of Scotland's
police within the union and the
extraordinary significance that was
attached to that and the Declarations
and commitments that the king made and
in the fact that the Secretary of State
for Scotland the first minister of
Scotland the Lord advocate of Scotland
the Lord president of the CO2 session in
Scotland were signatures to the uh the
the the the to the documents which
essentially facilitate the accession so
that was a vivid reminder of Scotland's
absolutely Central constitutional
position uh within the United Kingdom
but when you come to to Edinburgh right
at the heart of our historic City you
see all of the symbols of Scotland's
identity and our history just in a few
moments time there will be a
proclamation of King Charles at the
market cross
um up just beside St John's Cathedral
before it moves on to the castle
Esplanade and Edinburgh Castle and these
are these are scenes and and centers of
enormous significance in the identity of
Scotland and it's important that this
important moment of transition we are
properly reflected and observed within
the accession and indeed King Charles
having to make an oath specifically
about the independence of the of the
Church of Scotland as part of that
because it was back in the time I think
of Charles the first was it not that he
was trying to impose a different order
in Scotland which was such a central
part of the reformation and so you know
such strong Protestant values uh at that
time well these the the the these are
ancient elements of Scottish society and
but they were clearly remain relevant
because they were so Central to the
accession ceremony yesterday so I think
that's a it's a really important point
to remember just the significance of
those historic elements of the
foundation of the United Kingdom go back
to the agreements that were made at that
time and the fact that in 21st century
Society the king is essentially giving
that solemn affirmation that he will
protect the independence of the Church
of Scotland and many other aspects of
the Constitutional identity of Scotland
post boxes too I suppose e2r you see in
England do you not you don't see them
here because clearly
um this is Elizabeth II was the first
Elizabethan era for Scotland too uh if
you think about what happened uh back
back then but I mean all of it's
absolutely fascinating and what we see
that weaved in do you think the the
ceremonial part of that
um with the Palace of Hollywood house
and also the uh Cathedral at St Giles
where we we start to see the History
built up for that I think in the course
of the next couple of days the the the
the the the the the the layout of of
Edinburgh lends itself to essentially
telling that story how much this Cortes
will be but will process up the the
Johnson Terrace and onto the lawn Market
that's the one market is right at the
top of the royal mile beside them for a
castle and it will travel down the Royal
mile later on this afternoon to holidays
Palace it will pass Scottish Parliament
the first Minister and the leaders of
political parties will be there to pay
their respects with our presiding
officer of the Scottish Parliament later
on this afternoon and then tomorrow the
journey will take place in Reverse where
the Queen's coffin will be conveyed from
Hollywood Palace up to Saint John's
Cathedral for the national service of
Thanksgiving for the life and the
commitment of her majesty so these are
really Central significant parts of our
society and another capital city and of
our country and it's important the heart
of the process of the series of events
that are now taking place
and the Royal mile a Scott smile I was
reminded by a tour guide I spoke to
yesterday who told me it was and you
might correct me
1814 meters long is that right well I I
I I I defer to the two kinds of
Edinburgh who will know these who will
know these these fights but it but it
essentially tells the story
the palace down here are Parliament the
castle at the top of the hill and St
Giles a good way up there and it
essentially captures that Journey that a
the uh that that I'm going to switch so
much is anchored in Scottish society and
a journey that the Queen's coffin will
take today and tomorrow and will you get
to speak to King Charles yourself
tomorrow and if so what is it that you
would like to convey to him King Charles
is is coming to Parliament tomorrow and
members of parliament will be there and
there will be an opportunity to to speak
with King Charles I think all of us
feel I think very much the same just now
we want to express our condolences to
him on the loss of his mother his you
know for any of us who have lost our
mother we know how hard that is and he
also has to assume significant
responsibilities as a consequence and
we'll want to encourage him in what he
does and to give thanks for the
astonishing unchallengeable service
given to the country by by his mother
and going back to Hollywood week this
year when the queen was here end of June
um what were the sorts of occasions that
she you know the the events that she
went to what was what did she most enjoy
doing while she was here normally on a
normal coverage week the queen would
have a combination of events at holiday
Palace where she would for example have
an audience provide an audience for the
first Minister she would also have a
large garden party she would also travel
around the country so she would go to
various parts of the country whether
it's the islands of Scotland or other
parts of the Mainland to visit different
events and organizations this year it
was slightly slimmed down the queen
stayed at Hollywood she undertook a
number of events more than we perhaps
envisaged that she would take part in
but she did them with energy she looked
great she looked in great form and very
strong and she actually did more than
most people thought she was going to do
and made a fantastic contribution as
ever and we're grateful for all that she
contributed to Scottish Society over
there very many years as well John
Swinney Deputy first Minister thank you
so much for talking to us thank you
well we can speak now to Andrew Bowie
the Scottish conservative MP whose
constituency includes the Balmoral
estate thank you for joining us and I
understand you watched the Cortez pass
at ballater how was that
hi Anna yeah it was a huge privilege it
is a huge privilege to represent
Balmoral and be one of the Queen's
members of parliament uh representing
the estate and all the people that work
on that estate including her majesty uh
but to be present this morning when the
Cortez passed through ballots are
alongside the three Lord lieutenants for
this part of the world was a huge
privilege and an honor and it was quite
something to feel the the sense of uh
solemn quiet reflection as the Cortez
passed through this Village that the
queen herself and the entire Royal
Family knew very well you know stories
of the queen popping into baluster being
spotted in The Butchers or in the queue
the news agents um you know our Legend
there isn't a person who lives in
volatile that hasn't come across the
queen or another member of the royal
family so it really meant a lot for the
people of biology to be able to pay
their respects to her majesty as she
passed through this morning and indeed
traveling down the East Side a part of
the world that knew her well and that
knew her uh so well uh so apt that she
made her final Journey from here today
we saw a Applause and tears in bankery
in ballater it seemed
contemplative to to feel like a personal
loss do you think to those people who
live so close to the Balmoral estate
yeah very much so I mean the queen was a
part of uh life here in balater and
upper east side for over eight decades
you know it was here George V was on the
throne when she first was a football
model the gates on the gate at the
Balmoral estate were erected in his
honor and Queen Mary's honor and it's
quite something to think that they were
put up as the queen visited for the very
first time she is so well known so well
loved in this part of the world I heard
Alistair Bruce earlier talk about you
know her connection her Affinity uh to
the countryside to the land to the
people of this this incredibly beautiful
part of the world
um who had a very unique relationship
with her majesty and do with the royal
family and indeed continue to have with
his majesty King Charles III who spends
a large portion of his of his year here
at Burke Hall in the bar model estate
very quietly arriving without any
Fanfare and and um and that's actually
why I think people up here
um felt so uh kindly and felt so much
love and respect for the royal family
and for her majesty Queen in particular
because she saw very much the place
where she could get away from the rigors
of government in London Balmoral was a
or is a royal residence uh unlike any of
the others it's a private home
and not like Buckingham Palace or
Windsor uh where they are able to spend
time to relax and enjoy the the
Fantastic Countryside we have here and
and be welcomed as a part of the
community by by the people of this part
of the world um and so she will be
greatly missed
well we know that the Princess Royal and
her husband Admirals Tim Lawrence are in
this Cortez as it makes its way towards
the coast and Aberdeen we've just had
confirmation that the the Duke of York
the Earl Encounters of Wessex and Lady
Louise have left Balmoral to head to
Edinburgh as have Beatrice Eugenie and
Zara so the royal family are beginning
to make their way to the Scottish
capital for a series of events which
will culminate in A procession from the
Palace of Hollywood house up to Saint
Charles Cathedral where members of the
public will be able to pay their
respects to her to her majesty in a
church setting and this this will be
also extremely poignant don't you think
yes extremely poignant and very poignant
that she's being escort on this journey
by the minister of crafty Kirk uh quite
apt that she is lying and rest in Saint
Charles Cathedral of high crook uh of
Scotland in Edinburgh
um because as well as being the titular
head of the Church of England so it
might just be uh was a member of the
Church of Scotland and we saw in those
historic scenes yesterday uh his majesty
King Charles III uh like his mother
before him pledging to defend the
independence of the Church of Scotland
and and that was very much uh Central to
her life when she came to Scotland
regularly attending church at crassie
when she was in Edinburgh regularly
attending church uh there and so I think
to have final respects paid to her in
Scotland uh in one of our great churches
in Edinburgh I think is uh very fitting
and I think would be very much what she
she would have wanted
she will lie and rest in Saint Charles
Cathedral here in Edinburgh but all of
these cities that she'll pass through
today you know beginning in Aberdeen
these are places you will have visited
often and you know many people will also
feel that that she was part of their
Community there too
oh absolutely I mean Aberdeen is a city
that has long uh enjoyed a close
relationship to her majesty the queen uh
great stories of her visiting in her
early rain uh hotels in Aberdeen for
afternoon tea escaping away from the the
the the the the Press through
underground tunnels into Union Terrace
Gardens uh so there are there are great
stories about circonnection uh to the
cities across uh Scotland Dundee of
course a city she knows well uh let's
not forget that her first prime minister
Winston Churchill was a member of
parliament for Dundee uh uh back uh in
his early parliamentary career so the
connections to her across Scotland are
great and of course on her way South
through Angus on the way it's done being
further to Edinburgh she will pass uh
glams which of course was the childhood
home of her mother the Queen Mother and
so all every step along the way you will
see uh connections to to her family
which is very much carried on uh with
Charles who as I said is a great
Affinity uh to this part of the world we
saw that here in the constituency in
West Africa just a couple of weeks ago
when her majesty two frail to attend the
Vermont Gathering was represented by uh
then Prince Charles uh Who and the
Princess Royal who thoroughly enjoyed uh
and you know do thoroughly enjoy their
time here relaxing enjoying uh the
unique traditions and atmosphere that we
have and that I'm privileged to
represent in the House of Commons
foreign
and is it your hope that the royal
family will still choose to come to
Balmoral for part of their summer
holidays obviously King Charles has
Burke Hall uh nearby does he not
inherited I believe from Queen Elizabeth
the queen mother I'm much loved by him
so he will be coming back to there but
what about the Balmoral Castle itself
what do you think will happen to that
well of course that's um that's very
much her decision to be taken in the
future by by the now King yes Charles
has broke calls he's had that for quite
some time now he's made it very much a a
home for himself and and our Queen
concert Camilla uh it's where he comes
it's about a large proportion of the
year as I said the rides are that much
fun for you sometimes uh not even
noticed by the local community that he's
in Residence and so the connection to
the royal family from this part of the
world will indeed continue about model
itself first became a royal castle back
when it was purchased by uh Prince
Albert in Queen Victoria so we have a
long Association in connection with
royal family and I'm sure that will
endure and continue uh with King Charles
and and hopefully uh with uh with
William and his family uh when they grow
up as well
I mean it draws so many tourists it must
boost the economy and enormously the
association uh with the Royals and the
first Minister I don't know if you heard
of Deputy first Minister rather John
Swinney telling me that the the Heather
was resplendent this year presumably
because of the the climate conditions
we've seen that the queen would have
looked out at Banks and banks of purple
hillsides around her and it would have
been quite beautiful
it is I mean I'm standing here in the
middle of Balto now and surrounded by uh
beautiful hillsides you know resplendent
purple heather and this year it has been
uh extraordinary presumably well
definitely because of the quite
remarkable uh weather that we've had
this summer and it's quite nice to think
and I hope for some comfort to people to
think that some of the last views the
queen would have looked out on in these
last weeks and days would have been uh
the beautiful hillsides of this part of
the world part of the world that she's
as I said uh has known all of her life
and has evidently loved being able to
spend so much time famous barbecues by
the river D with uh Prince Philip uh
treks hikes yomps across the mirrors uh
up into the hills
um you know it's a part of the world
that just she has such a connection and
will miss her uh so keenly
um but yes the hills looking resplendent
this summer and today the the weather
having been incredibly uh grief would be
the Scott's word to describe it uh in
the latter part of the week and you
almost felt the weather was reflecting
the mood of the nation today the sun has
come out and Shone on Royal decided
she's passed through and that's uh
something I think that we can all be
very thankful for and um uh hopefully
yeah paying a fitting tribute to hers
she departs this this part of the world
to the very last time
and the wreath of flowers uh picked from
flowers in the in the garden of Balmoral
said to be the Queen's favorite but any
personal Reflections from you of of
meeting her majesty and the experiences
that you shared with her
yeah I mean being her MP we uh you
frequently find yourself at a functions
and events with the senior members of
the royal family including the queen uh
most recently the last time I was in her
presence was at the bramore Gathering uh
three years ago actually before the
corvid pandemic
um the thing about Balmoral is it's very
much a private home uh when they go
behind the Gates they very much see
themselves as retiring as getting a time
away from public life so there are not
so many public functions that there are
in other oil residences but uh you know
my first recollection of I think the
queen was on a school geography field
trip up around the hills here in bar so
you know growing up in aberdeenshire and
nearly every school kid has a story of
uh being almost run over by uh by a very
fast moving green Land Rover in the
Hills above Balmoral not very much is my
story as well uh having to dive out of
the way as a Land Rover came zooming
past and all of us uh gotting as we saw
the queen in a head scarf at the wheel
and followed very quickly by another
Land Rover uh which we thought uh was
being driven by her qualification and
you know it's it's experiences like that
that people around here just saw the
queen as a as another member of the
community as a as a yes of course always
treated with the difference in respect
that she deserved as as the queen but
you know everybody around here has a
story like that and it's um it's very
very sad to think that there will be no
more opportunities uh to see her majesty
but uh an incredible privilege to be
able to say goodbye to her uh from from
Royal decide this morning
and just turning our attention to what
will take place in the next 20 minutes
or so after the accession council that
we witnessed at St James's Palace
yesterday and the proclamations continue
in the Realms do they not and not least
here in the center of Edinburgh
yes of course the center of Edinburgh
the American cross will be the
proclamation of King Charles the Third
succession but actually in Balter uh at
12 35 there will be a proclamation of
King Charles III succession as here uh
outside uh glenwick uh Parish Church
which is where we all gathered this
morning as the Cortez went past
um because uh yes he's becoming King
Charles Iber he's also becoming layered
of the Balmoral Estates as well and so
we uh observe that here when 12 35 or
Saturday
in Edinburgh
thank you
I'm just beginning to lose you slightly
but uh Andrew Bowie Scottish
conservative MP for West aberdeenshire
and Kincardine which includes Balmoral
thank you very much Cindy for sharing
your reflections of the queen and the
experience that you had today stood
there in balita as the Queen's Cortez
past thank you very much indeed thank
you
and Alistair we still see those crowds
coming out in these Villages and towns
that follow the river D on its way to
one of those major cities Aberdeen that
the queen would have known so well
he
it's been very mournful and very
reflective but my goodness Scotland is
looking beautiful today as the queen
makes her final journey through these
roads on her way to Edinburgh
it's as though after the
gloomy weather that the queen mentioned
to the photographer who was waiting
to take the picture of the new prime
minister being received and invited to
form a government
recalled how the queen said gosh look at
the weather outside and it was gathering
terrible terrible clouds at that time
and those who were at Balmoral to cover
the
really significant moment of the queen
inviting her 15th prime minister to form
a government
you know within two days Her Majesty was
dead but
in this her last journey through
aberdeenshire
the sun is as warm as the hearts of
those that
Express their grief for the queen today
on the outskirts of
Aberdeen now
across bridges that members of her
family have opened in the development
of this part of Scotland
salutes from those who watch
from roads
and have just taken time to
to see the woman who has been the head
of state of the United Kingdom now for
over 70 years pass by
Scotland always puts on the most
beautiful appearance in the Glorious
sunshine
and the glinting River deed that has
been a compliment for the Queen's
Journey
winding its way onto the sea
when still in commission the Royal York
Britannia used to bring the queen at the
end of her summer round of
responsibilities from Portsmouth
on a journey around the United Kingdom
past Cornwall
at the Irish
see
and around into the locks of Scotland
and she would stop at any number of
places and go for a walk
and there's one wonderful story about
when she was out on one of those walks
and the yacht was
obviously docked down in the lock below
and a lady came over the hill
and said to the queen Oh I thought it
was you
and she said oh well I'm sorry if I've
come at a bad time and she's having a
chat in the directness that the Scots
always have
and then over the hill behind came
This Woman's husband who shouted
leave that woman alone she's on her
holidays
the queen insisted on
having a chat with them both in her head
scarf and her blue surge tries as she
walked up the same Hill that this happy
Scots couple were enjoying and it was a
wonderful
meeting between the Monarch and the
people of Scotland who as I have always
said have a much more direct
relationship
with kingship which is because of the
very nature of kingship in Scotland
the Monarch was the chief of chiefs the
sort of
head of the family of Scotland
and the title itself was never monarch
of Scotland but
of Scots
and Robert the Bruce king of Scots Mary
Queen of Scots
and that relationship between the chief
or monarch and her people reflected by
those who have come out
to see the Queen of Scots finally pass
by
Queens headed past Peter cooter and
heading on down towards Stonehaven
circling around
the edge of Aberdeen
and the very rich fields that were
harvested not all that long ago
in this
warm sunshine
another story I love of the queen when
she was on the Balmoral estate
driving back from
a visit she'd made
told to me by one of
protection officers
that
the
almost
all over Scotland there are groups of
four youngsters doing the Duke of
Edinburgh award scheme
and she came across a group of
youngsters doing
the scheme that after all was named and
organized by her husband
and she stopped the car and they were so
surprised and she started talking to
them about what they were doing and they
didn't know whether to talk to her or
take a photograph but they talked to her
and then they rushed and scrabbled for
their photographs
to be taken as the queen left and the
Protection Officer said to the queen
I feel sorry for them and the queen said
oh why and the Protection Officer said
well because nobody will ever believe
them
throughout Scotland the queen has
enjoyed
good and direct
conversations with a number of Scots
and it's why she just loved being here
and she learned
so much about Scotland from her mother
and shortly the court age will pass
close by
glom's Castle
where her sister Princess Margaret Rose
was born
and where her grandparents lived
and another of the locations that is a
child before
the reality of the burden of coming
sovereignty was to
present itself she had many wonderful
holidays with her
cousins and her family and throughout
the Queen's Reign she's kept very close
to her Bose lion relations
many of them living in very much the
area she's passing through now
and down past fourfa
and on to Dundee
and through Persia
as this procession began from the main
door of Balmoral Castle
a royal salute was given to the queen
by the royal guard at palata
formed by balaclava company
of the royal Regiment of Scotland and
the Queen
was their colonel in Chief
she was also colonelin chief of the
Scots guards
and colonel in Chief
of the other
great Scottish regiment the Royal Scots
Dragoon guards who evolved out of the
Scots grays
and as Colin chief of all three of
Scotland's primary
regiments
she has taken enormous interest
in their life and work and it is from
families
who are lining these streets that the
soldiers came to serve in those
regiments or to
serve in the Royal Navy
the Royal Air Force the Royal Marines
or other regiments and cause in the army
and that link between the queen and the
Armed Forces we will see played out
throughout
the splendor
of the funerary events that will take
place
and the lyings in state
that are presented for
the United Kingdom to say their final
salute
but the queen was always aware
that it was the people who line the road
now that she
was there to serve
sovereignty was not about her but it was
about serving as we watch her now leave
and make her way
through these streets
and shortly in Edinburgh
the proclamation will take place of King
Charles III
first of all at the market cross
and then at the gates of Edinburgh
Castle
meanwhile in Belfast
and also in Cardiff
Kings of arms and Heralds will read out
that Elizabeth II
has died and
we have a new king
well a helicopter has just arrived in
the grounds of the Palace of Hollywood
house here uh in Edinburgh carrying we
believe the Duke of York the Earl and
Countess of Wessex and Lady Louise who
have traveled from Balmoral just a short
time ago our understanding is that
Beatrice Eugenie and Zara are also
traveling but separately making their
way here to Edinburgh the focus from
this afternoon of the events surrounding
the death of her majesty Queen Elizabeth
II as we see the coast there
and Aberdeen in all its Glory
Aberdeen the third largest city in
Scotland a population of about 200 000
people and nicknamed the Granite City or
the Silver City from the granite which
comes locally quarried used to build
many of Aberdeen's most famous buildings
and also shipped all around the UK and
Europe for use in construction and
Monument work including in London's
Houses of Parliament Trafalgar Square
Waterloo Bridge and the Thames
embankment famous of course for the oil
the industry and the North Sea off the
coast there once the oil capital of
Europe its Prosperity really grown on
this enlargement of the city over the
years because of the development of
North Sea oil and gas and clearly the
focus only this week of Liz Tross and
her plans when she outlined her energy
plan for the future
uh which seems already so long ago does
it not and that was only
on Thursday
there are in fact more than 30 places
in the world called Aberdeen
in the United States of America
Australia New Zealand and even Hong Kong
and it's home to a record number of
whiskey distilleries too and certainly a
place that the queen would oft visit on
many at Royal occasions she would be
there to the coast
again a beautiful part of Scotland
incredible spot for spotting Dolphins
basking sharks
Bottlenose white beak Dolphins too
and this beautiful countryside before
the cottage will turn South and head
through Angus to Dundee and onto Perth
and then
across the Queensbury Crossing into
Edinburgh
where she will be welcomed
at Hollywood Palace
where she will lie and rest in order for
the household staff
to bid their own farewell
a helicopter here taking off once again
it appears from the grounds of the
palace which is the official
home of the royal family in Scotland it
was here where the queen came towards
the end of June for what they called
Holly rude week where she would have so
many visits including tears we heard
from the deputy first minister
the Scottish Parliament too which is
where King Charles will head tomorrow
after A procession of the Cortez
from the palace here up the Royal Mall
to Saint Charles Cathedral
where the queen will lie and rest
there'll be a vigil with royal family
members but also it will be open to
members of the public who will be able
to pay their own respects
to her majesty
and then on Tuesday the body will be
flown back to London
for the days of rest there
this is a journey of some six hours
a hundred miles
occasionally going at walking pace so
people can pay their respects and
certainly in bankery along the river D
we saw Tears For Her Majesty and we saw
Applause too as people say thank you for
this life well lived
as King Charles said in his National
address Queen Elizabeth was a life well
lived a promise with Destiny kept and
she has mourned most deeply in her
passing
crown of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland
is solely and rightfully covered then
and the proclamation
Arthur George
we therefore
the Lord's spiritual and temporal of
this realm
and members of the House of Commons
together with other members of her late
Majesty's privy Council
and representatives of the Realms and
territories
aldermen and cities citizens of London
and others
do you know hereby with one voice
and consent of tongue and heart
publish
and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George
is now
by the death of our late Sovereign happy
of memory
become our only lawful and rightful
leads Lord Charles III
by the grace of God
of the United Kingdom of Great Britain
and Northern Ireland
and of his other Realms and territories
King
head of the Commonwealth defender of the
faith
to whom we do acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection
beseeching God by whom kings and queens
do Reign to bless His Majesty
with long and happy years to Reign Over
Us
given at Saint James's Palace
on the 10th day of September
and in the yield of Our Lord 2022
the Lord Lion King of Arms from the
merkut cross giving the proclamation to
Scotland as the state trumpeters reply
with a Fanfare after which he will shout
God saved the king and the Royal salute
of 21 guns will be fired from Edinburgh
Castle
princess
God Save the King
[Music]
[Applause]
morning
[Music]
foreign
bodyguard for Scotland the Royal company
of archers and the Royal Regiment of
Scotland forming the guard
will prepare to remove headdress
[Music]
in order to give three cheers to the new
king
[Applause]
foreign
and then the Lord line will be taken in
procession up the Royal mile
to
the castle to again proclaim the new
king the second position of it all is
the state trumpeters first followed by
the Heralds of the court of the Lord
lion and Lord lion himself who is
wearing the cocked hat and just gave the
Proclamation is also walking with the
Lord Provost of Edinburgh who is the
senior citizen and only took appointment
earlier this year
and we can see beside this Market Cross
the great Hyde Kirk of Saint Giles where
tomorrow
the late Queen will be brought to a
service of Thanksgiving for her life
and she will lie in state here for 24
hours
in order to give those who wish in
Scotland the chance to come pay their
respects to the Queen of Scots
Elizabeth II
who
will be for 24 hours
placed upon a catafalk at the center of
the cathedral
let's take you to the streets of
Aberdeen where the Cortez is about to
arrive where the crowds have been
gathering with the Union flag waiting
patiently
it's been on the move for two hours the
quotation now accompanied by the
Princess Royal and her husband
[Music]
as before the outriders first and the
cameras Aloft as people await the Cortez
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
well once again the crowds are quiet as
they watch the Cortez pass
Babes in Arms many parents bringing
their children so they can bear witness
to this historic moment
the Cortez will pass the King George VI
bridge over the river D in Aberdeen the
foundation stone of that bridge laid by
the Lord Provost back in September 1938
and officially opened by Queen Elizabeth
the queen mother in the presence of her
husband King George VI on
the 10th of December 1941 and today the
bridge carrying the Great Southern Road
into Aberdeen from the south and it is
now that the Cortez will begin to head
south towards Stonehaven and then
through Angus Dundee to Perth and then
South on through across the Queen's free
Crossing which has broken so many
records heading as it will towards
Edinburgh where now we know that members
of the royal family have already arrived
to take part in some of the
commemorations and events which are
scheduled today tomorrow and on Tuesday
all right
by Wales Herald of arms Thomas Lloyd
in the presence also in English of it
being written
and read by
his Majesty's
Lord Lieutenant Forsyth Glamorgan as the
guns are fired
thank you
Cardiff Castle
dominating the scene
21 rounds being fired by 104 104th
regiment Royal artillery
on conclusion of the gun salute the
officer commanding
the proclamation god of the lord of the
guards to remove headdress and
the Lord of talent
and whales held in both English and
Welsh will call for three cheers for his
majesty the king
first in Welsh and then in English the
guard will respond the Herald's
declaration in the traditional manner
three
gun salute concluded
they will now get into position for
foreign
[Music]
Third Battalion the Royal Welsh
preparing to give
their salute
to the king who was Prince of Wales
longer than any other
three chairs for his majesty the king
hip hip
[Applause]
and that concludes the proclamation in
Wales the principal Proclamation also in
Scotland done although a second will
take place at Edinburgh Castle as the
Third Battalion recover their arms
splenade of Edinburgh Castle where
[Music]
the dissembling of the stands that were
here for the Royal Edinburgh military
tattoo during August
and
there the
[Music]
drawbridge gate of the castle
and the escort of the royal company of
archers the king's bodyguard for
Scotland state trumpeters
and the Royal Regiment of Scotland
bringing Lord Lion and the Heralds of
the court of Lord lion
to the main gate of the castle in order
for the second of the proclamations
here in Edinburgh it's this one that is
supposed to be for the people of
Edinburgh
[Music]
sadly as governor of Edinburgh Castle I
was unable to be present but
I'm represented today by
General Bill Wright the general officer
Scotland who waits to receive Lord LAN
along with Lieutenant Colonel Thorne
Campbell
The Garrison Commander
thank you
the Woodland welcomed by the general
office of Scotland he will now read out
the proclamation for the second time
[Applause]
foreign
the Lord line is waiting for all those
in the guard to be in position
and for the king's bodyguard of the
royal company of archers
to also be in the correct location
as members of the public are brought in
to
the area of the Esplanade for the
proclamation to be made
behind the great Fortress there that
has really stood as a place of
fortification
for a thousand years
it's been in different forms it was
knocked down by King Robert the Bruce
in 1314 and rebuilt in part by his son
but much of what you see today
was completed and adorned during Queen
Victoria's reign
but the queen first came to Edinburgh
Castle quite soon after her coronation
and in Saint Charles High Kirk which we
saw this procession come from earlier on
was where she was presented the honors 3
that's the crown The Sword and the
scepter
of Scots that represent the nation's
identity as a kingdom
they're the oldest crown jewels in the
United Kingdom
made
for Mary Queen of Scots father and in
fact first used the crone
to Crown marry Queen of Scots
in 1543
and it's that crime that would be placed
upon the
coffin of the queen when she lies in
state
lordline is a great officer of Scotland
and
in such capacity represents the monarch
of Scots and wears over his shoulder
a collar or chain which is
comprised of thistles and sprigs of Roux
alternately
the thistles represent the Scots and the
sprigs of Roux depicts
who came together to form
Scotland way back in our history
and of course they wear the Scottish
Royal Standard
which at the moment
in its flag form lies across
Elizabeth II as she's conveyed here to
the City of Edinburgh
[Music]
so the guard had been prepared now
everything's in place for Lord lion to
read the proclamation
always here the sand of the pipes
making their way up from the Royal mile
this is the second most visited tourist
attraction in the United Kingdom
it's been closed recently because all
Royal palaces and fortresses have been
closed
at the point of Court morning beginning
but normally they can have up to 12 000
people here
a day in the summer
as governor of Edinburgh Castle I have
the privilege of being installed here as
the Queen's governor
I took on the appointment in 2019.
and
it was a great privilege to greet the
queen when she came to Scotland down at
Hollywood as her governor
today it's
the general officer Scotland who stands
in on my behalf
say more about the honors 3 the
Crown The Sword and the scepter that are
kept here sword and such were given by
popes to various Scottish monarchs
as symbols of authority and when
Cromwell
was seeking them out in order to destroy
them as symbols of Scotland
they were taken away to donate Castle on
the east coast and hidden there
and they were rescued because
cromwell's troops encircled The Fortress
on the coastline pretty much where the
Queen's procession is now passing on the
coast on its way here to Edinburgh
and they were passed down
from the castle walls to women who were
collecting kelp along the seashore
and the crown was placed underneath the
kelp the sword was broken into placed in
another basket and the scepter was
unscrewed and hidden in a third
and very politely the three women came
up the hill
and passed the soldiers they had every
day
and no one checked the baskets
say the greatest collection of crown
jewels was protected
and kept safe
when I go in and look at the crown of
Scots which we will see because it'll be
placed upon
the coffin tomorrow in Hollywood I like
to think that the circlet
could indeed be what many think as the
circlet placed upon the head of Robert
the Bruce
in 1306 when he was crimed
king of Scots
for him this Fortress was important too
so much so that he needed to
to remove King Edward of England's
soldiers from it and when he'd done so
he had it leveled to the ground
what our camera here can't see is the
number of people being brought up the
Royal mile
[Applause]
a lot of changing arms again getting
ready for the point that Lord lion
speaks it's difficult to know the
precise time because it's important that
members of the public get the chance to
get into
the Esplanade
so the queen was here in Edinburgh
earlier this year during the summer
last
royal visit and it was one where
actually she felt more able to take part
in events
she was received at the entrance of
Hollywood house
with a god of Honor
and she met
the new Lord promised of Edinburgh
she held audience with the first
minister
and also
she received an act of loyalty from the
armed forces in the garden
at the back of Edinburgh Castle
[Music]
meanwhile in Cardiff the
public who watched the first of the
proclamations there are moving away
and we know that
the guns need to be returned
the light guns which will be driven Away
now by
wild artillery who also the Royal
Regiment of artillery had the queen as
their colonelin chief
and this role will be taken on I'm sure
by the king
as they pull away Cardiff Castle has a
wonderful
appearance within the city
and the Armed Forces throughout this
coming week will play their part in
the various events surrounding
[Music]
[Applause]
the death of the queen and the start of
the new reign
soldiers who've completed the firing of
the guns
who will return now to prepare these
guns for
other tasks
the Queen's visits to the
Castle itself have been many really
the first time she came to the castle as
I was saying just after her coronation
in 1953
and the then Lord lion
made the challenge
to all those gathered
the god of honors nice sloping arms
ready for
the second proclamation in Edinburgh
as with him the Heralds and perseverance
of the court of the Lord lion
each holding titles that represent
elements of
the sovereign's identity in Scotland
according to Scott's tradition
meanwhile on the right hand side
we see people passing away from the last
population
[Music]
whereas it just please almighty God
to call to his Mercy
our late Sovereign Lady Queen Elizabeth
II
of blessed and glorious memory
by whose demise
the crown of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland
is solely and rightfully come
to the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George
we therefore the Lord's spiritual and
Temple of this land and Realm
and members of the House of Commons
together with other members of her late
Majesty's privy Council
and representatives of the Realms and
territories
aldermen and citizens of London and
others
do now hereby with one voice
and consent of tongue and heart
publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George
Is Now by The Death of our late
Sovereign of happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege
Lord
Charles III
by the grace of God of the United
Kingdom
of Great Britain and Northern Ireland
and of all other Realms and territories
King
head of the Commonwealth
defender of the faith
to whom we do acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection
beseeching God by whom kings and queens
do reign to bless His Majesty
with long and happy years to Reign Over
Us
given us in James's Palace
on the 10th day of September
and in the year of Our Lord 2022.
[Music]
the state trumpeters give their Fanfare
and a royal salute is given followed by
three cheers it's perhaps worth
looking at the proclamation that took
place in Northern Ireland
12 noon and recap on that
when it was
the chance
for those
[Music]
thank you
and as the proclamation continues in
Edinburgh meanwhile our thoughts go to
the procession making its way from
Balmoral back to
the capital city of Scotland
Edinburgh
well it was just after 10 o'clock this
morning that we saw her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II's coffin leave Balmoral
seeing it for the first time as it made
its way now heading south in
aberdeenshire on through towards
Edinburgh the capital of Scotland where
it will arrive mid-afternoon today for
the beginnings of commemorations and
services here including with members of
the royal family who some of whom have
already arrived and Rihanna We believe
that the helicopter landed a short time
ago carrying the Duke of York and the
Earl Encounters of Wessex and uh and
their daughter and this is part of
the involvement of the royal family in
the events in Edinburgh
we've seen have we the proclamations
again being carried out across the
United Kingdom but I think in the last
48 hours we have constantly made clear
that this is a family in mourning and a
family who want to continue to to
support their mother their grandmother
as she makes that that final Journey
from Balmoral stopping here in Edinburgh
and then we'll make that that long trip
down to London ahead of the the state
funeral and it is difficult for the
family I understand that they they
didn't see this coming when it did and
and you could see that in the fact that
there was this Rush wasn't it to
Balmoral to be to be with her in those
those final moments but I think as we we
look at the
the coffin being driven in the hearse
away from Balmoral for me that this is a
journey that really represents how the
queen split her life
and there was something particularly
touching about the fact that she was she
was there at Balmoral
um
a place where she enjoyed so much time
with her family and yet she is now
heading here towards Edinburgh and the
huge crowds that will gather then down
to London and finally we'll be at
Buckingham Palace where all the official
work was carried out and also where only
a couple of months ago we saw her on the
balcony surrounded by her family for the
Platinum Jubilee I think for many people
it is still really hard to take in that
it's happened the sight of the coffin
for the first time like when we lose any
loved one I think
cements in people's minds that this this
has happened and that we're having to
adjust
to having a new king to saying farewell
to a much-loved monarch but also her
family are as well it is often the first
sight of a coffin where you feel that
pain of loss most acutely and I think
many people watching will have felt that
but as King Charles said his mother's
was a life well lived of a destiny
that she pursued and what a life she had
96 years old the longest serving Monarch
this country has ever seen she will go
down in history and in the memories of
so many of her subjects and it's
interesting you should mention those
different records that she achieved
throughout her Reign including becoming
Britain's longest rainy Monarch and
actually that happened on the 9th of
September and it was a moment that she
marked here in 2015 it was a moment that
I remember traveling up to Scotland for
and then for her it was so important she
got on the train she traveled around to
share that moment with the public and
and again her family are picking up that
mantle and yesterday it was made very
clear in the briefing where we were
given more details about what's going to
happen in the next few days or so that
yes for King Charles III
State business continues he's
automatically taken on the mantle of
being head of state and everything that
comes with that but for him his priority
is now to lead the country and his
family in mourning and and to share a
grief that he feels very deeply and it
was always going to be fascinating to
see how throughout this period we saw
the shift between the official and the
proclamations the accession council
yesterday
and the family moments and actually I
think yesterday there is no doubt that
really the most striking and poignant
images were the ones that involved the
family for example Zara and Eugenie in
tears looking at the flowers that have
been left
and then again we saw King Charles
wanting to get out and meet as many
people as possible and then of course
that moment that I think everyone was
taken by surprise by where we saw that
Prince William had in a way sent that
Olive Branch to Prince Harry and said
look
let's do this together and you had the
Fab for
as they were described when Harry and
Megan got married back together and and
also for them I think putting to bed
those questions about whether the Sussex
is a welcome or not there's gonna be so
many public moments where all the family
are likely to be involved in some way
questions about how of the difficulties
that sussexes might be involved But
ultimately every member of that family
wants this now to be about one woman
and however they describe her
granny mama
and of course for us
the queen
um and and I think they are they are
hugely aware that this is a moment of
shock of mourning and they want to share
it with the public
I have the quote of the queen uh on
September the 9th 2015 you said you were
there on becoming Britain's longest
reigning monarch during a speech whilst
opening a railway at the Scottish
borders you remember and she said many
have kindly noted another significance
attached to today although it is not one
to which I have ever aspired inevitably
a long life can pass many Milestones my
own is no exception so with the with a
humble put down effectively to this to
this extraordinary historic day and then
also at the cop climate Summit in
Glasgow addressing world leaders there
acknowledging her own mortality and and
saying to all of them none of us will
live forever which we remember as well
which began an acknowledgment of her age
and her husband had already passed he
had retired before that too so there was
there was a sense
of you know these these roles they live
a long time if you think about the Queen
Mother 101 yeah you know Duke of
Edinburgh just short of a hundred and
yet there was an acknowledgment there
that uh she would not be here forever
and then monarchy must continue and ever
so modest as ever when it came to to
those those speeches there was another
wonderful one on on her birthday
um her 90th birthday where she she sort
of talked about how she she was hoping
that people would stop reminding her
that it was it was such a big birthday
um but yeah the the
the fact that she always wanted to share
those big milestones
with people but also I think
increasingly over the last
12 months of course
we were becoming increasingly aware of
her age and and it might sound
ridiculous but I think we were so used
to her being so well
in her 90s and and people in a way were
shocked when I said to them well she's
96 years old because we've been so used
to her walking unaided not having a
walking stick and simply getting on with
that annual calendar a very busy
engagements and constitutional duties
and yet in the last 12 months
that gradually was a slowing down and
and actually what what was lovely was
earlier in the summer actually she
probably had one of her busiest weeks
here in Scotland for Hollywood week
every summer she would come here spend
the week here and we saw her
still carrying out that ceremony of the
keys which we will see
um the new King Charles
um take part in where the ceremony
ceremonial key is passed over to the
arriving monarch that moment had to be
changed this time because she wasn't
able to inspect the guard but she still
did it and actually as the week went on
there were various occasions where we're
told actually her majesty does want to
attend this Her Majesty does want to be
alongside her Air at the Time Prince
Charles and she was always beaming from
ear to ear I remember there was an event
where she was at Edinburgh Castle
and she was there surrounded by by the
military
um who she hugely loved and respected
and realized that her being there meant
a great deal but not in a showy sense
not because it was about her but because
she knew that that was what her life was
about and and she knew that it was about
bringing that sense of joy and being
seen being seen to be believed was was
what her Mantra always was
Leanna Mills for the moment thank you
very much indeed they're our Royal
correspondent but let's take you to
Balmoral and Greg marlam who witnessed
that first moment when we saw the coffin
and the cottage Greg
yes and we're starting actually now to
see the first members of the public who
have come I think 5 000 was the the
official figure yesterday five thousand
people have come and uh paid tributes
laid flowers left messages and um that
that was paused this morning for that
moment of uh the coffin carrying the
queen uh to leave here in Balmoral 10
o'clock uh the the uh the ceremony if
you like started inside Balmoral Castle
and a poignant moment for a number of
reasons of course poignant for the royal
family and the members of the royal
family who were still here but also for
the estate workers that the staff many
of whom have worked for the Royal
household for many years who were able
to pay their respects to her inside the
ballroom where the coffin sat for a
couple of days
important for them to be able to do that
and then those six gamekeepers the
symbolism of the members of the the
household staff taking part in the
movement of the the coffin uh I think
really important for those who work here
those who who considered the queen one
of their Community uh carrying the
coffin we have a piper playing now as
you can hear with the sovereigns piper
played as that coffin was carried from
the ballroom through the small dining
room and then into the hearse and then
we saw it leave
here from the gate drapes in the Royal
Standard with flowers picked from the
garden here at Balmoral some of the
Queen's favorite flowers in that wreath
Atop The that coffin as it began its its
Journey they talked about quiet dignity
the quiet Dignity of the last few days
here for the royal family the members of
the royal family who remained and have
now left and headed to Edinburgh
themselves but but particularly those
people local to here who either worked
on the estate or would see the queen in
and around ballater who feel this is a
very personal loss as well as the loss
of a monarch
foreign
joining us there from Balmoral thank you
and we continue to watch this Cortez
heading south now towards Edinburgh
where it will rest at the palace of
Hollywood house
before being taken for a vigil by both
through our family and indeed members of
the public who will be able to pay their
respects at Saint Giles Cathedral up the
Royal Mall here in Edinburgh
okay
well let's bring in now Lord Michael
Howard former conservative party leader
member of the privy Council too who
would have taken part in those events at
the accession council yesterday and we
really are witnessing history being made
that so few people in this country will
remember an event like this
that is of course true Anna and it's all
been incredibly moving
um the scenes we're watching now are
very moving
the ceremony yesterday the same a
ceremony which really symbolized I think
the the continuity as well as the
evolution of of our constitutional
Arrangements of the way in which we do
things of the way in which
um we have managed to achieve such
tremendous stability in our country over
such a long time
and of course because they really
believe the pervading I was going to say
to you
our enormous gratitude
to uh someone we remember as our queen
as a as a friend as she put it herself
as the country's servant as the
country's greatest and most faithful
servant
and I was going to say to you do you
really believe that it was um the queen
that you know kept the nation steadfast
all those words we hear described about
her her kindness her calmness but above
all
um this sense that she gave this country
stability and and in a sense how did she
do that what was it that that allowed
that to happen was it the fact the the
Prime Minister has a weekly audience and
her wise counsel and and raised eyebrows
and questions were always there to to
keep things in check if you like
well she was a very great Monarch she
was very good at her job
um she provided leadership inspirational
leadership for our country
um without ever trespassing on the on on
the realm of Party politics without ever
putting a foot wrong it was an
extraordinary achievement
and we are all tremendously in her debt
we are we are all the beneficiaries of
her sense of Duty of her Devotion to
service and of her dedication to the
well-being of her subjects
everyone talks about her kindness how
across her brief she was and how in tune
with people that she put them at their
ease so much and I know you spent a
night did you not with your wife at uh
at Windsor Castle when you were leader
of the opposition how did you find that
well she she was renowned for putting
everyone at their ease and one of the
things I should always remember is the
trouble that had been taken when we went
to the library at Windsor Castle to
um
they'd laid out a home series of objects
relating to my constituency of Folkston
and hide objects which I never knew even
existed
um which I'd certainly never seen before
and it was just just an example of the
extent to which such trouble was taken
to make people feel at ease she was she
was the world's greatest expert at that
and you had a friend as well who'd been
invited to the palace and had sat next
to the queen and in the middle of the
lunch froze what did she do then that
was an extraordinary story because
she she just knew what to do she sent
for the corgis
and I think they were down to feed the
corgis and and that was that was the
answer and he unfroze and was able to
resume the conversation
um but how many people would have known
to do that she was completely remarkable
quite unique
the houses of Parliament as you know um
took two days paying tribute to her
majesty what were the words you chose to
to Mark how you knew her and your
experience of of of this life this the
longest serving uh Queen the longest
serving Monarch that this country has
seen what what did you say about her
when I I recounted the two anecdotes
that I've just told you Anna but I I
ended with something which I always
thought was tremendously significant A
lot's been said about
the extent to which she was admired and
respected and indeed loved far beyond
our Shores and I was once in a Caribbean
country where a new governor general had
been appointed and the local newspaper
published some advice to him an article
giving him some advice
and it said you will have many difficult
decisions to make we suggest that when
you come to make them you ask yourself
one question
what would her majesty do
and I thought that was just tremendous
the king we know later on will me
of the Commonwealth and the high
Commissioners too I mean do you hope
that the Monarch still has a head of
state role in some of these nations or
do you do you do you get a sense that it
will change now
it's up to them and that's what the
royal family have always said and that's
the case it's entirely up to them
um but whatever they decide I don't
think there's any question if they're
leaving the Commonwealth so I think the
Commonwealth will continue I hope to
play a significant role in world affairs
and the role of the new king as head of
the Commonwealth will be very
significant
thank you
well 2.5 billion people there are those
who are Francophile Nations who are
asking to join so it still has great
relevance and and vibrancy to this day
does it not but tell us about the
accession council yesterday we've had
the proclamations two of them here in
Edinburgh uh Cardiff Belfast II uh the
flags were raised this was supposed to
be a moment of Celebration uh one can
presume after one o'clock that the flags
will be returned to half Masters uh in
tribute to her majesty the queen but but
for you what an historic occasion to be
there
indeed a great privilege to be there
um and a ceremony that goes back to
Saxon times more than a thousand years
and really symbolizes the the continuity
and the evolution and the sense of
tradition of our constitutional
Arrangements
um which have given us such stability
which are I think in many respects the
Envy of the world
um and I thought that ceremony yesterday
symbolized that in the most moving and
significant way
what was the atmosphere in the room
no doubt a sense of sadness but did
people feel they were witnessing history
well of course I think everyone was
completely aware of that we were doing
that it was witnessing history we are
living through an enormously historical
moment
which none of us will ever forget
these are difficult times for the royal
family too this is such a personal loss
this grandmother mama obviously for King
Charles we know that some of the royal
family are now here in the Palace of
Hollywood house behind me how will they
do you think be seeking Comfort now we
heard King Charles in his National
address say that my mother's life was a
was a life well lived
well I hope
they will derive some comfort that was
must be a desperately difficult time for
them
from the the outpouring of of Love
um which which has been demonstrated
not only in our own country
um but perhaps especially here the
crowds that have gathered
um in London elsewhere the crowds that
are
um marking
um her funeral procession today
um the the this this should be I hope
something which will be of some comfort
to the family as They Mourn because I I
I'm sure that their morning as our
morning is infused with a deep sense of
gratitude for everything she has done
for us
we've been the beneficiaries of her her
Devotion to service
her sense of Duty in her dedication to
the well-being of her subjects
Lord Howard we really appreciate your
time thank you very much indeed
thank you Douglas Ross joins me now
leader of the conservatives here in
Scotland and
Lord Howard there suggesting that we are
the beneficiaries that everybody coming
out on the streets today is expressing
their gratitude and settling bankery we
saw tears but also Applause as the
Cortez went through what do you make of
what we've seen so far of this journey
just incredible images of a country
wanting to show their respects for the
final time to Monarch Who Loved Scotland
and was loved by Scotland and it has
been so touching just to see the size
the numbers of the crowds I was looking
just before I came on there was a guard
of Honor by tractors as the Cortes
traveled through aberdeenshire at one
point just incredible scenes and
incredible scenes later no doubt here in
Edinburgh as well the Cortez will make
its way down the Royal mile to the
Palace of Hollywood house where we are
now and will people want to come and pay
respects do you think absolutely I was
at the proclamation
um earlier on at 12 o'clock and the
crowds were huge at that point and I
just think many of them will stay for
hours to get a glimpse of the Cortes
traveling to Hollywood house and of
course the St Giles tomorrow for the
service as well what did her majesty
mean to Scotland then well she meant so
much to so many people right across
Scotland and the UK I had an opportunity
very briefly in the House of Commons
this week to pay tribute on behalf of my
constituents in Murray and people across
Scotland and I spoke about her smile
that radiant smile that just seemed to
be every picture of the queen she looked
so happy she was celebrating her life
here in Scotland that final picture
taking it by moral while undoubtedly
frail but that smile and and the the
sparkle in her eye was still there and I
also spoke about her final visit to my
constituency which was back in 2014 with
the late Duke of Edinburgh and it was
their 67th wedding anniversary but still
they put their duty to the public above
their own private celebrations and it
was a fantastic occasion that people in
Murray still speak about
everyone tells about Prince Philip his
comments have just get on with it you
know that sense of you know this The
Show Must Go On And clearly the queen
had mobility issues when she came here
for for Hollywood week but the number of
engagements she has and you know
continue to to take a full part in in
all of the events here as well yeah and
the mobility issues clearly got worse in
in recent months but it was less than a
year ago that she came to officially
open the new session of the Scottish
Parliament where she walked and eat it
and gave an amazing speech to the new
and attorney members of the Scottish
Parliament and indeed it's one of the
pictures I've got with the queen when I
was introduced to her as a party leader
and I show it to my one-year-old and
three-year-old and I'm just so proud to
have got the opportunity I've met the
queen and that story is told many times
over by many people who have had that
great opportunity to have had a small
moment of time with her majesty the
queen and King Charles will make his way
from London to Edinburgh tomorrow he'll
be met by the first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon and then come here to the
Palace where they have the the ceremony
of the keys as well which is something
the Queen is obviously always always
done with the keys of the city are given
over to the Monarch
um when will you get a chance to to say
hello to him but also to pay your
respects to the loss of his mother yes
well tomorrow all the party leaders will
meet his majesty the king and the queen
consort and they will then come into the
debating chamber behind us tomorrow
evening after the service it's in Giles
and each party leader has a small amount
of time to pay our tributes to the late
Her Majesty the queen but also to
provide our full support to the new king
and for me you know I've spoken in many
debates for many years a bit to do it in
front of the new king will be an
air-wracking experience but one I know
the Scottish Parliament will rise to in
the same way the House of Commons and
the House of Lords has done this week do
you know what you want to say well I've
been asked for a copy of my speech and I
thought well I haven't quite finished it
yet so hopefully I get a little bit of
time this afternoon to finish some
remarks pass it into to the palace and
the presiding officer and I hope as I
say the tributes we can give here at
Hollywood can Echo many of the tributes
we've seen across the world
the death of the queen in Scotland has
added many layers of in a sense you know
tradition and spectacle and
commemoration here and has really put
Edinburgh very Central to that has it
not well it's it's Edinburgh Central but
I think we have to remember
aberdeenshire as well where the queen
started our final Journey today a part
of Scotland she loved and adored and I
know you had my colleague Andrew Bowie
on earlier on who spoke very well about
the connection to our model to
aberdeenshire that the communities there
have with the lead her majesty the queen
and I think that just shows us the
Cortes makes its way down Scotland down
through Scotland today we will see that
replicated at every opportunity people
have to to express their their
sympathies and to show themselves their
affection for the late Queen and do you
hope that that relationship with
Scotland stays strong obviously King
Charles has Burke Hall does he not in
aberdeenshire still and still enjoys the
the beautiful countryside absolutely
stunning Countryside you can see why you
know the queen enjoyed the tranquility
and the wildness of that part of the
world but do you hope that relationship
continues well I hope and I expect it to
because the king is a very regular
visitor to Scotland he's Patron and
husband people into many Charities here
north of the Border he also loves as
you've said The Great Outdoors again in
my own area he's a fairly regular
fisherman on the speed he loves that a
part of Scotland as well and I expect to
see the king back and what we saw from
his his own remarks and indeed from the
accession council yesterday just how
important are all Scotland and the
Church of Scotland has in the accession
of the new king well indeed and having
to guarantee the independence of the of
the Church of Scotland I mean the
fascinating history that comes with all
of this is remarkable not least
Scotland's role in the monarchy in fact
absolutely and you know it is an
important role and I think we've seen
from the crowds already Gathering behind
us here at holyrood hours before the
Cortez will get here and it'll be the
same tomorrow it's just that support
that there is across Scotland for the
new king the royal family and of course
to join in The Grieving across the
country for the late Her Majesty the
queen
heading on to places like Dundee famous
for its fruit jams and indeed marmalade
which brings everyone to Paddington
doesn't matter it's an amazing video
home of marmalade and then on the
queensfree crossing which is broken
records with extraordinary concrete
pores that itself will be quite a sight
don't you think is the Cottage Place it
will and of course there's three Bridges
there there's the old fourth Road Bridge
there's the rail bridge and it's an
iconic image that people look across at
Scotland and to see the Cortes going
over there will be very moving for many
many people Douglas Ross appreciate your
time thank you very much indeed and from
the Queensbury Crossing obviously on
here to Edinburgh events from here later
on but let's go back now to Alastair
Bruce
it's been a very slow and dignified
Journey from Balmoral
and as we watched The Hills fall away
and the Flatlands of the East Coast take
over so the roads have become broader
and
the number of villages that have been
gone through have been reduced
and now leaving
the larger roads and heading off
ultimately to get to Edinburgh this
afternoon
the moving start of this
procession at Balmoral when
very close
members of the Queen's private household
who nursed her and her final hours
doctors
and those who have been at her side were
present
to take leave as the hearse left the
castle
members of the royal family will have
watched as
Princess Anne
Princess Royal went with her husband
Admiral Sir Tim Lawrence out of those
distant aberdeenshire Hills and to where
we now see the cottage making its way
gently along the coast
but it is in those Hills where the
memories of the queen at her most
relaxed
taking time off her role as head of
state every August
being with her family and
in the Haven that she loved so much
ultimately
losing her life meanwhile back at Lauren
at
Central London
his majesty the king coming down the
mall and making his way
towards
Buckingham Palace
still large crowds waiting there to
witness every
moment of this sad time
and flags will have been returned in the
last four minutes to half-mast across
the United Kingdom one hour after the
final National
Proclamation
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
the king heading in through the garden
gate to the private entrance at the side
of the palace and later on he will be
receiving
the Secretary General of the
Commonwealth
baroness Scotland he has a number of
engagements today he will have been
receiving people
at Clarence house from his
own household earlier on this morning
but this afternoon he has a number of
engagements particularly meeting
representatives of the realms
and
having his chance to further
received the compliments of those
different nations through their
representatives here in the United
Kingdom
as his Reign begins
the area around Buckingham Palace has
become a great pilgrimage point for a
number of people who've come to just be
a part of this story families bringing
their children perhaps some of them no
idea what it is that they're witnessing
but
with the King now inside The Gardens of
Buckingham Palace he will go into the
rooms where the queen
lived and which he would have known as a
boy and from there he would go to where
he will be receiving probably
overlooking the gardens and the 1844
room that's where I was going to first
hold his initial
audience and then with all the
representatives of the realms
in the boat room literally at the back
of the palace
and the police are regulating the
enormous number of people who've come
here
with Crossings along the mall according
to the way they traditionally cried
manage and I'm sure plans are being made
for
dealing with however many people wish to
come and witness what is going to be
quite a short ceremonial route
initially for
the Queen's body when it has arrived
here at the palace from
Scotland to then be taken from
Buckingham Palace to
Westminster Hall beside Parliament for
the lying in state
which will happen later in the week
this is very much the center of the
Queen's life
Buckingham Palace it's where she worked
and
it had her own Apartments it was full of
all the offices of her household and
obviously had all the state rooms where
events could take place in the distance
across
from the roof of the palace on the right
here you can see Wellington Barracks
which will be the mounting station for
most of the military taking part in the
state funeral and the processions that
lead up to it
and the park itself
absolutely beautiful with this canopy a
verdant green
St James's which leads up
are towards horse guards Parade Where
year after year we watched as Elizabeth
II
received her annual Queen's birthday
parade all tripping the color
as during the Queen's Reign that the
centuries were moved from outside the
gates to Within
full court of the palace Jesse
Soldier there the century on duty in
front of the century box
beside the center gate looking through
the central
approach point of the palace and over
there in the distance you can see
Lancaster house and the white building
is Clarence House where his majesty the
king lived as Prince William remains for
the moment as king and to the right of
that the red brick Saint James's Palace
where yesterday the
accession Council took place
we're here outside Buckingham Palace the
crowds have been Gathering since early
this morning and patiently waiting for a
glimpse of the new monarch and they'd
have of course just received what
they've been waiting for and the shouts
went up we knew something was happening
with the crowds all raising up their
phones
and lots of excited
matter
as the new King King Charles the Third
made his way to Buckingham Palace where
he has a series of meetings this
afternoon the atmosphere until that
point had been very quiet
rep respectful
an atmosphere of reflection it was very
quiet but then of course that moment of
excitement to see the new monarch
arriving
in the vehicle
and they've certainly were repaid for
the patients this morning and the car of
course drove
uh just outside here turning into the
garden entrance that as Alistair was
just saying where King Charles III is
going to be hosting his first meeting at
2PM today with the Commonwealth
Secretary General baroness Scotland in
the 1844 thing that's named after the
meeting that was held there with
Russia's son Nicholas III but a room
where they received most distinguished
visitors half an hour after that he is
going to be meeting High Commissioners
and spouses from countries where the
king is head of state that would be in
the bow room named after the window at
running along one side and access of
course to that famous garden in
Buckingham Palace
about it
been interesting meeting because it does
include the High Commissioner for
Antigua and Barbuda who had confirmed
that they will be holding a referendum
probably within the next three years on
whether or not to become a republic
um
we're joined by uh Dominic waghorn who's
been sort of reflecting here at
Buckingham Palace to um Dominic how do
you think the meetings will go later on
today well they're important meetings
because the uh the king the new king
will be meeting the Secretary General of
the Commonwealth Baron of Scotland
so that's an important meeting in terms
of connecting him uh with those the 56
Nation members of the Commonwealth um
and it is going to be his first role as
head of the Commonwealth it's not an
automatic assumption that he would have
been there to the Commonwealth but we
understand he now will be and he will be
the third head of the Commonwealth after
his grandfather George VI and his mother
Queen Elizabeth II of course now that
Commonwealth was the group of Nations
that effectively replaced Empire and
it's become an extremely effective kind
of networking group for these nations
diplomatically politically culturally
economically and commercially very very
important so popular actually that a
number of
non-former British Empire Nations have
joined most recently Gabon and Togo
which were former French colonies allows
them to sort of hedge their bets they
have their French Connection and the
British connection so it's a it's an
organization that that's remained very
important very relevant uh to today and
was hugely important to the queen uh
King Charles's mother of course
throughout her Reign and
you get the impression they think he
wants to modernize it as he wants to
modernize the monarchy but wants to keep
up that tradition of supporting the
Commonwealth then he's going to be
meeting the high Commissioners from the
Commonwealth Realms now those are the
countries who still holds the Monarch
the British monarch is their head of
state it's there's a dwindling number of
nations that do of course Australia New
Zealand Canada a number of Caribbean
countries and some Pacific countries as
well and the number is dwindling uh we
had uh Barbados leave their number last
year we've heard now that Antigua and
Barbuda will hold a referendum on
Independence uh within the next three
years their prime minister has decided
that and Jamaica is also in the process
of transitioning
to an independent republic status and it
should I think it should be stressed
there's not a kind of rush for the exits
for um these countries because the queen
has died under her Reign uh she began
with 32 countries recognizing her his
head of state and 17 left so it's part
of a process if you like of of countries
coming of age and for whatever reason
deciding they don't want to have the
British monik as their head of state and
the most I think the more important
point is is that King Charles replaces
his mother as head of the Commonwealth
which is a very powerful as I say group
of countries that remains relevant and
and most crucial I think for Britain
keeps it cements the kind of position
that the queen
enjoyed and promoted promoting British
soft power through the Commonwealth
which is hugely important
a challenge for King Charles III taking
over from a monarch who was well
respected for as you say that kind of
soft power around the world I remember
the words of the famous Republican
Australian prime minister Malcolm
Turnbull who said even Republicans might
myself can be strong elizabethans and
now of course he perhaps needs to find
his own way of negotiating a world where
many are questioning I guess the role of
having the Commonwealth realm and
whether they do want to have a British
head of state yes I think I think the
challenge for Charles is that the queen
software is hugely important and for
those who don't understand what soft
Powers it's kind of it's the it's the
non-military the non-sort of
um heavyweight political wielding of
power it's it's it's it's it's the use
of prestige and influence culturally and
other ways we're a country
um punches above its weights and the
queen was
um a hugely powerful asset in terms of
projecting soft power sort of one-woman
soft power superpower and that was
through her office through the
institution she she had most importantly
the Commonwealth but also just through
her strength of character she she did
more than anyone else
um and probably ever will do so
effortlessly and effectively to promote
soft Powers it's hard to imagine anybody
one individual being as successful as
she has been and promoting improving the
reputation the enhancing The Prestige
and power and influence of her country
as much as the queen did and that was a
lot of it it was through her experience
a number of years on the throne but
through the force of her personality and
the reason why so many people are here
as well drawn by the memory of of the
queen and Charles just doesn't simply
have that I mean who who does so he's
got to replace those very big boots okay
thank you very much Dominic I have more
from Dominica course as those meetings
take place just looking at that lovely
picture of the little boy in the Arsenal
shirt waving the Union Jack Flag outside
the gates of Buckingham Palace and
really there has been such a variety of
people down here young and old all
filling the pool of the palace to pay
their respects to a queen who of course
felt such a constant presence and also
the new King King Charles III who in the
last few moments has entered uh
Buckingham Palace driving through those
crowds well let's go to Kamali Melbourne
shall we who is out and about in those
crowds Kamali what's the atmosphere like
hi so well the atmosphere as you can
imagine is really joyous actually people
have been here waiting quite a while for
the king to make his way into biking and
pies but when you eventually did we
heard a war from the crowd and we also
saw some moments of a little bit of
connection with the King as he was
making his way into the palace I've got
some people here who were right on the
very front row as the King was making
their way and Melissa Haley
what's your name again Melissa Melissa
Melissa Haley Haley Orleans Sonia Sonia
I'm Pauline I'm Pauline you said that he
may have winked to you when you were
away
I was giving him the wave and look in
them and I'm sure he wouldn't tap me I
am sure how long were you guys standing
here waiting for him to make his way in
um we walked from the the top there and
they said anybody with flowers go turn
right and we did so we've only been
there about half an hour and we thought
well something must be coming by because
everybody's just stopped so we just
stopped something waited we would just
stop as well yeah you've got a very very
good shot so was he on this side of the
car as he as you pass by no no
body looked over this but in October
just as he came just as he got to us and
then he waved it was amazing that's a
lovely bit of connection I mean what
what are your thoughts about King
Charles III oh yes absolutely amazing
and we've seen him my daughter many
years ago said that the Prince Charles
waved at her and she holds that title
and now I can go home and say King
Charles has waved at me and went oh wait
I'm ready
where have you traveled in from today to
come and see we've come from Leicester
so it's not close is it you've had to go
on the train or drive down the train at
nine o'clock this morning yes and then
we thought from Houston to train station
and come here and why do you think it
was important to come here to Buckingham
Palace today
um
I don't know man it's just thinking in
history now isn't it it's a lovely
atmosphere isn't it people have families
and lots of people here very you know
I've got grandchildren that that you
know they've known the the queen and now
they will you know have the king to to
support them and everything yeah
why do you think you came down here
what's the what's the feeling like when
you sort of arrived in because as I
walked down there were just so many
people turning up and as we can see
people are still turning up now aren't
they
just for the amount of people that hear
it's so so quiet but it's so just
somewhere that we had to be I think I
think I mean it's a quiet respect isn't
it people are just sort of coming here
and leaving their tributes you've got
flowers as well where are you going to
put those do you think well we were
planning on
Chris but there's a really long wait
um so I think we're going to go back
through Green Park and then put them
around somewhere like that so
amazing
just met each other in the at the
barrier so it was a lovely experience
for all of you guys to get a wave and a
wink
definitely definitely
and you think it's going to be a somber
moment which which it is but actually
seeing the king
just made you look to the Future and
what the future is going to hold for us
now with the king so amazing absolutely
amazing meeting these ladies thank you
so much
we wish him all the very best don't we I
mean that is the sentiment as well that
we're looking now to the Future to King
Charles the Third he's inside Buckingham
at Palace now and those guys we spoke to
they were very very happy to get a wave
and a wink Anna
yes Kamali thank you very much Dunedin
certainly some people I heard earlier
suggesting it was quite hard to get
flowers in London right now so uh Kamali
outside Buckingham Palace there thank
you well let's just remind you of the
events of the day so far the Queen's
coffin has left Balmoral for Edinburgh
the Princess Royal and her husband sir
Tim Lawrence are part of the procession
traveling directly behind the lake
monarch for thousands lining the streets
as the Cortez travels through Scotland
through Villages and towns cities indeed
she's already been through Aberdeen as
well and what has been described by King
Charles is his mother's last great
journey
well the procession of cars left
Balmoral just after 10 o'clock this
morning led by the hearse carrying the
Queen's coffin
it had been carried to the hearse by six
of the Queen's gamekeepers at Balmoral
until now the queen had been at rest in
the castle Ballroom
so her state workers could say their
final farewells
oh
the wreath on top of that coffin made
from some of her favorite flowers picked
from the garden of Balmoral flocks
dahlias sweet peas lemonium white
Heather and pine Fern certainly we've
been told by the local MP in the area
that the Heather has been quite
rescindent this year and certainly she
would enjoyed the view out of her
windows at the castle
well the journey to Edinburgh expected
to take around six hours the Queen's
only daughter as I said the princess
Royal is accompanying the Queen's coffin
traveling with her husband
Admiral Sir Timothy Lawrence in a
limousine
the procession slowed as it drove
through the nearby Village of balita
where the Queen's neighbors lined the
streets to pay their final respects some
of them throwing flowers
the Queen's Journey then continuing
through the beautiful Scottish
Countryside
the coffin arriving in Edinburgh later
this afternoon and there the river D
this is a Royal D side
and those stood
quietly watching as the Cortez went past
dozens lining the route as the
procession passed through the village of
a boyin
foreign
as the Queen's coffin was driven through
the village of bankery
hundreds of people Gathering there on
the High Street
for a view of that Cortez tiers too for
some of those there
well from there the cottage swept
through rural aberdeenshire local
farmers coming out as you can see to say
goodbye the tractors lined up
in their own Honor Guard along the
roadside
and hundreds were seen lining Bridges as
the hearse arrived on the outskirts of
Aberdeen
and this was the scene as the hearse
passed near Duffy Park in Aberdeen
before crossing the King George VI
Bridge across the river d
well meanwhile thousands of people have
gathered in the four nations of the
United Kingdom to witness proclamations
of King Charles III as the pneumonic he
was formerly proclaimed King at a
ceremony in Saint James's Palace
yesterday you'll remember and this has
been followed today by ceremonies at
Cardiff Castle Hillsborough Castle
Windsor Castle and Edinburgh Castle
foreign
with one voice
and consent of tongue and heart
publish
and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George
is known by the death of our late
Sovereign happy of memory
become our only lawful and rightful
needs Lord Charles III
[Music]
please
[Applause]
foreign
to whom we do acknowledge
all faith and obedience with humble
affection
beseeching God
by whom kings and queens do reign
to bless His Majesty with long and happy
years to Reign Over Us
[Music]
thank you
do now hereby with one voice and consent
of tongue and heart
publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George is now
by the death of our late Sovereign of
happy memory become our only lawful
and rightful
lead Lord Charles III
God saved the king
thank you
[Music]
foreign
but one of those proclamations took
place at the Marquette cross on the
Royal mile here in Edinburgh very near
Saint Charles cathedral which is where
Joe Pike is now and you you witness this
um you know extraordinary moment of
history as well the crowds there too but
also waiting Joe for the Cortez of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II to come down
the Royal mile towards where I am at the
palace of Hollywood house
exactly Anna earlier today during that
Proclamation crowds here six to eight uh
people deep not as many people at the
moment but in a couple of hours that of
course will change as you say when the
Cortez comes down the mile down Canon
gate towards where you are at the palace
of holyrood house at the center of the
mile behind me is of course Saint
Charles Cathedral the high Kirk of
Edinburgh this medieval Parish shirt
that will be at the heart of proceedings
tomorrow when the king will accompany
his mother's hearse here a service will
take place and then there will be that
24 hour video where people will be able
to pay their respects on the top of the
cathedral you may be able to see police
Marksman making it clear I think quite
how much of an effort police Scotland
have put in to keep this event these
series of events secure a whole range of
people attending I spoke to a couple of
women from Denmark who are here on a
knitting tour and decided to join in are
also Dan and Amy here who are students
at the University coming forward Amy
tell us when you decided to come out so
basically this morning we were having
breakfast and obviously some monuments
occasion we decided to come down and got
here quite early and we've been here for
about an hour so yeah and you've come
prepared yes yeah snacks a lot of
Pringles and why did you want to come
down I just thought I'd obviously it's a
massive occasion probably once in a
lifetime for us and we come down a pair
of respects and just see everything
that's going on and take it all in yeah
it's just on our doorstep as well so
it'll be stupid if we didn't come along
see it I mean Dan thank you for joining
us on Sky News it's also perhaps worth
pointing out Anna that um the queen did
adapt her approach a key constitutional
role in Scotland as Scotland has changed
itself and certainly towards the start
of a Devolution in 1999 she was at the
heart of the ceremony to open or was
some argue reconvene the Scottish
parliament of forming relationships with
Scotland's first ministers it wasn't
just Prime Ministers who were invited
for Weekends at bound moral but first
ministers two although to signify the
difference Prime Ministers for two
nights and first ministers for one and
of course that continues to be a
challenge for the new King King Charles
does know the key personalities uh here
well in terms of politics for the key
institutions and he uh doubtless will
remain at the heart of them for now here
the crowds have a couple of hours to
wait until the next key moment that
Cortez with the Queen's coffin diving
here moving down from the top of the
mile where Edinburgh Castle is down to
the Parliament and the Palace of
Hollywood house at the bottom
yes and I stand in the middle of those
two in fact Joe Pike thank you very much
indeed well let's bring in a now Louise
Tate the Queen's Scottish press
secretary worked in the Royal household
for very many years and you know people
there stood at multiples deep waiting
for several hours to see the Cortez a
sign that everybody wants to come and
pay their respect here in Scotland today
and I think I think that's true and the
Royal Mail actually is quite a tricky
location it's the payments are not that
deep
um so it was always going to be a
challenge to fit in as many people as as
possible but that of
thankfully many people have been able to
do it you were one of those people who'd
been closely involved in these plans or
United is it is it going how you'd
expected it to are there you know are
there pots that you're noticing that are
different from from the things you'd
worked out
uh not substantially no not that's how I
can see it but what I'm grateful for is
these positions work that we have for
the media there was a lot of people put
a lot of work into making sure that
everybody could get the pictures those
people who can't be here in person or
any of the other locations could see the
pictures on their television screens and
we have a particular problem here at uh
Hollywood host and it's called Arthur's
seat it's a great big lump of volcanic
rock and uh so I'm just pleased that oh
technically it all works because largely
much of this is untested okay the next
point of course is that King Charles
will come tomorrow we know that members
of the royal family have already arrived
from from Balmoral and obviously the
Princess Royal and her husband are
traveling with the Cortez two they'll be
back in this Palace weren't they how
important is this Palace to the royal
family what's its role well this is how
much is the Queen's official oh no sorry
his majesty the king's official
residence in Scotland and it is this it
is a place where all the formalities
happen the audience with the first
Minister presiding officer
um occasionally the moderator very
multi-commissioner I'm just trying to
and of course it was the the location of
a couple State visits including I think
it's Pope Benedict the 14th you're right
we're wrong about that forgive me if I
am but there was a people visit here and
it's it's it's it's it's very it's such
a historic building and Prince Albert
and uh Victoria responsible for the
fountain that is in the courtyard it
dates back to the Mary Queen of Scots
and her father it's a very very
important building
that's this end of the journey the other
end was Balmoral and how poignant was it
do you think for for the staff you've
worked there for so many years to to say
goodbye to her majesty I can only
imagine how difficult the last few days
have been for them um
the the it is as I said before a very
intimate castle and then the activities
that they're all family
um enjoy the Outdoor Pursuits that
inevitably lots of game Keepers and
Gillies and you know there's people with
the ponies of course the royal guard as
well and it will have been a very
surreal experience but they'll all be
focused on doing their jobs to the best
of their ability and I can only imagine
how those Keepers felt Louise Tate thank
you very much indeed and obviously we
await uh King Charles tomorrow he'll be
met at Edinburgh airport by the first
Minister Nicola sturgeon
but here we are the journey proceeding
from
Aberdeen down to Dundee
and then on further south towards
Edinburgh for the ceremonials that will
happen today let's return now to
Aleister Bruce and Aleister the the
beautiful Scottish Countryside has been
much on show today
it certainly has and certainly the
weather when the queen left Balmoral was
unbelievably beautiful it was as though
that ideal that it is was completely
wearing its best to see
the lad of Balmoral leave for the last
time and the journey has wended its way
through first of all the most amazing
Highlands and we saw the hills of
Scotland almost right up to Loch nagar
which dominates the Balmoral
scenery and then you see the hills sort
of fall away as the Cortez made its way
ultimately to the Sea at Aberdeen and
now making its way further south
but we're seeing the whole of the east
coast of Scotland in that Central area
and
yet again more people in Dundee
lined up to watch as the queen is passed
before them and taken to their capital
city of Edinburgh
each person there with a memory
every one of them
in their life have
handed over currency with the Queen's
face upon it
every one of them has used post boxes
with her crown and symbolism Associated
and
all the state apparatus that has
associated with her as the queen now
comes through
her people
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
as the queen was conveyed through
bankery
watched by
people who live nearby many of them had
driven into the town in order to have
this moment to pay their respect to
their former sovereign
and then a line of tractors were lined
up for a salute from Farmers to
another farmer the queen who had farmed
obviously at Balmoral and elsewhere
around the United Kingdom
she understood tractors well
and
the war of course
the Royal Estates were using horses
and in Aberdeen
as the queen passed Again by
people from the city who'd come out
and the route was arranged so that as
many people as possible over quite a
long distance could have their chance to
witness as the hearse
pass by followed of course
by a royal car
which carries the Queen's daughter the
Princess Royal
the reactions of people very
quiet and peaceful some have thrown
flowers towards the hearse
some have clapped
many have just silently watched as the
queen goes by
but wherever the queen has passed the
chance to Glimpse the Royal Standard of
Scotland
and the wreath of Balmoral flowers from
the garden
[Music]
with me here in Edinburgh is the
Scottish labor party leader anasawa very
good to see you here as well and some
amazing pictures that we've seen from
Balmoral this journey through Aberdeen
now heading south what have you made of
it so far I think it's a perfect
illustration of not just how much the
queen loves Scotland back say how much
Scotland loved her back she was a
constant in so many of our lives and you
know as this TalkBack divides all the
time but actually she was the great
unifier of our nation and I think you
can see that love from right across the
political Spectrum from right across the
communities across the Scotland paying
tribute to this remarkable remarkable
one I know you were at one of those
events which takes the monarchy forward
the proclamation for King Charles III
what was that like just a short distance
from here well the most striking thing
was seeing God save the King For the
First Time which it was quite a
different experience but you know you
could tell you're part of a historic
moment there of course a historic
recognition of the roles and
responsibilities of her majesty the
queen recognizing the affection the love
that we had for her but also that
historic moment of King Charles III now
being our head of state and all that
pressure that comes on his shoulders in
terms of pulling our great nation
together
pressure on her shoulders that
responsibility at a time of personal
grief for him too and I know you're
amongst those people the politicians of
Scotland who'll be able to pay your
respects tomorrow I think that's more
striking thing is you know of course
there's the Pomp and ceremony of course
there's the processes but let's not
forget ultimately that he's lost his
mother his sons have lost their
grandmother and his grandchildren lost a
great grandmother and to have to go
through all the processes he's now going
through in the accession of becoming our
King he still has to grieve the loss of
someone probably the most closest person
to him in his entire life and so for
that I think The Bravery that's acquired
the these emotional sacrifice that's
required I think is also recognizing
people across the country
and the Queen's coffin will rest here at
the palace of Hollywood house to allow
staff to say therefore well as well and
then tomorrow another another one of
those really poignant moments when it
will leave here excuse me head up the
Royal mile towards Saint Giles Cathedral
to be followed by the Queen's children
and you know to witness them making that
walk uh saying goodbye to their mother
in front of so many people who want to
come and see these are it's very
difficult for the family isn't it
absolutely difficult but in in 70 years
of service Her Majesty gave this country
I was joking earlier on with another
politician up the road when we were at
the proclamation that in 70 years as
head of state she always seemed to say
the right thing do the right thing at
the right time something political
leaders across the world would be so
jealous of in order to try and get that
same balance right but you mentioned the
staff at the palace if this was the
individual who in 70 years of dedicated
service must have come across thousands
if not tens of thousands of people every
over that 70 years those emotional
connections and relationships and I hope
when they do make that route up to some
jazz tomorrow at that service as they
will see the coffin coming down to
Hollywood Palace I hope her family can
see that of course she was someone
special to them but actually she was
someone special to the entire country
and Beyond this country as well and I
hope that's a source of comfort for them
and many people choosing to go to give
thanks and that was certainly a theme at
the Platinum Jubilee as well wasn't it a
way of the nation saying thank you for
for all those years of excuse me
dedication and service well if you think
about her majesty the the queen she was
a comfort at times of national tragedy
you think about her words during the
height of the pandemic she was a unified
and brought Joy at times of national
pride the Jubilee being a perfect
example of that she was thinking about
times of of challenge globally and she
was Delight in those moments of Darkness
for our country and I think that is a
great dedication to her majesty the
queen 70 years I say of dedicated
service and you can see the love from
people and I think it's also important
to stress that not everyone might be
natural royalists or monarchists but I
think even across that divide people can
recognize that this was perhaps the
greatest public servant our country has
ever seen someone who pulled our country
together and someone that we all had a
great affectional love for
have you worked out what you will say to
King Charles when you meet him tomorrow
well first and foremost will be a
condolence on on the passing of his
mother and then after that I'm not sure
what else what I'll say but uh look I'm
of course looking forward to have that
opportunity to speak to him tomorrow but
I hope the sense he gets tomorrow is yes
we're United in grief we're also United
in our commitment to building a more
prosperous country going forward and
that falls on his shoulders of course
his political shoulders that falls on
but as our constitutional Monarch some
of that responsibility and pressure also
falls on him and I hope he can get the
same love that his mother got from
people right across this country it was
values I'm sure his mother taught me if
he's looking for a role model and how to
do the job properly he's got no greater
role model than her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II if he follows that
tradition if he follows that model he
will be remembered as a remarkable King
also and there are so many patronages
out there and Charities supported in all
the Realms of the UK and including here
in Scotland that have to be shared out
you know so a lot of Charities will will
be wondering you know who will be their
Patron now the queen has gone and Prince
Charles suggesting he will have to to
give some up and step aside from some
because his role will change this comes
with a lot of change doesn't it well I
think about the for example you know my
own Heritage around Pakistan and India I
know the a huge affection and love the
royal family has they're the queen in
particular I know the dedication that
King Charles no King Charles had when he
was Prince Charles as the head of the
British Asian trust looking to promote
the responsibilities and the great
talents of the British Asian Community
right across the country that will
probably now fall on somebody else's
shoulders but it it demonstrates that
yes of course they have the ceremonial
rules yes of course they have these
formal things that they do but actually
underneath that there is lots of
emotional attachment lots of Engagement
lots of great causes that they advocate
for that they Champion that they
fundraise for that helps change people's
lives yes here but also in other parts
of the world as well and I saw our labor
leader here in Scotland thank you very
much talk to you thank you and obviously
King Charles III that you mentioned
there has important roles also this
afternoon so let's get the very latest
on that and head to Sophie Ridge at
Buckingham Palace
thanks very much uh Anna good afternoon
live from Buckingham Palace where people
have continued to gather feeling the
pull of the palace leaving flowers and
of course trying to wait for a glimpse
not only of King King Charles III but
his new Queen console as well who has
arrived in the last few moments to join
her husband here at Bucky and Palace you
can see her there
waving to the crowds of people
who have phoned a loft
waving back cheering happy to see the
new Queen consort there driving into the
palace to join King Charles III
he's going to be holding meetings in
just over 10 minutes time the firstborn
with the Commonwealth Secretary General
baroness Scotland and also Then followed
half an hour later with a meeting with
high Commissioners and spouses from the
countries where he is currently at head
of state that will be in the bow room
let's bring in a dominant Wagon at shall
we who's been across proceedings here in
Buckingham Palace today when Queen
Elizabeth took the throne the number of
countries where she was head of state
was a lot Fuller than it was today isn't
it and are we expecting that number to
be dwindling further yes it was 32 yeah
she was so she was Head of State for 32
Realms of the Commonwealth they're
called and then during her Reigns 17
Nations chose to move away from that
constitutional Arrangement and opt for
Independence so became republics instead
or various Arrangements that don't have
her as the head of state so Prince
Charles inherits
um the position of being Head of State
for 14 Nations as well as as Britain and
he'll be meeting the high Commissioners
for most of those Realms in half an hour
or so after he's met with the Secretary
General of the uh the Commonwealth now
what's been happening recently is that
that sort of process of attrition if you
like dwindling down the number of Realms
regarding that the monarchist ahead of
state has continued and kind of speeded
up recently so Barbados has left that
number Jamaica's in the process of doing
so and in the wake of the Queen's death
Antigua and Bob Buddha's prime minister
has indicated that he'll hold a
referendum within three years the prime
minister of New Zealand Jacinda Arden
has said that she can't see New Zealand
remaining in the same arrangements as it
has been by the end of her lifetime so
there's a natural process I think moving
away from that and we'll probably see
that continue under Prince Charles but
at King Charles but it's it's worth
stressing that there's a kind of not a
rush for the exit because the Queen's
gone it's just a process that's that
began years ago and continues and that's
that's that's the realm so that's
distinct from the Commonwealth
um as such which is a much bigger
organization that effectively replaced
the British Empire and that process of
transitioning from Empire to
Commonwealth was obviously a key part of
the the beginning of the Queen's Reign
when Nations chose Independence and and
the Empire basically broke up now the
Commonwealth has 56 Nations it has
within those Nations two and a half
billion people that's third of the
population in the world and it covers a
quarter of the world's land mass so it's
a it's a hugely almost a huge
organization it's a hugely powerful and
influential organization and for that
reason countries who weren't actually
Imperial uh subjects of the British
Empire weren't British colonies some of
them have joined as well so Gabon and
Togo former French colonies have joined
as well because they want to benefit
from all the perks of being a member of
that club as well so Prince Charles King
Charles uh you have to check yourself
yes King Charles yeah exactly but King
Charles wasn't wasn't it wasn't
automatic he would be head of the
Commonwealth but he now becomes the
third head of the Commonwealth and
that's really important to Britain
because it's such an important mechanism
for projecting British soft power
through that huge organization and that
number of people
thank you very much Dominic so really
important meetings there for at King
Charles after that at 4pm he's going to
be meeting the dean of Windsor from
Saint George's Chapel which is the place
of worship for the royal family 10
former kings and queens buried there and
he of course is going to be committing
couldn't conducting the committal
service which was when the queen will be
lowered into the Royal Vault to rest
alongside her beloved husband the Duke
of Edinburgh and I think that really
perhaps sums up the mix of emotion that
people are feeling here today at
Buckingham Palace at the sort of
mourning at the end of something the end
of the Elizabethan era while also
welcoming in the new king and the new
Queen consort as well and let's go now
shall we to Kamali at Melbourne who's
been in the crowd meeting people who
have felt the pull of the palace today
Kamali what's the atmosphere been like
thank you Sophia the pull of the post is
a lovely way to describe it because it's
really been sort of a place of
pilgrimage for people from all over the
country all over the world really to
come here to try and be a part of the
history that we're all witnessing and as
you said in the sort of the past 45
minutes or so we've seen King Charles
III go in and then we saw the car go
away people waved at the car but it was
empty he was going to pick up we think
of course the queen concert Camilla who
just entered in the past 10 minutes or
so and a family they've come down from
Saint Albans just to kind of um be a
part of this moment and also pay their
respects uh join me now thank you so
much for waiting around to have a little
conversation with us and you missed the
king but you saw Camilla didn't you we
saw we saw Camilla yes and what was it
like when you saw her going past I mean
little buzz wasn't there atmosphere kind
of yeah the atmosphere raised a bit
there's quite a somber atmosphere in
general at the atmosphere raised a bit
when we saw when we saw Camilla go past
yes now Kavita why do you think it was
important to come down here with your
family today well the queen was a stable
presence and an ever-changing world she
was a reassuring present so we come to
power respects and and twisted our new
king well as well and everyone I'll
guess you'd Echo a lot of that wouldn't
you
what were we going to say why did you
decide to come down here today
because lots of people
and she was the longest reigning monarch
he certainly was I mean you know your
facts about it and you you said you
weren't able to see committee because
you were too little is that right but
next time we're gonna encourage you to
climb on a barrier won't we safely yeah
make sure you see the next one going in
and why did you think it was important
to come down here Jasmine well she
reigned for 70 years and she was a
really great role model in society did
you feel that as well I mean obviously
you're you're a young woman and she
hasn't been your queen for a long time
but you could still sense the fact that
she was a role model for you yeah
100 it's a lovely lovely sentiment why
do you think it was important to come
down here today we thought we'd just
bring the children down to pay their
respects we put some flowers down and
take in what was going on and give us a
sense of the atmosphere I mean it's a
lovely family sort of feel about it and
there's loads of people it's all very
well organized it's very sort of relaxed
and sort of Collegiate isn't it there
are lots of people there's lots of
waiting everybody's
um respecting each other though and yeah
it is good atmosphere it really is and
thank you so much you guys for coming
and uh thoughts could be of King Charles
the Third I mean we wish him well don't
we of course we wish King Charles the
Third well and yeah it's a new era so
we'll see what happens absolutely okay
thank you very much guys I mean that's
just a flavor of the the kind of people
who are coming here today to try and pay
their respects to for the passing of her
majesty the queen and also to welcome
the new King King Charles III
but thank you very much indeed Kamali
they're outside they're backing Palace
at ningling with some of those uh crowds
and as we were reflecting on it really
does feel like a kind of mix of emotions
for people uh today uh paying their
respects to the queen who many people
felt was you know a real constant
presence in our lives but also looking
ahead to King Charles the Third the
beginning of something new and let's
bring in uh Dominic Michael and again
shall we because it's a challenging
moment for the monarchy in many ways
isn't it and people of course having
that immense amount of affection for
Queen Elizabeth but also of course
questioning the role of the common realm
and questions about the family as well
how much of a intro do you think the new
King has got oh a huge intro and a huge
amount of challenges but I think I think
the immediate challenge for the monarchy
and the institution that that building
is the sort of headquarters of is is to
reassure the people at a time which is
emotionally very turbulent I mean we've
we've seen extraordinary sort of ranges
of emotion today and a real sort of I
think contrast between what we've seen
in Scotland today which has been very
somber very moving uh as one woman
outside the palace said she expects it
to be heart-wrenching to see the hearse
come out of Balmoral Castle and I think
many people will will feel it was and
it's it's it's the first sort of
tangible concrete evidence that we have
that this has actually happened
something that's still really hitting us
I think and we've seen people breaking
down in tears dignitaries being
interviewed in Scotland unable to
control their emotions so very somber
very moving feeling up there whereas
down here it's it's felt much lighter
more celebratory more excited and that's
what we've seen the last few days even
the same breath some people have been
saying you know I've been talking to
people here very very upset very sad but
also very excited and the people I've
spoken to earlier this morning here felt
that they did feel reassured so far but
from what they've heard from the
mnemonic and what they've seen of the
process I don't know if you agree with
me doing it but it felt to me that there
was a shift in the atmosphere you know
one kind of first walked in this morning
uh before King Charles entered the
palace it did feel very reflective quite
quiet I remember overhearing a little
girl asking her mum how did she get up
into the sky it felt like that kind of
period of morning I guess but then
almost as soon as that car drove along
the mile behind us here and through the
gates it felt as if it was almost
something had lifted in the crowd
slightly chattering began their phones
all came out and it was almost looking
forward I guess to the new era yeah
completely which mirrors exactly what
happened on Friday where there was that
feeling of I think stunned disbelief in
the morning and then it's very
reflective people were quiet it was a
very slightly Eerie atmosphere people
said they felt it was very surreal and
then when Prince Charles's car arrived
having flown down from Scotland actually
the the clouds parted as well as a bit
of sunshine which lifted the mood but it
changed very much from being more
reflective in some bit too much more
excited and optimistic and I think we
felt the same a feeling here from those
who've come here and a lot of people
very real sense of expectancy I think
people came here to uh to line the route
not really knowing what they'd expect to
see but hoping to see something
we're coming here to see but they and
they were held back and then allowed
through um just in time to see the king
go past in his in his limousine and then
the queen consorts as well shortly
afterwards they're ready for those
they're all important meetings and I
guess it also does feel doesn't it that
after the kind of untethering moment of
hearing the news about Queen Elizabeth
to suddenly the the wheels kick into
motion again and and and things move
have moved quite quickly it seems you
know the new king
imperceptibly the crown immediately
passes to him and he's already got a
full day of meetings yeah there's a lot
of business now going underway uh on in
their uh as the king takes on his role
as head of the Commonwealth meets the
Secretary General of the Commonwealth
and meets those High Commissioners from
the Realms Who Remain loyal to seeing
him as their new head of state as well
as the head of state for Britain
exactly a really interesting uh to
reflect on all of that are here at
Buckingham Palace as King Charles III
arrives here to meet with the
Commonwealth Secretary General and also
of course the high commissioners of the
countries where he is currently the head
of state some important meetings for uh
Charles the Constitutional meetings the
business meeting and then perhaps the
more personal meeting later at four
o'clock when of course he is going to be
meeting with the man the dean of Windsor
hilgan is going to be committing that
very important committal service with
the queen luring her to rest alongside
her beloved husband as always with these
Royal Stories the mix of the
Constitutional and the personal clashing
and certainly I think the people here
are going to be very pleased to have got
their glimpse of the new king
it is two o'clock this is Sky News live
from the Palace of Hollywood house in
Edinburgh
a last great journey the Queen's coffin
is seen for the first time as it leaves
Balmoral for a slow journey to Edinburgh
[Music]
the Queen's only daughter the Princess
Royal and her husband are accompanying
the coffin on the six-hour journey
[Music]
crowds line the streets as the cottage
passes through towns and villages in
aberdeenshire
[Music]
the Duke of York Earl and Countess of
Wessex and other members of the royal
family arrive here at Hollywood house
ahead of the Queen's Cortez
here at Buckingham Palace a busy
afternoon in Prospect for the new
monarch
[Music]
as Proclamation Ceremonies for King
Charles III are held around the country
foreign
[Applause]
has arrived at Buckingham Palace for
meetings with senior Commonwealth
officials as the Prime Minister of
Antigua and Barbuda says he will call
for a referendum on becoming a republic
here at Buckingham Palace crowds are
still Gathering to pay their respects to
the queen
foreign
[Music]
I am live at the Queen's official
Scottish residence in Edinburgh where
the Queen's coffin will arrive later
this afternoon as the Monarch Begins the
journey to her final resting place the
hearse left the Balmoral estate shortly
after 10 o'clock this morning with the
Princess Royal and her husband Admiral
Sir Tim Lawrence part of the procession
traveling directly behind the late
monarch well thousands have lined the
streets is the Cortez travels through
the Scottish towns and Villages of
aberdeenshire and Beyond
well our Royal correspondent Rhianna
Mills is here with me now and Rihanna
and Stephanie the first sight of the
coffin the moment when you realize it is
true that the queen has passed always
going to be a heartfelt and emotional
time for people I think when when anyone
loses a loved one
it can take some time to sink in can't
it and this does all feel it all feels
very sudden that the she died and now we
have a new king and so it was it was
quite an arresting site wasn't it seeing
seeing the coffin being driven away from
Balmoral and I couldn't help but think
about the fact that I was only there on
Tuesday
reporting on the fact that she had again
carried out that key constitutional role
she had been very clear with her
advisors that she wanted to be again
responsible for handing over power
between one prime minister and the next
and yet within such a short space of
time
we were then reporting her sad death and
I think for for me this journey that she
will now make
really encapsulates
The Divide sometimes between that that
private life that the time that she
would spend with family important time
the likes of Balmoral Sandringham she
loved the countryside she loved being
surrounded by her dogs and her horses
Balmoral is a place of seclusion and
actually a wonderful place where the
family at least over the last 48 hours
could have come together and taken some
time to pause and spend their final
moments with her
but now she is making that Journey
crowds lining the streets paying their
respects
the crowds out as they so often were
when she carried out all of those
thousands of engagements throughout her
reign and she will gradually make her
way to Edinburgh where again you can see
all of the barriers are going out we've
already got hundreds thousands of people
making sure that they are here with
their flowers with their Union Flags to
pay their respects and eventually make
that final move down to Buckingham
Palace which I think for all of us will
be such a symbolic moment if you think
only a few months ago the crowds were
there in front of Buckingham Palace
looking up at that balcony as our 96
year old Monarch at the time made every
effort to be there leading her family
for what was such a symbolic moment and
yet we will see the car with her coffin
head to Buckingham Palace for one final
time I think that will be an incredibly
moving moment she's about to arrive in
in Dundee the home of marmalade and
everyone relating it to Paddington as
well but there we are in the air and the
toast out of the bag or the marmalade
sandwich out of the bag that amazing
amazing sense of humor that she showed
at that time too and that I think is
something that that really stands out
over the last few days as we've all been
been getting used to this news is yes we
were so used to the official side of the
queen and we talked so much about her
her dedication to service Duty the
Constitutional role but now increasingly
we're hearing from those who were who
were so close to her who her family or
or those who who worked alongside her
and it's those those little flashes of
sense of humor Paddington Bear I
remember the night that we saw that
video it was completely out of the blue
completely unexpected and just
effortlessly acted it was just
spectacular and for her she just always
wanted to make sure that she was able to
to connect and for those that knew her
very well who worked with her
such kindness she would show to them in
just little ways in in asking about
their families because she knew that
they gave so much and that is why I
think it's been it's been a lovely touch
that she the coffin was at Balmoral for
some time the coffin will be here at
Hollywood house for 24 hours so that raw
household staff have their own private
time to pay tribute
as we then wait amongst the crowds for
those more public moments
yes a place of quiet dignity is how
Buckner Palace described the scene at
Balmoral in that bull room the same as
you say will be repeated here at the
palace of Hollywood house Rhiannon thank
you very much indeed well let us go to
Dundee then that Journey continuing
Adele Robinson is there for us Adele
yes within the last uh half an hour 45
minutes a few hundred people have
gathered here we're on the outskirts of
Dundee just by the side of the A90 the
aptly named Kingsway and it's just a few
minutes from when we're expecting the
Queen's coffin to arrive it's a mixture
of different things here today from the
people that I've spoken to it's an
amalgamation of emotion for some people
grief for a lot of people it's the
spectacle that they want to see a moment
in history and for others it's a
celebration of the Queen's life and I'll
just bring in uh Jillian here he's
waiting to see the Queen's coffin thank
you for joining us Jillian you're from
Dundee yourself uh just it can be a
sense of why you felt you needed to be
here for this well it's a part of
History so we've come down with the
family and the grandchildren and really
to pay a respects to a well-loved queen
do you have fairly strong feelings
towards Queen Elizabeth II I've always
been a monarchist yes I think she's the
granny that you never had and she's just
lovely and the conscience of the country
I think I was just saying that it's a
mixture of different emotions some
people are here for
um the moment in history some people are
here because they feel they need to to
grieve in their own way
um our longest second longest serving
Monarch in the world
um for you is it about Elizabeth II is
it about the sense of occasion as well
at the same time I think it's both and I
think it's um because television
as any other home to actually feel
personally related in some sort of way
you know and just she was lovely women
if you feel emotional yourself yeah I do
actually yeah
a lot of people I've spoken to here
today just said that she just reminds
them of of losing their own
um relatives as well I think that sort
of human side that we saw of the queen
that's something that you found yeah
yeah just had a great long life she's
guided the country well and I think she
will be solely missed
from Dundee um how would you describe
the relationship that the queen has had
over the years with with ending I think
the queen has had quite a bit to do with
Dundee and the Queen Mother opens a
tailored bridge I was there my dad was
on the bridge building that and um I
just think with them Catherine and
William Bennetts and Andrews there isn't
close connection really because we're
not far from uh Saint Andrews either so
yeah I think we do feel part of it and
somebody on the news this morning said
she was Queen of Scots and I actually
think that was well said yeah you feel
that um as a Scottish person that yeah
she had that special connection yes yes
they really do I just think she was a
lovely woman as was her mother and I
think she was probably brought up you
know to serve the people and I really
don't think anybody could say that she
hasn't done her field you
thank you so much for your time Jillian
um we'll just uh pop over here just to
show you the rest of the crowds who have
gathered and we'll speak to Bruce who
isn't from Dundee but you're from
Huntley not too far away and you're here
on holiday you actually live in
Peterborough
um so kind of good timing and a way for
you just to see this to witness this
yeah it's a shame it's had to happen but
yeah it's a nice time to be here
see something here
will never happen again in my lifetime
sure
yeah it's nice to see yeah yeah just
tell me um why you felt that you needed
to come here to be here in person for
this
because the queen should've done so much
for the country she's been such a
Ambassador for the country everywhere
she goes she's
been great for the country and
the support
just for the family and things many I
don't know but just felt I had to be
here and
show my respects type thing it's about
showing respect to you and and a lot of
people a few hours say a lot of people
quite a few people that I've spoken to
you here today have felt quite emotional
because with the the passing of Queen
Elizabeth II they themselves related to
their their own lives and losing
relatives is that something that you've
felt when she passed
yeah it's my grandparents when they
passed there
things are cut but yeah it's
just more for the Royals because they
went through such a bad time themselves
lately had such bad publicity
the Queen's shooting so much for the
company just felt that he had to show
support for the whole family the whole
royal family really
do you think it's a special relationship
that was speaking to Jillian over there
special relationship between Elizabeth
VII uh sorry the second had with
Scotland she saw Balmoral as a place
where she could be most happy for
example yeah she loved it here I used to
work in battle term before many years
ago now and it was always a great time
when she was here she was always
larger people came to share it was good
for the tourist area she was happy when
she was here so yeah she loved it in
this area and she'll be badly missed Now
by people in Bala oh and crafty around
that area so yeah do you ever anywhere
in Scotland or elsewhere when she
visited
go to a local Town Huntley they went to
the dean shortbread and everything up
there so I had connections with my local
child as well so yeah thank you very
much for your time uh Bruce and of
course Julian over there as well you can
see all these Spectators waiting to see
the Queen's coffin it's due here in the
next few minutes
um and really want him to Mark the end
of what is the Elizabethan era but also
the era of what the people I've been
speaking to here today see is a a very
special a very unique monarch
Adele perhaps you could tell people
there it's just under 20 minutes until
they arrive where you are the Cortez has
just traveled through fufa it's about 20
minutes or so away from Dundee now and
we were looking there let me bring in
Louise Tate the clean Scottish press
secretary for uh for 15 years it looked
like we were looking at the Royal car
there and obviously we know that the
Princess Royal and her husband are are
following on on this six hour Hundred
Mile Journey it's a long way but I I
think I said earlier it gladdened my
heart that she's there and I I think the
Princess Royal will be very determined
that that was in fact the right thing to
do
feels right to me take us back to what
it would have been like in the in the
ballroom before those six estate game
Keepers picked up the common and moved
through the small dining room on the way
to put the Queen's coffin in the hearse
that we that we see now a time for the
family to say their own private goodbyes
before in a sense they release it to the
public yes and we and we get to share
this experience yes I can only imagine
what moving scenes there must have been
in the ballroom at Balmoral and these
game Keepers you know they she cared
about people she knew exactly who people
were where where they were meant to be
what their job is
and I I can picture the Liberty that
we've been wearing and
just how emotional it must have been for
them what an honor it must be to see the
queen I used to Balmoral Council for the
last time and I would imagine they'd
really work hard to hold it together and
get that history
no pictures of that moment whether she
was quite firm about that I'm not sure I
don't know it's a private residence
holiday
home and yes it's visited by the public
but it's it's still once the Queensland
residents we try to preserve that sense
of privacy and just that moment it
wouldn't possibly felt slightly
interesting and it's not part of the
crown estate is that it is privately
owned by the royal family and much loved
as We Know by the queen and many people
taking Solace that it was there that she
passed away well I think that's true I
think that is actually true that there
was some Solace that she was where many
could say that she was happiest
I'm not respect to any other residences
but it was such a free time and I I
think it would have felt
that she was at home she had just
done that last official moment with the
uh outgoing and then incoming new prime
minister and I think that was her
determination to see that moment through
and so typical so typical of them
Louise Tate thank you very much indeed
and we will certainly remember that
photograph weren't we in that smile on
Tuesday just last week of uh of her
majesty appointing the new prime
minister Alistair
Anna it's very special that the queen
has just passed by forfeit
and therefore very close to glam's
Castle
it's the closest that this procession
will come to what was her mother's
family home
in fact
shortly the queen will pass by Craig owl
Hill which can be seen from the glams
castle parapets
and this is very much
the area of Scotland that her mother who
taught her almost everything that
started her love of Scotland off
all about and
interestingly four fur is also the name
of the town
which the queen gave her youngest son as
his Scottish title
Prince Edward is known as the Earl of
Wessex and fortha
so it underscores why
it meant so much to the queen
that this part of Scotland
has all the links to her family history
through her mother and glam's Castle is
itself one of the Great bastions of
Scotland's story
and the Bose lion family themselves
have plenty of Steward blood within them
and it is that Stewart connection that
brought
the king of Scots in 1603 at the death
of the last Queen Elizabeth
when James VI of Scots came down with
the Scottish Royal inheritance to take
in addition
the crown of England
and
in the new King Charles III we have an
echo
of that great Stewart family name
and both King Charles the first and
Charles II were from the house of Stuart
and the
those lines descended from that Stewart
Royal House
and it's antecedent
in Robert the Bruce
on the bridges people Gathering
and as we saw on that very busy road a
few moments ago people
had part their cars and
were standing on either side of the
carriageway to see the queen
pass by followed by
her daughter
Princess Royal who's accompanying her
mother on this lonely Journey out of the
highlands of Scotland
the signpost declaring the route to
Dundee
on to Perth and to Edinburgh
it's a somnolent Sunday site
here in eastern Scotland
Cortes slowing down considerably here
the progress is slightly delayed from
the plan but
it is because
the plan was to make sure that those who
had wanted
to pay their respects to the former
Queen
would get the chance
perhaps it just might give us an
indication
of
the crowds who are likely to want to
visit Saint Giles High Kirk in Edinburgh
when the queen is placed at rest there
and in state
tomorrow for 24 hours
and also too when the queen lies in
state
in Westminster Hall
in London before her funeral
flowers cast there
the lion rampant flag
adorning
the side of the road which also
enrapts the former Queen of Scots as she
passes by
so many of her Scots
she was 25 when she came to the throne
Young by any Reckoning
no one had expected that her father
would necessarily die quite so young and
I think as she put it it was all of
tremendous taking on
for her as she became Queen took on the
responsibilities of sovereignty it was a
different world too from the one we know
today
but whilst there is
rightly much less deference
for institutions and Grandeur and
position for the sake of it
respect is enduring
and it grows
and Scots have many differing views but
perhaps in this lady
there has been
a great Union of respect for
what she has delivered as head of state
and the genuine love that she's held for
Scotland
as she comes into Dundee
excuse me
[Music]
[Applause]
slowly along the King's Way
with the
carriageway on the opposite side
completely stopped with people who've
climbed out to come and Witness
the Queen of Scots passed by
never happier than when walking in a
howling Gale across Scotland's Hills
wearing a Tweed skirt
and robust Footwear
and a stick the queen always enjoyed
being up here amongst Scots and
at Balmoral
and as she has reigned the nation has
grown development everywhere has been
considerable and so many of these houses
that have been built perhaps during her
reign
and the 70 years of the Elizabethan
age here in Scotland the first
Elizabethan age for Scotland
has been one of immense technological
advancement
unbelievable social change
cultural alterations and attitudes have
been different
in so many ways from the way they were
in 1952 when
the young 25 year old became Queen
when the queen paid her first visit to
Scotland after her coronation in 1953
her visit to Glasgow was marked by the
terrible misfortune of a number of
people in the crowd that had come to see
her
being trampled in
a difficult moment of crime management
and it's perhaps again
a reminder that because she and her
young husband
was such a flash of Youth
and future opportunity for a post-war
world that she brought that additional
zest to the start of her reign
Prince Philip always said as
those First tours of not only Scotland
but of the Realms and other parts of the
Commonwealth and at the beginning of the
Queen's Reign they were
mobbed almost everywhere they went
and the Duke said that if they had ever
allowed themselves to think it was about
them
it might have gone to their heads
but the queen and the Duke always knew
that any adulation that came towards
them
was owed to the institution
and the crown that the queen had the
honor to serve
which belonged not to her
but to all the people of the United
Kingdom and the respective Nations
and perhaps as we see her taken
through Scotland on this first of her
last Journeys
it is that
guiding moral Direction
that has helped her find her way through
kingship
throughout a very long reign
Dundee salutes that Queen and that long
reign of service
well the King's Way Dundee's
indispensable outer Ring Road was
immense originally meant to be a wide
tree-lined Avenue a long time in the
planning and the name devised during the
planning stages was meant to commemorate
the then current Monarch Edward VII
although the actual completion was in
the reign of Victoria and Albert's
grandson George V these infrastructure
projects as we know take a take a long
time but Dundee famous for for other
things for jute and for jam and for
journalism they say once known as
deutopolis it produced so much of the of
the world's dut and in terms of jam
specifically the Dundee woman Janet
Keeler inadvertently playing her role in
the creating of the Beloved children's
character Paddington Bear by inventing
marmalade in the city in the 1700s
the first radio message in the world was
sent in Dundee In 1832 and it's also
home to two historical ships the
discovery the ship that took Scott to
the Antarctic and the frigate unicorn
the sixth oldest ship in the world and I
did wonder Alistair if that is why
operation unicorn the words operation
unicorn came from the code name for the
plan if the queen should die in Scotland
as she did indeed do so
foreign
which is the heraldic Beast for Scotland
and holds the shield bearing the lion
rampant
but gives so many other links to the
Scottish story and any other that links
to other Queen's Reign and indeed it is
Operation unicorn that is being carried
out here
to ensure that the queen is recovered
from Balmoral where she died brought to
the capital city of Edinburgh past the
great Castle down to the palace and to
lie and state in the high Kirk
of Saint Giles
the crowds are just everywhere aren't
they it's extraordinary to see how many
had filled that King's Way today
the journey now carries on down along
the Firth of the day
one of the other Great Rivers of
Scotland the Tay
which reaches also into the can gorms to
draw its water down to the Sea
and will come to the Great Bridge by
Perth and then the queen will leave the
highlands of Scotland
and we've taught much of her
love for the highlands and
not only the hills but most particularly
the people and the character of those
Scots who live there and have made it
such a vibrant and warm place to be
leaving the highlands for anybody who
loves them is a tough thing to do but
this will be her last departure from the
highlands from which so much of her
family's ancestry have taken their home
and idea of Scotland she will leave it
shortly when she passes by over the day
and away from Perth
well the work of the Royals goes on
let's speak now to our Royal
correspondent Rhianna Mills and the the
new Prince of Wales
um and what has happened it's still
taking some getting used to isn't it
because of course we've known the now
King Charles for so long as as Prince of
Wales and that investiture for him was
such a a moment
um in his raw life but yes the new
Prince of Wales spoke to the first
minister of Wales today so so Prince
William and it's quite rare for us to to
get a readout or a sense of those
conversations they normally
conversations between members of royal
family and political representatives are
normally um kept private however I think
to Mark the fact that this is such an
important moment for the new Prince of
Wales they have released this joint
statement in which they said
um his Royal Highness the Prince of
Wales and the first minister of Wales
spoke by a tele by telephone earlier
today and his Royal Highness thanked the
first Minister for his fitting tribute
on behalf of the people of Wales to her
majesty the queen his Royal Highness
Express his and the princess of wales's
honor of course Kate now the princess
Wales in being asked by his majesty the
queen to serve the Welsh people they
will do so with humility and great
respect he goes on to say the prince
acknowledged his and the princess's deep
affection for Wales having made their
first family home in Anglesey of course
he he served with the air rescue service
there including during the earliest
months of Prince George's life the
prince and princess will spend the
months and years ahead deepening their
relationship with communities across
Wales they want to do their part to
support the aspirations of the Welsh
people and shine a spotlight on both the
challenges and opportunities in front of
them the prince and princess look
forward to celebrating wales's proud
history and traditions as well as a
future that is full of Promise they will
seek to live up to the proud
contribution that members of the royal
family have made in years past
so that readout in terms of the
conversation that was had between the
new Prince of Wales and the first
Minister I think they're alluding to how
much that his father has done over the
years when it comes to cementing that
relationship of course today we are here
in Scotland we are reminded of the
discussions about a United Kingdom the
Queen's fondness for all nations and now
her family are continuing that tradition
and making sure I think that every part
of the United Kingdom feels involved in
this moment so Scotland today of course
will the crowds will be the first they
are the first to see Her Majesty's
coffin and we know that the new King
Charles will subsequently travel here to
Scotland tomorrow he will then move on
to Northern Ireland and the new king
will also travel to Wales at the end of
the week
well Dundee has its own slang we are
told including a roundabout being called
a circle which seems simpler although
that's not quite a circle I think that
they are are going around now the
cortesh there but more details coming
through also about the events of
tomorrow and the fact that the Prime
Minister will be accompanying King
Charles uh on the way to Edinburgh yeah
so this was something that has been
announced in the last 24 hours that that
Liz truss is actually going to be making
the journey that we know that the the
new king is very keen to make to share
this moment of grief with every corner
of the United Kingdom so as I said
Scotland Northern Ireland and then Wales
but I think for some it might be a
slight surprise that prime minister Liz
truss has also decided to make that
Journey with him apparently it's not
something that has to be done from a
constitutional perspective but she has
decided that because this is such a
significant moment of national that she
should be accompanying our new king
of course there will be some people
think well he is traveling to the
different nations to meet other first
ministers
um
but she still wants to be there
alongside him
and once the again the Cortez slowing
down to a walking place
and
I think it's been very important
for the royal family to make sure that
people feel involved
in this moment because
it would be so easy for us to
to get lost in a way in the ceremonial
in the pageantry that we saw yesterday
at the accession council
but I think over what there's been this
overwhelming
kind of sense that the royal family
appreciate this is a moment where
as so often the queen managed to do she
has brought the country together in this
moment of mourning and so this slow
Journey that she's made
she is making through
Scotland
the crowd's able to come out and pay
their respects
and I was down in London yesterday of
course you've got people flocking to
Buckingham Palace monarchy HQ was as
many would describe it but but the fact
that she she died in Scotland a place
that she was so fond of and people here
fond of her
means that
others across the United Kingdom can
can step out of their front doors and
and very easily pay their respects
and there we see that beautiful scene do
we not uh Dundee a city on the Firth of
estri in eastern Scotland the fourth
biggest city in Scotland as the Cortez
continues its Journey down to Edinburgh
let's head now to Buckingham Palace and
Mark Austin
you very much indeed Anna and as the
Queen's coffin makes its way to
Edinburgh here at Buckingham Palace in
the past hour
King Charles III has arrived for
meetings with the Secretary General of
the Commonwealth as well as the high
Commissioners from the countries where
he is now head of state
thousands of people have also been
gathering in the four nations of the
United Kingdom to witness proclamations
of King Charles the Third as the new
monarch he was a formerly proclaimed
King at a ceremony in Saint James's
Palace yesterday and today ceremonies
were held at Cardiff Castle Hillsborough
in Northern Ireland and at Windsor
Castle and also Edinburgh Castle
so much
do you know hereby with one voice
and consent of tongue and heart
publish
and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George
is no
by the death of our late Sovereign happy
of memory
become our only lawful and rightful
leads Lord Charles III
[Music]
fearful it might just be the king amen
everybody
St James a dig red deed already I'm
Louise in herkloid Deweyville are doing
to whom we do acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection
beseeching God
by whom kings and queens do reign
to bless His Majesty with long and happy
years to Reign Over Us
[Music]
thank you
one place
[Music]
so proclamation's continuing then around
this nation and as we continue to watch
these pictures of the Queen's coffin
continuing to make progress towards
Edinburgh let's speak to our
International Affairs editor Dominic
waghorn who is with me here at
Buckingham Palace and these meetings
with the Secretary General of the
Commonwealth for the king and now we
think the heads of various Commonwealth
or high Commissioners are very various
commonwealth countries this significant
meetings because I guess there will be
some countries who maybe see this as an
opportunity for a
a reset of some sort in the relationship
yeah it certainly could be a watershed
moment for the Commonwealth and what
we're seeing at the moment is the sort
of twin track process going on a series
of events north of the border that is
laying or is is heading towards the
laying to rest of the past Monet while
the pneumonic King Charles III is now
getting down to business in Buckingham
Palace he's now already carrying out the
duties of his office and it's uh it's
not coincidental that one of the first
things he has to do is is a commonwealth
two pieces of Commonwealth business he's
got to meet the Secretary of Secretary
General of the Commonwealth who
represents the 56 Nations that form the
Commonwealth he's done that already
meeting baroness uh Scotland the
Secretary General but as you say he's
now meeting the members or the high
commissioners of the Realms of the
Commonwealth and those are the countries
14 countries in addition to Britain who
still recognize him as head of state and
there's a process of attrition going on
in in that number before last year
Barbados applied and became an
independent republic and in the last 24
hours or so in the wake of the Queen's
death the Prime Minister of Antigua and
barbudas said he's going to offer a
referendum for Independence so that
state could become fully independent and
no longer recognize the monikers as head
of state uh Australia said this isn't
the time the Prime Minister Australia's
told Sky News this isn't the time for
Australia to do it but there is there is
a process because the that system
whereby the Monarch is the head of state
for these countries is effectively a
Vestige of Empires so there's a there's
a process there has to be stress mark I
think that this isn't sort of rush to
the exits uh because of the queen dying
under her Reign she began with 32
Nations recognizing her as had a state
in 17 left but I think as he says I
think it's an opportunity that will be
seized on as it has but been already by
the Prime Minister of Antigua and
Barbuda to reset relations and come up
with a new constitutional arrangements
and I think so I think to some extent
they have waited for this moment the end
of Queen Elizabeth's Reign to then seize
the opportunity it may be of course that
uh Charles will see the modernizing of
the monarchy as a way of maybe
preventing some of these countries doing
what they maybe want to do yeah or he
may see it as an actual part of that
process of modernization we seem pretty
relaxed about it in Rwanda at the
Commonwealth heads of government meeting
when he said that individual countries
have the right to choose and it should
happen calmly and without Rancor so he
seems pretty relaxed about the idea I
think he might be privately sad but I
think he will recognized it as part of a
process that has you know been going on
for decades and happened under his his
mother's reign as well yeah he said it
was entirely up to the individual
company so he seems fairly relaxed about
what's happening with the Commonwealth
though he will take it seriously but
important challenges ahead for the king
diplomatically yes and I think it's
important to mention we talked about the
Realms of the Commonwealth but the
Commonwealth itself is in robust Health
56 Nations two and a half billion people
that's a third of the population of the
world uh countries that cover a quarter
of the land mass of the world and it was
decided some time ago he would be the
head of the Commonwealth I'm not sure if
there's a formality required to confirm
that but he will be the head of the
Commonwealth and that cements his
position and Britain's position at the
heart of an organization that is really
important for the projection of soft
power British soft power around the
world something that his mother excelled
at of course
okay Dominic thanks very much indeed
let's bring in uh Simon Morgan a former
Royal Protection Officer
to the queen uh good afternoon Simon
thank you very much for being with us
and these are very moving scenes where
watching with the Queen's coffin moving
slowly through Scotland
good afternoon Mark uh yes they are and
this was always always part of the plan
um should the queen pass away in
Scotland then she would go through
Scotland from Balmoral down to to
Edinburgh not just as a part of a
constitutional role but the fact that
she saw herself very much as a as a
Scottish resident having spent the best
part of a third of each year in Scotland
and when you say well planned this will
be
plan down to the finest detail wouldn't
it
absolutely
um which I'm wishing to you know over
dramatize the situation this has the
potential to be the biggest policing
operation UK policing has ever got
involved in whilst the Bridge's plans
are well known and London Bridge has
been being looked at many times over the
years it's been tabletopped to certain
elements of it have been have been
tested already with regards to events
such as the queen mother's funeral and
indeed the wedding of the now Prince and
princesses of Wales the Purdue
conductions of Cambridge at Westminster
Abbey so all this now is going from a a
plan to reality but it's certainly a
very big policing operation
and on the more personal side Simon give
give us a sense of what the queen was
like to work for
she was a fantastic principal she fully
understood what our role was as
protection officers why why we were
there I had a great Rapport because
without that Rapport you don't get that
element of trust
um because the reality is they need to
trust that you will do your job when
you're required to do so but a great
Principle as much as we were working in
and around her she would often work in
and around us because she was fully
aware of what protection was all about
having had it all her life she knew when
we were uncomfortable with things and
would work around us which is a bizarre
scenario if you think about it but you
know she kind of knew what what we were
doing and why we were there but great
principle tremendous sense of of humor
and someone that you know would engage
you in conversation which you are you
are talking to the monarchy and
certainly when that happens for the
first time
um you do realize actually where you are
and what your day job has just become
I gather you were also close protection
for the corgis
yes very much so um on one particular
trip to to Scotland
um to Balmoral the queen was out on one
of the picnics and as I opened the door
for the queen girl the car she was
telling her guests that
um actually um they also count the
corgis and right on cue one of my
colleagues was counting the corgis um at
the back of the car one two three and
four and she looked at her guest of the
Roswell and said I told you so almost as
if the guest was unbelieving of that
statement so yes we did have
responsibility for the corby's as well
something um that we didn't want
everybody's got their lovely stories
what will be your abiding memory of the
queen
I think someone who is very much a
people person she understood people
um and that is quite a quite a gift to
have
um no she could talk to people at all
levels from from heads of state all the
way to to the ordinary man in the street
and I think that is a particular gift
that not many people have
and of the new king what do you think uh
what sort of King do you think he will
be like
I think he will carry on in his mother's
vein with regards to King Charles it's a
very tried and tested format in so much
as he had a very long apprenticeship
he's seeing what is what has worked and
what hasn't worked during that time I
think he will be very much a man of the
people he will want to look to to meet
people and as is his role as it was when
Prince of Wales he will want to
understand what people are going through
what their anxieties are and and he will
go there and he will talk to people and
He will engage probably even more so
than the queen he was very much somebody
that would go and Shake Hands
um and he would take an interest in in
your issues you know and private
secretaries roughly past past notes back
to you know find out what is going on
with this particular village with this
particular project you know he wanted
updates around those as well so I think
he will carry on in some aspects what
his mother was doing but also he will be
his own man around it as well
one thought does occur to me with that
you know walkabouts and close contact
with the public uh often a nightmare for
police protection officers there could
be many more of them
very much so very much so and yes you
know that is your your pressure point
part of the day when you know senior
member royal family wants to go and meet
the public and Shake Hands certainly I
wasn't enrolled when the the modern
phenomena of the selfie took place but
no that is something now that as
protection officers you you have to
facilitate you're looking into a crowd
for what you expect to see and what you
don't expect to see but again all these
things you as a Protection Officer and a
Protection Team have to make sure that
happens and happens in a in a safe
environment because your principles are
going to want to do this and certainly
King Charles is going to want to carry
on in that vein that we often saw when
he was the prince of Wales
okay Simon Morgan uh thank you very much
for being with us uh this afternoon
appreciate your time thank you
well let's uh go to Edinburgh now our
correspondent Joe Pike is on the Royal
mile Joe
Mark the Royal mile is of course really
a center of tourism in this city partly
because of its a rich history and the
sheer International variety of those
Gathering here ahead of that Cortez
arriving in the city is pretty
astonishing many are here by coincidence
or have amended their holiday plans and
what is wonderful and quite striking is
that
some have I suppose today realize that
history is not just something in the
past but something that is made in the
present and can be witnessed in the
present Saint Charles Cathedral the high
Kirk of Edinburgh this medieval Parish
church is at the heart of a number of
different events over the next day or so
earlier we had the Scottish Proclamation
at Market Cross we had a procession
passed here later the Cortez will come
down the mile towards the Palace of
Hollywood house the official residence
of the queen in Scotland unlike Balmoral
which of course is a private residence
and then tomorrow the king will join
that procession with his mother's hearse
before a service takes place at St Giles
Cathedral a place where John Knox was
once Minister That central figure in the
Scottish Reformation among those present
here today Graham and Laura who have
come from the United States from Georgia
why you are here on the role model well
we actually retired in April and we've
been traveling nomadically my mother is
originally from Edinburgh so we're here
to just maybe look up some family ties
and a little family history
and you're also going to witness history
in this country today right
unfortunately yes yes it's not something
that we ever expected no we wanted to be
here for his mom since she can't be here
since she's still in the states and like
he said she's 97 so and you think it's
important to see this I think so
absolutely it's a very important piece
of history and that's
it's nice to be part of it but it's sad
to be part of it at the same time
Grandma who traveled from Georgia thank
you for joining us on Sky News I think
it's also perhaps worth reflecting a
mark how the the queen changed and
adapted her constitutional role north of
the Border as this country uh changed of
course especially in the last 25 years
with Devolution with the start of the
Scottish Parliament with this new role
of first Minister she has had to adapt
and change she was determined to be at
the heart of the ceremony to open or
some argue reconvene that parliament in
1999 specially commissioning a Scottish
designer to create a a thistle themed
outfit a green silk dress a purple coat
Her speech and the presentation of a
ceremonial mate was at the heart of that
ceremony but also as the years
progressed the Constitutional question
of Scotland's future potentially of
Independence has also been discussed
although it's perhaps worth pointing out
that under the most recent proposals the
ma would remain the head of state a bit
like Canada or Australia certainly King
Charles is aware of all these
institutions and personalities he was
present last October at holyrood in the
Scottish parliament in a Highland dress
and a face mask because of the pandemic
to witness the start of the sixth
session of the Scottish Parliament and
he will be here at tomorrow walking
behind his mother's hearse ahead of that
service in Saint Giles before that in
the next hour that Cortez that has been
traveling down from Balmoral will reach
the Royal mile coming past the castle
and then down to Hollywood house and to
the Scottish Parliament
Joe Pike thank you very much indeed
keeping us abreast of the situation
there at St John's Cathedral which will
play such a central role to the events
of the next couple of days as we watch
the Cortez now on the A90 in perthshire
heading towards Perth but not going into
Perth as it makes its way towards
Edinburgh and alongside me now are royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills and uh due
to arrive around four o'clock we think
in Edinburgh yes making the most
incredible journey around
175 miles
due to take
about 5 hours 50 minutes we're told
depending on on the size of the crowds
and as you're reflecting the likes of
Dundee people have come out and even
here along the main roads people are
stopping getting out of their cars to
pay their respects
I think for so many this has all
happened so fast and
as when we lose anyone that we feel fond
of I think the moment that it really
hits home often is is when when you see
the coffin
and it was such a poignant moment
in the the Tranquility the peace the
seclusion of Balmoral when we first of
all saw
the Queen's coffin being being driven
away from
from a home that she loved so much from
a place that she was able to get away
from it all you were there in Balmoral
the other day and and I think only if
you travel up there do you get a sense
of help why that place would be so
important for the Royal Family
tucked away amongst the the trees and
and the hills they could they could
really Escape
um enjoy barbecues together
a queen could enjoy her horses and and
we were reflecting on this earlier how
they they are so much seen as part of
that that Community they are so loved
and respected and
really local people felt that she was
one of their own and that might sound
slightly strange when you when you think
about her dressed up in her finery and
carrying out her constitutional duties
but for so many people who lived in
Balmoral they would see her out on a
horse they would see her in that Tweed
skirt in the cardigan and the head scarf
which of course is is what we saw her
dressed in only on Tuesday it's less
than a week
since she carried out that important
constitutional role
here in Scotland of the Handover of
power from one prime minister to the
next
and on that day
people reflecting on the fact that in
some ways the queen yes those
arrangements had to be changed because
she wasn't able to travel down to London
but in the way the queen probably would
have enjoyed it the fact that she was
appointing
the prime minister of the United Kingdom
here in Scotland and of course there is
still so much debate at the moment about
Scotland potentially wanting
Independence
um
the queen of course a woman who many
said very rarely put a foot wrong
we very rarely knew how she felt but
there of course was that one moment
outside crafty Church where she would go
and worship every Sunday during the
run-up of the independence referendum
where she did apparently say to crowds I
hope people think carefully before they
vote and that was seen as probably a
very rare intervention from the queen
David Cameron saying that she she uh
raised an eyebrow and well he raised an
eyebrows and heard at the result in the
end but here we are people standing on
bridges on grassy banks on verges in
laybys central reservation too in fact
as a as we watch now
but as we look ahead to the events of
the next couple of days and certainly
here in the Edinburgh amongst the more
poignant moments again that we can
anticipate is the Queen's four children
walking behind this coffin from the
palace here and up to Saint Charles
Cathedral and we know that the main
lying in state will be in London but
here the queen will be at rest in that
Cathedral and for the first time people
will be able to go
in a place of worship and pay their
respects to her
you can tell over the last few days how
important it is for the royal family
that
people across the United Kingdom feel
they can share in this this moment of of
mourning grief
if they want to
and yesterday as a briefing we were told
that yes for the new King Charles
State business has to continue he's
immediately taken on those
constitutional responsibilities but for
him his primary focus is making sure
that he is the one who is leading this
country the world when it comes to that
sense of mourning that he is getting out
and sharing in that grief
a grief that he feels
so deeply despite the fact that we know
over the coming days and we already saw
it yesterday with the accession council
there is all of the ceremony and what
may be seen as the celebration of his
role as as a new monarch but also of
course and as we saw with his mother the
family have a very important role in
supporting him
and we saw that yesterday didn't we with
the new Prince and Princess of Wales
inviting the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
to carry out a walkabout at Windsor to
see the piles of flowers that have
already been left and to spend 45
minutes talking to people which was was
quite incredible also the king himself
wanting to do another Walkabout
yesterday at Clarence House and also
other members of the family shedding
tears as they saw saw flowers that had
been left near to Balmoral
you can only imagine how the family are
feeling and it does make me reflect back
on on when we
when they said goodbye to the Duke of
Edinburgh
they're a family who at times may be
depicted as having that stiff upper lip
and that distinctly wobbled around the
death of Prince Philip and in a similar
way we've already seen with the tributes
that they are paying to the queen
the terms that they're describing her in
So Yesterday Prince William calling her
granny
um the king in his message talking about
his mama
ultimately she was a mother
and a grandmother to them as much as
being
that incredible and unique head of state
well we're seeing the uh the end of the
first of Tay here they will eventually
cross the river Tay just short of Perth
in fact and head due south towards
Edinburgh but lots of cars as you say
pulled over how would you feel if you're
on the other side of the road and you
see this passing it's it really is you
know quite an extraordinary moment this
is it not and and how much of what we're
seeing in terms of what the royal family
are doing now specifically I suppose
King Charles about the securing the
future of the monarchy because
70 years you know everybody knew
that everybody adored the queen but the
future you know it does look different
doesn't it
it does and and as I was talking about
that that sense of connecting with the
public and meeting people look I do
think it is spontaneous I've spent a lot
of time following members of the royal
family around on engagements on overseas
tours and
and they have got this remarkable
ability to to put people at ease to
literally walk up to any crowd and start
a conversation they know that their
presence matters
but
these these kind of ways that they're
they're meeting people they're looking
at the flowers They're they're allowing
this to happen here the fact that they
want the queen to be seen
I think again is that that reflection of
wanting to make sure that this is a an
institution that feels in touch and and
I think that stood out yesterday
these events have been decades in the
planning and many of us have been given
an Insight previously into these plans
yesterday we thought was all going to be
about the accession council
first time that cameras were allowed in
the moment that the King was proclaimed
from a constitutional perspective highly
highly significant however the pictures
that in the end everyone ends up talking
about or actually
cambridges and the sussexes walking side
by side
the cottage is crossing the river tea
Alastair
and with that crossing the queen has
left the highlands of Scotland
and she now heads into the journey due
south but I think with the highlands
behind her
it is symbolic of so much of what
Rihanna was talking about her love of
the Highlands and that part of her life
which was always restored by Balmoral
but
we see the queen has now left the
highlands of Scotland
and heads for Attenborough
well once again as you can see once
again as you can see the bridges are
crowded
people glimpsing of you from wherever
they can
the difficulty now these are a roads
motorways it's hard to find places to
stop but the cars are parked up
the verges are full the lay-bys too
as the Queen's Cortez heads South
the journey into Edinburgh
will skirt around the castle and into
the Royal mile as it makes its way down
to the Palace of Hollywood house and Joe
Pike is on the Royal malware Joe
yeah and in the next hour or so we
should see that Cortez passing is here
the crowds are really Gathering very
International uh in in flavor uh among
them Terry and Cheryl who are here from
California tell us why you've decided to
come to the Royal mile today
well we had a trip planned here for over
three years that got canceled we finally
made it here we happened to be on the
Britannia having high tea the Royal
yacht which is a docked at least on the
edge of the city yes we were having tea
looking at the Queen's family photos
that she chose to display on the art
when we heard about the Queen's illness
and by the time we disembarked from the
yacht we heard that she had passed
and show you you then decided to change
your holiday plans yes well we were we
were here in Edinburgh staying um right
down the street and we realized quickly
that many of the things that we wanted
to do were going to be canceled because
of the Queen's death and so we decided
well why don't we just stay here and and
look at all the ceremony and all the
different things that are happening
because we wanted to be a part of this
everything else took a back seat to our
plants took a back seat and we're so
happy to be part of this yes and how do
you feel about what you're about to see
it's amazing it's amazing you can't
really put it in words it's just you're
part of the scene but and we feel the
sorrow is tangible in the air from the
people
and we feel it as well yes we're big
fans of the royal family and everything
family I watch every show I subscribe to
BBC so I can see everything about I love
the royal family and we're so proud and
happy that we're here at this moment to
be part of it with all of you yeah
Terry and Cheryl thank you so much for
joining us on Sky News there won't be
that much longer for this crowd to wait
we expect the Cortez to arrive in the
city at around half past three and get
to the Palace of Hollywood house the
official home of the Monarch in Scotland
at four of course Balmoral in contrast
is a private Residence at the center of
the mile with the castle at one end the
palace at the other is Saint Giles
Cathedral the high Kirk of Edinburgh
this medieval Parish Church which has
been adapted added to a change over the
years it will be at the center of a lot
of what we see in the next 24 hours not
just the courtage passing today but
tomorrow when King Charles joins the
hearse containing his mother's coffin
that will be brought here a serviceable
take place and there will be that
24-hour video allowing the people of
Scotland and of course the visitors to
this city to pay their respects
yeah so that's my kind of official but I
am a privy councilor but I wasn't part
of the accession council so
well I'm joined now by the former leader
of the Scottish conservatives uh
baroness Ruth Davidson who joins me now
here amazing scenes there as as the
Cortez heads over the river Tay leaves
Perth the overalls of Perth behind and
and head south people are grabbing
whatever spot they can right now you
know it's been lovely and as somebody
who's spent you know a lifetime versus a
journalist and then as a politician
crisscrossing Scotland and knowing all
of these roads intimately I was chatting
someone they were asking questions oh
that looks like the start of the
Kingsway and Dundee uh and and you know
to see the people that have come out in
their hundreds and their thousands both
in ballater and brecon and Dundee and
and the outskirts of Perth and we'll
come down
through canross to get to the Queensbury
Crossing and into Edinburgh through Fife
as well uh you know it's been lovely and
to see people have taken their horses to
the side of the road to watch it because
she was such a fan of that those
aberdeenshire Farmers that took their
tractors out to line The Roots sure was
a real sense of people wanting to do
their bits for somebody that did so much
for so long absolutely and then here
obviously the ceremonials begin to we
were just discussing the cortesh coming
down the Royal mile to the building
behind us which is you know this the
seat of the of the monarchy in Scotland
if I can put it like that the Palace of
uh presumably you've you've been in
there yourself every year yes and indeed
it's the smallest of all the Royal
palaces and it's the official residence
of the Monarch in Scotland Balmoral is a
private State that's where she goes for
arrest and recuperation it's her
downtime it's where she enjoys
holidaying and sort of recharging the
batteries down the years this is where
the business took place and and you know
20 odd years ago um there was a a new
neighbor that was put up which is the
parliament right across the road 50
yards away and she's always been a very
hospitable neighbor to politicians
within the devolved government and
within the doll Parliament and when
she's been down to to open and do the
state openings of parliament uh we've
always been invited across the road
after to speak in a more relaxed and a
more private uh arena with her uh and
you know she's always taken a great
interest in the political life of
Scotland not the people that shout at
each other within the parliament but
with how the work that we were doing
affected the people of Scotland and that
was what she was interested in
and we can see the Royal car following
the Queen's coffin there accompanying
her on this journey the Princess Royal
and her husband as well how important is
it do you think that members of the
royal family you know stay close and
we're going to see you this week aren't
we how close they will be as they
accompany their mother well indeed we
often associate the Princess Royal with
Scotland you know she's a patron of a
number of Scottish Charities we kind of
think of her as ours out the Royals uh
you know she's the the patron of the SRU
the Scottish rugby and she goes to all
the games she's involved intimately with
a number of of organizations up here and
spent a lot of time up here her daughter
also was married just a few hundred
yards from where we are at the Canon
gate Kirk
um and I think it is important that we
see not just the Monarch herself but
also that she was a mother and a
grandmother and a great grandmother and
we've seen it so much and tomorrow as we
see the coffin being moved from the
Palace of Hollywood house up the Royal
mile for the lying in at St Giles which
is the the cathedral for Scotland the
the main Cathedral here Charles will be
part of that as the new king as the
Elder son as well and not just within
His official title but within his family
Title II and you will see a lot of
people line that route I I imagine a lot
of Scots will want to come out and make
sure it's done right because when it
comes to a funeral you want to make sure
things are done right
and her full children will follow the
Cortez the coffin as it makes its way up
the hill to Saint Giles as you say it
will be a really poignant moment but
beyond that there are questions too
aren't there about what happens to
Scotland those questions of Independence
how important is this
you know for unionism effectively
do you know it's a funny one um I think
you could speak to a thousand Scots from
each side of the divide and they would
tell you there is absolutely a time and
a place to discuss the future of
Scotland within the United Kingdom and
this is not the time and this is not the
place and people have put aside any
competition or enmity
um everybody wants to make sure that
this woman who's given so much uh is is
shown out the right way that we do it
right here and and there has been as
you've seen no enmity on other side
we've seen uh the
s p first minister of Scotland taking
her own part in the accession council in
terms of ushering in the new King You've
seen opposition leaders here in Scotland
making sure that they are conducting
themselves in exactly the way in which
we shoot and uh I think possibly it it's
the only political question that's being
asked right now and people in Scotland
don't want to ask right now because they
want to do the same as everybody else
across the rest of the United Kingdom
and say goodbye to a woman who performed
just a mighty service
and what is your tribute to her and the
work she did do you know I think
it's hard to quantify somebody that's
always been there and I think what this
week has shown
is that this is a an enormous period of
history and you can you can watch the
television and you see the history
happening but almost everybody that I've
spoken to
has found it really personal and been
surprised by the emotion of it
um because she's such a good woman
because everything that we've seen about
her service and her Duty and all the
things that we talk about her humor her
ability to put people at their ease her
ability to reach out to people
um it's it's you know it's just so
thoroughly kind of
wholesome um but it's also reminded
people of the fact that it's been a
tough few years that we've all lost
people and this National morning
has reopened for many people a lot of
wounds in their own personal life and
their own personal morning and
I I think the way I would sum up this
week is that
it's brought out the best of us in the
saddest of times
we've Davidson we much appreciate you
joining us here thank you very much
indeed
Alistair
come on
watching the hearse now making its way a
little further south towards Edinburgh
and
skirting around by the town of drone
and heading down towards Ken Ross
this is one of the main arterial roads
of the east coast of Scotland
and it will deliver
the queen and this procession to
enormous crowds as they wait on Bridges
or stop cars on the way
and
the chance for anyone who wishes to as
the queen is carried towards the capital
city of Edinburgh
a chance to stop and look and take part
in this moment and many of the people
who
are reporters have spoken to along this
route
have
had a chance to say why they came what
the queen meant to them
the fact of her constancy and presence
in National and world life
the number of presidents she met in the
United States for that lady who was on
board the Yacht for instance and was
there
having tea just as the queen when she
was on board the yacht would have had
tea every day at five o'clock
and heard that the queen was unwell and
it led of course to the Queen's demise
and
she changed her holiday plans everybody
deals with news of this gravity
to the life of somebody who has served
and become known around the world in
different ways
one of the roles of the crown is to as I
often feel
is sometimes to give people
an institution about which they can
complain or be angry or
or is that to Earth
the sentiments of Anguish in a nation
the queen certainly did that after the
death of Diana Princess of Wales
and
Managed IT
with the eloquence and care of somebody
who I think always knew the national
mood
better than most of those who advised
her
but her turn is over and the King
will take on that responsibility having
watched so much as the
Alice now
thank you
Gemma add some
[Applause]
so back to Buckingham Palace then let's
just take a look at the pictures there
looks like the queen consort is waving
to the crowds the thousands of people
who have come to pay their respects she
of course is accompanied her husband
King Charles III on many already of the
occasions that we have seen him the
Walkabout first of all the accession
council too but returning it appears to
Buckingham Palace as you can see
and the crowds are cheering
applauding the flags waving too
as Camilla Queen consort arrives back
well let's remind ourselves of pictures
from a little earlier today farmers in
aberdeenshire lined their tractors along
the road as a mark of respect as the
Queen's coffin made its way
along the road
one of those who joined in with her
family Grace Noble who joined those
aberdeenshire Farmers as you can see
almost 50 tractors lined up together
in a guard of Honor for the Queen's
Cortez
well I'm pleased to say that Grace Noble
joins me now owner of aberdeenshire
Highland cattle and Grace
um everybody all the politicians I've
spoken to today have picked up on on
your idea to line the tractors up who
came up with the idea and and why did
you think of it yeah it wasn't actually
myself that came up with idea it was one
of my farming neighbors Rodney Blackpool
um who came up with the idea and rallied
around to all the neighboring farming
Community uh to come along
um we all attended a park on the route
um which was parented by Alan Beaton or
Phillies estate and that's where
um all the families congregated with
their tractors to Mark's respects to a
very special lady
and how did you feel when the Cortez
passed
um it was a very um important to be a
part
um and
um it really brought the mood and the
feeling for the whole community and the
whole country and in particular Royal
decide and living here we've got very
strong connections with the royal family
and and what they bring to the community
um and the economy as well
um here so it was very important to um
pay tribute to
um the queen and our service and the
family at this time
and she used to of course spend so much
time walking in the Hills the fields
enjoying the river D
um were you amongst those people that
you know caught a glimpse of her every
now and then as she enjoyed her her
summer break in Balmoral
um well I don't actually
um catch a glimpse of her but I've seen
the farmer of Highland cattle um I have
done business with her in the past and
buying cattle from her Highland cattle
every year
um from her estate models so we
certainly have a connection there and um
and and covert times as well we um had
the address from the Duke of Rossi who
invited myself
um to Burke hall for morning coffee
um which was um of your Boost um to
people like themselves and other
producers that he also invited
um when we're going through challenging
times so it just shows how supporting
they are and whatever we they can and to
to farming and business in the region
which is just shows
um you know it's just remarkable
foreign
and give your tribute now while we have
you on you know how would you like to
remember her majesty
really fondly
um you know our women that were very
passionate about Scotland
um and um the rural community
um you could clearly see that as our
passion and you know horses and the
countryside and the rural uh living
um which I think is lovely to think that
was such a privilege and what she
enjoyed uh being up here and choosing to
spend her her annual holidays here in
Scotland and it's just really lovely and
to feel connected and I also fondly
remember
um when she used to sail and the Royal
York Britannia and I grew up on the Isle
of Wrath Phoenix Style with sky so we
were used to seeing the Royal yacht uh
Britannia pass by
um our Islands
um in the in our summer holidays and
thinking wow how special it was that
she'd choose she chose to to come up to
Scotland for her holidays with her
family and make special memories for
herself and her family
absolutely yes none of the uh the
foreign holidays or the Caribbean island
beloved by her sister for her it was
certainly
it was set for me
um a British holiday that she much
preferred was it not Grace Noble owner
of aberdeenshire Highland cattle one of
those uh Farmers almost 50 tractors who
lined up together facing the road on the
side of the fields there as the Queen's
Cottage passed
let's head now to Mark Austin
and I thank you very much indeed and
wonderful stories emerging of farmers
lining up their tractors all sorts of
people coming out to all ages I'm joined
Now by The Raw press secretary former
Royal press secretary Patrick Harrison
and Patrick these have been just
wonderful images fantastic images and
another very poignant day Mark I I think
the moment when we saw the Queen's
coffin for the first time this morning
was another of those uh incredibly
emotional moments that we've had over
the past few days and will continue to
have yeah and the people there on the
flyovers it just shows the affection in
which she was held absolutely
um and you know it really important that
everybody has an opportunity to express
that emotion and to and to reflect on on
a wonderful Reign where she was quite
simply our Guiding Light for Generations
and all the planning that has taken
place that'll be all done will it I mean
you've worked for 14 years inside these
palaces down to the finest Detail no
doubt give us a sense of what of the
kind of planning I mean it's years years
of planning and meticulous planning uh
these 10 days uh it's the balance of
ceremonial but also personal and public
and getting that balance right I
remember working on the plans gosh you
know 10 20 years ago and they would have
evolved over time and I I think we've
seen in the proclamations today as well
the ceremonial aspect but also an
opportunity for people in Cardiff and
Belfast in Edinburgh to be part of this
as well and of course crowds here at
Buckingham Palace and at Windsor Castle
laying flowers so lots of different
moments of interaction for the public
which is an important part of this
and you worked for the then Prince of
Wales now King Charles for quite some
some time just give us a sense of what
it was like to work for him but I've
never worked for a more committed and
dedicated and hard-working human being
uh very very passionate very very
committed as we know to his causes and
his initiatives but also a great sense
of public duty he has already served 50
years in public life and he takes that
sense of public duty with him
um but I I think also a compassionate
side to him as well I witness when we
did things behind away from the cameras
so visits to Children's hospices or
visiting the injured and and that sort
of thing where the compassionate side of
his personality came through and I think
we'll see that more in this unifying
role as king
yes and we just saw um a few moments ago
ago Camilla leaving Buckingham Palace
and I think going to Clarence House we
don't have a picture as well I think of
um
King Charles on his way from Clarence
House to Buckingham Palace to meet
Commonwealth leaders and high
Commissioners from the Commonwealth he
is straight down to business absolutely
and when we saw that uh with uh the
first uh time that he received the Prime
Minister and now of course uh these
these meetings as well and that is a key
part of these 10 days as well these
first uh crucial meetings and uh you
know the fact that he's meeting the high
Commissioners today shows the importance
of that relationship
and times change you know it was clear
and quite interesting that the queen
didn't do interviews she never gave
interviews you were worked on the Press
side for a long time so
do you expect
the king to give interviews as Monarch
he's obviously given several as the
Prince of Wales do you expect him to
give interviews as the Monarch well I I
wouldn't rule that out
um but the focus at the moment is on
these first 10 days and of course we've
already seen that Personal Touch in that
very heartfelt address that he gave
um which was was absolutely the man I
knew and very much a speech that he
would have written himself and again got
that wonderful balance between public
tribute to not only his mother but other
members of the family and then that
re-commitment to public service but yes
and we saw the Walkabout that he did
here on that on that first day as well
so I think we will see Perhaps Perhaps a
little bit more of that Personal Touch
uh come through as he's king
um but as I say the focus at the moment
is leading the nation in remembrance of
the late Queen over these 10 days and
many people would say at the moment
you know he hasn't hasn't really put a
foot wrong absolutely uh you know many
people have said Pitch Perfect and I
would absolutely agree with that um it's
it's a grueling schedule and there's a
lot that's going on over the next 10
days for both here man the queen consort
yes um but so far I think they've done
brilliantly it is a grueling schedule
off to
Scotland clearly tomorrow and then
Northern Ireland subsequently Wales and
um it is a very busy schedule you say
that he will have learned from his
mother and of course he will he had many
many years uh watching and listening and
um looking at how she did the job
um but it will inevitably be a different
style and a different monarchy
I believe me a little bit different
because he's a different personality
um but there will be an awful lot that
is the same as well you know that sense
of public duty which uh he not only
inherited from his mother but he's been
around it all his life and as I say he
has spent already 50 years
in public service and don't forget he's
going to be doing quite a lot of those
uh
head of state roles when the queen was
still alive so investitures State
opening of parliament Commonwealth heads
of government in Rwanda so he's already
done quite a lot of those roles already
slimmed down monarchy that will happen
do you think I mean well it is it is
happening yeah yeah that is something
that he would want I think that's
something that will be considered um but
I think that's that's that's in the to
do to do on the to-do list for a bit
further on beyond the Beyond these
initial days from a press secretary
point of view there's uh pictures
yesterday of William and Harry coming
out together
um was that a good idea do you think
yeah I do I think it was fantastic and I
think the king set the tone there by uh
referencing his love for both his sons
in that address and I think that was
very deliberate and I think it was
fantastic to see both of them with their
wives doing that uh Walkabout of Windsor
yesterday you know this is a moment to
come together
the king is leading the nation in
mourning leading the nation in
remembering the late Queen and he talked
about the family of Nations he's leading
the family of Nations but he's also
leading his own family as well
Patrick thank you very much indeed let's
go back up to Scotland and join Anna
yes we are watching the funeral Cottage
uh make its way towards the Scottish
Capital Edinburgh
not much longer to go in fact for that
and uh though crowds already gathered on
the Royal mile they were there earlier
today too for the proclamation of King
Charles the Third and certainly they
will be waiting to see the Queen's
Cortez
around Edinburgh Castle down the Royal
mile arriving here at the palace of
Hollywood house
well let's bring in now the very
reverent Dr Laura Hood former moderator
of the general assembly of the Church of
Scotland and former chaplain to to the
queen and these are important moments so
they're not history being made time for
people to pay their respects and their
own tributes to her majesty the queen
yes absolutely I mean the streets are
just absolutely line there I did text
message from my son and my daughter once
in Aberdeen one's in Dundee and they
were already going out and they said the
place is just mob around about here and
people just just waiting and watching
and it is it's history it's his face on
its way
well it really is isn't it and it's
something we've not witnessed uh for for
decades and decades and most people
alive in this country will not have
remembered an occasion like this
but let's talk about the Queen's faith
we know it was sincerely held and uh and
very strong and how will she feel now do
you think or or how would she have felt
about you know the moment of her passing
what what would her thoughts have been
at this point
I think she would be very humbled at all
the people who are who are out there who
are there to see her going past to see
her remains going past and because of a
Christian faith saying she would have
that knowledge that understanding that
she was going home uh very much going
home into the the arms of a loving
father who's been with her all her life
because her faith was very much part of
her DNA it's difficult to separate her
faith and the queen they're one in the
same thing
um there's a lovely prayer that's been
put up and the the Church of Scotland
website and resources and it says that
in your life she shaped her life under
your sovereignty she fashioned her reign
in your loving heart she found wisdom
and peace and I think that sums it up
that was The Guiding Spirit of her life
The Guiding spirit that gave her that
straight thought compassion
and that assurance that what she was
doing that she was creating not because
of some constitutional way but she was
Queen by the grace of God
well the present the current moderator
of the general assembly of the Church of
Scotland the right Reverend Dr Ian
greenshields was invited to stay with
the queen at Balmoral Castle only last
weekend after being invited to to hold a
sermon at the church where her her
majesty worshiped while in Scotland he
said that he asked her what her favorite
hymn was over lunch but she refused to
say and instead told him if I told you
that then that would be the hymn that
everybody would think they had to have
at a service and then she just smiled
and never divulged it
and he said that even at that time she
was reflecting on the Afterlife with him
and his and was in quite a contemplative
state
yes I mean when you get to 96 I think
that that does they tend to focus your
mind a little bit
um because in 96 you would be thinking
of all that she had accomplished and and
all that she had done and and working up
and until the end and working up until
the end because she didn't look on it as
a job but she took up at a certain time
and then retired from and laid down she
took it as something she had been called
upon to do and it wasn't hers she'd been
given that it wasn't hers to lay down it
would only be laying down when she was
called home to a Heavenly Father
and that was that's one of the joys of
um moderators and there's ministers in
the Church of Scotland Royal chaplains
that you are invited to Memorial and you
spend the weekend with the queen and the
royal family who are there at that time
so you get that intimate detail and and
the the discussions that you have with
the very intimate discussions and you
realize that her faith was so so much
part of of her life it was her life and
it was part of that DNA of our makeup
and her humor was clear to see too he
also revealed she would make jokes and
recalled it was funny I was staying in
what was called the tower suite and what
did the queen say to me that she was
sending me to the tower so she was still
very much finding that sense of humor
which no doubt you saw when you were
trapped in to her what what are your you
know Fondest Memories if I can call them
that of the queen
yes and the humor um side of things I
was being driven by the queen to uh to
the barbecue faith in one of the Lord
Jesus and uh so so there you are and
first of all you're thinking I'm sitting
in this London and the queen is is
driving me so she had just got a new car
so we were driving these very dark roads
um up to to the barbecue and let's just
say that the queen she didn't dawdle
when she was driving uh so we're going
through and suddenly
a deer came out of of the bushes in
front of us and she she very quickly
breaks 12 Etc
um and I said oh well done mum and she
said yes it wouldn't do to have the
moderating in a ditch wouldn't it
[Laughter]
oh that's not you're not the first
person to say that she drove quickly I
guess
and in another occasion I have been
speaking at a big Guild event before I
was up at War Memorial and um I'd made
some comment shall I say about
um a possession of women in the church
and sometimes how that wasn't accepted
by by various people and it made the
Sunday papers the next morning so when I
we came back in from church and she's
she was flicking through the papers I
think in purpose and she just turned on
and she said making the Sundays I see
moderator
and I say yes
and then later on we discussed it she
was very very supportive of what I've
been seeing Etc but uh yeah still just
told that that twinkling or I that sense
of very very quick with it humor I'm
very often seeing her and Prince Philip
riding with her alone the humor was was
um yeah it was a privilege to be to be
there and to witness it
from what you're saying you know they
made the experience fun for you didn't
they but uh returning to what King
Charles said in his National address
um as we looked at the moment when she
arrives in Edinburgh and he said I know
that her death brings great sadness to
so many of you and I share that sense of
loss beyond measure with you all in a
little over a week's time we will come
together as a nation as a commonwealth
and indeed a global Community to lay my
beloved mother to rest in our sorrow he
said let us remember and draw strength
from the light of her example what for
you was that example that she said
foreign
that sense of
realization that she she was there for a
purpose that she'd been called by God
but alongside that her her example her
compassion her forgiveness were also
very much there but just the simple fact
that she she realized who she was she
realized whom she was serving uh and and
she did it to the very very best of her
ability you know 96 and still still
carrying out her duties and carrying
them out with a with a smile and a
another moderator emailed me just a very
short time ago and he was a past
moderator Lord Wallace in fact and he
said
um he'd been there a couple weeks ago
and although she was frail her brain was
still razor sharp and she was still so
interested in what was happening what
was happening in the court uh what was
happening in in the country at large but
just just told it she was like the face
that the faith that she proclaimed and
the faith that she lived out because it
wasn't just in words it was what she was
and and that would always remain with me
well I think it was Queen Mary who said
uh we are Royals we never get tired and
we love hospitals did you ever see any
sign of uh of tiredness or or was it
like you know the Duke of Edinburgh you
know packing the day and living life to
the full as people describe
um
weird of many times when she showed that
she was bored with anything or I mean it
must have been if you think about it one
of the things I said to people this
morning and imagine every weekend you go
your holidays but every weekend you'll
get guests and you never have that kind
of time off one of the ladies and
waiting taught me that when she had gone
to
um United States to New York after 9 11
and it was to to pay tribute to the
British people who had who had lost
their lives in that setting and she said
she was only supposed to be there for a
certain amount of time because the
weather was so so hot it was so so humid
but she was just determined that there
was absolutely no way that she wasn't
spending the time and she spent much
longer than she should have done because
she wanted to show that that she cared
and she accepted the Heats and
everything else and everyone else was
flagging around about her she was
counting on because it meant so much and
she had that ability when she was
speaking to someone to make them feel
that that they were important and they
were important in her life
well determined uh Resolute steadfast
and carrying on as you said uh very
Reverend Dr lauderhood thank you very
much indeed for for joining us as we see
the Queens Ferry Crossing there in the
distance Alistair
yes and the queen is coming close now to
leaving the kingdom of Fife and to the
right of her Cortes at the moment is the
city of dunfermline
where dun Furman Abbey the resting place
of King Robert the Brewster and Abby
founded by a famous
Scottish Queen called Saint Margaret who
was an English princess who married the
king of Scots
and we passed a little earlier the
Loch leaving where a very unhappy Queen
of Scots Mary Queen of Scots was kept
prisoner and
it has been through that history of
Scotland that the queen has been passing
as she approaches now
the Queen's Ferry Crossing and
the Queens Ferry Crossing is where Saint
Margaret
used to have the
boat that crossed to get her from one
side to the other
and it was opened by the queen not all
that long ago
and it is one of the three great
Crossings of the Firth of fourth
and once Her Majesty crosses from the
kingdom of Fife it's a short distance
then to her capital city
of Edinburgh
and you see the great rail bridge on the
left and the endless view that it's a
bridge that once you finish painting it
you have to start again
and then in the middle the first of the
road Bridges
which the queen opened at an early point
of her reign and with the pressure
of the requirements of traffic
the great Queens Ferry Crossing which
Her Majesty will be conveyed across
shortly
and as we go in to see that moment
we know that she's being followed in the
car behind by the Princess Royal
and she is accompanied by her husband
said Tim Lawrence we saw a photograph of
the Princess Royal as she left Balmoral
earlier today with the queen at the
start of this journey
and in that photograph
we saw
the face of a daughter
who
was accompanying her mother on this
journey
and Crossing that
amazing bridge now
again traffic
stopping people Gathering to watch this
moment and on the bridge perhaps to
people witnessing as she crosses away
from the kingdom of Fife
the traffic on the bridge on the
Northerly Lane pretty much at a
standstill to witness the queen dominate
the southbound Avenues
and in the background
the Royal dockyard of recite
and looking into
the first as it winds its way up into
the heart of Scotland
it's great wide Firth of water
bringing us now to the Central Valley
of Scotland which at this end is
dominated by the capital city of
Edinburgh
and also a little further out to see
from this Great Bridge
is where the Royal yacht Britannia
has been
tied up alongside in Leith so many
memories that the queen had the Royal
Britannia was designed and planned in
the reign of her father King George VI
to replace the Royal yacht that the
queen would remembered as a child and
used Before the War which was the
Victoria and Albert number three
but sadly the king died and it was for
the queen and Prince Philip to design
the Royal yacht Britannia
nobody knew what it was going to be
called and when she
gave it its name
as it's launching
over on the other side of Scotland
and Clyde Bank it was a great cheer when
she said I name this ship Britannia
and God bless all who sail in her and
the Queen and Prince Philip traveled
across the world she is the most
traveled of monarchs in our history
but perhaps no surprise after 70 years
as our Queen
but once asked about the Royal yacht and
its decommissioning she said if she had
a choice she'd love to
just have it driven into a beach
and live on it
as just herself and not as Queen perhaps
for the rest of her life she loved it so
much
one of the Great
ships to be built in Scotland and still
one of the most beautiful
the crowd's really forming here on these
Crossings and
following the journey
into Edinburgh itself
there's a point here where the roads
will divide
and the Queens
Journey will then follow towards
Edinburgh specifically
but look at the traffic on the other
sides
if it's moving it's crawling as the
awareness of this cortage has passed
around and people seeing the blue
flashing lights of the outriders at the
head of the procession
will alert people
the late Queen is coming
the queen came to Edinburgh in 1953 soon
after she was crimed and instant Giles
High Kirk where she will lie in state
from tomorrow
she was presented the honor 3 of
Scotland which were the crown the
scepter and the sword as we've
temporarily lost pictures it might be
interesting to see where they're waiting
now for the Queen's Court age to arrive
but she was presented the crown and
took it from the
Duke of Hamilton at the time
and it was quite heavy and it was
interesting if you see the film how she
almost had to struggle to hold it
this young 26 year old woman as she then
was who'd recently been crowned queen of
the United Kingdom
it'll be a bit of time before the queen
arrives at this spot
but clearly we just lost the shots there
from the
helicopter but
returning to it now it's perhaps worth
remembering that the queen is being
accompanied on this journey by her
daughter the Princess Royal
and we have a photograph of her Royal
Highness and
sir Tim Lawrence who were seen as they
left Balmoral on that
very
somber Journey
a daughter accompanying her mother from
the home of their family in the
highlands
and she's still in the car immediately
behind the queen
as that cortage approaches the capital
city
and the Palace of Hollywood house
crossing the cram and brig
there's a special tradition that goes
back to one of the early King James's of
Scotland who like to walk amongst his
people
unrecognized but he fell amongst
brigands who beat him up and a farmer
heard that somebody was in distress and
came and chased off the brigands had no
idea that it was his King
and washed the king's wounds
still not knowing who this person was
the farmer was asked what he Most Wanted
and he said he'd love to own the farm
where he was working
and the man said well why don't you come
and visit me I'm going to be
at the palace in Edinburgh
and so
the family went down and they went in
and they had asked how will we recognize
you
and he said oh well you'll see me
because I'm
going to be wearing a hat
when they arrived they were told only
the king wears a hat and they went in
and they met the king
and the King
gave the farmer
his land on condition that once a rain
his descendants would wash the Monarch's
hands
and I met Mr Houston Crawford Who as a
young man of ten had married King George
VI's hands once and then when he
had the opportunity he watched the young
Queen's hands when she became Sovereign
and I'm sure it'll be his
grandson who will shortly be invited to
carry out that tradition
and wash the hands of the new king of
Scots Charles III
what Alistair you clearly know the
castle here as governor of the castle
with me now is Louise Tate the Queen's
press secretary for Scotland for 15
years and your office was at the palace
so you know the palace so well and the
Royal Mile Falls between the two does it
not with us this Cortez will drive down
but talk us through what will happen at
the palace and and much of what will
happen there tonight will be to allow
staff to pay their respects it will be
that personal moment uh coffin will rest
in the throne room and at some point
membership staff will be able to pay
their respects and I'm of high emotional
I'm sure for them
um clearly we all knew this was coming
but it it is a real shock
and holidays is not a big Palace it was
the smallest of Her Majesty's official
residences but it was somewhere that she
enjoyed very much spending time and the
the garden parties that are hosted for
over 8 000 people incredible how she was
able to meet so many people right up
until obviously a pandemic
including for those uh who are members
of the order of the thistle the the
highest uh order of chivalry in Scotland
the epistle nights and but this old lady
Knights um yes that is the highest order
of showroom comes after the Garter in
terms of Bank
and it explain how the the layout of the
of the palace is the oldest part is at
the back is it
is on the on the North side which is the
Abbey and that dates back to the 12th
century then there's the
the tower which was I think I'm writing
scene was built by Mary Queen of Scots
Father James IV I hope that's not wrong
Mike Royal collection colleagues will be
shouting at me but then the other side
of the the this East or South
um side of the palace is much newer I
think it dates the 1600s
um but it has been had an interesting
history it was damaged by fire and fell
into disrepair for a little while but
obviously it's come back
um as a
as a real Center especially since the
parliament is here now to have those two
things so close together that
juxtaposition of monarchy and Government
after the evolution
and certainly people are gathered here
now outside the parliament uh and the
streets uh there are stewards everywhere
barricades too because just in front of
us is where the cottage will come down
and enter Hollywood
Hollywood house and as you say the queen
will rest there tonight before making
her way to Saint Charles Cathedral doing
the journey in Reverse effectively and
traveling up the uh this historic Road
of the Royal Mall
it's a very um it's got such a long
history the role of my own you're part
of the Old Town of Edinburgh and all
those little Alleyways and closes and
it's a real Haven or somewhere that
tourists flock to and during Festival
time that's that location is you can't
move and it's a real Center for
celebration as well it's a real focal
point for Edinburgh
and now the Cortez as you can see once
again the Pavements are packed with
people who have been no doubt waiting
patiently this has been a a long journey
waiting to get that Glimpse and before
we've talked about
it's an almost tranquil moment for them
it feels like a moment of a silence for
everybody is there as they see this
Cottage pass through it's a moment to
reflect and have the reality
Dawn
um you were asking me earlier about
Balmoral and I Can Only Imagine
the emotional anguish that they must
have been feeling and
just trying to keep it together to to as
Ruth Davidson said to
do this right and
people I I've often said I
people didn't know now other people have
said it too how just how strongly
they're going to feel when this actually
happened and I think many many people be
surprised and surprised at what they
were moved to do to go and stand at the
side of the road as they are now and
when you saw the tractors and you saw
everybody on the carriageways stopped to
watch you know you the world it just
felt like everything Stood Still stand
still when that quotation was passed
well King Charles and his National
address drawing on that broadcast from
Cape Town that the queen had made on her
21st birthday back in 1947 whether she
promised to devote her life to the
Commonwealth whether it be short or long
and to the services of her peoples he
said then that was more than a promise
it was a profound personal commitment
which defined her whole life she made
sacrifices for Duty did you see that
I didn't see that the sacrifices I I
couldn't comment specifically on those
um but yes she she lived it it it it was
palpable in her that she always at the
heart of what she wanted was was this
meeting people you'll get connecting and
making that moment
of connection with her easy for for me
so many people in so many different
situations young and old and she just
had a great gift and what I feel about
that is just huge gratitude for that
she was
never here like
well he also said in her life of service
we saw that Abiding Love of tradition
together with that Fearless Embrace of
progress which make us great as Nations
the affection admiration and respect she
inspired became the Hallmark of her
Reign and today we see that admiration
and respect but we also see the
tradition too which we know the queen
did enjoy yes and I think that's very
very important to reflect these
traditions and many of them have been
seen for the first time as we saw with
the accession council yesterday and it
it is part of the richness the pageantry
it's part of culture and I think I can
certainly speak to how Scotland's um
ceremonial um events are slightly
different to other parts of the country
but they're all distinct each of the
four nations has a different
um way of demonstrating their culture
and their civic life
we saw there the high Kirk as you put it
Saint Giles Cathedral and the queen
certainly made regular visits there
herself did she not as Sovereign of the
order of the thistle it is where her
coffin will go tomorrow A procession
which will go from the Palace of
Hollywood house with her four children
following on behind solemnly walking
behind her up the Royal mile
that's what we will see tomorrow
um there will also be a small group of
Royal household staff I believe uh also
walking up the Royal mile
um
you know it's a very
St Giles is just I love suggestions it's
it's got It's it's slightly not what one
might expect I guess where I could think
it's Presbyterian
but it does feel a little bit more
ornate it's me to my mind and it's not
you know it's it's it's very very
distinct the hiker
well dates back what 800 years or so and
I I was speaking to one of the Edinburgh
tour guides yesterday and they were
describing that it's had many
incarnations as a school and as a prison
and they were telling me that beheadings
took place outside so the history of
this place is uh is truly fascinating
certainly but really a strong part of
the Reformation which took place in
Scotland and we heard did we not in that
accession Council yesterday the
separation of the Church of Scotland and
the church of England and that um King
Charles had to swear the independence of
the Church of Scotland which really
feels like it is it is centered on on
Saint Charles Cathedral yes I think
that's that's fair to see I think most
people would perhaps think of Saint
Giles um other wonderful cathedrals in
Glasgow and other cities too but that is
the high cook and that's it's it's
around there that the general assembly
of the Church of Scotland meets each
year you spoke to
Laura hood and for many many years until
the Advent of devolution it was said
that the church was the most democratic
institution in Scotland but it was a
seven I think 1707 the act of Union and
it meant that this was one of the
conditions
the separation of church of Scotland and
monarchy and that's demonstrated during
Lord High commissioner's week
which is the Queen's representative to
the general assembly when the Monarch
symbolically sits to the side
and out not in the body of the Kirk
to symbolize that distinction yes in
Scotland becoming a Protestant country
in 1560 and Saint Charles is 400 years
as a Catholic Church coming to an end
the stained glass windows inside removed
and all the old church silver melted
down and sold to raise money for the for
the redecoration but more recently the
stained glass window as a mark to the
National Bard rabby Burns added to the
cathedral in 1985 and possibly that is
what we will see tomorrow when the
family begin the service there we know
that Liz trust the Prime Minister will
now be joining them as well and then
there will be a vigil by the family and
it then will be time for members of the
public to also enter the cathedral to
pay their respects yes yes
that would be a very moving thing to
witness individuals
Queen Elizabeth II
in the center of the Union flag
the children who've come out
to witness history
the streets lined as we have seen in
other cities that The Cottage has made
its way through Aberdeen Dundee
and here in Edinburgh
Scotland's capital
as she makes her way to her official
residence
her body will rest overnight at the
palace of Hollywood house
and members of her
household staff will pay their respects
to the monarch
for whom many have worked
for years
members of her family already arriving
here leaving Balmoral earlier today
the Duke of York
the Earl Encounters of Wessex
and their daughter arriving by
helicopter to the grounds of the palace
taking part in the events of Tomorrow
centered on that Cathedral we saw on the
Royal mile
King Charles also flying up too
with the queen consort
the Prime Minister joining events here
in Edinburgh
tomorrow
there is an almost a Wonder as they're
not as people wait Louise
it's in the west side of the city
and the route from there
I wouldn't like to speculate exactly
there is a I understood Royal route of
coming from the airport and so forth but
uh
this is very close to the center of town
now across the center of Edinburgh
think it'll be printer Street and then
up the mound
how hard is this for you to watch
it is difficult and and you know we've
seen these pictures but until we
perhaps see this over our shoulders here
we might not I don't think I I don't
think it's sunken yet but you know it's
so grateful that so many people along
that route have had the opportunity to
see her
one last time
thank you very much indeed well let's
head back to Aleister Bruce who
as governor of Edinburgh Castle knows
this area so well Alistair
coming along Queens Ferry Road
and we're about to cross
Dean bridge and into the new town
and this really is the queen returning
to the heart now of
Edinburgh City
the city that she
first came to as
a crowned Queen in 1953 to which she
returned almost every year apart from
the period of covid
and it was to the Palace of Hollywood
house that she came at 11 o'clock
on the 27th of June this year on her
final royal visit
to the capital of Scotland
it was quite soon after her Platinum
Jubilee celebrations down in London the
nation had noticed how
unable she had been to fulfill all the
plans that had originally been put
together but she did attend at the
beginning and at the end with balcony
appearances
and so when she came to Edinburgh on the
27th of June it was
very heartening for those who wished her
well to see her get out of the state
Bentley which is currently following her
hearse with the Princess Royal inside
and she
received the new Lord promised of
Edinburgh she was accompanied by the
Earl Encounters of Wessex and fortha
who played their part in supporting the
Queen's arrival
the dean Bridge we look down at now
as and I just knew now crosses leaf
water
and comes into the new town
the new town itself was being built and
was
really an emblem of the Revival of so
much in Scotland after King George IV
had come on his visit in 1822.
and it was typical of the queen that she
wanted to Mark the 200th anniversary of
that visit by King George IV this year
let's see her cross the bridge
[Music]
foreign
the queen returning to the city that
was the name of the dukedom that King
George VI gave her husband
when she married him in 1947.
and he was Duke of Edinburgh and she was
very proud to be his Duchess of
Edinburgh
from Queens Ferry Road to Queens Ferry
Street
and there
Dead Ahead
the castle and Fortress of Edinburgh
Castle and the old town of that great
City
the Athens of the North
and the stronghold in that Fortress of
the symbols
of the Scottish Nation
the Queen's procession will come down
to Princess Street and turn onto Lothian
Road
The Fortress where earlier today Lord
Lion King of arms
gave the second of two proclamations
here in Edinburgh
that Elizabeth II
is dead and
King Charles III is the new king
and they are at the top of the royal
mile we wait for
the Queen's procession to come up and
turn towards us
she first of all will skirt around the
base of the Fortress and come up Johnson
Terrace
and only a few weeks ago this area was a
throng with the glories of
celebration that is the Edinburgh
Festival each year where
a profound quantity of Youth creativity
and arts and culture come into this
Royal duketum
the name of which she carried and bring
it to life and just up the Castle Hill
to the right of the church there which
is now known as The Hub just up to the
right there the castle Esplanade where
the Royal Edinburgh military tattoo
takes place each year
all that seems a long way away but the
crowds Phil know this most ancient of
Royal processional routes
there is no processional route older
than the Royal Mile in Edinburgh
and the great tradition in Scotland was
not a procession but a riding
and the lover of equestrian things and
horses that the queen was would probably
have seen some Delight in her final
Journey Down
from the highlands ending up
passing along where the great writings
of Scottish tradition right back to when
Mary Queen of Scots moved through this
ancient city being shouted at by John
Knox
always
there is controversy in a vibrant City
and that is also true today
there's a hush in the crowd
police Scotland holding the ground
a long journey for
those in accompanying roles particularly
for the Princess Royal
and Admiral Sir Tim Lawrence who's kept
his wife company on the journey from
Balmoral
it's now
six hours and 10 minutes since
the queen came out of Balmoral
leaving the clutches of her favorite
home
to make this journey to her royal palace
here in Edinburgh
and the queen makes her journey
come to an end with this route done
the Royal mile
foreign
[Applause]
the queen passes the high Kirk of some
Giles where tomorrow she will lie in
state
and also the Market Cross where in 1952
her father the King's death was
announced in the start of her Reign too
her Proclamation and today we saw the
proclamation of her son the new king
foreign
[Applause]
Street of
this Royal mile which will turn into the
cannon gate shortly will bring the queen
to The Abbey strand gate into
the four Court of Hollywood Palace
waiting for
the late Queen there will be
the god of Honor
provided by the Royal Regiment of
Scotland
and the King's color will be lowered in
salute to the late Queen
no band will play
and when the hearse comes to a halt
the officer commanding the bearer party
will move forward
and her late Majesty will be lifted from
the hearse
and Born Into The Palace
along the colonnade inside the courtyard
and then up to the great stair
and the coffin placed
in the throne room
of a palace that she left
only at the end of June earlier this
year
looking up from the start of Abbey
strand gate
up the hill awaiting the queen
being brought down past the Canon gate
Kirk where when she was in Edinburgh she
regularly again attended Divine service
and where her granddaughter
Zara Phillips was married
foreign
it is so difficult to believe that the
sparkly eyed happy enthusiastic
courteous Queen who came on that morning
of the 27th of June this year to the
very place where she will halt today is
returned in this particular manner so
soon
but Scotland has welcomed her home she's
passed through this long and interesting
Journey Through the Highlands and
finally
we see her come home to her Palace
yeah
beside the Parliament building that was
built in her reign
to be received and to rest in private
overnight
foreign
good luck
whoa look
s reasons
foreign
party for their colonel in Chief from
the Royal Regiment of Scotland prepare
to lift
their precious burden and carry her late
Majesty
into the palace
foreign
after more than 70 years as Queen of
Scots
Elizabeth II is taken into the palace
and would be placed in the throne room
peacefully at rest overnight
before the ceremonies begin tomorrow
and she's taken to the high Kirk of
Saint Giles
where a service of Thanksgiving for her
life of service to Scotland will take
place in the presence
of his majesty the king
the queen
is home
wow
Joseph
oh right
no
the god of our arms well God
foreign
[Music]
right wow
the guard of Honor with the king's color
taking leave of this sad sight here at
holyrood so different from when the
queen arrived and many of these soldiers
gave their own salute to the arrival of
their Queen
but today they've shown their ultimate
respect on the instructions of the new
king to the late queen as they now leave
out towards Arthur's seat and the
Glorious views that this great palace
has of the hills that sit right within
the Heart of the City as Scotland has
brought home
the late Queen from the highlands here
to the heart of Edinburgh
and tomorrow these soldiers will return
they will take their part
in escorting the late Queen to the
cathedral on the Royal mile
and following the procession will be his
majesty the king and other members of
the Royal Family
the constables of holyrood
taking their leave also from this scene
and with the courtyard once again empty
and the century marching out his pace
foreign
journey is at an end and the Queen
is at rest in Hollywood
[Music]
well the high constables of Hollywood
the last to leave out of the south gate
with me here Louise Tate former press
secretary to her majesty the queen and
our Royal correspondent Rhiannon Mills
and Louise you watch on this was your
office of course was it not the coffin
taken now to the throne room for you
know the household staff to pay their
respect yes and for them to have that
moment and for her majesty spend a
little bit more time in a place that she
very much enjoyed being
incredibly moving I think the palace
looks wonderful and I think should be
delighted to see it as she saw it just
in the end of June this year
and then
as she was brought down through the
Abbey strand
and
this was the first time really that
crowds in in this number
were able to to pay their respects and
the contrast to to where she left what
six hours ago could not have felt
greater the quiet seclusion of Balmoral
where her family were able to to gather
to mourn their mama their grandma
in in silence and
they are a family however who are very
aware
that they want to share this moment with
the public
and that's what they were able to do is
Princess Anne and her husband sir Tim
Lawrence were in the car behind the
hearse carrying the coffin
and they would have witnessed the crowds
as they came out throughout the
Highlands
in Dundee
Farmers with their tractors paying
tribute
Scotland really coming out
to pay their own respects to the queen
and it was at this moment where we saw
the coffin arriving at the palace of
Hollywood house
where we could see
the Queen's children
prince Andrew
and Prince Edward along with Prince
Edward's wife the Council of Wessex
Sophie
standing there waiting to No Doubt
welcome and comfort the Princess Royal
hoot who followed the coffin
and as we've alluded to it was only at
the end of June that the queen was here
on the forecourt of the Palace of
Hollywood to begin Hollywood week a time
that she enjoyed so much where she would
commit herself to Scotland for the week
to make sure that she could meet as many
people as possible so she could really
submerge herself in everything that was
going on in Scottish society and this
year was no different despite the fact
that we knew she had those mobility
issues
she still conducted the ceremony of the
keys there on the forecourt she still
attended events that we didn't expect
her to and during those events you could
see the Joy on her face
because this was a place that she loved
this of course her official residence
Balmoral the place where she would take
her family for some rest and
recuperation and some time away from the
cameras
but today again as she has always done
throughout her reign as she always did
there was an appreciation that she must
be seen by her people and today Scotland
came out in their thousands to pay their
respects
and bringing a little bit of the
Balmoral garden with her with that
wreath
her children with a bow and a curtsy as
they saw the coffin arrive
and now to the throne room and inside
the throne room
a portrait of James VI of Scotland
became James the first Louise of uh of
England and Scotland after the death of
Elizabeth that the history is steeped as
it not in in this building oh yes it's
such this building is is
such a
Rich tapestry of different eras that
have been Blended together to look
seamless The Abbey even the Abbey is
attached to that Terror on the on the
North side and the
there has been other influences as
Prince Albert the fountain on the four
court it's a replica of the one at the
mythical Palace but different monarchs
have made their mark
on Hollywood house
and perhaps there will be some change
under the new king
but he was also very involved in the
refurbishment of the Abbey strand
buildings which I know the queen was
very well kept informed of those plants
and we can see that just there behind us
right next to
um as you can see in that image there
the Scottish Parliament and that will be
part of the commemorations tomorrow with
King Charles going to meet those
politicians who will be able to pay
their respects as we saw also in London
just standing here reminds me that it
was it was literally
about 13 months ago that I was here
standing virtually in this same position
watching the queen leave the parliament
as she had been there once again front
and center
as part of that opening ceremony and on
that occasion she was supported by
the then Prince of Wales and The Duchess
of Cornwall
but it was that enduring sense that she
continued to want to serve
but I think what has also come out over
the last few days as we reflect on her
remarkable service
is just how much she meant to those who
served her and Louise was one of them
and and I think those those heartwarming
stories that the queen of course she
kept so much to herself of her own
personality but but now people like
Louise here are able to to share the
most wonderful stories of of her
kindness she was certainly
a very warm
very caring
um person after I think I mentioned I
had a period of ill health and I missed
Hollywood week one year and when I came
back she asked me to be a lady in
waiting for the garden party
and after that there was actually one
evening when I had I just felt I need a
minute because we had a busy day and I
actually quite later said to the master
of the household might I be excused
didn't it this evening which of course
the answer came back yes
but in the morning I got a message
see the queen was worried I was doing
too much
and I was so so touched I just felt I
had to explain I needed him
and I dropped the biggest courtesy and
gave her the biggest smile at the first
engagement of the day to reassure that I
was actually fine
well the crowds we anticipate will start
to peel away as they have elsewhere I
can see over our shoulder those still
lingering looking through into the
palace through those main gates
um but they'll be back of course
tomorrow won't they because the king
will arrive along with the queen consort
and the Prime Minister and we will see
the reverse journey of the Cortez so
tonight it's the time for members of the
royal household to pay their own private
quiet respects but as you said tomorrow
again we will see the ceremony take to
the streets as King Charles and the
queen consort will arrive in Scotland
they will join the Queen's other
children and then we will see this
procession up to Saint Giles Cathedral
we understand that
the Queen's children so the king and his
siblings and Sir Timothy Lawrence will
walk behind the hearse as the coffin is
taken to the Cathedral of this service
of Thanksgiving and also the queen
consort and at the Council of Wessex
will will drive behind and this will be
a service where the whole of Scotland
can come and
pay their respects this won't just be
about politicians the Great and the good
we're told that this is going to be a
chance for all sections of society here
in Scotland to to remember the queen and
for those who won't be inside the
cathedral no doubt they will take their
place once again on the streets here in
Edinburgh as we saw as we saw them in
such numbers today
and a final thought Louise from you for
now
the queen is home we heard from Aleister
Bruce you were intimately involved in
some of these plans we're seeing now and
the complexity of putting this all
together
you know was she involved too was this
was it were these her choices you have
to understand that there's a ceremonial
plan and we have their Marshall and the
Lord lion who responds with overall
responsibility but within that there is
a media plan because it is one of the
only ways that people will be able to
connect to what's happening abilities
actually see for themselves what's
happening
um there's so many agencies involved so
many aspects of the council government
Parliament and they've all come together
all come together and I've just been so
impressed by what I've seen today I'm
this was done at such short notice we
all got such a shock at the announcement
but all that we see here today to allow
us to do this
came together very very quickly and I'm
very grateful for that because
we needed to see it it's part of history
and it's part of our connection
well rehearsals took place before Dawn
today certainly for tomorrow's
procession there is so much organization
that goes behind an occasion like this
and it is a historic occasion which we
have all witnessed here the journey from
a much-loved Balmoral Castle now to the
official residence of the queen in the
building building behind us the Palace
of Hollywood house but uh the queen of
the king rather remains still in London
so let's now go to Buckingham Palace
Anna thank you very much indeed just
unbearably sad pictures there from uh
Edinburgh this evening as the Cortez
along the Royal mile across those
cobblestones absolute silence then
someone starts clapping and then the
Applause Just grew but as Alistair Bruce
says the queen is at rest again this
evening at the palace of Hollywood house
now what about here at uh Buckingham
Palace
uh these are the latest pictures of the
king alongside uh the queen consort he
had a day of receptions for guests
including the foreign secretary and
various High commissioners of
Commonwealth Nations
side
the palace thousands of people have
gathered once again
uh still they come
in their thousands just to uh pay
tribute and around the country to to
witness the proclamations of King
Charles III as the new monarch and as we
speak uh behind me here
um forces and troops
uh coming past the crowds
who are here again as I say to
um
lay their floral tributes
here they are and people have just come
all day they walk slowly down the mall
they move slowly towards the palace
Gates and then they move on to areas
that have been created where they can
leave their floral tributes and
and they just stop and they just reflect
but it is the sheer numbers and
and all sorts of things going on
preparations going on in the background
there the building work and
these no doubt preparations for the
formalities that are about to take place
in
the coming days
well I was talking about the
proclamations he was formally proclaimed
King at a ceremony of course in Saint
James's Palace yesterday and today
ceremonies were held at Cardiff Castle
Hillsborough in Northern Ireland at
Windsor Castle and at Edinburgh Castle
[Music]
do you know who hereby with one voice
and consent of tongue and heart
publish
and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George
is now
by the death of our late Sovereign happy
of memory
become our only lawful and rightful
leads Lord Charles III
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
James a dag red deed already I'm Louise
in Hercules Deweyville aduisine
to whom we do acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection
beseeching God
by whom kings and queens do reign
to bless His Majesty with long and happy
years to Reign Over Us
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George is now
by the death of our late Sovereign of
happy memory become our only lawful
and rightful
lead Lord Charles III
God saved the king
[Music]
well someone else seeing the King today
was the dean of Westminster and he's
been describing how it feels to be the
efficient leading the service of the
Queen's funeral which is taking place as
we know on Monday the 19th of September
at Westminster Abbey
I think the two things that strike me
immediately are is that it's a huge
privilege
and that it's a huge responsibility
um uh this but it's also this is what
the Abbey is for this this building and
its long history uh this is this is the
Church of Coronation this is a place
where nation and Commonwealth gathers uh
so we're stepping up stepping into the
role we're supposed to to play and I uh
all my colleagues in the Abbey uh all of
us share that sense of privilege and
responsibility and we'll do a good job
dean of Westminster there let's go up to
our correspondent Joe Pike now who is on
the Royal Mile in Edinburgh and Joe
um extraordinarily moving scenes there
yes Mark a hushed crowd 10 to 15 deep as
the Queen's Cortez came past here past
some Giles Cathedral the high Kirk of
Edinburgh a medieval Parish Church will
be at the center of tomorrow's
proceedings and ceremonies much of the
crowd has now dispersed walking one way
down the mile down the High Street the
Canon gate to Hollywood Palace where the
Queen's coffin now is at the foot of the
Salisbury Crags and opposite of course
the Scottish Parliament this place will
be at the center of proceedings tomorrow
because we know there'll be procession
with the King taking part on foot behind
at his mother's hearse to this historic
church at almost a midpoint of the royal
mile there will be a ceremony of service
tomorrow before that 24-hour vigil where
Scots and many visitors to the city will
be able to pay their respects and
talking to the crowds here it really is
a mixture of locals but also many
visitors many tourists too because the
mile of course is the center of the
history and the tourism of this uh City
I've talked to people from America from
Japan from Denmark people who for whom
either were here on holiday and have
changed their plans or have specifically
decided to travel talking to each other
in the crowd introducing themselves a
very warm atmosphere and the rain did
hold off until after the Cortez had
moved past it's also worth I think
reflecting at this point that the that
her majesty did adapt throughout her
reign as the constitution of this
country uh shipped she was at the center
of some key moments such as the start of
devolution the opening of the Scottish
parliament in 1999 and of course she
formed close relationships with first
ministers as well as prime minister as
Prime Ministers being invited to
Balmoral each summer for two nights
first ministers for one because she
understood as her son the King Charles
DARS the importance of maintaining those
relationships when of course uh Mark the
Constitutional position of Scotland
within this Union as Still Remains up
for debate north of the Border
okay Joe thank you very much indeed well
what about here as I was saying the
crowds are still coming uh Sky's Kamali
Melbourne is among them uh here at uh
Buckingham Palace let's go and talk to
Kamali
thank you Mark yeah and you're right the
crowds are still coming there's still
just tens of thousands of people over
there on the mail lining up trying to
get closer to the Palace the uh security
guards here have been telling people
there are no more Royal movements yet
people are still lined up along the
barriers waiting anticipating hoping of
course to get another glimpse of the
Royals of course you know that King
Charles is inside Buckingham Palace
right now and people are still waiting
even though as I said the security
guards have told them that really it's
time for them to move on and people have
been coming here all day Mark you're
right there's been just a steady stream
of people I've been here since very
early in the morning and it hasn't
stopped people have been coming paying
their tributes leaving their flowers and
just being in this sort of family
atmosphere and there's a few people here
that I want to just uh speak to hi guys
just quicker on live on Sky News you're
the first guys I've seen picnicking
you've decided to bring a little snack
as well hello love don't wait for us but
um it's nice to be here yeah and it's a
yeah it's a nice day as well the weather
held out for us it's lovely why do you
think it's important to come and pay
your respects to the queen and have
bring the family here as well I
think that they wanted to come and lay
flowers for the queen leave a note to
commemorate her 70 years of rain so
we've brought them here for the
experience
do you want to say a little something
about why you came though you don't
you've got shy now you're talking to me
before you at least wanted to be on
telly before Mum would you like to say a
few words as to why you think it's
important to come here what in Jamaica
part of the Commonwealth I've lived here
most of my years but it's important to
bring my children and my grandchild
children to see the Heritage and it's
such a sad day you know I'm feeling for
the queen so we had to come and lay some
flowers
it's a lovely sentiment everyone's
having a nice time and you've had snacks
I might stop by as well because I'm a
little hungry and it's been a long day
for me thank you very much for talking
to us look the people have just been
coming here all day let me just show you
this been areas to to lay sort of floral
tributes flowers of course and a little
messages for people and here's one that
has kind of spontaneously started to be
used by people because
the security guys have been kind of
moving away a lot of the flowers from
various places but you can see here
people have just been Gathering
leaving their flowers leaving their
messages uh taking their pictures of
course but really wanting to be here for
this historic moment and spend time with
like-minded people have all come if the
same thing to honor the queen and wish
the new king all the very best
Kamali thank you very much indeed well
the labor leader Sakia starma has been
speaking about the Queen's Legacy and
the future of the Commonwealth
well I think across the Commonwealth
it's very important to recognize that
every country will evolve in its own way
according to their tradition and their
wishes I think the king will be an
incredible head of the Commonwealth and
has an ability to bring people together
I know that he has a very very deep
commitment to the Commonwealth so of
course different countries will evolve
in different ways but I think that the
king will strengthen that bond with the
Commonwealth
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent John Craig and John I know
that there's been uh a couple of days of
tributes from politicians what happens
with the politics of all this now
well before I tell you about that Mark
let me just explain that sirma there was
responding to some comments made by the
Prime Minister of Antigua and Barbuda in
the Barbuda in the Caribbean that is
Gaston Brown who was talking about the
possibility of his country having a
referendum on the country becoming
independent in the next three years now
Mr Brown said it's not a matter of uh
hostility or differences between the
countries of Antigua and Barbuda and the
monarchy he's talking about the final
step to complete the circle of
Independence remember this follows talks
about independence in Jamaica after a
visitor by William and Kate the new
Prince and Princess of Wales they were
criticized for shaking hands with people
through a mesh fans and also looking
very Colonial in an Old Land Rover
anyway the better news on the uh on the
uh the countries becoming independent
course it came overnight in interview
Sky News the Prime Minister of Australia
the new labor prime minister Anthony
Albanese told Sky News no Independence
moves there for three years so that's
that issue now What's Happening Here
further events over the next few days
Mark now in what about an hour's time
there's a service for MPS and peers in
Saint Margaret's Church just across the
road from Parliament the little church
next door to Westminster Abbey then
tomorrow big event tomorrow in the
morning
the king and queen consort that's
Charles and Camilla are coming to
Westminster Hall where both houses of
Parliament MPS and peers are going to
meet uh to express their condolences the
king will make his reply what we are
expecting is um
speeches more pledges of loyalty uh
following the humble addresses in the
Commons and the Lords yesterday
um the Speaker of the House of Commons
sir Lindsay Hoyle will speak then the
Lord speaker that's Lord McFall then the
king will reply
um then of course the king and queen are
off to Scotland where among other things
they'll meet they'll get a Scottish
Parliament they'll meet the first
Minister number 10 of stress today uh
that unlike an announcement yesterday
when they said the PM was joining the
king and queen uh they're not
accompanying them and they're attending
that she's attending the church services
something some criticism after the
announcement that the Prime Minister
would be joining them on what was
described as a tour Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland then of course the line
of State here in Westminster starts on
Wednesday Westminster Hall I can tell
you there are massive preparations
taking place in and around the houses of
Parliament for that massive crowds
expected for that that's the lying in
State starting on Wednesday
okay John thank you very much indeed a
busy week ahead clearly
um it has been planned in the finest
detail and we now know that the events
that uh will take place but the event
that took place today was truly uh
moving we have seen the Queen's Cortez
make its way to Edinburgh
175 mile Journey
uh finally ending up in Journey in
Edinburgh wending its way through
aberdeenshire through Angus and tayside
before reaching now the Palace of
holyrood house you see there where the
queen will lie
at rest
in the palace
overnight and on Monday there will be a
procession from the palace to Saint
Giles cathedral in Edinburgh
where the coffin will rest again
this time for 24 hours and that will be
to allow the people of that City the
people of Scotland to pay the
respects that they want to pay to their
monarch
well this is Sky News live from the
Palace of Hollywood house in Edinburgh
[Music]
a last great journey the Queen's coffin
leaves Balmoral this morning for a slow
route to Edinburgh
foreign
[Music]
people lined the streets and Roads as
the hearse made its way across Scotland
[Music]
before eventually arriving at the palace
of Hollywood house in Edinburgh were her
children paid their respects
and I'm live at Buckingham Palace this
evening
where the new King has held meetings
with the Commonwealth and the realm
as crowds gathered to get a glimpse of
their king and the queen consort but
also to pay tribute to the late Queen
[Music]
God Save the King
earlier proclamations for King Charles
III held around the four nations
foreign
[Music]
is remembered around the world and in an
international exclusive Australia's
prime minister tells Sky News there will
be no break with the monarchy in the
near future it will need to continue to
move with the times but the bigger
questions about our Constitution are not
ones for this current period
[Music]
hello good evening you're watching Sky
News at five people have had their final
chance to say farewell to Elizabeth II
today as her coffin took its final
journey through Scotland leaving
Balmoral this morning the procession led
by the hearse carrying the Queen's
coffin which was followed by the
Princess Royal it has now arrived in
Edinburgh where it will rest in the
Palace of Hollywood house until tomorrow
afternoon
well James Matthews has our first report
of the Queen's final Journey through the
gates of Balmoral it was the quietest
farewell
brutal aberdeenshire it's both song and
the rumble of the river D played the
soundtrack for a site most sad
the hairs carried the Queen's coffin
wrapped in the Royal Standard of
Scotland the wreath on top was made from
her favorite flowers picked from the
Balmoral card
in the car behind the queen was escorted
by her daughter the Princess Royal and
her husband sir Tim Lawrence
the geography of circumstance had placed
the queen in Balmoral when she passed
at Journey's End there will be a state
funeral set piece ceremony and all that
but between here and there this was an
informal farewell an opportunity for the
public to save their goodbyes
in balater near Balmoral they line the
streams here they knew her as the queen
next door their Village was her Village
it's just so fond of this area
it's just a very very sad day for us all
very emotional today and very Pride
to be part of the United Kingdom so yeah
I cried
everybody here you see them all crying I
just find it really emotional it's like
it's almost like saying goodbye to
family member it's just really really
upsetting
tractors were positioned by the side of
the road an agricultural guard of Honor
as the Cortez wound a route through
rural Scotland
horse riders too formed up in a field by
the roadside as it made it slow six hour
Journey South
this journey had been meticulously
planned
even if there was no public rehearsal
here in Bank area there was Applause
[Applause]
else elsewhere there was silent
everywhere there was respect and
Remembrance
yeah it was it was quite overwhelming to
be honest I'm very very proud to be here
I've never come along to anything like
this before but just really felt that I
wanted it was it was important it was
beautiful once in a lifetime it's not
gonna happen again
people line Joe carriageways linking
Aberdeen Dundee and Edinburgh Beyond and
they looked on from walkways overhead
closer to Edinburgh the Cortez crossed
the fourth or fourth via the Queensbury
crossing a bridge officially opened by
the queen in 2017.
members of the royal family had traveled
ahead by helicopter to fulfill their
duties
one sin Edinburgh the Queen's coffin was
driven through the streets towards
Hollywood in the city's Old Town
[Applause]
the Royal Regiment of Scotland formed a
guard of honor of the Palace of
Hollywood homes and the Queen's coffin
was received with a royal salute
it's being placed in the throne room
overnight to allow Palace staff to pay
their respect
as the queen was carried inside a
daughter cuts it to her mother her Duty
done
this was day one of the Queen's long
goodbye which will span a nation that
grew with her and Having learned of her
loss is learning to live with it
James Matthews Sky News in balloter
well let's bring in our Royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills and now the
Queen's coffin at rest in the throne
room in the palace behind us but leaving
the tranquility and privacy of Balmoral
where her family effectively had to say
goodbye before it was opened up to the
public effectively and you and I this
week have both been at Balmoral for
different reasons I was there for the
Prime Minister Handover and you were
there after we heard of the Queen's
death and the thing that hits you there
is the the seclusion the privacy and I
think for her family it was the perfect
place for them to
try to in some way come to terms with
what is a huge shock for so many
but they're also so conscious of the
fact that this is a a moment of grief of
mourning that the public want to be able
to share in and that's what we saw today
as we saw the
funeral
the coffin
um leaving
Balmoral there the heads of the police
officers vowed it was very quiet and I
think also as the coffin came here to
Edinburgh there were quiet ripples of
Applause but also also silence because I
think
it has also happened so quickly
and as we've spoken about today often it
is when you see
a coffin that finally that news
begins to sink in but it was so striking
wasn't it to see how many people had
come out onto the streets of Edinburgh
here but also the likes of Dundee we saw
all of the farmers with their their
tractors as well everyone wanting to pay
their tribute and and the fact that she
died here in Scotland has has allowed
another important part of her United
Kingdom what was her United Kingdom to
come out and pay their tribute of course
this evening it's now the Royal
household who can quietly peacefully pay
their own private respects as tomorrow
we wait again to see the new king join
his siblings who are already here in
Edinburgh as we saw as the Queen's
coffin arrived and we will see them
attend that service of Thanksgiving at
sir Giles
well the Cortez passing from Edinburgh
Castle down the Royal mile to here at
the palace of Hollywood house and Joe
Pike is at St Giles Cathedral the high
Kirk
and witnessed the Cortez passing amidst
the crowds there Joe
yes Anna they were 10 to 15 people deep
some had been waiting many hours they
were calm the crowd was pretty hushed
introducing themselves to each other
over the hours starting this weight as
as strangers and ending it as not quite
friends but people who had shared a
quite a special moment that spontaneous
Applause certainly at touching for some
I'll step out of the way of the shot so
you can see what
the cortesh path this stunning building
the the Cathedral of Saint Giles the
high Kirk of Edinburgh
and standing in front of it uh watching
the the hearse and the Cortez come past
the statue of the fifth uh Duke of the
clue a man who knowed would have known a
lot about a lot about these sort of
Ceremonies because he played a key role
in them including the time of Queen
Victoria this is the place that we'll be
at the center of some of tomorrow's
proceedings that is when uh Charles King
Charles will follow his mother's hearse
up the raw mile from the Palace of
Hollywood house to Saint Giles that
service will take place and then there
will be a vigil for 24 hours Anna
allowing the people of Scotland to pay
their respects before the Queen's coffin
is taken down to London
Joe Pike thank you very much indeed
there Joe stood there on the Royal mile
well the queen and the royal family have
been dedicated to their faith attending
a special Christmas service at
Sandringham every year today of course
Sunday and the queen has been remembered
in churches right across
the country well Katarina vitotsi has
been to a service in Liverpool and sent
this report
she is the only monarch most of us have
ever known
and today at Liverpool Parish Church the
lake Queen was mourned by some like a
member of family
[Music]
this was a special Requiem service
a chance to remember an extraordinary
life
we give you thanks
for her love of family and her gift of
friendship
for her Devotion to this nation and the
nations of the Commonwealth
the Queen's passing brings Global
cultural change
and a new National Anthem with
unfamiliar words
[Applause]
speed who's 77 remembers the previous
King but the late Queen became his
constant
ly what a lovely lovely lady lovely
and why don't you see
every Friday seven o'clock which is the
toast the queen
but we've got to look forward to King
Charles
hopefully he'll do as good as he mum
I'm sure he will
church services like this one held here
today and those indeed across
have given people a chance to pay
tribute to the late Queen but in many
ways they also reflect the way in which
Queen Elizabeth II lived her own life
at her coronation 70 years ago the queen
pledged to lead the Church of England
but the public pageantry was matched by
personal faith
seen in times of Celebration like
Christmas day trips to church
or more recently at the funeral of her
late husband
[Music]
her role as defender of the faith will
be remembered a late Majesty taught us
much
if not more
about God and Grace
both in words and the actions that
reinforce them
than any other contemporary figure
the Queen Once said her faith guided her
through good times and bad it feels then
particularly poignant the places of
worship like Litchfield cathedral in
Staffordshire have become such focal
points during this time of national
mourning it's just like the nation's
Grandma weren't you she just everyone
just loved her there was nothing not to
love about her really she's really
important for everyone and a lot of
people looked up to her and thought she
was amazing really and I did as well
it's a sense many share
a feeling many will miss
Catherine evertotsi Sky News
[Music]
well let's bring in our Royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills once again
and certainly tomorrow the focus will be
on the church service we will see and
the procession of members of the royal
family from the palace here up the Royal
mile to Saint Charles Cathedral
a reminder of how
it was the Queen's personal faith that
really sustained her throughout her
reign she didn't see that role as a
chore she saw it as as a role that she
was born to fulfill and her personal
religious Faith her Christianity we
always saw that within for example her
Christmas messages it was there to be
seen and tomorrow we will see this
service of remembrance of Thanksgiving
and for everyone involved Yes again it's
a time where we will see the royal
family so we will see them leave the
Palace of Hollywood house the new King
King Charles III will be here with his
Queen consort in the morning to join the
Queen's other children and spouses who
we've seen as the coffin arrived earlier
some of them will walk behind the coffin
in which we'll be
I think an incredibly touching moment no
doubt very resonant of when we saw them
walking behind Prince Philip's coffin at
his funeral they will then pause
remember her at that service of
Thanksgiving if I'm told that service is
also about bringing Scotland together
it's very inclusive it's not just the
greater the good it's not just political
figures it's making sure that every
aspect of society is represented is
represented and no doubt also members of
the royal household who we know are now
going to be Central to the plans
and isn't it remarkable that so far the
plans have run so smoothly nothing has
gone wrong in terms of that procession
coming here to hollyroot and for them no
doubt this is incredibly difficult they
are feeling deep mourning they knew the
queen personally they felt her her
kindness and her warmth now they want to
do the right thing they want this to be
the most fitting tribute possible for
her as tonight as Aleister Bruce said
earlier she is now home
Rihanna thank you
well good evening to you from Buckingham
Palace King Charles III has held
meetings with the Secretary General of
the Commonwealth as well as the high
Commissioners from the countries where
he is now head of state today's events
are just the start of a list of duties
for the king over the coming days Skies
Royal correspondent Laura bundock has
this report
[Music]
with flourish and fanfare
and from every corner of the United
Kingdom
[Applause]
the pageantry of proclamation and as his
Reign is confirmed
the new king already at work
head of the Commonwealth and meeting its
leaders he is for now Head of State in
14 Realms but knows some are already
questioning their Royal relationship
supported by the queen consort these are
important moments for the new monarch
and on top meetings to finalizing his
mother's funeral it's an opportunity for
us to grieve it's an opportunity for us
to try and put some of our gratitude and
Remembrance into words it's an
opportunity for us to pray for ourselves
and for our new king and his family
um and it's uh it's an opportunity I
think uh for us all to have a focus for
our grief but
one hand it is a focal point for people
mourning the queen but as they gather
Outside Inside the king that's just
getting on with a job with his new role
and responsibilities
he is Keen to reassure that this
unsettling time taking a tour of the
nation's first stop Scotland where there
is a huge sense of expectancy I think he
has been taught well by his mother she's
a great role model for him and I
honestly think we'll see a very
compassionate king a king who will look
um to unite the country I would hope he
would continue along the path that she
tread so well and I think he'll be a
little bit more outspoken I imagine
about environmental issues and because
there are causes close to his heart and
I think he'll probably work to modernize
the monarchy the king will also travel
to Northern Ireland and Wales creating
connections and meeting people in the
countries he now rules Laura bundock Sky
News Buckingham Palace
and Laura is with me now so these are
busy days for the new king
Feathering tomorrow
at the end of this era at the same time
we don't get a transition period the new
era has begun and it is well underway
and the office is Buckingham palaces is
where the king is you know with another
day of first yesterday was meeting
political leaders today the Commonwealth
this family of Nations a family he knows
was so close to his mother's heart and a
family of Nations that really some would
say is a big part of her Legacy and he
knows the meetings are important these
are difficult diplomatic and very
delicate times you know the number of
Commonwealth Realms that he is now he is
now Head of State for has been dwindling
over the years and he knows there are a
lot of countries now very much
considering and debating their own
Futures with him as head of state so
important meetings underway there he was
there of course when Barbados declared
itself a republic last year others are
in the pipeline as well for now though I
think it was a day of meetings but
important meetings regarding the funeral
as well so as well as that sort of side
of the job he's got this difficult job
of planning his mother's funeral and
it's been planned obviously for years
and years but he had an important
meeting today signing off some of those
final details and he will want to get it
right he will want to make sure he's
been able to sign off those details so
it is a difficult time and then of
course this huge tour of the nation
starting tomorrow with Scotland then to
Northern Ireland then to Wales as well
very much wanting to be out there to be
seen to be able to as he said sort of
share the grief of the people who he is
now Head of State for okay Laura thank
you very much indeed well joining me now
is uh Tony Juniper the chair of Natural
England Tony thank you very much for
being with us and just first of all I
thought I'd ask you about the scenes
that we've been witnessing today with
the Queen's Cortez heading towards
Edinburgh where it is now and all the
people coming out
well Mark just to say that I'm appearing
this afternoon in a personal capacity
not not um as the chair of Natural
England and appearing as someone who's
who's worked with the Prince of Wales
for a long time on some of his
environmental causes and uh like
everybody else looking at the images
coming through deeply saddened and
deeply touched by uh the way in which
everyone's reacting uh to the passing of
the queen it's an incredibly sad moment
and no sadder for anyone other than the
the Prince of Wales and his family uh
once Prince of Wales now King Charles
and his family as they uh come to face
the coming period including all the
complexities of the Handover which your
coverage was touching on a moment ago
yes you mentioned environmental issues
and uh clearly these are issues that uh
the well he was the prince of Wales now
um King Charles is passionate about
yes indeed and I I was privileged uh to
be able to work quite closely with him
over a period of years on a variety of
different subjects that he sought to
make progress on uh sustainable
agriculture and food security the huge
question of climate change
deforestation in the tropical countries
the health of the marine environment and
the reason why he has been so devoted to
doing something about all of those
things is really because of the impact
that an unhealthy environment has on
people and if you look at what he's been
doing over the years he's talked about
Farmers as much as he has about farming
and when it comes to the health of the
marine environment working and engaging
with communities whose livelihoods had
been hit by the collapse of fish stocks
and then when it came to the tropical
rainforests it wasn't only the wildlife
that he was concerned about but also the
the culture and the sustaining of the
rainforest peoples who lived there and
the sense of of empathy he's brought to
all of this in in terms of seeing how
the people are being affected by these
environmental changes really has been
front and center at what he's all about
and uh I I think you know the the the
service and devotion that he devoted to
all of that I think is is an excellent
sign of what he will do as king
well that's an interesting point I mean
he was clearly influential on these
issues as uh the Prince of Wales will he
find a way do you think to be
as active on this despite assuming uh
the role of King
well like everyone else I listen to his
address uh the other evening and uh he
was very clear that things will change
uh he will need to stand aside from some
of the work that he's been doing with
his Charities and so on and uh you know
that is inevitable and not not apart
from anything else you know the uh the
time will have available for those
subjects is going to be considerably
diminished and just listening to some of
the work that's on uh his hands already
in terms of the Commonwealth and Beyond
this is going to be an incredibly
demanding role that uh he's acknowledged
will need to change the way in which he
works
I mean he also mentioned that he was
looking to William to take some of this
over do you think that he will uh
William will be active on this subject
after all he's still I mean he's got
already the Earth shot prize I think it
is that William isn't it
yes Prince William has already been
engaging on some of these environmental
questions and has been for some years
and indeed I remember a few years ago
the Duke of Edinburgh the then Prince of
Wales and the and then the Duke of
Cambridge working together on the
illegal Wildlife trade bringing together
an enormous Global Coalition of
organizations to work on on the scourge
of continued hunting of animals like
elephants and uh you know it's already
been there uh in his work and the Earth
shot you mentioned is another example of
that I was really struck on the day of
the big Saturday celebration at the time
of Her Majesty's Jubilee back in early
June this year in the evening speeches
which were given by the then Prince of
Wales and Duke of Cambridge and it was
really striking the extent to Prince
William uh going on the environmental
theme it was really very powerfully put
across uh by him the need to be taking a
different approach on sustaining the
natural world and avoiding the worst of
climate change it was a message that
could equally have come from his father
and I don't know if that was some kind
of uh sense of the Baton being handed on
but it did seem like that uh up to a
point and you know I think it's worth
just reflecting on the extent of which
you know that this has been an Endeavor
that hasn't only been the prince of
Wales in his previous Incarnation his
father as I say was very very strongly
engaged with this work including through
being president of of WWF International
for a long time uh alongside other work
that he did uh including being involved
in the early days with the setting up of
the wildfowl and wetlands trust so this
is something that you can chart across
the decades and across the family uh and
I wouldn't be at all surprised if we see
a more prominent role now for Prince
William uh in taking this this
discussion further
okay Tony Juniper good to talk to you
thanks for coming on thank you bye-bye
right what about uh what's Happening
Here Sky's Kamali Melbourne is among the
crowds of people still coming here still
Gathering here to pay their respects to
the queen Kamali
thank you Mark yeah and they are still
Gathering I mean people just keep
walking along the mountains I don't know
if you can pick this up over there
there's about 10 people deep there
gathered along the railings
um waiting here to pay their respects
now the security guards have told us
there are no more Royal movements today
and the security guards just here in
front of us are trying to move the
barriers forward to create more space
because people keep arriving I've been
here since about seven o'clock this
morning and uh there have been just tens
of thousands of people coming it's
always hard to judge the crowd numbers
but the police were expecting there to
be millions of people coming every
single day as you can see they're making
a bit more space because it's coming a
bit of a bottleneck there are so many
people who are coming here to try and
pay their respects to the queen
obviously with uh our new king the best
of luck and Katie has come in here thank
you so much for talking to us let's come
here with these your girls hello guys
why did you decide to come down here
today okay pay some respects what she's
done for our country is amazing so this
is what we can do to say thank you then
it's a small price to pay it how long
have you been waiting here to sort of
see this one o'clock this afternoon did
you get to see him drive in we didn't
know because it was just too many people
it was just so many people so we've come
back this afternoon to try and hopefully
get from Rosie are you just waiting
hoping that he comes out again yeah and
then we've got flowers to lay in tribute
so it's really it's a really lovely
thing to do isn't it what'd you make of
like the people you've been around so
overwhelming so overwhelming but it's a
real calm sort of somber atmosphere it's
it's really lovely it's kind of quiet
isn't it but like a really respectful
sort of calm it is really respectful
like really calm sort of yeah really
comforting really yeah I mean it's
really nice in so many families here as
well I know you said you didn't want to
talk to me what do you you want to say a
little something you're live until
you're right your sis your sister will
say something why do you think it's
important to come here say something for
the queen she's done a lot for our
country and I think the least we could
do is pay a little bit of respect for by
laying flowers and greeting the new king
you're happy to hang out here you've
been here quite a few hours now you
might be waiting a little bit longer I
know my legs are hurting but it's not
too bad it's worth it it shows the
commitment that you've gotten the
respect that you've got for the royal
family thank you so much Katie we love
your speech have a good evening I hope
you have to wait too much longer hope he
does come out look people as I said just
keep coming there we go uh thousands
here I mean as I said the police are
expecting there to be at least two
million businesses every day and that's
the same thing that we hear from
everyone Katie telling us that it's
worth the wait to try and show their
respect and their love for the royal
family the passing of the queen and
giving the best of starts to the new
king
Kamali thank you very much indeed with
me now as the former Royal press
secretary Patrick Harrison thank you so
much for being let's just talk about uh
what Kamali was talking about and this I
mean it's an endless queue of people
just patiently waiting very slowly
coming up to the Palace yes indeed and
they want to be part of History don't
they but I'm sure many of them also
would have laid flowers
and take a moment to reflect upon her
majesty and um it's quite interesting
it's quite quiet for a very big crowd
it's quite quiet isn't it and then you
get the occasional cheer as someone goes
past or a car emerges
um so yeah and it's fascinating that
they they keep coming and we'll continue
to do so and those images that we saw
earlier the people coming out who watch
the uh the very sad spectacle of the
Queen's Cortez that was well it was just
overwhelming but it was incredibly
moving wasn't it when we saw the coffin
for the very first time in emerged from
Balmoral and starters the king said her
last great journey and people in towns
in villages the farmers that you
featured earlier paying their respects
uh quietly for most of the route and
then just a ripple of Applause when the
when the coffin finally came into to
Edinburgh
now you worked for the then Prince of
Wales now King what sort of King I mean
if anything is to go about the first few
days it's going to suggest that he's
going to be a very hard-working King
well he's an incredibly hard-working man
I've never worked for anybody more
hard-working than the Prince of Wales as
he was our King uh now I remember a time
when we were on a flight over to uh to
America on a commercial flight and
everybody in the Entourage was watching
one of the films there was only one
person working and that was the then
Prince of Wales very very committed we
know incredibly passionate about the
issues and the comma and the Charities
as he was Prince of Wales but also that
great sense of public duty he's been in
public service for over 50 years and it
would be that sense of Duty that will
guide him now well I mean we were
listening to Tony Juniper there he was
talking about
his passion for the environment and
those other issues and
he's also got you know other subjects
like the Commonwealth to deal with
meeting the high Commissioners today but
on things like the environment
presumably he's now going to have to
slightly Reign things in well he made it
very clear a couple of years ago that he
clearly understood the difference
between being Prince of Wales and being
King and he won't be able to do all the
things that he he did previously in fact
a few years ago his charity some of his
main Charities were put on a slightly
more independent footing you know in
anticipation of today
but the environment is is something that
we all have consensus around now and uh
and I for one am thrilled that we have a
head of state who cares so deeply about
an issue which affects all our lives now
talk to me a bit about what will be
going on in the Palaces right now
clearly it's a very busy week
culminating with the funeral but that
will have been planned in the most my
new detail already meticulously and I
remember remember working on the plans
of London Bridge as it's known you know
15 20 years ago and of course they
evolve over time these plans but yes
every detail meticulously covered with a
few final decisions to be made at the
time uh we're just seeing
someone come through now
we've got a we've got an escort we have
the cheers
yes it's the uh I think
difficult to us
um King Charles I think that might be
King Charles yes
coming past
[Applause]
and this of course is what the crowd has
been waiting for for a number of hours
now to get a glimpse yes it is it is him
get a glimpse of their new king as he
goes past
yes
and they come past because he doesn't
seem to be living at the palace he's
living at Clarence House and saying yeah
so of course Clarence House was up until
Thursday
um his London residence and so a lot of
the uh a lot of his personal effects but
also of course staff and offices are all
operating still out of Clarence house as
well as Buckingham Palace and you were
talking about the minute planning going
into this would you say that things are
going to plan absolutely uh 100 going to
plan at the moment and uh you know
various people have said that it's been
Pitch Perfect to date and I would
definitely agree with that
and what kind of funeral do you think we
can expect clearly a state funeral yes a
state funeral and and a moment when the
eyes of the world really are on this on
this country and uh we've got a a number
of really emotional moments until before
then of course uh not least
um the vigil at St Giles tomorrow when
uh the king will uh keep vigil by his
mother's coffin and then of course the
funeral Monday week is the sort of
climax of everything that leads up to
that and um and the eyes of the world
very much on it and we'll have of course
representatives from countries all over
the world at that event it's interesting
isn't it meeting the
um secretary a general of the
Commonwealth and the high commissioners
of the commonwealth countries he seems
very relaxed about the Commonwealth it
obviously means a lot to him but in
terms of some countries
what you know resetting the relationship
he seems he says look you know these
countries have to decide for themselves
absolutely you know he's always said you
know I'm here to serve as long as you
want me basically and that that's his
view but you'll see how important it is
to him the fact that meeting the high
Commissioners tonight
um you know that that's uh one of the
priorities of his new Reign but we're
only in the third day of it and already
uh that that's one of the key priorities
[Applause]
yeah I'm totally has gone to Clarence
House so um
um he's gone home for a while so I mean
just finally on William and Harry and
those pictures yesterday
um this is difficult time for the for
the brothers do you think they were
right to do that yeah I absolutely think
they were right to do it and I think
they uh I think they took their cue from
their father in that first address that
he made to the nation that wonderful
heartfelt address where he paid tribute
to his mother his wife Camilla but also
to both of his sons I thought that was
very significant and I think they picked
up on that and uh and I think it was
wonderful to see them go out together
with their wives all right thank you
very much indeed for now uh we'll be
back with you a little later I'm joined
now uh by a former conservative Minister
Sir Nicholas soames who's also the
grandson of Sir Winston Churchill and a
close friend I should say of uh King
Charles good of you to join us today and
just first of all
the pictures that we have been
witnessing today with the Queen's Cortez
I wonder what you made of those
well good evening Mark
um
I thought they were deeply touching and
very moving and
I was particularly struck with I
happened to switch on to see the uh the
Queen's Her Majesty's late match She's
coughing going through domji but there
were enormous crowds enormous cries
and then I thought the arrival in Ember
at the palace of Hollywood was
unbelievably dignified ensomber I mean
these are
very very historic and somber days and
um the ritual and the procedure is being
carried out absolutely perfectly in my
view it's immaculate
yes and the reaction uh in the last
couple of days clearly shows the
affection in which she was held across
this country
I don't think there's any doubt about
that at all and um I think um the crowds
uh in London and elsewhere are absolute
evidence of that I think people find
themselves
much sadder I think than anyone sort of
thought is interesting hearing the
interviews with people who some of whom
have never bothered to come to things
like this before who turned out to watch
how that match did go past
and um I think it has commanded immense
respect and affection
and of course the fact that she died in
Scotland a place that she loved very
very much indeed and is coming home to
her royal palace of Hollywood
uh in embra I I think he's very symbolic
and her final acts public duty I should
say was to appoint a new prime minister
of course uh her first was your
grandfather and if reports are to be
believed he was her favorite
well I I don't know about that at all
but he my grandfather
had known the queen since she was a
child I mean I I you and I I mean I'm
much older than you are but frankly
we've only grown up with One Sovereign
Churchill grew up in the Reigns of six
sovereigns
um and um uh served six sovereigns in
his lifetime
uh and he had the most profound
reverence and respect
for the queen who he had known since she
was a little girl
and um he had great faith in her and I
think it's
absolutely clear that all that all that
marvelous new Elizabethan age he talked
about it was
admirably fulfilled by 70 years of
impeccable service by the queen
and what do you think was so special
about the relationship between the queen
and your grandfather
well I don't think it's possible to tell
I mean I think the fact that obviously
my grandfather had been her father's
prime minister throughout the war
um they strongly depended on each other
my grandfather grew great strength from
The King and I think the king
uh vice versa with the King
and uh they were very they became very
close
and the queen will have known that and
um of course she inherited entirely the
throne entirely by accident I mean her
uncle abdicated her father died very
young really
and she inherited without as she said
about any apprenticeship at all and I
think he was able to provide tremendous
stability and experience for her
um and I don't think
he would ever have I mean he wouldn't he
wouldn't he he wouldn't have been fault
as a patronizing figure I think he was
genuinely wise and sage and I think she
would have depended on him
and so Nicholas is your friend King
Charles ready for what is to come
well he has inherited uh the throne the
crown has passed to him I think he
is very ready he served very long time
Apprentice he's sat at the feet of his
mother who must be one of the greatest
moments this country has ever had he's
well aware of his duty and always has
been and I think his duty and service
and loyalty to
his his people has been impeccable
already and he will now I think do this
very well but these are very sad days
and I think it's worth remembering but
you know when you look at the royal
family today and um that's rather
touching photographs of them yesterday
looking at the flowers at Balmoral well
I have to remember that you know they
only lost Prince Philip 18 months ago
another queen herself has died and these
are these are heavy days for them and
and
um I I think it's clear that the whole
nation extends our sympathy to the Royal
Family
indeed and just finally
the very personal statements that we've
had from King Charles and from his son
yesterday and all the walkabouts and the
close contact with the public and the
handshakes and the hugs does this
suggest to you a different monarchy
emerging now
well clearly it's a different Monarch so
and each Monarch
acts in the way that they think is best
but he's a younger monarch
um he's well aware of the uh of the um
of the interests and the sensitivities
of these people is extremely empathetic
for Prince Wales he understands very
well people's feelings
um and I think we saw the other night
how strong is the connection
um but these are very early days and um
yeah there are many many bridges to
negotiate
um but I believe personally that
this great machine of the British
constitution has
seamlessly passed in a way that has been
rather marvelous to watch and I think it
was very enlightened that the cameras
filmed the accession council I think
that you know and I'm I'm sure will be
more more of that too
so Nicholas it's good of you to come on
thank you very much indeed thank you
well the Australian prime minister
Anthony Albanese has told Sky News that
he will not hold a referendum on whether
Australia should become a republic in
his first term in his first
International interview since the
Queen's death Mr Albanese said this was
a moment to show gratitude for the
Queen's service he was speaking to our
correspondent Cordelia Lynch
the sights the sounds of a new Sovereign
a ceremony for a new era in Australia
under a king
the queen was adored here in death they
honor her
even those uncertain about the
institution
the Prime Minister a republican himself
leading the tributes this is a land of
cyclones of floods of natural disasters
and Queen Elizabeth always reached out
to give that Comfort to Australians at
our time of need and she was such a a
respected figure regardless of where
people stand on the political spectrum
that 70 years of public service that
that Devotion to duty is something that
holds her in in such high regard part of
the success of Queen Elizabeth reign
here seems to be that people perceived
her as being politically neutral do you
think her son will be able to achieve
that too I'm sure he's very conscious of
the need to be above politics and he
certainly has always been that in terms
of of Australia this of course is is a
substantial change the the only monarch
that we have known in my lifetime and in
the lifetime of most Australians has
been uh Queen Elizabeth it's reignited a
debate about a republic do you think in
this moment that that is appropriate so
perhaps even opportunistic
well I I am the person of you and I've
made it uh clear that now is the time
for us to pay tribute
to the life of Queen Elizabeth II to
give thanks uh for her service to
Australia to the Commonwealth and to the
world and that is the focus that I have
when it comes to the monarchy do you
think though Australians want to see the
institution evolve
uh will of course and and it has evolved
and it will continue uh to evolve uh it
will need to continue to move with the
times but the bigger questions about our
Constitution are not ones for uh this
current period uh this is a period in
which uh we are showing the grief that
so many Australians are feeling at the
moment showing our deep respect and
admiration for the contribution of the
queen to Australia and she certainly had
a powerful connection and we've
witnessed that firsthand here in
Australia and just to confirm though no
referendum in in your first term no
in recent days some politicians have
openly pushed for a second referendum
but the man running the country isn't
ready and neither are they
they just want the right words to say
goodbye Cordelia Lynch Sky News Canberra
Australia
well throughout her life and her Reign
the queen held a unique position on the
world stage as the head of state for 15
Commonwealth Nations but beyond the
Commonwealth the queen also wielded soft
power through her enduring International
popularity and as a key tool of British
diplomacy uh International Elders the
Dominic waghorn reflects now on the
Queen's Global reach
I mean I just do went ashore accompanied
by the governor of Fiji she reinvented
monarchy and took it to the world from
Young Queen to Global Mega star she was
incredibly popular I mean she was like
this multimedia star the lifetime of
travels would Circle the planet 40 times
over
as the world changed beyond recognition
Queen Elizabeth remained constant
confidante and Confessor to presidents
and prime ministers
what's quite extraordinary is the love
and affection they had for her and
champion of a commonwealth of Nations
and it's two and a half billion people
their ability to come to your level and
tell you that you're doing a good work
meant almost everything to me as Queen
of Canada for nearly six decades
remains undimmed
we've become used to seeing the queen on
the world stage but it was a role she
envisaged even before being crowned I
declare before you all
her life whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and for the service of our great
Imperial family to which we all belong
it was a promise you would honor from
the very beginning barely six months
after her coronation embarking on a tour
of the Commonwealth
[Music]
the royal couple Drew enormous crowds
welcome was the word formed by some of
the 17 000 children on Melbourne cricket
ground there was no doubt they emitted
it was clear that this was going to be a
very different kind of monarch the queen
when she came to the throne she was very
young but she had very clear ideas of
how she wanted to shape her role and
definitively travel and international
collaboration and building an
International Community and particularly
the Commonwealth was so important to her
the queen and Prince Philip toured the
Commonwealth for six months taking in
its vast size and diversity
by the end the young Queen was already
becoming a global icon
the status cemented a few years later
when she took New York by storm
Americans came out in their thousands
inside the great Assembly Hall 2500
delegates and their wives Rose to greet
the queen
when the queen went on her visit in the
early days no one had any idea she'd be
so popular they had no idea there'd be
thousands of people the advisors were
really quite surprised by the level of
popularity level of fascinated level of
the fact that everyone seemed to be out
there on the street who wants to see a
glimpse of the queen and she was
incredibly popular I mean she was like
this
multimedia star she was like the
ultimate celebrity bigger than a
Hollywood celebrity on the maintenance
of understanding between us
the future of the Free World depends
she was already mastering the Arts of
soft power her personal chemistry with
leader after leader would prove one of
her most effective assets
saw her with leaders like President
Yeltsin and sort of again the level of
conversation and confidence
ability to to observe your Discretions
and and secrets were very high and I
think you know got on well because he
respected the queen of having
some enduring qualities that are not
related to politics or the stage of
gioract politically
but if you could claim to be on an equal
footing with the queen Nelson Mandela
was one I mean she could speak very
frankly with him because he was a prince
in his own tribe so in that sense he had
an easy way with the queen he's the only
head of state I've ever heard called The
Queen Elizabeth
at home the queen hosted world leaders
some of them less Savory than others but
treated them all with the same decorum
and Royal welcome her role was far from
just ceremonial she had a diplomatic
importance with a global reach and depth
politicians could only dream of we in
Britain have often underestimated the
immense impact that the queen had on the
whole of the world with America she'd
met 14 U.S presidents nobody in the
world not even in America has met 14
presidents and then take a place like
Ireland she was pivoted all in bringing
about that reproachment between Britain
and Ireland in 2011. so a hugely
understated but very significant
influence globally the monarchy
continues the monarchy will always
continue that's what it's designed to do
but will anybody coming in now have that
same clout that same footprint on world
history obviously not the queen and Duke
of driving the Queen's ambition above
all was a passion for the Commonwealth
to say something good rise out of the
end of Empire Secretary General says the
queen played a unique role for all of
its leaders
you could tell her anything and she'd
never talk about it and she had the
wisdom and the generosity to listen and
then to give really Sage quiet advice
and so I think if you had the privilege
as a number of us have of seeing her
interact with them what's quite
extraordinary is the love and affection
they had for her I commend the Queen's
young leaders of 2018 but the Queen's
love for people extended far beyond
leaders and politicians she had a
passion for the Youth of the
Commonwealth like Derek Omari who set up
a charity for disabled children in Ghana
age 19 singled out by her majesty for
the Queen's youth leader Awards it was
it was a day that
nobody ever thought about I know where I
grew up never ever thought of in my life
that I even leave Ghana to the UK and
then come all the way to the backyard
Palace and be honored and and one of the
things that really left that that that
has gotten stuck with me was the chance
to meet her in person
have a conversation with her
humanness and their ability to come to
your level and tell you that you're
doing a good work keep doing it keep
going on and we are proud of you meant
almost everything
for Rihanna Patterson recognized for
setting up a dementia charity the queen
was a personal inspiration she was a
young person taking on this leadership
role and she had to kind of
find herself in it quite quickly you
know there was a lot of formalities a
lot of rules a lot to take in and it was
something that was quite sudden
um so I think she is relatable in that
regard like taking on The Stance at a
young age
the woman who took on so much in her 20s
would go on inspiring so many other
young people like her for decades and
carry on traveling for as long as her
health would let her
the queen transformed the monarchy
turning it into a globetrotting
multimedia phenomenon years ahead of her
time letting Britain punch above its
weight in the world and leading a
commonwealth of Nations a death leaves a
void as she has mourned by hundreds of
millions far beyond these Shores Dominic
wagorn Sky News
well the labor leader sakir starmer has
been speaking about the Queen's Legacy
and Antigua's plans to hold a referendum
on becoming a republic let's bring in
our chief political correspondent John
Craig and John Liz trussov on this tour
with the King these political
relationships very important for King
Charles
yes what's happening is that the prime
minister is going to Scotland uh Wales
and Northern Ireland with the prime
minister with it with the new king and
uh and uh Queen consort this week
sirma meanwhile uh has uh was was asked
about comments by uh Gaston Brown now he
is the Prime Minister of Antigua and
Barbuda and he has talked about the
possibility of a referendum on
Independence there within the next three
years he said this is not an act of
hostility or difference between Antigua
and Barbuda and the Monarch uh it's the
fact uh it's the final step he said uh
to uh him to complete the circle of
Independence as he called it this was uh
circus response to a question about that
well I think across the Commonwealth
it's very important to recognize that
every country will evolve in its own way
according to their tradition and their
wishes I think the king will be an
incredible head of the Commonwealth and
has an ability to bring people together
I know that he has a very very deep
commitment to the Commonwealth so of
course different countries will evolve
in different ways but I think that the
king will strengthen that bond with the
Commonwealth
so while Australia's new prime minister
saying no to an independence referendum
there for uh three years or so as well
as Antigua and Barbara Buddha in the
Caribbean uh this talk of uh
Independence in Jamaica uh there were it
was criticism of William and Kate over
their visit uh when they were criticized
for shaking hands with the crowds before
behind YMS benches fences giving a
colonial impression by riding on a open
top jeep which was considered not the
right not right tone at all
um so that that is a challenge for the
new monarch and indeed for the new prime
minister now this coming week in
Westminster there are many more events
in a few minutes time there's a service
in the parliament's church queen king
said Margaret's just opposite to the
Palace of Westminster tomorrow Charles
and Camilla will be in the uh in the
Westminster Hall the old Hall inside the
houses of Parliament where they will
receive speeches from the speaker sir
Lindsay Hoyle Lord speaker Lord John the
Lord speaker as the the Lord speaker
there and also then we've got this tour
coming up later in the week and then
Wednesday of course the lying in state
also in Westminster Hall of the queen
and I can tell you that around
Westminster there are massive
preparations going on already for the
huge crowds that are expected for that
okay John thank you very much indeed and
here at Buckingham Palace that's still
the people come just this endless stream
of people
um they were here
um
all day yesterday all day today still
they come there's no sign of an end to
it all the way down the mall it's very
carefully controlled but they come very
slowly down with their floral tributes
to pay their respects to the queen it's
been another remarkable day and this is
why uh the Queen's Cortez we've been
watching that for uh much of the day 170
mile Journey it has made through
aberdeenshire Angus and tayside Fife
before reaching Edinburgh and now the
queen is lying at rest in the Palace of
Hollywood house
overnight
it is six o'clock this is Sky News live
from Hollywood house in Edinburgh
a last great journey the Queen's coffin
leaves Balmoral for Scotland's capital
foreign
people line the streets and Roads as the
hearse made its way across Scotland
before eventually arriving in Edinburgh
where her children paid their respects
to Buckingham Palace
thank you
where the new King has held meetings
with the Commonwealth and the realm
as outside crowds gathered to get a
glimpse of their king and the queen
consort but also to pay tribute to the
late Queen
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign also proclamations for King
Charles III held around the four nations
and the queen is remembered around the
world and in an international exclusive
Australia's prime minister tells Sky
News there'll be no break with the
monarchy in the near future
it will need to continue to move with
the times but the bigger questions about
our Constitution are not ones for this
current period
thank you
hello good evening you're watching Sky
News at 6 live from Edinburgh people
have had their final chance to say
farewell to Elizabeth II as a hearse
carrying her coffin took a final journey
through Scotland leaving Balmoral this
morning the Cortez included the Princess
Royal and her husband sir Timothy
Lawrence
well it has now arrived here in
Edinburgh where it will rest at the
palace of Hollywood house until tomorrow
afternoon Skies James Matthews has this
report
through the gates of Balmoral it was the
quietest farewell
brutal aberdeenshire it's bird song and
the rumble of the river D played the
soundtrack for a sight most sadness
the hairs carried the Queen's coffin
wrapped in the Royal Standard of
Scotland the wreath on top was made from
her favorite flowers picked from the
Balmoral guard
in the car behind the queen was escorted
by her daughter the Princess Royal and
her husband sir Tim Lawrence
the geography of circumstance had placed
the queen in Balmoral when she passed
at Johnny's end there will be a state
funeral set piece ceremony and all that
but between here and there this was an
informal farewell an opportunity for the
public to say their goodbyes
in balater near Balmoral they line the
streets here they knew her as the queen
next door their Village was her Village
it's so fond of this area
it's just a very sad day for us all
very emotional today and very paid to be
part of the United Kingdom so yeah
it was so dignified more than I thought
it would have been
in the hush
as as she came through
and then you could hear this open it's
not I had that stuff myself
find it
to be a motivator family member it's
just to be really upsetting
tractors were positioned by the side of
the road an agricultural guard of Honor
as the Cortez wound a route through
rural Scotland
horse riders too formed up in a field by
the roadside as it made it slow six-hour
Journey South
this journey had been meticulously
planned
even if there was no public rehearsal
here in Bank area there was Applause
[Applause]
else elsewhere there was silent
everywhere there was respect and
Remembrance
it was it was quite overwhelming to be
honest I'm very very proud to be here
I've never come along to anything like
this before but just really felt that I
wanted it was it was important it was
beautiful once in a lifetime it's not
gonna happen again
people line dual carriageways linking
Aberdeen Dundee and Edinburgh Beyond and
they looked on from walkways overhead
closer to Edinburgh the Cortez crossed
the fourth of Fourth
via the Queensbury crossing a bridge
officially opened by the queen in 2017.
members of the royal family had traveled
ahead by helicopter to fulfill their
duties
once in Edinburgh the Queen's coffin was
driven through the streets towards
Hollywood in the city's Old Town
[Applause]
the Royal Regiment of Scotland formed a
guard of honor at the palace of
Hollywood homes and the Queen's coffin
was received with a royal salute
it's being placed in the throne room
overnight to allow Palace staff to pay
their respect
as the queen was carried inside a
daughter cuts it to her mother her Duty
done
this was day one of the Queen's long
goodbye which will span a nation that
grew with her and Having learned of her
loss is learning to live with it
James Matthews Sky News in balloter
well Joe Pike is at St Giles Cathedral
where crowds paid their respects to the
queen and Joe the rain holding off until
moments after the Queen's coffin made it
safely into the palace behind me but for
you amidst the crowds there as the
Cortez made its way down edinburgh's
Royal mile
yes and uh the crowds were 10 to 15
people deep calm uh pretty hushed as
they waited hour after hour for a
glimpse of the Cortez and of the Queen's
coffin a real range of people I spoke to
some freshers from University one who
had arrived in the city to start a new
life in their education at University
yesterday and what an introduction to
Scotland's capital others tourists who
changed their plans to witness some
history happen in front of them the
Cortez passed this big Edinburgh
Landmark behind me Saint Giles Cathedral
the high Kirk of Edinburgh a medieval
Parish church that has adapted and
evolved over the years just as the royal
family the monarchy has in front of it
watching over that Cortez and that hurts
as it passed this statue of the fifth
Duke of the clue a significant figure of
19th century Scotland and a man who
would have recognized many of the
Traditions the ceremonies we have seen
and we've all witnessed in recent days
because in the 1800s he was a part of
them tomorrow this will be at the heart
of the next stage of Scottish
commemorations the new king will join
the procession from Hollywood house
behind the Cortez behind his mother's
hearse before a church service takes
place at this Kirk at St Giles Cathedral
then Anna there will be that 24-hour
vigil to give Scots the chance to pay
tribute to their Queen
Joe Pike thank you very much indeed
there from Saint Charles Cathedral the
high Kirk
[Applause]
well the queen of the royal family have
been and are dedicated to their faith
attending of course that special
Christmas service at Sandringham every
year and of course today Sunday the
queen has been remembered in churches
right across the country Katarina
vitotsi has been to a service in
Liverpool and has this report
she is the only monarch most of us have
ever known
and today at Liverpool Parish Church the
lake Queen was mourned by some like a
member of family
this was a special Requiem service
chance to remember an extraordinary life
we give you thanks
for her love of family and her gift of
friendship
for her Devotion to this nation and the
nations of the Commonwealth
the Queen's passing brings Global
cultural change
and a new National Anthem with
unfamiliar words
Arthur speed who's 77 remembers the
previous King but the late Queen became
his constant
ly
what a lovely lovely lady lovely
and when I was at sea
every Friday seven o'clock we should
charge the queen
but we've got to look forward to King
Charles
hopefully he'll do as good as in mum
I'm sure he will
church services like this one held here
today and those indeed across the
country and the Commonwealth have given
people a chance to pay tribute to the
late Queen but in many ways they also
reflect the way in which Queen Elizabeth
II lived her own life
coronation 70 years ago the queen
pledged to lead the Church of England
but the public pageantry was matched by
personal faith
seen in times of Celebration like
Christmas day trips to church
or more recently at the funeral of her
late husband
[Music]
her role as defender of the faith will
be remembered a late Majesty taught us
much
if not more
about God and Grace
both in words and the actions that
reinforce them
than any other contemporary figure
Queen once said her faith guided her
through good times and bad it feels then
particularly poignant the places of
worship like Litchfield cathedral in
Staffordshire have become such focal
points during this time of national
mourning it's just like the nation's
Grandma weren't you she just everyone
just looked there there was nothing not
to love about her really she's really
important for everyone and a lot of
people looked up to him thought she was
amazing really I did as well
it's a sense many share
feeling many will miss
Catherine evertotsi Sky News
good evening then from Buckingham Palace
King Charles III has held meetings with
the Secretary General of the
Commonwealth as well as the high
Commissioners from the countries where
he is now head of state today's events
are just the start of a list of Duties
to the king over the coming days Sky's
Royal correspondent Laura bundock has
this report
foreign
with flourish and fanfare
[Music]
and from every corner of the United
Kingdom
[Applause]
the pageantry of proclamation and as his
Reign is confirmed
the new king already at work
head of the Commonwealth and meeting its
Representatives
he is for now Head of State in 14 Realms
but knows some are already questioning
their Royal relationship
supported by the queen consort these are
important moments for the new monarch
and on top meetings two finalizing his
mother's funeral it's an opportunity for
us to grieve it's an opportunity for us
to try and put some of our gratitude and
Remembrance into words it's an
opportunity for us to pray for ourselves
and for our new king and his family
um and it's uh it's an opportunity I
think uh for us all to have a focus for
our grief but
had it is a focal point for people
mourning the queen but as they gather
Outside Inside the king it's just
getting on with a job with his new role
and responsibilities
he is Keen to reassure that this
unsettling time taking a tour of the
Nations first stop Scotland where there
is a huge sense of expectancy I think he
has been taught well by his mother she's
a great role model for him and I
honestly think we'll see a very
compassionate king a king who will look
um to unite the country I would hope he
would continue along the path that she
tread so well and I think he'll be a
little bit more outspoken I imagine
about environmental issues and because
their cause that's close to his heart
and I think he'll probably work to
modernize the monarchy the king will
also travel to Northern Ireland and
Wales creating connections and meeting
people in the countries he now rules
Laura bundock Sky News Buckingham Palace
and Laura joins me now so a busy start
for the new king after
I King is that
that was the end of an era let's
wear it hasn't Just Begun it is already
well underway and that's what we've been
seeing as those trumpets were sounding
out with the proclamations across the
whole of the country that it was back to
business as usual and these important
meetings now taking place first up of
course we'd had yesterday uh the
political leaders coming to the palace
and today it was the turn of the
Commonwealth and the new king knows how
important these meetings are it was the
cause incredibly close to his mother as
we know but we also know there was a lot
of feeling within some of those
Commonwealth Realms questioning you know
what their future is with the British
Monarchy do they want King Charles as
head of Stace and he will have been
there as we know in Barbados last year
thinking exactly that so it's very
difficult sort of diplomatic and a
delicate meeting underway and we're only
a couple of days obviously into the job
for him and then of course meetings
about his mother's funeral at the same
time as well so incredibly busy
incredibly important and then moving on
quickly to this tour of the nation so
Scotland Northern Ireland Wales in quick
succession wanting to be seen to be out
there and I think you get a sense of how
on the one hand all this is going on and
the flowers are mounting up and people
are coming to pay their respects and no
doubt these crowds were to continue to
build particularly here in London with a
lying in state but also there's a job to
be done and day by day the new king is
taking on and taking over the duties of
that job and just briefly are we
learning a little bit each day about the
style of this monarchy what it may look
like I think we are and I think the
walkabouts say an awful lot that wanting
to be there in the crowd wanting to take
the crowd with him on this journey is he
takes over such a big and important role
so going to all the different nations
very much Keen to be seen among the
people he obviously needs to support of
the people he needs their trust he won't
have the seven decades that his mother
had in the role so he will want to do as
much as he can and I think the cheers
when he could have comes into the palace
when he left the palace just recently
will probably mean a lot he knows he's
preaching to the converted here with
these crowds but of course going to
Scotland being in Northern Ireland being
in Wales a big moment for him as he as I
say takes on and visits these countries
for the first time as their head of
state Laura thank you very much
but I'm joined now by the former Chief
of the defense staff Lord Janet thank
you very much indeed for being with us
and
I guess I'm asking this question of
everybody really just those images that
we've been watching all day Lord Janet
of the Queen's Cortez moving through
aberdeenshire and on to Edinburgh and
the people coming out I just wonder what
you made of those pictures
well I think we're witnessing truly
dramatic scenes at the present time and
as your report has been covering just in
the last few minutes there's really two
stories running here of course the
nation is grieving and quite properly
grieving for the late Queen Elizabeth II
and the images that'll be on the screens
all all day today of the motor Cortes
moving slowly from Balmoral to Hollywood
absolutely sum up this aspect of our
beloved Queen's last journey but then
today all around the country following
on from the proclamation in London
yesterday there have been proclamations
of the new king all around the country
we've been involved here in Norfolk in
in uh up and down the country up and
down the county today and so people are
very much thinking in two directions
this morning the queen but actually also
looking ahead with hope and anticipation
to the new Reign to to King Charles III
and
but forgive me if there's anything until
presumptuous but I think that
having listened to the new king speaking
on his first evening it's been very
reassuring to people that this
extraordinary Unwritten British
constitution is unfolding one chapter
ending in another chapter ending but
another chapter beginning in a very
seamless sort of fashion and I think
this idea of continuity I think is very
reassuring yes we must be on the state
funeral being really important on Monday
but there is there is a new chapter eye
opening as well
absolutely and for the Armed Forces she
was the queen clearly but she was also a
commander-in-chief how important was
that
well it's very important because all of
us who have joined the Royal Navy in the
Army Royal air force Royal Marines we
all on our very first day held a Bible
in one hand and swore an oath of
allegiance to the Sovereign actually
what one forgot at the time was we were
so pledging our allegiance to the
Sovereign harriers and successors so at
the moment that Queen Elizabeth II
breathed her last and and passed away
but then died that actually our
Allegiance moved to the new king
straight away because our oath was to
the queen her heirs and successes so our
Allegiance has transferred quickly to
the new King King Charles so that's
another aspect really important to
continuity and again this is another
really important aspect about the
wonderful British constitution
um those of us who serve in uniform risk
life and limb for the nation we don't do
it for the government or the prime
minister or the Secretary of State for
defense we do it in the name of the
Sovereign and for the people of this
country and that that's very special and
it's a really key core part of the
motivation that makes morale amongst
British Armed Forces so hardly our
expertise frankly so good
yes and just on a personal level like
either you've met her a few times your
your wife am I right and saying
um was or is the Queen's representative
in Norfolk Lord Lieutenant is that right
so you've you've met them uh the met the
queen a few times
um give us a sense of
what she was like
well you're right I mean um I've met the
queen a number of times as was my wife
and you say my wife is daughter of
Norfolk
um I think the thing about it when you
first meet the queen and I met her when
I was really quite a young man like
everybody meeting her for the first time
you're a little bit Panic struck you're
not quite sure what to say and what to
do but if you're fortunate enough to
meet her on more than one occasion then
actually you can get through that sort
of blind panic bit and actually realize
that you've got a very human very
inquiring very interesting very
sympathetic person and actually I've sat
next to her at lunch on a couple of
occasions and you get to talk in an
extended period of time and you realize
that you're talking to a very well read
very well informed
um given the age difference
um sort of Grandmother type figure and
that is a huge privilege and a huge
pleasure there was there was I would say
nobody better informed about what was
going on in this country than um than
the late Queen right up until her last
day last Thursday you've just seen the
pictures of them saying goodbye to her
14th Minister on welcoming her 15th last
Tuesday absolutely on the wall Trail but
on the wall and then died less than 48
hours later that's real Devotion to duty
that's what soldiers say the same and
Marines really really respect someone
who does their Duty and earns the right
there portal leaders very happy to be
led by her as we will be happy to be led
by King Charles III
and Lord Danny I wonder if I could just
have a very brief work with you about
events in Ukraine and it seems there has
been some potentially significant uh
progress by the Ukrainian forces in the
last
uh well few days
well yes what we've actually seen over
the last few days is a very clever
operational level design for battle
um if you recall uh just very briefly
they've been talking about an offensive
in the South around the area of Curson
the gateway to Crimea and that led the
Russians to move quite a lot of their
best troops from the donbass area round
to the South to reinforce around Kirsten
but in fact what the what the ukrainians
have done is carry out a major attack in
the north around Hakim they've pushed
forward a long way they've captured
cupions which is a major Logistics Hub
of the Russians causing absolute Mayhem
for the Russian's five railway lines
come in there all that has now fallen to
the ukrainians so the ukrainians have
actually pulled off what we would call
an operational level coup they've done
extraordinarily well by threatening in
the South and then attacking in the
north it's deceived everybody all of us
commentators were thinking they were
going to attack counter-attack in the
South but actually they've made a major
counter-attack in the north and it's
been very successful just last me of
course
the morale is a major issue here I think
the
Russians morale will be Rock Bottom at
the present moment and with the
ukrainians rushing at them well while
the ukrainians morale is Sky High
and just finally do you think it could
be a turning point in this conflict or
is it too early to say that I think it's
too early
um it takes more than one swallow to
make a summer but this is a significant
move by the ukrainians the question is
whether they can back it up with they
can follow it up they will need more and
more a western high-tech arms and
ammunition but um as you know we in the
UK have been training uh hundreds
thousands of Ukrainian infantry well
these are now feeding back onto the
front line their school level is going
up their equipment capability is going
up whereas the Russians are struggling
with Manpower old kit a lot of it that
doesn't work and now they're on the back
foot
um and the ukrainians Frontline troops
are tearing into their lines of
communication their doctors and
hospitals and nurses are all being being
withdrawn they're they're in a model the
Russians at the present moment question
how far can the ukrainians keep this up
okay Lord Janet uh thanks very much for
being with us appreciate it thanks Mark
right let's get back to events uh we're
dealing with here and uh the Cortez of
the queen heading to Edinburgh uh today
and people here at Buckingham Palace
still come in vast numbers to pay their
respects with me now as the former Royal
press secretary Patrick Harrison and
um just give me your sense of the day I
mean here and and those
pictures from Scotland well they keep
coming don't they Mark as you said and
um I I'm struck by we're now getting
into the evening it's dinner time for
many people but that doesn't seem to be
the primary consideration that it's a
very well controlled operation you can
see them being held up there and they go
all the way up the mall I think and
they're being let through gradually and
of course I remember when I organized
helped to organize the the wedding of
Prince William back in 2011. what you're
seeing just here outside Buckingham
Palace is a number of different agencies
all working together the Royal Parks the
Metropolitan Police the palace
authorities and of course the media as
as well see here these images you really
don't get the sense of the people who
are on either side of the of the um of
the mouth and you know there's a
constant cue and they come and they pay
their respects and then they move on and
all come through absolutely which is
wonderful and early on today of course
as as we been reflecting the movement of
the lake Queen's coffin from Balmoral
down to Edinburgh that was a very very
poignant moment wasn't it when we saw
the coffin for the very first time and
it was it was the moment what we see the
transition of the coffee moving from
just the family out to the general
public and the general public lining the
streets and and and uh quietly
reflecting as as it goes past and into
Edinburgh and the new king you worked
with him as Prince of Wales for a long
time
um
is he ready for this do you think
absolutely yes I mean we we must
remember that he has been in public
service for over 50 years and of course
in recent years has been taking many of
the duties uh of of the late Queen so
investigators of course for a number of
years as does uh Prince William
um but also the state opening in
Parliament we saw recently
um he obviously represented the the late
Queen at the Commonwealth heads of
government in Rwanda as well this is a
man who has spent his life in public
service and uh absolutely ready to to be
our King as I think we've seen over the
last few days and these as we see here I
mean receptions today meetings today
here the Secretary General of the
Commonwealth High Commissioners and so
forth I mean he's got off to a busy it's
an incredibly busy schedule but of
course you have to remember these are
all people that he knows well this isn't
somebody coming into a job who doesn't
already have these relationships he
knows these people very well he's
traveled to many of the countries
um that they represent uh and uh and it
was the longest apprenticeship in the
world
yes indeed and of course he did that did
all those public duties and those Royal
duties alongside his own interests as
well as Prince of Wales those Royal
duties that he's done for many many
years continue as our King and this
whole idea of William taking on some of
the I don't know whether he'll take on
precisely the same issues as as Charles
but he will move into that kind of space
yes I mean very quickly appointed Prince
of Wales and of course he's
automatically the Duke of Hallmark so
now looking after the duchy of Cornwall
and I think we can expect to see him
also take on other other duties uh in
support of the king and finally quick
word those images yesterday William and
Harry together I mean you know it was on
the front pages of all the papers I
don't know how it was organized who
decided it should happen but was it a
good idea I think it was a fantastic
idea it was a wonderful seat to see the
two brothers with their wives uh
chatting to the crowds there and I think
they took their cue from the king who in
that first heartfelt address not only
paid tribute to his mother but also
reflected on his love for his wife and
both his sons William and Harry
yeah Patrick for now thank you very much
indeed
well throughout her life and her Reign
the queen held a unique position on the
world stage as the head of state for 15
Commonwealth Nations but beyond uh the
Commonwealth the queen also wielded soft
power through her enduring International
popularity and as a key tool of British
diplomacy International Affairs editor
Dominic waghorn reflects now on the
Queen's Global reach
Manchester went ashore accompanied by
the governor of Fiji she reinvented
monarchy and took it to the world from
Young Queen to Global Mega star she was
incredibly popular I mean she was like
this multimedia star the lifetime of
travels would Circle the planet 40 times
over
as the world changed beyond recognition
Queen Elizabeth remained constant
confidante and Confessor to presidents
and prime ministers
what's quite extraordinary is the love
and affection they had for her and
champion of a commonwealth of Nations
and it's two and a half billion people
their ability to come to your level and
tell you that you're doing a good work
meant almost everything to me as Queen
of Canada for nearly six decades
age three remains undimmed we've become
used to seeing the queen on the world
stage but it was a role she envisaged
even before being crowned I declare
before you all
my whole life whether it be long or
short shall be devoted to your service
enter the service of our great Imperial
family to which we all belong it was a
promise you would honor from the very
beginning barely six months after her
coronation embarking on a tour of the
Commonwealth
[Music]
the royal couple Drew enormous crowds
welcome was the word formed by some of
the Year 17 000 children on Melbourne
cricket ground there was no doubt they
admitted it was clear that this was
going to be a very different kind of
monarch the queen when she came to the
throne she was very young but she had
very clear ideas of how she wanted to
shape her role and definitively travel
and international collaboration and
building an International Community and
particularly the Commonwealth was so
important to her the queen and Prince
Philip toured the Commonwealth for six
months taking in its vast size and
diversity
by the end the young Queen was already
becoming a global icon
the status cemented a few years later
when she took New York by storm
marathons came out in their thousands
inside the great Assembly Hall 2500
delegates and their wives Rose to greet
the queen
when the queen went on her visit in the
early days no one had any idea she'd be
so popular they had no idea there'd be
thousands of people the advisors were
really quite surprised by the level of
popularity level of fascinating the
level of the fact that everyone seemed
to be out there on the streets who wants
to see a glimpse of the queen and she
was incredibly popular I mean she was
like this
multimedia star she was like the
ultimate celebrity bigger than a
Hollywood celebrity on the maintenance
of understanding between us
the future of the Free World depends
she was already mastering the Arts of
soft power her personal chemistry with
leader after leader would prove one of
her most effective assets
saw her with leaders like President
Yeltsin and sort of again the level of
conversation and confidence
ability to to observe your Discretions
and and secrets but very high and I
think you know got on well because he
respected the queen of having
some enduring qualities that are not
related to politics or the stage of
gioract politically
but if you could claim to be on an equal
footing with the queen Nelson Mandela
was one I mean she could speak very
frankly with him because he was a prince
in his own tribe so in that sense he had
an easy way with the Queens he's the
only head of state I've ever heard
called The Queen Elizabeth
at home the queen hosted world leaders
some of them less Savory than others but
treated them all with the same decorum
and Royal welcome her role was far from
just ceremonial she had a diplomatic
importance with a global reach and depth
politicians could only dream of we in
Britain have often underestimated the
immense impact that the queen had on the
whole of the world with America she'd
met 14 U.S presidents nobody in the
world not even in America has met 14
presidents and then taken a place like
Ireland she was pivotal in bringing
about that reproshno between Britain and
Ireland in 2011. so a hugely understated
but very significant influence globally
the monarchy continues the monarchy will
always continue that's what it's
designed to do but will anybody coming
in now uh have that same clout that same
footprint on world history obviously not
the queen driving the Queen's ambition
above all was a passion for the
Commonwealth to say something good rise
out of the end of Empire Secretary
General says the queen played a unique
role for all of its leaders
you could tell her anything and she'd
never talk about it and she had the
wisdom and the generosity to listen and
then to give really Sage quiet advice
and so I think if you had the privilege
as a number of us have of seeing her
interact with them what's quite
extraordinary is the love and affection
they had for her I commend the queen
Chung leaders of 2018 but the Queen's
love for people extended far beyond
leaders and politicians she had a
passion for the Youth of the
Commonwealth like Derek Omari who set up
a charity for disabled children in Ghana
age 19. singled out by her majesty for
the Queen's youth leader Awards it was
it was a day that
nobody ever thought about I knew where I
grew up never ever thought of in my life
that I even leave Ghana to the UK and
then come all the way to the backyard
Palace and be honored and and one of the
things that really left that that has
gotten stuck with me was the chance to
meet her in person have a conversation
with her
humanness and the ability to come to
your level and tell you that they are
doing a good work keep doing it keep
going on and we are proud of you meant
almost everything
for Rihanna Patterson recognized for
setting up a dementia charity the queen
was a personal inspiration she was a
young person taking on this leadership
role and she had to kind of
find herself in it quite quickly you
know there was a lot of formalities a
lot of rules a lot to take in and it was
something that was quite sudden
um so I think she is relatable in that
regard like taking on the stunts at a
young age
the woman who took on so much in her 20s
will go on inspiring so many other young
people like her for decades and carry on
traveling for as long as her health
would let her
the cream transformed the monarchy
turning it into a globetrotting
multimedia phenomenon years ahead of her
time letting Britain punch above its
weight in the world and leading a
commonwealth of Nations a death leaves a
void as she has mourned by hundreds of
millions far beyond these Shores
Dominic wyghorn Sky News
I'm joined now by the documentary
filmmaker John brigcott who has known
and worked with King Charles for quite
some time John thank you very much
indeed and uh we'll talk about the
documentary Charles at 60 a passionate
prince in a moment but as I say you've
known him for 15 years or so what kind
of King do you think he'll be
well I think we've already seen that
he'll be quite an outstanding King
really I mean it's going to be a bit
different it's going to be the same and
different at the same time when he
arrived at the Palisades and the way he
got out of the car on on the first day
and shook hands with the crowd was quite
extraordinary I think and the way that
he wasn't worried about the number of
hands he had to shake
um the the people who were kissing him
in the from the crowd and then the
extraordinary address that he gave which
was both dignified but also very apt and
very well thought through I think and
and clearly his own words so I think
it's going to be a personal Reign and
quite a spontaneous one too
and the documentary I mentioned Charles
at 60
um a passionate Prince just tell us
about that
well
This was um for his 60th birthday in um
in 2008 I've done I did another one
actually called Prince San Andreas for
his 70th birthday and um this was really
showing him at work and I think people
have not really appreciated the extent
to which he really puts himself out for
his Charities and he's got and we're
listening just now to the amazing reach
internationally that the queen has had
and I think he will continue that
because he's had so many decades of
speaking to world leaders and um and
being able to talk to them about big
issues that concerned him the
environment and so on so the the
documentaries that we did were
looking at what it was like with him
behind the scenes and what struck me
really was
he